BEGIN WITH THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
HEARING FOR TODAY. EXCUSE ME WE
WOULD LIKE. WE. YOU'RE A MOMENT
. OKAY WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN THE
HEARING HERE THIS THIS AFTERNOON
BEFORE WE BEGIN I'D LIKE TO MAKE
A STATEMENT PROVIDING TO ABOUT
PROVIDING TESTIMONY AT THIS
HEARING. WE SEEK TO PROTECT THE
RIGHTS OF ALL WHO PARTICIPATE IN
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS SO THAT
WE CAN HAVE AFFECTED
DELIBERATIONS AND DECISIONS ON
THE CRITICAL ISSUES FACING
CALIFORNIA. AS WE PROCEED WITH
THE WITNESS AND PUBLIC COMMENT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
HOUSE RULES TO ENSURE WE
MAINTAIN ORDER AND RUN AN
EFFICIENT FAIR HEARING. AND THAT
INCLUDES BEING QUIET WHILE WE'RE
ACTUALLY ACTUALLY ARE
DELIBERATING UP HERE. WE APPLY
THESE RULES TO ALL PEOPLE WHO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR PROCEEDINGS.
TO THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE
HAVE LIMITED SPACE FOR PUBLIC TO
PARTICIPATE SO WE CAN ENSURE.
EVERYONE MAINTAINS SIX FEET A
SOCIAL DISTANCE. ANY WITNESS WHO
DID NOT MAKE THE REQUEST IN
ADVANCE AND ARE NOT ON OUR
WITNESS LIST WILL NOT WILL BE
PERMITTED TO NAME. ORGANIZATION
A POSITION ONLY AND NO TESTIMONY
NO EXCEPTIONS WILL BE MADE.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY AFTER THE
MAIN WITNESS TESTIMONY WILL BE
LIMITED TO A MAXIMUM OF TWENTY
MINUTES ON EACH BILL. WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED. IN LIGHT OF HE PUBLIC
INTEREST IN THIS BILL WE WILL
ALLOW A MAXIMUM OF NINETY
MINUTES. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COOPERATION AND HOPE AUTHORS AND
STAKEHOLDERS ARE RESPECTFUL OF
THE PROCESS. FOR THE PUBLIC IN
THE CHAMBERS. THIS YEAR WE AGAIN
WILL BE COMPLYING WITH ALL
PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS ARISING OUT
OF THE COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
REQUIRING THAT MASKS BE WORN BY
ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
TESTIFYING WEATHER HRE IN THE
ROOM. OR IN A VIDEO CONFERENCING
SITE YOU DON'T HAVE A MASK WE
CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. BUT AS
PUBLIC TO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN SIT YOU CAN
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU'RE DONE TESTIFYING OR RETURN
TO YOUR SEAT IF THE SPACE IN THE
ROOM PRINT PERMITS. BECAUSE WE
ARE NOT ABLE TO SANITIZE DURING
THE HEARING IF A SEAT IS VACATED
IT MUST REMAIN EMPTY FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THE HEARING. IN
ORDER TO FACILITATE THE GOAL OF
HEARING AS MUCH. FROM THE PUBLIC
WITHIN THE LIMITS OF OUR TIME.
WE WILL NOT PERMIT CONTACT
CONDUCTED DISRUPTS DECIRTE
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT. OF
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS. WE WILL
NOT ACCEPT DISRUPTIVE BEHAVIOR.
OR BEHAVIOR THAT INCITES OR
THREATENS VIOLENCE EVEN FAILED
THROUGH EVEN VEILED THREATS. THE
RULE FOR TODAY'S ROSE FOR TODAY.
HEARING INCLUDE WEARING A MASK
OVER YOUR NOSE AND MOUTH AT ALL
TIMES AND COMPLYING WITH
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. NO TALKING
OR LOUD NOISES FROM THE
AUDIENCE. PUBLIC COMMENT MAY BE
PROVIDED ONLY AT THE DESIGNATED
TIME AND PLACE AS PERMITTED BY
THE CHAIR. PUBLIC COMMENT MUST
RELATE TO THE SUBJECT WERE BILLS
BEING DISCUSSED TODAY. KNOWING
GAUGING AND CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THE HEARING SHOULD YOU CHOOSE TO
DO THAT YOU WILL BE ASKED TO
LEAVE SHOULD YOU DECIDE THAT YOU
DO NOT WANT TO LEAVE. YOU WILL
BE ESCORTED OUT. PLEASE BE AWARE
THAT VIOLATIONS OF THESE RULES.
WILL SUBJECT YOU TO REMOVAL OR
OTHER ENFORCEMENT PROCESS- WE
WILL HEAR. FROM THE TO MAKE WHEN
THIS IS ON EACH BILL FOR UP TO
THREE MINUTES EACH. A. B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED WE WILL ALLOW A
MAXIMUM OF FIFTEEN MINUTES
DIVIDED. HOWEVER THEY WISH
BETWEEN THE TWO MAIN WITNESSES.
THE PUBLIC WILL THEN HAVE NINETY
MINUTES FOR AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED.
AND TWENTY MINUTES IN TOTAL FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ALL OTHER
BILLS STARTING WITH THOSE WHO
ARE HERE IN THE ROOM. AND THEN
AT THE REMOTE VIDEO SITE AND
FINALLY THOSE CALLING IN BY
PHONE. ADDITIONAL TERRITORIES TO
MONEY AFTER THE MAIN WITNESSES
WILL BE COMBINED AND NOT GROUP
TYPE POSITION ON THE BILL. ALL
PUBLIC COMMENT NEEDS TO FOCUS ON
THE BILL AT HAND. COMMENTS ON
OTHER ISSUES WILL BE RULED OUT
OF ORDER AND YOUR TIME WITH
SPIRE IMMEDIATELY. FOR VIDEO
WITNESSES. IN ADDITION TO BEING
ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WE MAY HAVE SOME
WITNESSES MAKING USE OF A REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. LOCATED AT
THE NORTH STEPS OF THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS. THOSE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THE TESTIMONY LIVE
FROM OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING ROOM
IN MASTIN QUESTIONS. WE WILL BE
USING A MODERATE TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE FIVE. FOUR TWO OH TWO.
COULD FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IN THE DAILY FILE IN ON
YOUR SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING
IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO WELL
BEFORE THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING. ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR PRESENTATION.
THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE. YOUR LIVE
STREAM AND YOUR SMART DEVICES TO
REDUCE SOUND DISTORTION. IF
YOU'RE A WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST A BILL
YOU REMAIN ON A LIFELINE. WILL
NEED TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL
YOU'RE CALLED UPON TO SPEAK. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE MODERATED PHONE SERVICE CALL
THE COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO NINE
SEVEN AND MY STAFF WILL WILL TRY
TO HELP. THREE WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THE POSITION PORTAL WITH
INSTRUCTIONS ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. YOU CAN FIND THE EMAIL
FOR THE FOR THE COMMITTEE THERE
AS WELL. THANK YOU VERY FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WILL ALSO
BEING MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE
STILL ALL FACE. BILLS WILL BE
HEARD IN THE ORDER PRINTED IN
THE DAILY FILE AND ON OUR AGENDA
PROVIDED AT THE HEARING. POSTED
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE.
FOLLOWING BILLS ARE PROPOSED FOR
CONTENT FOR CONSENT FOR TODAY'S
HEARING ANY MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE MAY REMOVE A BILL FROM
CONSENT. I DON'T NUMBER ONE AB
NINETY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA. ITEM NUMBER SIX AB EIGHT
NINETY FIVE. BYE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN WITH AMENDMENTS.
SUBSTITUTE MEMBERS WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
WILL JOIN FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
CHAD MAYES. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JORDAN CUNNINGHAM WILL REPLACE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRANK BIGELOW
FOR TODAY'S HEARING ONLY- WE
ARE. FAR SHORT OF A QUORUM. SO
WOULD ASK THAT MEMBERS. IN THE
BUILDING PLEASE- PLEASE COME. TO
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE- SO THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY CONDUCT OUR
BUSINESS. AND ACTUALLY VOTE ON
BILLS- AT THIS POINT- WE WILL.
BEGIN WORK OR WORK AS A SUB
COMMITTEE WE HAVE AUTHORS IN
THE- IN THE CHAMBERS. AND I
WOULD ASK THAT OUR FIRST AUTHOR-
IS QUICK SILVA COME FORWARD AND
PRESENT. EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY TWO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS I FIRST WANT TO START BY
THANKING SCOTT BAIN- THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR WORKING
WITH MY STAFF ON THIS BILL HE'S
GONE ABOVE AND BEYOND AND WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FIVE TWO
WOULD ALLOW NOT TO REQUIRE
SCHOOLS AND COUNTIES TO ENTER
INTO AN INTEGRATED SCHOOL BASED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE EARLY
INTERVENTION AND ACCESS. TO
BEHAVIORAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR ALL STUDENTS. PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC REPORTS HAVE
PROVIDED STARTLING INFORMATION
ON THE MENTAL HEALTH AND
BEHAVIOUR LANDSCAPE OF SCHOOL
AGE CHILDREN AND YOUTH AS WE
KNOW THINGS ONLY GOT WORSE IN
ORANGE COUNTY. WE HAVE THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL OF ORANGE
COUNTY AND THE REPORTS OF
SUICIDES DURING THIS TIME THE
NUMBERS HAVE STARTED LEE GONE
WAY UP. SCHOOLS AND HOSPITALS
HAVE SEEN A STEADY RISE I'M NOT
ONLY TRAUMA FROM STUDENTS
ANXIETY DEPRESSION AND AS I
MENTIONED SUICIDAL THOUGHTS.
SOCIAL MEDIA BULLYING SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS FAMILY SUBSTANCE ABUSE
AND POVERTY OR SOME OF THE
UNDERLYING CAUSES AND ADDS THAT
WE ALL KNOW TOO WELL COVERT
NINETEEN HAS JUST MADE THIS
CRISIS EVEN WORSE STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN OUT OF SCHOOL FOR OVER A
YEAR SINCE THE PANDEMIC BEGAN.
AND AGAIN EVEN SINCE THESE NOTES
HAVE BEEN WRITTEN WE NOW SEE
SCHOOLS HAVING TO POSSIBLY PIVOT
BACK TO ONLINE- EDUCATION.
BEHAVIOR HEALTH MENTAL WELLNESS
AND SUPPORT HAVE BEEN CRUCIAL
SINCE STUDENTS HAVE RETURNED TO
SCHOOL AND OF WITH THIS BILL WE
MUST DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
ADDRESS THIS IMPORTANT NEED.
TODAY WITH ME VIA PHONE I HAVE
TWO WITNESSES MISS SHEFALI I'M
SORRY I'M GONNA SAY THIS WRONG
MISCHIEF FREE POLY D. SAW
ASSISTANT VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
SCHOOL BASED MENTAL HEALTH AND
EARLY EDUCATION SERVICES. WHAT
THE HEALTH WILL HAVE A HALF AWAY
SIR SYCAMORES CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES AND MS HELLO COLE ARDO
DIRECTOR GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS THE
COUNTY BEHAVIOR HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS QUICKSILVER
WILL GO AHEAD AND OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND WHENEVER YOU'RE READY PLEASE
PROCEED. HELLO MY IF I CAN'T I
DON'T KNOW MY LINE IS OPEN IS
OPEN. IF YOUR WITNESS YOUR LINES
ARE AUTOMATICALLY OPEN SO-
WHENEVER PLEASE GO AHEAD
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
CHAIR WORD AND HONORABLE
COMITTEE MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
TO THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT. FOR
HELPING STRENGTHEN THE BILL
LANGUAGE THIS IS ANY EXAMPLE I'M
I'M WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
WHICH REPRESENTS THE PUBLIC
MENTAL HEALTH. AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER PROGRAM AT THE LADIES
AND COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND THE PROUD CO SPONSORS
AND AB FIVE FIVE TO. EIGHTY FIVE
FIVE TWO AS MENTIONED WOULD
CREATE THE INTEGRATED SCHOOL
BASED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM ENCOURAGING
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AND
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES TO COLLABORATE. ON
PROVIDING SERVICES ON CAMPUS FOR
STUDENTS AT THE EARLIEST ONSET
IN THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONDITION. AS MENTIONED THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS CREATED A
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER FOR THE
PROVISION OF BEHAVIOR HEALTH
SERVICES ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES. AT
A TIME WHEN THE THOSE SERVICES
CONTINUE TO FIX THE NEED FOR THE
SERVICES CONTINUES TO GROW. AS A
RESULT THERE'S AN UNPRECEDENTED
RISE IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS
AMONG THE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
ACCORDING TO THE CDC. A PORTION
OF CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH
RELATED EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
VISITS AMONG ALL PEDIATRIC
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT VISITS
INCREASED BY MORE THAN THIRTY
PERCENT. I REMAINS ELEVATED AS
THE PANDEMIC CONTINUES. COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES HAVE
BEEN PROVIDING SERVICES TO
MEDICAL STUDENT BENEFICIARIES
AND UNINSURED STUDENTS ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES SINCE BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. ACCORDING TO A SURVEY
OF COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES A BARRIER ENCOUNTERED
TO EXPANDING COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES. IS THE RELUCTANCE ON
THE PART OF SCHOOLS TO ALLOW
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ON CAMPUSES UNLESS
ALL STUDENTS CAN BE SERVED
STUDENTS. UNDERSTANDABLY SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS ARE RELUCTANT TO
HAVE A GROUP OF STUDENTS TREATED
DIFFERENTLY IF A BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH NEED ARISES. IN SCHOOLS
PARTICIPATING IN THE PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAMS COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AGENCY TRAINED
PROFESSIONALS WILL SERVE ANY
STUDENT APPROPRIATELY REFERRED
BY SCHOOL PERSONNEL INCLUDING
PRIVATELY INSURED STUDENTS. AND
PROVIDE BRIEF UNUSUAL
INTERVENTION SERVICES THAT ARE
APPROPRIATE TO LIVE TO DELIVER
ON. THE SCHOOL SITE AND INTENDED
TO PREVENT A BEHAVIOR HOW
CONDITION FROM WORSE. CAN
BEHAVIORAL FOR. WILL PRIVATE
INSURED STUDENTS AT A PRIVATE
PLAN. IF AVAIL. AND IF THE
PRIVATE CAN PROVIDE AN
APPROPRIATE PROVIDER WITHIN
STATE MANDATED TIMELY ACCESS
TIME FRAME FOR ANY REASON
INCLUDING THE CURRENT STATEWIDE
SHORTAGE OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS- COUNTY WILL THEN HAVE
BEEN AND WILL INITIATE SERVICES.
AB FIVE FIVE TWO WITH AN
IMPORTANT RESPONSE TO THE
GROWING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS
OF OUR CHILDREN IN YOUTH WHAT
BETTER THAT THEY'RE CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING FOR THESE REASONS
WE ARE PROUD CO SPONSORS AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YU VERY MUCH
TO MOVE ONTO OUR NEXT WITNESS ON
THE PHONE. ABOUT ME THAT THIS IS
PROBABLY THE STOCK. YES MA'AM
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY THANK YOU
. ONE FIVE YOUR MAYES AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TO FOLLOW
THE FIVE DEVICES OF EARLY
EDUCATION SCHOOL BASED NONPROFIT
WITH THE MARS WHERE A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES OPPOSED AT THE FELLOW.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO FIX OUR INTO
THE WHO WE ANY THANK A LARGE
REMAIN STRONG OF AB FOR FIFTY
YOU CURRENTLY ARE MADE. THROUGH
FUNDING FROM THE A. COUNTY
DEPARTMENT ON HOW ENABLES THE
THIRD IN OVER THIRTY FOUR CAMPUS
AS RESULT OF YOU TO LOCAL
DISTRICT AND FIVE STARTERS WITH
. AS OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVING AND TO MEDIC HOW EARLY
AND SCREENING INTO ET ALTHOUGH
EACH YEAR YOU CAN FOR. MARC
BERMAN BELIEVE STUDENTS CONNECT
NEED TIMELY TO HEALTH. THROUGH
MORE ROBUST AFTER PARTNERSHIP
NEEDS STUDENTS ARE ALLEN FOR MY
ETFE THREE FAVORITE PEOPLE COMP
SET OF BENEFITS ENCONTRA IF
UNITS ARE THEIR BY HEALTH THEY
RECEIVED SIR. HOW DO HAS LEFT IN
IN THE MARK ON ALL OF LIFE AND
CHILDREN YOU TRACKING AS TWENTY
FOUR ONE MORE THAN ONE AND FOUR
THOUSAND YOUR CHILDREN HAVE LONG
A PRIME OR SECONDARY GIVERS YOU
TO COPE. THAT FUNDING FOR YOUTH
AND HEART CLINICALLY HEIGHTENED
DEPRESSIVE SYMPTOMS AND ONE IN
FIVE YOU FACE HEIGHTENED ANXIETY
INTO. THE RECENT US SURGEON
GENERAL'S ADVISORY ON YOUTH
MENTAL HEALTH EMPHASIZES THAT
USED SOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
LGBTQ PLUS YOU AND OTHER
SPECIALIZED YOU POPULATION ARE
AT GREATER RISK OF MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES. DURING THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC. THIS DATA ADDITIONAL
PRELIMINARY RESEARCH ON OUR
EXPERIENCE ON THE GROUND SERVING
CHILDREN IN FAMILY. WENT TO A
VERY URGENT NEED TO STRENGTHEN
THE LOCAL INFRASTRUCTURE SO ALL
STUDENTS REGARDLESS PREPARE FOR
HAVE TIMELY ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND- AB FIVE
FIFTY THREE WITH THE THOUGHT
GREATER COOPER. ACCORD TO
FURTHER CLOSE THE EXISTING GAP
ACROSS THE SYSTEM. I WANT TO
CLOSE WITH AN EXAMPLE OF THE
STUDENT REFERRED BY PASADENA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT JOHN WAS
A SEVEN YEAR OLD CLIENT AND HIS
PARENTS GRANDPARENTS CARE HIS
GRANDFATHER CONTRACTED COBIT
LEADING TO LOSS OF FAMILY
INCOME. PARKING PROVIDED
INDIVIDUAL AND FAMILY THERAPY
ASSISTANT FAMILY ACCESSING
RESOURCES LEGAL ASSISTANCE TO
PROTECT THEIR HOUSING AND
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE. TO KEEP
THE HEATING GAP ON IN THEIR
HOME. WE WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THE CALM SERVICES UNDER MEDICARE
ETS IF HE ENTERED A PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE SCHOOL DISTRICT L. A.
COUNTY DEPARTMENT AMONG HOT.
ENCLOSING SYCAMORE STRONGLY
URGES THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE TO ENDORSE ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE FIFTY TWO WHICH
CODIFIED PROGRAMMATIC BEST
PRACTICES IN THE PROVISION OF
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SERVICES. ANY
STUDENT IN NEED ON A SCHOOL
CAMPUS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE NO
REGISTERED WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SO WE WILL GO TO
OTHERS- WITNESSES UP HERE IN THE
CHAMBER YOU WANT TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. YOU MAY
DO SO. AT THIS TIME. IF THERE IS
SAYING NO ONE AT THIS POINT WE
WILL MOVE ON TO IS OR ANY
WITNESSES IN A REMOTE TESTIMONY
ROOM. SINCE I CAN'T SEE IT I'M
GONNA GUESS NO SINCE WE HAVE WE
DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER- THE WILL
NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINES SO WE
HAVE THE OPERATOR OPEN UP THE
LINES- FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME.
AND POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE. AND IF YOU DO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WAS
LIKE WE HAVE EIGHT INTO AT THE
MOMENT VERY WELL THANK YOU. AND
SERVICE LINE ONE TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY ONE ONE
ONE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MARSHALL
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION FOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
SPECIAL ONE ONE FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
ADRIAN SHELTON WAS THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES PRODUCT
COSPONSOR AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
SPECIAL LINE EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO HEARING MEMBERS
COLIN SWEARS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. LINE ONE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS PRISCILLA KIDDER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT TO ALIGN ONE SIXTY FIVE ONE
SIX FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ALIGHT. ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT WE HAVE LINED ONE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
MADELINE COOPER FROM NIELSEN
MARKS MORE ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT HEADLINE ONE TWELFTH PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FINALLY THE WILL BE
HAPPY THE CALIFORNIA COUNSELOR
CAN BE BE BE A HEALTH AGENCY
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. YES WE HAVE ONE NUMBER
ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANIEL SABINO ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE FOUR
MORE TO AT THE MOMENT WE'LL GO
TO LINE ONE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IF YOU'RE BORN
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RAINY HICKS
CALIFORNIANS AND WE'RE
DISABILITY RIGHTS INK IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WE HAVE LINE
ONE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES I NICOLE YOUNG WITH
KNOWLEDGE FOR LIBERTY PLASTER
COUNTY I AM IN OPPOSITION AT THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER ONE I'M SORRY WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINETY SIX YOU WANT IS
OPEN. NUMBER NINETY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND WE HAVE NO NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO- TO A
CLOSING STATEMENT ORFOR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE- WE
DO HAVE A QUORUM SOMEONE ASKED
THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHAT HERE. ROBERT RIVAS
AGUIAR-CURRY. ARAMBULA YOUR
CUNNINGHAM. BURKE YEAH CARILLO
LARA YOUR MAIENSCHEIN. MCCARTY
NAZARIAN BUT- THREE OF US.
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO WALDRON. THAT
NUMBER IS. OKAY THANK YOU I
UNDERSTAND WE DO HAVE SOMEONE AT
OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE SO WE
CAN CATCH THEM THROUGH- BEFORE
WE GO INTO QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE.
WE SEE THE MICROPHONE
BUT THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT THERE SO
IT'S A VERY NICE MICROPHONE
THERE- ANYWAY MAYBE SOMEONE WILL
USE IT LATER SO THANK YOU I WITH
THAT WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. WE DON'T
HAVE A MOTION. SEVEN THE MOTION
WE HAVE MADE WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM- MISS BURE A SECOND BY MR
RODRIGUEZ- ANY QUESTION ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE ON
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO
MOTION IS WE HAVE A MOTION TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS MOTION
MADE BY MS BURKE SECONDED BY MR
RODRIGUEZ MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WHAT I WHAT. I
ROBERT RIVAS. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE CUNNINGHAM
. BURKE BURKE I TO RIO CORREO I
FLORA. LARA I MAIENSCHEIN
MCCARTY. NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE
THREE OF US. RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
I SANTIAGO. WALDRON WALDRON I.
EIGHT ZERO THE BILL HAS A BOAT
SITS OUT BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN
THANK YOU LETTER THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO A MISTER RAMOS. YOU HAVE A
B. SIX EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT TO START
OFF WITH THE TECHNOLOGY THAT I
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU SB SIX EIGHTY ONE.
WOULD REQUIRE DESIGNATED
FACILITIES TO SUBMIT QUARTERLY
REPORTS ON THE LETTERMAN
FEATURES SHORT LPS HOLDS. TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. THIS BILL WILL SATISFY
ONE OF THE TOP RECOMMENDATIONS
OF THE RECENT AUDIT OF THE LPS
SYSTEM. AND PROVIDE TRANSPARENT
DATA TO DEVELOP BEST PRACTICES.
IN JUNE TWENTY NINETEEN SEVERAL
STAKEHOLDERS REQUESTED AN AUDIT
OF THE LPS ACT. IN AN EFFORT TO
BETTER INFORM FUTURE DECISION
MAKING IN MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT AND CARE. THE AUDIT
WAS SUPPORTED BY A NUMBER OF
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS INCLUDING
MENTAL HEALTH ADVOCATES PUBLIC
SAFETY GROUPS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THE GOALS OF THE
AUDIT INCLUDED IDENTIFYING DATA
ON HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS ARE
BEING PLACED UNDER HOLDS
THROUGHOUT PS AND SUBSEQUENT
SUBSEQUENT SPECIFICS OF THOSE
HOLES AS WELL AS DISCOVERING
CONSISTENT CRITERIA OR
STANDARDIZATION OF THE PROCESS
AND SERVICES OFFERED ACROSS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. RECENTLY THIS
COMMITTEE HELD A DETAILED
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THIS
ISSUE. AND THE NEED FOR THIS
BILL WAS HIGHLIGHTED IN
CONVERSATION AROUND DATA
HOSPITAL USAGE RATES AND MANY
ELEMENTS OF THE LPS ACT. THIS
BILL IS AN IMPORTANT FIRST STEP
IN DEVELOPING SOUND EFFECTIVE
DATA FOR ALL PARTNERS ESPECIALLY
THOSE ON THE GROUND INVOLVED IN
THE L. P. S. PROCESS. JOINING ME
TODAY BY PHONE IS MICHELLE
CABRERA EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER RAMOS WILL MOVE
TO THE PHONE LINES FOR OUR
WITNESS IN SUPPORT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY MISS CABRERA. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR THE ROBUST HEARING
IN DECEMBER EXPLORING THE MYRIAD
ISSUES THAT TOUCH THE LPS FACT.
WE KNOW FROM THAT CURING
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA HAS A LACK
OF RELIABLE STATEWIDE DATA. TO
SHOW PATIENT TRENDS RELATED TO
INVOLUNTARY HOLDS AND TREATMENT.
AS PART OF THE P. TWENTY
NINETEEN AUDIT WHICH ARE- IS IN
THE AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER. MOST
MENTIONED THE AUDITOR NOTED THIS
LACK OF INFORMATION AS WELL AS
PART OF HER FINDINGS STATING.
THAT BECAUSE COUNTIES CANNOT
ACCESS STATEWIDE DATA ABOUT
SHORT TERM HOLDS THEY LACK
INFORMATION THAT MIGHT ENABLE
THEM TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE ONGOING
HERE. THE INDIVIDUALS WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS. EVEN IF COUNTY
FOR TO DEVELOP LOCAL AGREEMENTS
WITH DESIGNATED FACILITIES TO
SHARE INFORMATION. THAT WOULD
STILL LEAVE COUNTIES WITHOUT
INFORMATION ABOUT INDIVIDUALS
HOLD ANOTHER COUNTY. IF BILL
DRAWS FROM BACK HE RECOMMEND TO
LEVERAGE AN EXISTING FAT OF LPS
DATA REPORTED TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ENFORCING FIREARMS POSSESSION
PROHIBITION IN EXISTING LAW. FOR
THIS SUBSET OF THE LPS
POPULATION. DOJ REQUIRED
DESIGNATED FACILITIES REPORT TO
THEM WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS
I'VE BEEN ITS MISSION AND SO
THIS BILL WOULD DO THREE THINGS
ONE IT AUTHORIZES THE DOJ TO
TRANSMIT THE DATA. TO DTS
DIRECTLY TO HELP IMPROVE
OVERSIGHT AND CARE COORDINATION.
AND EXPENSE DATA REPORTED BY
THESE FACILITIES TO INCLUDE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ADMITTED TO
AN INPATIENT. FACILITY DUE TO
GRAVE DISABILITY AS REQUESTED BY
THE AUDITOR. WE HAVE ALSO ADDED
A REQUIREMENT TO INCLUDE RACE
ETHNICITY DATA TO ALLOW THE
STATE TO ANALYZE AND ADDRESS
DISPARITIES OVER TIME. I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS WHICH WE
BELIEVE STRENGTH IN THE BILL AND
SEEK TO ADDRESS CONCERNS RAISED
BY DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND VHA
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
DIALOGUE WITH KEY STAKEHOLDERS
TO MISS IMPORTANT POLICY AREA WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE DO HAVE
ONE WITNESS REGISTERED IN
OPPOSITION SO IT WOULD BE MISTER
ALEX HOW HAWTHORN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY MR HAWTHORNE. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
GONZALEZ AUCKLAND CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WE ARE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION-
WE DO THINK THE CHAIRED
COMMITTEE FOR HOLDING THAT
IMPORTANT INFORMATIONAL HEARING
THAT WAS MENTIONED ON THE LPS
ACT. AND COMPLETELY AGREE THAT
WE HAVE TO IMPROVE THE DATA WE
HAVE ON INVOLUNTARY DETENTION.
CONSTABLES TODAY REPORT LARGE
AMOUNTS OF DATA TO THE STATE AND
COUNTY AND WE JUST WANT TO
INSURE THAT SUBMITTING IT IS AS
STREAMLINED AS POSSIBLE. THE WAY
THAT THOSE WRITTEN TODAY WE DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
CREATING DUPLICATIVE OR
NONESSENTIAL REPORTING NOW THAT
SAID WE THINK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RAMOS FOR TAKING THE ISSUE ON
AND RESOLVING THIS IMPORTANT
FINDING- NOT FROM THAT THE AUDIT
THAN FROM HEARING AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HIM AND
SPONSORED TO IMPROVE. THE
IMPORTANT GOAL IN THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELL
NOW MOVES TO- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OR OPPOSITION IN THE
CHAMBER. C. NONE WILL GO TO THE
ROOM THE A REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE
THERE'S NO ONE THERE. COME BACK
TO THE PHONE- MISTER ROCK
FREIGHTER PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
LASTLY WE JUST STATE YOUR NAME.
POSITION ON THE BILL AND IT IS
ATION IF YOU REPRESENT. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IT ON THIS
LEGISLATION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME WE'LL
START WITH LINE. ONE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
CALLING IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO THE
LINE ONE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
FIRST CHRISTOLOGY DOC ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX EIGHT ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WELL I NUMBER EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CHAIR
MEMBERS COLLINS WORSE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YES LINE ONE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AND NICOLE
YOUNGSTER TO SEND LAST
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. NATIONAL ONE ONE FIFTY ONE
FIVE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RENDON NEXTEL GOING TO
DISABILITY RIGHTS AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT WE HAVE LINE ONE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. CANADA
HI-LO'S NEAR THE RECALL GAVIN
NEWSOM AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
BUT HE DIDN'T TAKE PLACE THAT
YOU JUST OPENED BACK UP OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. MEDICAL ONE TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI NEED WILL BE
HOW THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR HEALTH AGENCY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT WE HAVE ONE NUMBER
ONE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
UP. I'M SORRY ONE ONE SEVENTY
TWO I APOLOGIZE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THANK YOU THIS IS HEATHER
KELLER SACRAMENTO COUNTY
RESIDENTS IN STRONG UP. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NATIONAL
LINE ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH THIS IS MICHAEL
JOSEPH- ONE OF THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA. I OPPOSE ANY STATE
READING THANK YOUNG GETTING
INVOLVED IN WALKING PEOPLE LIVE
FOR NO REASON THANK YOU YOU
THINK SO. THANK YOU GOODNIGHT IS
THINKING A LOT. AND WE HAVE NO
ONE LEFT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OF MR RAHMAN'S. C. NINE- YOU DO
THE BILL DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION YOU'VE ACCEPTED
THE AMENDMENTS IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER FLORA.
THE SECOND BY MISS WALDRON WHICH
LIKE THE CLOSENESS FROM US JUST
WANT TO THANK GOODNESS FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE ROBERT RIVAS.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
AYE CUNNINGHAM BURKE BURKE I
CARILLO. LARA LARA AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY THIS AREA OF
THIS AREA AND I THREE OF US
RODRIGUEZ. REGUS I SANTIAGO
WALDRON WALDRON HI. SEVEN ZERO
WE HAVE SEVEN WILL LEAVE A BILL
ON CALL AND- WHEN WE HAVE MORE
MEMBERS WILL WILL TAKE IT UP AT
THE END SO THANK YOU MR RAMA
SEVEN MISTER DOCTOR REGULAR I
WOULD AS THE CUSTOMER THE
COMMITTEE I WILL HAVE THE
MEMBERS PRESENT LAST SO THE
OTHER DAY THAT WE CAN'T DO THAT
I WAS WE DIDN'T FOLLOW ORDERS
NEVER MIND. SO WEEK WEEK. I
APOLOGIZE IT'S EARLY IN THE
SEASON EUROPE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB SIX EIGHTY
SIX WILL ESTABLISH A LOCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM TO IMPROVE
THE DELIVERY OF COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
TO IDENTIFY AND PROMOTE
STATEWIDE BEST PRACTICES. COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIANS ACROSS
A BROAD SPECTRUM OF NEED AND IN
COORDINATION WITH MULTIPLE
INTERRELATED SYSTEMS. HOWEVER
THERE IS NO COMPREHENSIVE PLAN
TO EVALUATE THE CLIENT OUTCOMES
IN COMMUNITY BASED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SYSTEMS. AB SIX EIGHTY
SIX WILL SOLVE THIS ISSUE BY
DEVELOPING AND OUTCOMES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FRAMEWORK FOR
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BASED
ON AN EXISTING SUCCESSFUL MODELS
IN CHILD WELFARE SERVICES AND
MORE RECENTLY WITHIN CAL WORKS
AND CAL FOR. THIS PERFORMANCE
DATA OUTCOMES WILL HELP TO
ENSURE PROPER LOCAL AND
STATEWIDE ANALYSIS AND
COMMUNICATION RESULTING IN THE
IMPROVEMENT OF SYSTEMS AND
SUPPORT TO INCREASE THE OVERALL
BEHAVIORAL WELLNESS FOR
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ITEM.
THANK YOU YOU DO HAVE A
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONES WILL GO AHEAD TO THE
OPERATOR AND WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU CHAIR WOULD IT MAKE
SURE MAYES AN HONORABLE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
TO THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR
THE COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS. OKAY
YEAH THE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WHICH REPRESENTS THE
PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER PROGRAM
ATTORNEYS IN COUNTY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND PROUD CO SPONSOR
CO SPONSORS OF EIGHTY SIX EIGHT
SIX. THIS BILL WILL INCREASE THE
PUBLIC'S UNDERSTANDING OF THE
IMPACT OF THE COMMUNITY BASED
PUBLIC BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DELIVERY SYSTEM AND INCREASE
ACCOUNTABILITY OF COUNTY BE ABLE
HELP AGENCIES BY BEING ROBUST.
STATE WIDE OUTCOME AND
PERFORMANCE MEASURES FOR ADULTS
WITH SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS
CHILDREN AND YOUTH WITH SERIOUS
EMOTIONAL DISTURBANCES
INDIVIDUALS WITH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS AND OTHER POPULATION
SERVED BY COUNTY BECAME.
HISTORIC GREG. AND PAYMENT RULES
RENDERED THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DELIVERY SYSTEM COMPLEX
BY BY DESIGN THE COMPLEXITY
EXTENDS OFTEN DISJOINTED. OFTEN
DISJOINTED SET OF EXISTING WORK
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS TIED TO
THE BROAD SPECTRUM OF SAFETY NET
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND SOCIAL.
SERVICES PROVIDED BY COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES AND
OUR NETWORK OF PROVIDERS.
HOWEVER TO DATE NO ACTION HAS
BEEN TAKEN TO DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE JOINT PLAN FOR
COORDINATED EVALUATION OF CLIENT
OUTCOMES. THE COMMUNITY BASED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FOR THE
CLEANING BASED BEHAVIOR HEALTH
DELIVERY SYSTEM WITH EIGHTY SIX
EIGHT SIX AND UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY- CAL HHS. THEY WILL
CONVENE APPROPRIATE STATE IN THE
AGENCIES INCLUDING ALL CURRENT
REGULATORS. LEGISLATIVE
REPRESENTATIVES COUNTY'S CLIENT
AND FAMILY REPRESENTS PROVIDERS
AND DATA SCIENTISTS TO DEVELOP
THE MEASURABLE AND REPORTABLE
OUTCOMES FOR PUBLIC BEHAVIOR
HEALTH DELIVERY SYSTEM. THIS
BILL BUILT ON A. B. FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT TWENTY SEVENTEEN. BILL
AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA WHICH WHICH REQUIRED
EQUITY ORIENTED UPDATES TO THE
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
PERFORMANCE OUTCOMES REPORT FOR
MEDICAL SERVICES. AND AS
MENTIONED THE BILL IS MODELED
AFTER THE SUCCESSFUL CAL WORK
OUTCOMES AND ACCOUNTABILITY
REVIEW ACT OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
CAL HHS LED EFFORT THAT
ESTABLISHED CORE OUTCOME
ACCOUNTABILITY COMPONENTS FOR
CAL WORKS WHICH THIS BILL SEEKS
TO REPLICATE. THIS BILL LIKE THE
CAL WORKS TWENTY SEVENTEEN BILL
ESTABLISHES PERFORMANCE
INDICATORS. A COUNTY CITY SELF
ASSESSMENT PROCESS AND A LOCAL
SYSTEM FOR IMPROVED BY LOCAL
SYSTEM UP FOR IMPROVEMENT.
IMPROVEMENT PLAN. FOR THESE
REASONS CBH DA IN THE PROUD
SPONSOR SPONSOR OF. EIGHTY SIX
EIGHT SIX AND- DOES YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
WOMAN ON TO OUR WITH. JOHN
MEMBERS BOB LANE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL- COMMUNITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCY. ON
THURSDAY B. SIX EIGHT SIX. I YOU
KNOW CALIFORNIA LOCK A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN TO EVALUATE
CLIENT OUTCOMES FOR THOSE IN THE
COMMUNITY BATES BE ABLE TO HELP
WITH. THIS IN ADDITION TO THE
COMPLEXITY OF SERVICES MAKES
EIGHTY SIX EIGHT SIX VITAL TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
TO SEE THE IMPACT OF THE CURRENT
REMARKABLE INVESTMENTS AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. ALSO WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF CALLAHAN AND
THE RECENTLY APPROVED WAIVERS
OUTCOME MEASUREMENTS ARE MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER. SB SIX
EIGHT SIX IS IMPRISONED IS AIMED
AT IMPROVING THE TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY FOR BEHAVIOR
HEALTH OUTCOMES NOT ONLY IS A
VITAL TO DEFINE A PROCESS FOR
STATE WIDE OUTCOME IMPLEMENT
MEASURES. IT'S ALSO A CRITICAL
STEP TO ENSURE AGENCIES ARE VAST
SERVING TARGET POPULATIONS. IN
FACT THE BIGGEST- DATA CURRENTLY
SHOW THAT THE MAJORITY OF OUR
STATE'S BLACK INDIGENOUS PEOPLE
OF COLOR LESBIAN GAY BISEXUAL
TRANS QUEER AND TWO SPIRIT
POPULATIONS ARE OVERWORKED
REPRESENTED AND SEE CHARACTER
THE SAFETY NET. YEAH WE CANNOT
MEASURE EXPLAIN OR DEMONSTRATE
THAT SERVICES ARE ONLY BE
DELIVERED MORE OF HIGH QUALITY
BECAUSE MOST OF THE DATA
COLLECTED ONLY SHOWS A PARTIAL
PICTURE. ADDITIONALLY BY
REQUIRING A STANDARD AND
STATEWIDE METHOD FOR COLLECTING
REYES I THINK ANY ETHNICITY
LANGUAGE SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND
GENDER IDENTITY WILL BE ABLE TO
BUILD UPON PREVIOUS AFTER. THAT
SAID BEFORE SUCH AS EIGHTY FOUR
SEVENTY ALSO BY DR ARAMBULA.
GIVEN INCREASING BEHAVIOR.
HEALTH ISSUES DUE TO COLD AND-
L. IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER
WE FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN HELPING
OUR- BY ON. MEASURE OUR CALL
OUTCOME THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE HAVE NO. WITNESSES
IN OFFICE. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE CHAMBER. RIGHT
SPOKE. C. NINE ANY OUR REMOTE
TESTIMONY SIGHT SEEING NONE WILL
GO BACK TO THE PHONE FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME.
POSITION ON THE BILL AN
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE. IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK ON
THIS LEGISLATION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
START WITH LINE ONE NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRED MEMBER THE LIGHT IS
ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA. COURT THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANKS TWELVE ONE
ONE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON LINDA WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. WE HAVE
LINE ONE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON REBECCA
GONZALEZ CALLING IN SUPPORT
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE TWO OH FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND DURING A REPAIR ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HELP NETWORKING STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHANNON HEIL
AND I OPPOSE THE BUILT IN OTHER
WAYS. A LOT. THANKS HAVE ONE
NUMBER ONE TWELFTH PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FINALLY DO NOT BE HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ACCESS COALITION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT WE HAVE ONE NUMBER
ONE EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
J. R. MEMBERS ROBERT HARRIS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY
OF ADDICTION MEDICINE EXPORT
THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER. NEXT
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRAINIACS
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY RIGHTS AND
STRONG WORK THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IN LINE ONE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
NICOLE YOUNGSTERS IN A
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
INCLUDING A TEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTION OF ADDICTION
PROGRAMS AND PROFESSIONALS IN
SUPPORT OF THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT ONE ONE NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
HEATHER KELLER SACRAMENTO COUNTY
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BY
NUMBER ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO IT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN ALSO YOU
KNOW ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY
NUMBER TWO OH SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FOR A BI FOURTEEN HUNDRED
THIS IS NOT SO NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU THE NATIONAL
LINE TO ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SARAH MCDAID THANK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I WOULD ASK
THAT THE WITNESS WILL HAVE ONE
WEEK BEFORE YOU ASK THE PEOPLE
NUYS PLEASE BE QUIET IF YOU
CHOOSE NOT TO BE QUITE WE WILL
BE ASKING YOU TO LEAVE. I CAN
HEAR EVERY WORD YOU'RE SAYING UP
HERE SO PLEASE DO NOT PROPER
HEARING. YOU HAVE BEEN WARNED-
MIGHT BE TIME TO LEAVE NOW
ACTUALLY. THE NOTHING WRONG I'VE
ASKED YOU TO NOT BE TO NOT
DESTRUCTOR HEARING YOU'VE CHOSEN
DESTRUCTOR HERE TO ASK YOU TO
LEAVE. YOU CAN LEAVE AS WELL.
ALL NOT CENSORING THE CALL I
SIMPLY SAID. PEOPLE PLEASE LEAVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I'LL BE
BACK JIM THANK YOU. YOU CAN.
SHOULD ANYONE ELSE DECIDE THAT
THEY'D LIKE TO BE DISRUPTIVE
WILL BE ASKING YOU TO LEAVE AS
WELL. AND THAT INCLUDES ANY
OUTBURSTS COMMENTS WHEN YOU'RE
NOT WHEN YOU'RE NOT BE A WITNESS
HERE. SO YOU'RE ALL BEEN WARNED.
THANK YOU. MR A OPERATOR PLEASE
GO ON TO THE NEXT CALL. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE THIRTY ONE
X. ACTUALLY DAVE JUST DROPPED A
QUEUE I'M SORRY THANK YOU. NEXT
CALL WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE LEFT IN
THE QUEUE THANK YOU COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE. C. NINE I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE A PROMOTION. THE
MOTION WE DO NOW HAVE A MOTION
BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY. A SECOND
BY MISS BURKE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS DR EMILY
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WHAT I WOULD I
ROBERT RIVAS. AGUIAR-CURRY BAKER
CURRY I ARAMBULA HI ARAMBULA AYE
CUNNINGHAM. BURKE HI BURKE I
CARILLO. FLORA FLORA I
MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY THIS AREA
THREE OF US RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO
WALDRON WALDRON I. SIX ZERO WE
HAVE SIX BOTH WILL LEAVE THE
BILL ON CALL. THANK YOU DR
ARAMBULA ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
WHEN. YOU HAVE AB SEVEN THIRTY
A. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- TODAY
I'M FREEZING UP ON AB SEVEN
THREE EIGHT WHICH WILL REQUIRE
THE COUNTIES APPOINT AT LEAST
ONE VETERAN OR VETERAN'S
ADVOCATE TO SERVE ON A LOCAL
PUBLIC. MENTAL HEALTH BOARD. AS
YOU KNOW COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC
AND THE PANDEMIC RELATED
SHUTDOWNS OF SCHOOLS BUSINESSES
AND MORE. HAS MADE IT MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT FOR MENTAL HEALTH.
COMMUNITY ACROSS THE STATE.
THESE PRESSURES CAN HAVE AN
OUTSIDE AN OUTSIZED IMPACT ON
MANY PEOPLE WHO MAY HAVE WHO MAY
NOT KNOW WHERE TO TURN TO FOR
HELP OR HOW TO DEAL WITH STRESS
DEPRESSION OR OTHER DISTRESSED
SYMPTOMS. FOR THOSE AFFECTED
INCLUDE ALL VETERANS POPULATION
FIND RESOURCES FOR THEM CAN BE
CHALLENGING. A RECENT SURVEY
REALLY BILL STARLING DATA A
WIDENING DISPARITY IN VETERANS
RECEIVING MENTAL HEALTH CARE
SERVICES OR RESOURCES. AS
REPORTED APPROXIMATELY 85% OF
VETERANS REPORTER SOME OF FORM
OF SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER. 16%
REPORTED EXPERIENCE GENERAL
MENTAL ILLNESS OR SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS AND WERE RECEIVING NO
TREATMENT OR CARE. ADDITIONALLY
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AND
TWO THOUSAND NINE NINETEEN THERE
WAS A NOBLE SPIKE IN SEARS
MENTAL ILLNESS REPORTED VETERANS
BETWEEN THE AGES OF TWENTY SIX
AND FORTY NINE. WE OWE IT TO
THOSE WHO HAVE ASKED TO SERVE.
WHO WE'VE ASKED TO SERVE AND
SACRIFICE FOR OUR COUNTRY THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES A
RESOURCE THEY ARE ENTITLED TO.
WINDS OF BEEN FLICKED ON THE
BATTLEFIELD I'M NOT ALWAYS
PHYSICAL AND SOME SOMETIMES
COULD TAKE A LOT LONGER TO HEAL.
IT'S OUR JOB TO ENSURE OUR
VETERANS HAVE ACCESS TO LOCAL
AND HEALTH SERVICES AND
RESOURCES AND PROVIDE SUPPORT
FOR THEM AND THEIR FAMILIES. BY
REQUIRED THAT A VETERAN OR
VETERAN ADVOCATE BE APPOINTED TO
LOCAL PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH
BOARD. AB SEVEN THREE EIGHT WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT OUR VETERANS
ARE PART OF THE CONVERSATION ON
MY ON MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELLNESS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. WITH ME HERE WITH ME
ON THE PHONE WE HAVE- OUR
WITNESS ALEX TAURUS I BEHALF FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE. AGENCIES VERY
MUCH I WILL GO TO OUR PHONE
LINES FOR WITNESS WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY MISTER TORRANCE.
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR
WOULD MEMBERS I'LL BE BRIEF HERE
QUITE THE AGENDA BEFORE YOU
TODAY- ALEX TOWARDS THE
STRATEGIES THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES AND
WE'RE PROUD TO BE HERE AT LEAST
OVER THE PHONE AND SUPPORT TODAY
OF AB SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENT ON THIS
BILL CABS OF THE CONSORTIUM
SEVEN NONPROFIT VETERANS SERVICE
PROVIDERS WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP
TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS VETERANS AND TWENTY
TWENTY. KAPLER COMPLETED A THREE
YEAR EFFORT FUNDED BY THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION TO
IMPROVE AND REPORT ON
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICE SYSTEMS FOR
VETERANS AND CALIFORNIANS.
REVIEWED COUNTY THREE YEAR AN
HSA PLANS AN ANNUAL UPDATES TO
DETERMINE HOW WELL THEY ARE
MEETING THEIR OBLIGATION TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO VETERANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. THE REVIEW
SCORES REFLECTED DEGREE TO WHICH
THE COUNTY AND THE CHECK A
DOCUMENT TO TAILOR SPECIFIC
PLANNING TOWARDS WE NEED TO
VETERANS. AND THEIR FAMILIES TO
GAUGE THE EXTENT THAT IT COUNTY
PLAN WAS DEVELOPED WITH LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING VETERANS.
AND REPRESENTATIVES FROM
VETERANS ORGANIZATIONS- OR FAKE
CRAP ALLOCATE SOME OF THEIR
BUDGET SPECIFICALLY TO FEDERAL
PROGRAMS. WELL THERE WERE SOME
GREAT DATA THE REVIEW
ALTERNATELY UNDERSCORE P. R.
GREATER ENGAGEMENT WITH VETERANS
AND SO EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY WILL
PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE. TO
ENSURE THAT OUR VETERANS HAVE A
SEAT AT THE TABLE WE TALK ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH POLICY MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES. RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR SUPPORT HERE TODAY ON
THIS IMPORTANT MATTER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY WITNESSES- REGISTER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SO WE
WILL NOW GO TO. WITNESSES IN THE
CHAMBER. ANYONE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. SEE NO ONE WILL GO
TO THE REMOTE TESTIMONY SIDE. I
DON'T. THE I DON'T BELIEVE WE
HAVE ANYBODY THERE- AT THE WITH
AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY SITES
WILL GO BACK TO THE PHONE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME
POSITION ON THE BILL AN
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE. PLEASE GO AHEAD MR ROBERT-
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK ON THIS
LEGISLATION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. SPECIAL
START WITH LINE NUMBER TWO
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NUMBER TWO NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY TO MOVE THE LINE
NUMBER TWO OH SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HERE ARE GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS SANDRA MARQUEZ
PLASTER COUNTY AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
FOR OUR VETERANS THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. I ACTUALLY HAVE ONE NUMBER ONE
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FINALLY
WE WILL BE HAPPY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AGENCY SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT WE HAVE Y. NUMBER ONE FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RAINY NEXT
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY RIGHTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER ONE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RYAN HÌNH SAID THE SENATE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
HEADLINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ALL APPLE
REPORT BETTER THAT YOU HAVE A
QUESTION NO HUMAN WITHOUT ARMS.
YEAH THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT LEVEL I NUMBER ONE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE
NICOLE YOUNG FOR THE SENATE
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. WELL THANK YOU STRUCTURE
YOUR BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MISS WALDRON
JUST WANTED TO THANK. THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF MENTAL
HEALTH WITH VETERANS AND I THINK
THIS WILL GO A LONG WAY THANK
YOU. VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE. SEE
NO ONE ON THE BILL DOESN'T JOIN
A DO PASS HAS RECOMMENDED IT TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS HAVE YOU ARE
ACCEPTED OUR AMENDMENTS YES SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO WILL BE
DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. PARDON WE NEED THIS WE
HAVE A MOTION EXTREMELY
EVOLUTION BY MISTAKE HERE KOREA
SECOND BY MISS CARILLO. MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHAT HI WOULD I
ROBERT RIVAS. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA.
CUNNINGHAM BURKE HI BURKE I
CARILLO CARILLO AYE FLORA AYE
AYE LARA AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MCCARTY THIS AREA. I'M SORRY
MCCARTY MCCARTY I. THIS AREA
THREE OF US RODRIGUEZ- RODRIGUEZ
I SANTIAGO. WALDRON WALDRON HIGH. EIGHT ZERO THE BILL HAS A BOAT
SITS OUT OF COMMITTEE WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER STAT ON
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MR DALY. I
SEE YOU HERE. CHU DALY YOU HAVE
AB. NINE THIRTY THREE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS. A
RECENT REPORT BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTH CARE FOUND
THAT MANUFACTURED DRUG REBATES
IN CALIFORNIA TOTALED
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS. IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO YEARS AGO. THAT
FIGURE REPRESENTS OVER 14% OF
THE TOTAL AMOUNT SPENT ON
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS IN OUR STATE
. ON AVERAGE DRUG REBATES
RESULTING PBMS AND INSURERS
PAYING 40% LESS THAN THE LIST
PRICE OF THE MEDICATION. SADLY
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THAT THE
SAVINGS ARE SHARED WITH
CONSUMERS. THIS BILL PROPOSES TO
SAVE PATIENTS MONEY AT THE
PHARMACY COUNTER BY REQUIRING
THAT 90% OF MANUFACTURER REBATES
ARE SHARED DIRECTLY WITH
CONSUMERS. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IN YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL AND I
ACCEPT ALL FIVE OF THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS. LEANDRA CLARK HARVEY
WITH THE ACCESS COALITION IN A
SURE LYSYK. WITH THE
PHARMACEUTICAL RESEARCH AND
MANUFACTURERS OF AMERICA WILL BE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MISTER DALY- WE DO HAVE ONE OF
THE WITNESSES HERE IN THE
CHAMBER SO PLEASE PLEASE GO
AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN WIDE- YOU WILL HEAR
FROM THE ACCESS COALITION
TODAY'S THAT REBATES AND
DISCOUNTS ARE PAID BY
MANUFACTURERS TO MAKE MEDICINES
MORE AFFORDABLE TO CONSUMERS.
AND YOU'LL HEAR DATA FROM THEM
THAT- FIND THAT REBATES IN
CALIFORNIA NOW TOTAL OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS. WHAT I WANT TO
SPEND MY TIME ON IN. MY BRIEF
TESTIMONY IS ON HOW THIS WILL
ACTUALLY BENEFIT THE CONSUMER
WHEN THEY GO TO THE PHARMACY
COUNTER- A RECENT U. S. SENATE
FINANCE REPORT WAS RELEASED. ON
INSULIN IN THE REBATES IN THAT
SYSTEM. ONE OF THE EXAMPLES THAT
THEY FOUND. WAS THAT A VERY
COMMON INSULIN HAD A SEVENTY
NINE POINT SEVEN FIVE PERCENT.
REBATE OFF THE LIST PRICE- THAT
WAS PAID FOR TO THE PBM. SO
RIGHT NOW WHAT HAPPENS WHEN. A
CALIFORNIA AND GOES TO THE
PHARMACY COUNTER IS THEY PAY
FULL LIST PRICE AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE YEAR AND THE DEDUCTIBLE
PERIOD. OR FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS FOR THAT
INSULIN. IF THIS BILL WAS TO GO
INTO EFFECT. THAT SAME
CALIFORNIA AND WHEN THEY WENT TO
THE PHARMACY COUNTER WOULD ONLY
PAY A HUNDRED AND TWENTY DOLLARS
FOR THAT SAME INSULIN. BECAUSE
THEY WOULD BE BENEFITING FROM
THOSE REBATES. AND NOT EXAMPLE.
THE HEALTH PLAN WILL CONTINUE TO
PAY NOTHING BECAUSE THE PATIENT
WAS IN THE DEDUCTIBLE PERIOD.
AND THEY WOULD STILL RECEIVE A
REBATE OF THIRTY FOUR DOLLARS.
WE THINK THAT THIS. MEASURE IS
IMPORTANT FOR CALIFORNIANS AND
WILL HELP THEM AT THE PHARMACY
COUNTER AND I- APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I BELIEVE WE HAVE
ANOTHER WITNESS ON THE PHONE-
MRS ODDLY UNDER CLARK WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. AFTERNOON KAREN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BUSINESS
ACTUALLY ON RECORD PART OF THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACCENT COALITION
SPONSORED EIGHTY NINE THIRTY
THREE. WE THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAILY IN OUR SPECS ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE CO AUTHOR OF THE TWELVE
MORE THAN THIRTY ORGANIZATIONS
FOR THEIR SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. OUR GOAL IS TO LOWER
PATIENTS OUT OF POCKET COSTS FOR
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. AT TWENTY
TWENTY STUDY BY THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH CARE FOUNDATION FOUND
THAT 51% OF CALIFORNIANS SKIP OR
POSTPONED CARE DUE TO COST. AND
OF THOSE WHO PUT OFF HERE 41%
SAID DOING SO WORTH IT WORSENED
THEIR CONDITION. THIS TREND-
GROWING HEALTHCARE DUE TO HIGH
COST IS UNTENABLE AN EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY THREE PROVIDE THE REMEDY
ASSEMBLY SHOULD NOT FIX TO FIX
THE PRESCRIPTION DRUG BREEDING
HAS DONE. ACCORDING TO A STUDY
RELEASED JUST DAYS AGO BY THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS
REVIEW PROGRAMS COMMISSION BY
THIS VERY COMMITTEE. EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY THREE WOULD SAVE AT LEAST
EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY SIX
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS NEARLY
SEVENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS THIS
YEAR ALONE. HOW BY CORRECTING A
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT THAT ALLOW
PRESCRIPTION DRUG REBATES PAID
BY PHARMACEUTICAL MANUFACTURERS
TO GO TO HEALTH INSURERS AND
PHARMACY BENEFIT MANAGER PROFIT.
RATHER THAN TO KEEP CONSUMERS
FROM WHICH THEY ARE INTENDED TO
HELP. THE SAVINGS TO PBMS AND
INSURERS UNDER THE CURRENT
REBATE SYSTEM ARE SIGNIFICANT.
AND WITH THE AVERAGE AMOUNT OF A
REBATE BEING 40% OFF THE LIST
PRICE OF THE MEDICATION FOR
EXAMPLE. IS THE LIST PRICE OF
THE DRUG OF A HUNDRED DOLLARS A
PDM CAN BECAUSE SHE TO REBATE A
FORTY DOLLARS MY MEDICATION FOR
THE PBMS AND THEIR INSURED
CLIENTS ONLY PAY SIXTY DOLLARS.
BUT UNDER THE CURRENT REBATE
SYSTEM AND UNLIKE MOST OTHER
CONSUMER REBATE PROGRAMS
TEACHING DON'T RECEIVE A DYNAMIC
THAT REBATE OUT THE PHARMACY
COUNTER. INSTEAD OF POPPING. THE
REBATES BACK TO PATIENT. IN PART
OF THE READING AND GIVE THEM
REST OF THE INSURANCE COMPANY.
INTO NINETY ALLOW. PBMS IN THE
U. S. NICO. IN POINT BILLION IN
READ IT OVERALL. AND A RECENT
FROM THE- OF HEALTHCARE FOUND
THAT IN TWENTY TWENTY. HEALTH
PLANS IN CALIFORNIA RECEIVED
MORE THAN ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
AND REBATES FROM MANUFACTURERS.
WHICH IS A 57% INCREASE FROM
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. TO WHILE PBMS
AND INSURERS MAKE BILLIONS
PATIENTS OFTEN END UP PAYING
MORE FOR THE PRESCRIPTION IN THE
PBMS AND INSURERS PAID FOR.
PATIENTS WHO HAVE NOT MET THEIR
HEALTH PLAN DEDUCTIBLE MAX PAY
OUT OF POCKET AT THE PHARMACY
COUNTER AND ARE OFTEN FORCED TO
PAY THE FULL PRICE OF THE
MEDICATION. NOT THE REBATE PRICE
HERE THE PBMS AND INSURERS ONLY
PAY SIXTY DOLLARS AS A PATIENT
HAS A HUNDRED. THIS BILL IF
NECESSARY TO LOWERING
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATION COSTS
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING
THE THOUSANDS OF SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THEIR EMPLOYEES
WHO HAVE HIGH DEDUCTIBLE HEALTH
PLANS AND FACE HIGH OUT OF
POCKET COSTS. MAKE IT DIFFICULT
AND OFTEN IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO
AFFORD THE MEDICATIONS THEY NEED
TO GET AND STAY WELL SO LET'S DO
THE RIGHT THING FOR CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WE DO HAVE TO
WITNESS. AN OPPOSITION SO GO
AHEAD MOVE ON TO THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE PLEASE-
I'M SORRY IN PERSON. YOU'RE BOTH
IN PERSON OKAY PLEASE COME
FORWARD AND SHOCKED SO THANK YOU
. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
NICKEL RESOURCE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
PLANS HAPPY NEW YEAR AND IT'S
GOOD TO BE HERE IN PERSON. AFTER
A COUPLE YEARS- WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS AGAIN
AND- YOU KNOW WE ARE REGRETTABLY
OPPOSE- EIGHTY NINE THIRTY
THREE. WE DO WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR ANY STAFF THEY BROUGHT US
IN EARLY ON IN THE PROCESS AS
THEY WERE DEVELOPING THIS
PROPOSAL. BUT I REGRETTABLY WE
HAVE A FUNDAMENTAL DISAGREEMENT-
WE BELIEVE THAT THE COST TO
EMPLOYERS EMPLOYEES AND
INDIVIDUALS FAR OUTWEIGH THE
BENEFITS OF THIS LEGISLATION.
AND THIS IS MOREMOST CLEARLY
DEMONSTRATED- BY THE CONCLUSIONS
OF THE INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS BY
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS
REVIEW PROGRAMMER CHIPPER. A
CHIPPER CONCLUDED THAT THIS BILL
WOULD INCREASE PREMIUMS IN THE
FIRST YEAR BY TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS- IN THE EMPLOYER
ANY DIFFICULT FOR EMPLOYERS AND
INDIVIDUALS AT COVERED
CALIFORNIA- SO THAT WOULD MAKE
IT THE SECOND HIGHEST THE
HIGHEST COSTA MANDATE BILL OF
THIS LEGISLATIVE SESSION. I'M
DISCUSSES ALMOST THREE TIMES A
PURPORTED SEVENTY MILLION DOLLAR
BENEFIT THAT WILL BE EXPERIENCED
BY SOME CONSUMERS. I'M IN OTHER
WORDS CONSUMERS WILL
COLLECTIVELY PAY MORE SO THAT
SOME MIGHT PAY LESS AND WE DON'T
BELIEVE IT'S REALLY PENCILS OUT.
A SIMILAR PROPOSAL WAS
CONSIDERED- AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
FOR MEDICARE PART D. UNDER THE
PRIOR FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION IN
THE MEDICARE PROGRAM IN THE
CONGRESSIONAL BUDGET OFFICE.
ULTIMATELY CONCLUDED THAT THE
PROPOSAL WOULD COST THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS OVER TEN YEARS. AND
THAT THE MAJORITY OF
BENEFICIARIES WOULD SEE AN
INCREASE IN THEIR TOTAL OUT OF
POCKET COSTS AND PREMIUMS. SO WE
DON'T BELIEVE WE SHOULD BE
TRYING TO SING CALIFORNIA. ON
THE OTHER ISSUES WITH THIS BILL
FROM POLICY PERSPECTIVE ARE. IT
LEADS TO A PRIORITIZATION OF
EXPENSIVE BRAND NAME DRUGS- OVER
LOW COST ALTERNATIVES LIKE
GENERICS. IN THIS IS BECAUSE
REBATES ARE REALLY FOUND. ON THE
BRAND NAME DRUG SIDE- ALSO
THERE'S NO EASY WAY TO IMPLEMENT
THIS BILL- REBATES ARE NOT
ALWAYS. REAL TIME FOR MANY OF
THE HEALTH PLANS. A REBATE MAY
NOT BE GRANTED ARE GRANTED IN
THE- ESTIMATE EXPECTED. IN THERE
ARE A VARIETY OF REASONS FOR
THIS IT WOULD TAKE LONGER THAN I
HAVE. BUT IN MANY CASES IF THERE
IS A REBATE IT ISN'T ACTUALLY
SECURED UNTIL THREE TO SIX
MONTHS LATER IF NOT LONGER. SO
THIS BILL DOES NOT ADEQUATELY
ADDRESS IN OUR VIEW. THE
FUNDAMENTAL IMPLEMENTATION ISSUE
. MEMBERS ARE ARE ENROLLEES
ALREADY BENEFIT FROM THE REBATES
THAT OUR MEMBERS ARE ABLE TO
SECURE FROM THE DRUG
MANUFACTURERS. THESE REDUCE
REDUCE THE OVERALL SPEND FOR
PLANS WHICH ALLOWS MY MEMBERS TO
KEEP PREMIUMS IN CHECK. FOR
INSTANCE ACCORDING TO THE LATEST
SB SEVENTEEN TRANSPARENCY
REPORTS ISSUED BY REGULATORS.
REBATES HELPS DRUG REBATES HELP
REDUCE TOTAL HEALTH PLAN
PREMIUMS BY ONE POINT 8% IN
TWENTY TWENTY. THAT'S ABOUT TEN
DOLLARS PER MEMBER PER MONTH. SO
WHY WOULD WE WANT TO INTERFERE
WITH THE ABILITY PLAN STOPS IT
PREMIUMS ARE REBATES. FINALLY
ARE QUALIFIED HEALTH PLANS THAT
COVER CALIFORNIA- ARE WORKING ON
COST SHARING REDUCTION
STRATEGIES WITH THE EXCHANGE.
THAT CAN BE IMPLEMENTED IN A WAY
THAT AVOIDS THE PITFALLS OF THIS
BILL. THAT WORK WAS REQUIRED
LAST YEAR THROUGH THE BUDGET.
AND IT WAS ALLUDED TO IN THE IN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
YESTERDAY. SO WE APPRECIATE THE
INTENT BEHIND THE AMENDMENTS-
HOWEVER IT DOESN'T HELP AVOID
THE MASSIVE FIRST YEAR COSTS OF
THIS BILL. SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OUR
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PRESTON YOUNG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE TODAY AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO AB NINE THIRTY
THREE WELL CERTAINLY WELL
INTENTIONED BILL IT
UNFORTUNATELY COMES ALONG WITH
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OUR
PRIMARY CONCERN WITH AB NINE
THREE THREE IS THAT DESPITE
PHARMACEUTICAL PRICES REMAINING
UNAFFECTED THEIR COST INCREASES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BILL IS FOR
PRINT CHAMBER ANALYSIS INDICATED
THE BILL BECAUSE EMPLOYER
PREMIUMS TO RISE NEARLY A
HUNDRED NINE MILLION DOLLARS IN
EMPLOYEE PREMIUMS RISE OVER
FORTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS. A
CONCERN EIGHTY NINE THIRTY THREE
WOULD BENEFIT A SMALL GROUP OF
PATIENTS ALL PATIENTS WOULD HAVE
TO PAY MORE FOR THE HEALTHCARE
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS AVERAGE
FAMILY HEALTH PLAN PREMIUMS HAVE
INCREASED 22% A TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY KAISER FAMILY FOUNDATION
OF POOR HEALTH BENEFITS SURVEY
INDICATED THAT FOR JOB BASED
COVERAGE THE AVERAGE ANNUAL
PREMIUM FOR FAMILY COVERAGE IS
210-003-0040 TWO DOLLARS. WELL
THE NINE THIRTY THREE ADDRESSES
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE NO DOUBT WE
NEED TO REMAIN COGNIZANT OF THE
IMPACT OF THESE MANDATES HAVE ON
DRIVING HEALTH CARE COSTS UPWARD
WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS WE APPRECIATE THE
CONSIDERATION THAT WENT INTO
THIS BILL UNFORTUNATELY WITH THE
TO YOUR SUNSET DATE THE COST
WILL STILL BE IMPACTING
EMPLOYERS IN THE STATE SO FOR
THESE REASONS WE ARE-
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED AB NINE
THREE THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE CHAMBER IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. C. NINE
ANYBODY AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
SITE. LOOKS PRETTY DARK THERE
RIGHT NOW SO- WILL COME BACK TO
THE TELEPHONE FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST YOUR
NAME YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL
AND YOUR ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE. AND IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SPEAK ON THIS LEGISLATION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. STARLINE ONE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEX
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION IN STRONG ORDER. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ACTUALLY
HAVE LINE ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. STEVEN CHOI
JOKES- WITH THE ARTHRITIS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THANKS
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WHY NUMBER TWO THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOHN WEGER ON
BEHALF OF AMERICA'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU SIX CODE PLEASE. MY
NUMBER TWO NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. STOP IT AFTER TAMI IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MY NUMBER TWO OH SEVEN
TWO ZERO SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES HELLO- SANDY MARQUEZ PLASTER
COUNTY AND IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
BILL THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE TWO THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU KAREN
MEMBERS ANDRE TO TEARS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
BEFORE THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MY NUMBER ONE FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI LAUREN
THINKING WITH THE K. FOREIGN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE ONE TWELFTH PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FIND NEW DEAL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
OF COMMUNITY BEER HALL AGENCIES
AND COMPORT THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BY NUMBER TWO
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FEELING AGGRIEVED BY A CALM
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE TWO FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH I'M IN OF OPPOSITION
EVENTS THAT THE SHANNON CARE ACT
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
LINE ONE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SH YES NICOLE YANG
CALIFORNIA CITIZEN IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. ONE ONE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
. REDDING CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
RIGHTS INSTRUCT IN STRONG
SUPPORT SYNC YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MY NUMBER ONE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. REBECA
GONZALEZ NATIONALIST ATTENTION A
SOCIAL WORKER CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
IN THE PROPERTY THANK YOU NEXT
CALL PLEASE. TWO TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURST AT THE WATKINS ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU NEXTCODE PLEASE. ONE TO
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS GOT TO GO WITH THE LIVER
COALITION OF SAN DIEGO CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE THIRTY
THREE. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MY NUMBER TWO THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY TWO
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ALISON RAINY ON BEHALF OF THE
PHARMACEUTICAL CARE MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY
NUMBER TWO TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GABRIELLE AND GRANDPA
LEFT IN OFFICE THANKS THANK YOU. ONE TO THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY ARE THEY DROPPED OUT
OF Q. ONE TWO FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWO FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IT IS MY LINE YES
. OKAY YEAH I WOULD LIKE TO
OPPOSITION HONESTLY OKAY THANK
YOU. NEXT CALL PLEASE MY NUMBER
TWO FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
MEAN LISA LAST SACRAMENTO COUNTY
AND STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
MEXICO REPLACE. CHRIS NEXT WAVE
LINE NUMBER TWO FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS TYLER
BASICALLY IN PARKER COUNTY AND
OPPOSITION PLEASE THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE Y. NUMBER ONE NINETY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE NINETY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE INTO AT THIS TIME OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
STRUCTURE COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SO I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS- AND- I GUESS
THE FIRST ONE FIRST OF ALL
APPRECIATE THE INTENT OF THE
BILL- AND I THINK ALL ALL
CONSUMERS WILL HAVE LOWER
PRICES- AND- THAT IS A THAT IS
ADMIRABLE- AS I'VE SAID FROM THE
BEGINNING I'VE ALWAYS BEEN A
LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS WE'VE
HEARD THAT SOMETIMES ARE REBATES
NOW TAKE. MY TAKE SEVERAL MONTHS
SO I DON'T KNOW HOW WE DO THAT
AT A POINT OF SALE. YOU'VE BEEN
TO A PHARMACY LATELY REALIZE
THAT- IT SOMETIMES TAKES TEN
YEAR TEN TIMES LONGER JUST TO
PICK UP A PRESCRIPTION THAT THAT
YOU'VE BEEN THAT THAT WAS CALLED
IN EVEN DAYS BEFORE SO WE'RE
TASKING. BUT OVER WORK SYSTEM
WITH SOMETHING NEW THAT. IS
GOING TO BE REALLY DIFFICULT TO
IMPLEMENT AND SO THAT'S WHY I'VE
SAID MY IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS
OF HAVE BEEN THERE FOR THE YES
AND I RESPECT THOSE MISTER
CHAIR- BUT I GUESS MY QUESTION
FOR THE PROPONENTS IS. WHAT
KEEPS THE DRUG COMPANIES FROM
JUST. RAISING PRICES EVEN HIGHER
. I MEAN I DON'T SEE ANY I SEE I
SEE POTENTIAL. CONSUMER BENEFIT.
ON THE REBATE. BUT I DON'T SEE A
BENEFIT. ANYTHING THAT HELPS TO
KEEP THE PRICES LOWER. OR FROM
GOING HIGHER NEEDLESSLY. HI
CHAIRMAN LLOYD THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION I THINK WHAT WE HAVE
SEEN IN IN THE MARKET OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS IS THAT
COMPETITION TO MAKE PRICES MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR HEALTH PLANS AND
PBMS IS REALLY ON THE REBATED
PRICE AND SO THEY ARE LOOKING TO
GET A BETTER PRICE ON THEIR
DRUGS THROUGH NEGOTIATING A
HIGHER REBATE SO OVER TIME WE
HAVE SEEN. GROWTH IN REBATES IF
YOU LOOK JUST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE'VE GONE FROM A
NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN REBATES BEING
PAID TO ONE FOUR POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN REBATES AND
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S CREATED A
PERVERSE INCENTIVE WHERE A
HIGHER REBATE IS ACTUALLY
PREFERRED OVER A LOWER LIST
PRICE DRUG AND SO YOU KNOW WHILE
THIS BILL DOES NOT ADDRESS THAT
SYSTEM THAT I THINK IS IN NEED
OF FIXING IT DOES MAKE SURE THAT
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER IS
BENEFITING- FROM THOSE REBATE AS
AS THEY GO UP HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. I GUESS IF THE
REBATES IF THIS SYSTEM IS A
PROBLEM WHY WHY WOULDN'T YOU BE
LOOKING AT A WAY TO CHANGE THE
REBATE SYSTEM WHERE THE PROBLEM
IS RATHER THAN TRYING THIS ANGLE
OF IT BECAUSE CLEARLY I KNOW
WHERE THE PROBLEM IS YOU KNOW
WHERE THE PROBLEM IS YOU YOU
ILLUSTRATED VERY GOOD POINT. M.
OFTEN AS PART OF THE FORMULARY
WANT THAT BIGGER REBATES SO A
LESS EXPENSIVE DRUG DOESN'T GET
CONSIDERED BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO GET AS MUCH OF A
REPAIR. SO WHY NOT GO AFTER THAT
AS A WAY TO HELP PROTECT THE
CONSUMER BECAUSE THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY LOWER PREMIUMS
BECAUSE THE YOUR BILL. ACTUALLY
WILL LEAD TO INCREASE PREMIUMS
AS WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
OPPOSITION SO. HELP ME
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU WOULDN'T GO
IN THAT DIRECTION. I THINK YOU
KNOW PHARMA DOES SUPPORT RIGHT-
TRANSFORMING THE REBATE SYSTEM
AT A FEDERAL LEVEL- I THINK
DOING THAT AT A STATE BY STATE
BASIS COULD. COULD HAVE THE
PERVERSE INCENTIVES IN A
CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC MARKET PLACE
SO REALLY WE NEED TO SEE IT
CHANGED AT A NATIONAL LEVEL- AS
FAR AS THE POINT ON PREMIUMS
HEARING CALIFORNIA I DO WANT TO
NOTE AS PART OF THAT TRIP BURKE
REPORTS THAT WHILE. EXPENDITURES
ARE EXPECTED TO GROW TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. A MAJORITY OF
THAT IS DUE TO- X. THE
EXPECTATION THAT PEOPLE ARE MORE
ADHERENT TO THEIR MEDICINE AND
THAT THERE IS INCREASED
UTILIZATION AND THEN ALSO
INCREASED COST TO THE PLAN FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. OKAY I
STILL I STILL DON'T SEE WHERE
THERE'S ANY INCENTIVE OR OR ANY
ANY WAY TO KEEP. THE COST AND
THE PRICE THE PRICES FROM GOING
UP. SO WHAT ABOUT SOMEONE WHO
DOESN'T HAVE INSURANCE COME
COVERAGE OR HAS A REALLY HIGH
DEDUCTIBLE AND HAS TO PAY THAT
DEDUCTIBLE. THERE'S NOT GOING TO
BE A READ THAT THERE MAY NOT BE
A REBATE ABOUT AVAILABLE TO THEM
SO HOW DOES THAT HELP THAT
CONSUMER BECAUSE THERE'S A WHOLE
LOT OF PEOPLE OUT THERE. WHO
DON'T HAVE. THE YOU KNOW HE MAY
NOT HAVE A PLAN THAT ALLOWS THEM
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF A REBATE SO
HOW DOES THAT HELP THAT CONSUMER
. I THINK. WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE HAVE INSURANCE HEALTH
CARE IS NOT BUT THAT WASN'T MY
QUESTION. IF THAT WAS MICHAEL IF
I IF I DON'T HAVE INSURANCE. AND
YOUR PRICE IS REALLY HIGH AND
YOU KEEP RAISING PRICES. BECAUSE
YOU'RE GONNA GET REBATES TO
SOMEBODY. HOW DOES THAT HELP THE
POOR PERSON WHO DOESN'T HAVE
MEDICATION INSURANCE. AND THEN
THE POINT IS THAT WE'RE FOCUSING
ON A SMALL GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE INURANCE. AND WE'RE
FOCUSING ON THOSE HIGH PRICE
DRUGS- THAT THAT THAT ARE OUT
THERE SO HOW DOES IT HELP THAT
POOR PERSON WHO DOESN'T HAVE
INSURANCE. GOING TO THE COUNTER
AND GET STUCK WITH THAT BIG BILL
HELP ME HELP ME UNDERSTAND THAT.
I THINK QUITE FRANKLY SPELL IT
DOESN'T ADDRESS PEOPLE THAT
DON'T HAVE INSURANCE SO YOU
DON'T HAVE INSURANCE AND YOU
DON'T GET A REBATE. YOU JUST PAY
THE HIGH PRICE. CORRECT THAT
DOESN'T FEEL VERY FAIR TO ME.
ALL THE AND I WILL SAY FOR
PATIENTS THAT DON'T HAVE
INSURANCE WE DO HAVE
MANUFACTURERS ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS TO HELP MAKE THEIR
MEDICATIONS MORE AFFORDABLE- AS
FOR THE PATIENT WHO IS AT A HIGH
DEDUCTIBLE HEALTH PLAN THIS IS
THE BILL THAT'S GOING TO HELP
THEM THE MOST BECAUSE WHEN
THEY'RE EXPOSED TO THE LOWEST
PRICE IT'S WHEN THEY'RE IN THEIR
DEDUCTIBLE PERIOD- SO THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE ANYTIME THAT THEY'RE
IN THE DEDUCTIBLE THAT THEY
ACTUALLY BENEFIT FROM THAT NOT
PRICE OF THE MEDICINE THE
REBATED PRICE OF THE MEDICINE
NOT THE HIGHER LIST PRICES AND I
JUST I. SO WHEN I JUST LOWER THE
PRICES YOU KNOW YOU KNOW YOU'RE
GONNA GET THE ROUTE YOU KNOW YOU
KNOW WHERE THE- YOU KNOW WHAT
THE- THE WHOLESALE ACQUISITION
COSTS ARE YOU KNOW WHAT I WAS.
WHEN I JUST LOWER THE PRICES AND
MAKE IT AFFORDABLE FOR. PEOPLE
WITHOUT REPAYING. YEAH I THINK.
THIS IS DEFINITELY A COMPLEX
SYSTEM- AND OUR PRICES ARE NOT
SET IN A VACUUM AND THAT SAME.
U. S. SENATE FINANCE COMMITTEE
REPORT. THEY LOOKED AT GENERIC
INSULIN THAT IS NOW COME TO
MARKET THERE'S A- BIOSIMILAR
INSULIN THAT COST. LESS THAN
HALF OF ANY BRAND NAME INSULIN
THAT'S ON THE MARKET TODAY. AND
LARGE FORMULA ARIES LIKE EXPRESS
SCRIPTS WHO HAS. A LARGER
POPULATION IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY
OF FRANCE. DOESN'T COVER THAT
INSULIN ON THEIR PREFERRED
FORMULARY. SO LET ME LET ME POSE
YOUR QUESTION THAT I'VE MY
PRODUCT ACTUALLY WE TALKED
YESTERDAY. THERE'S A THERE'S A
MEDICATION FOR THE TREATMENT OF
KOVAN- THERE'S A COUPLE OF THEM
BUT I'LL JUST TAKE TAKE ONE NOT
GONNA NAME THE COMPANY. THE COST
FOR THAT TEN DAY COURSE OF
TREATMENT IS SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS. NOW INDIA HAS CREATED A
GENERIC DRUG. THAT COSTA TEAM IS
EIGHTEEN DOLLARS. SO AND THAT
SAME COMPANIES CAN INVEST IN
OTHER COMPANIES IN INDIA. HOW
DID THAT COMPANY IN INDIA TO
PROVIDE THIS **** THIS DRUG TO
OTHER LOWER LOWER LOWER INCOME
COUNTRIES AT THAT LOWER PRICE.
SO IN THIS COUNTRY OF WITH THIS
IF THIS COURSE OF TREATMENT IS
SEVEN YOU KNOW SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO THE DRUG COMPANIES
ARE DRUG COMPANY GOING TO BE
WILLING TO REBATE SIX HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO DOLLARS TO THE
CONSUMER BECAUSE THAT'S A YEAH
WE CAN DO IT IN ANOTHER COUNTRY-
WHY CAN'T WE DO IT HERE. I DON'T
KNOW THE SPECIFICS OF THE DAY-
KOBE NINETEEN TREATMENT THAT
YOU'RE SPEAKING OUT BY. I CAN
TELL YOU THAT FOR ANY- TREATMENT
THAT WAS DEVELOPED FOR KOBE
NINETEEN THAT THAT FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS- PROCURED THOSE
THOSE TREATMENTS AND VACCINES
AND ARE GUARANTEED- SPECIAL
PRICING AND BEST PRICING SO THEY
ARE GETTING REBATES AND
DISCOUNTS ON THAT MEDICATION.
AND WE'RE PAYING FOR IT AS
CONSUMERS AS TAXPAYERS AS WELL.
WHEN IT WHEN WE WHEN WE DO SO-
YOU KNOW AND I. I WILL SAY YOU
KNOW WOW WELL THE BILL CLAIMS TO
YOU KNOW HIM IMPROVE PATIENT
ACCESS TO DRUGS I AM
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE APPROACH-
TO REBATES AT THE POINT OF SALE
BECAUSE I DON'T SEE HOW YOU
IMPLEMENT THAT. TIME WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THAT- AND THE
INCENTIVE TOWARDS HIGH COST
EXPENSIVE BRAND NAME DRUGS ARE
ARE THERE ARE THERE IS AN
INCENTIVE IN THAT DIRECTION
RATHER THAN TOWARDS GENERICS
BECAUSE- THAT. THAT'S THAT'S HOW
I VIEW THIS SYSTEM- AND WE'RE
NOT REALLY LOOKING AT A KEPT
TAKING A COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT
THE RISING COST OF PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS MATTER FACT THERE'S
NOTHING TO PREVENT THE COMPANY'S
FROM ACTUALLY DOING THAT- AND
THE- IMPACTS OF HEALTH CARE
COSTS AND AFFORDABILITY- I'M-
YOU KNOW. I'D LIKE AN INSURANCE
THAT THE CONSUMERS WILL ACTUALLY
BENEFIT FROM THE BILL AND THAT'S
WHEN. YOU KNOW WHITE WE'VE- PUT
OUT THE A AMENDMENTS WHICH HAVE
AGREED TO AND I THINK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THAT. IT WOULD ASK FOR
AMENDMENTS- AND AN ANNUAL REPORT
OF THE DRUGS IMPACT ON A
PRESCRIPTION DRUG SPENDING. AND
HEALTH CARE PREMIUMS. HI IN
SPITE OF MY REALLY POINTED
COMMENTS HERE I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. BECAUSE
OF THE INTENT. AND MY HOPE IS
THAT DURING THE PROCESS THERE
WILL BE YOU WILL BE ABLE TO
ANSWER SOME OF THE QUESTIONS I
HAVE RUN IMPLEMENTATION WILL BE
WATCHING CLOSELY IF THE BILL
COMES BACK ON CONCERT
CONCURRENCE. IT HOPEFULLY MEETS
THAT MEETS WHAT WE'RE WE'RE ALL
LOOKING FOR HERE- BEFORE THAT
BILL. WOULD MOVE FORWARD SO. I
WITH THAT- WOULD YOU LIKE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER DAVE
MISTER CHAIR I RESPECT THE- MORE
GLOBAL. CONCERNS YOU'VE
EXPRESSED. ABOUT TO. THE PRICE
OF DRUGS OVERALL. AND I RESPECT
YOUR- DISLIKE OF THE REBATE
SYSTEM THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO
TAKE A PART OF THAT REBATE
SYSTEM AND MAKE IT BETTER
HOPEFULLY IT'LL IT'LL CAUSE NO
DAMAGE ELSEWHERE- SHOULD IT
BECOME LAW- AND I THINK WE'LL
ALL LEARN IF THE BILL DOES
BECOME LAW WE'LL ALL LEARN A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT. WHAT THE
REBATES SKEWS ME THE REBATE
SYSTEM. THAT YOU HAVE CONCERNS
WITH AND I THINK MANY PEOPLE DO-
BUT THIS IS ONE STEP FORWARD I
THINK- OF PROGRESS ON THAT
SUBJECT AND- WITHOUT ALL ASK OF
THE COMMITTEE TO APPROVE THE
BILL AND AGAIN WE'VE TAKEN LOTS
OF AMENDMENTS AT YOUR REQUEST
AND HAPPY TO DO SO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I'M THINKING THANK
YOU TO OUR WITNESSES AS WELL-
THE MINUTE YOU HAVE ACCEPTED OUR
AMENDMENTS THE BILL IS- I DON'T
KNOW IF WE HAVE A MOTION. WE DO
HAVE MUCH I APOLOGIZE-
EMOTIONALLY MISTER HIS HEARING
THE SECOND BY MR RODRIGUEZ. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MINISTER TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHAT I
WHAT I ROBERT RIVAS.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM AYE BURKE BURKE I
CARILLO. LARA LARA AYE
MAIENSCHEIN. MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN. THREE OF US RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
AYE WALDRON WALDRON I. CAN THE
VOTE IS THE BILL HAS TEN VOTES
HERE OUT WILL BE WITH THE BILLS
OUT WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR OTHERS THAT ON THANK YOU TO
ALL COMMITTEE MEMBERS
APPRECIATED THANK YOU MISTER
DALY. MR LEVINE. SHOULD THE
VENUE HAVE AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
FIVE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
WANT TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS RECOMMENDED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS IS AUTHOR
AMENDMENTS AS AGREED TO BY
COMMITTEE STAFF THESE AMENDMENTS
WILL BE TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
THANK YOU BY THE WAY FOR A-
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS BILL
OVER THE COURSE OF THE PAST
YEAR- REALLY APPRECIATE IT VERY
MUCH. AB THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE
WOULD EXPAND THE RIGHT TO
INDEPENDENT MEDICAL REVIEWS I AM
ARE AS TALL MEDIKAL MEMBERS
REGARDLESS OF PLAN OR SERVICE AN
INDEPENDENT MEDICAL REVIEW IS A
SECONDARY REVIEW. OF THE DENIAL
OF THE MEDICAL SERVICE BY AN
INDEPENDENT PANEL OF PHYSICIANS
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE HAVE ACCESS
TO I AM OURS THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE. FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE HOWEVER NOT ALL
MEDICAL MEMBERS HAVE THE RIGHT
TO AN EXTERNAL APPEAL REVIEWED
BY CLINICAL EXPERTS. THE IMR
OPTION IS NOT AVAILABLE TO OVER
FOUR MILLION MEDI CAL PATIENTS.
ADDITIONALLY MANY SERVICES ARE
NOT PROVIDED BY CERTAIN MEDIKAL
PLANS ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR I AM
MORE INCLUDING SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH. MOST DENTAL SERVICES AND
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS PROVIDED
THROUGH MEDICAID ARE ACTS
AFFECTED JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. AB THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE WILL
BRING PARITY IN ACCESS TO AYE
EMAAR'S AMONGST MEDICARE MEMBERS
AND FOR SERVICES NOT PROVIDED BY
THE PLAN. AND IMPROVE THE STATE
FAIR HEARING PROCESS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I BELIEVE
HAVE COUPLE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WILL- WE'LL TAKE OUR WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE AND
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD BUT- GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHEN MEMBERS BY THE FASHION ON
WITH LEGAL SERVICES OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE PROVIDE DIRECT
LEGAL ASSISTANCE TO HELP
CONSUMERS IN THIRTY TWO COUNTIES
IN NEARLY HALF OF THOSE COUNTY
AS MEDICARE ENROLLEES DO NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE ACCESS TO
INDEPENDENT MEDICAL REVIEW WHEN
THERE TONIGHT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES BASED ON MEDICAL
NECESSITY FOR THOSE CONSUMERS
WHEN THEY ARE DENIED HEALTHCARE
SERVICE A HEART SURGERY A
PRESCRIPTION PATIENTS THEIR ONLY
OPTION FOR APPEALING TO DO NOW
IS TO GO TO THE STATE FAIR
HEARING PROCESS. IS PROBLEMATIC
BECAUSE YOU THEN HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE WITH NO
MEDICAL TRAINING OR CLINICAL
EXPERIENCE EVALUATING MEDICAL
EVIDENCE SUGGESTS PATIENT
RECORDS MEDICAL JOURNALS STUDIES
AND LAB TESTS TO MAKE AND THEN
MEDICAL THE TECHNICIAN CITY
DETERMINATION. TO PROVIDE AN
EXAMPLE I HAD A CLIENT WHO WAS
DENIED A MEDICATION BECAUSE THE
HEALTH PLAN BELIEVED IT WAS NOT
MEDICALLY NECESSARY. YOUR DOCTOR
THE CONSUMERS DOCTOR AND HEALTH
PLANS MEDICAL DIRECTOR PRESENTED
OPPOSING MEDICAL OPINION ON THE
CONSUMERS CONDITION AND
APPROPRIATE TREATMENT
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE NOT
FULLY UNDERSTANDING THE RELEVANT
MEDICAL LITERATURE AND UNSURE OF
WHICH DOCTOR TO SIDE WITH
DECIDED TO STAY THE HEARING IN
ASK THE CONSUMER TO CONSULT THE
THIRD SPECIALIST AS A TIE
BREAKER THE CONSUMER ULTIMATELY
GOT HIS MEDICATION BUT THE
HEARING PROCESS TOOK SIX MONTHS
AND ADDED AN UNNECESSARY STRAIN
TO THE HEALTH SYSTEM BY
REQUIRING THE CONSUMER TO GO TO
AN ADDITIONAL SPECIALTY CARE
APPOINTMENT. IN A PLAN WITH I AM
ARE THAT CONSUMERS APPEAL WOULD
HAVE GONE STRAIGHT TO
INDEPENDENT DOCTOR FOR IF YOU
ACCESS TO INDEPENDENT MEDICAL
REVIEW ENSURES THE CLINICIANS
EVALUATE CLINICAL CRITERIA AND
EVIDENCE AND MAKE CLINICAL
DETERMINATIONS ACT MEDICAL
NECESSITY NOT ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGES WITHOUT CLINICAL TRAINING
AND EXPERIENCE MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES AND NON I AM MARK
COUNTY PLANS DESERVE TO HAVE THE
SAME RIGHTS AND PROTECTIONS OF
ALL OF THE MEDICAL MANAGED CARE
MEMBERS AND LEGAL SERVICES
ACCOUNTING CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
URGES. YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IN NEXT. WITNESS BY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS WENT
AWAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY PROUD SPONSORS OF AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE WHICH WOULD
EXTEND INDEPENDENT MEDICAL YOU
OUR MEDIC HEALTH SERVICE AMOUNT
BASED ON MEDICAL NECESSITY.
ATTENTION ALL CURRENTLY ALL
COMMERCIAL HEALTH PLAN ENROLLEES
CAN APPEAL HEALTHCARE SERVICE
AND NOW TO AN INDEPENDENT
MEDICAL REVIEW DONE BY IMPARTIAL
MEDICAL EXPERTS HOWEVER FROM
THAT ACCOUNT. EMILY'S THIS
DEPENDS ON WHERE THEY LIVE WHAT
PLAN THERE AND WHAT SERVICE
THEY'RE SEEKING HE SAID- IT.
INDIVIDUALS DEVELOP A JONES HAVE
ACCESS TO A STATE FAIR HEARING
WHICH MAY MAKE SENSE FOR
ELIGIBILITY CASES BUT NOT FOR
MEDICAL NECESSITY DETERMINATIONS
WHICH REQUIRED MEDICAL
EXPERTISE. THISIS EVIDENT IN
THE OUTCOME INDEPENDENT MEDICAL
REVIEW IS MORE FAVORABLE TO
CONSUMER BECAUSE OVER 60% OF THE
TIME DECISIONS ARE RULED IN THE
CONSUMER'S CARE VESUS LESS THAN
30% FOR STATE FAIR HEARING
DECISION. THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION ENERGY SUPPORT TO
ENSURE MEDIC CAL MEMBERS HAVE
THE SAME APPEAL RIGHT AND ACCESS
TO MEDICALLY NECESSARY SERVICE.
REGARDLESS OF PLAN TYPE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WHEN
THEY MOVE ON TO OTHER WITNESSES
IN THE CHAMBER ANYBODY IN. FAVOR
OR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THE
CHAMBER. SEE NO ONE IS THERE
ANYONE OF THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
SITE I ASSUME AT THE SCREEN
START THAT MEANS THERE'S NO ONE
THERE CAN I ASSUME THAT I CAN'T
ASSUME THAT IT'S JUST DARK. OKAY
ALL RIGHT THE BILL WHEN IT THE
SAID QUITE OKAY THAT'S GOOD
THANK YOU WILL BRING. IT BACK TO
THE PHONE LINES- WITNESSES IN
SOME JUST NAME. POSITION ON THE
BILL WE'RE GOING TO IF REPRESENT
ONE. AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK
ON THIS LEGISLATION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AND OUR FIRST
LINE IS SLIGHT NUMBER SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NEAR
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WITH SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. OUR NEXT
LINE IS LINE NUMBER ONE OH THREE. HELLO IS GO AHEAD WELL. THIS
HI MY NAME IS THE MATHIS STALEY
AND I AM CALLING ON BEHALF OF
ALL CALIFORNIA CITIZENS AS WELL
AS MY ELDERLY MOTHER AND I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND THAT
WOULD BE LINE TWO OH SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI THIS IS
DANTE MARQUEZ AND- I- I DID NOT
OPPOSE I SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
THANK YOU. AND NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THAT WOULD BE LINE ONE
FIFTY PLEASE BUT- CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY RIGHTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE HAVE LIKE TWO FORTY
TWO PLEASE BUT. MISTER JOSE
TOWARD THE TOP ACTIVE CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE BUT. SEVENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DO YOU WANT
TO THEIR GOT- WE HAVE CLIMBED TO
SEVENTY TWO. THREE RIVERA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND WE HAVE ONE
LAST ONE JUST GETTING THEIR LINE
NUMBER ONE MOMENT. WE HAVE LINE. TWO SEVENTY FOUR IS WHAT.
RIGHT- THIS IS THE WHITE TEAM
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND THERE ARE NO FOR THE
COLORS LIKE YOU VERY WELL THANK
YOU- WITH THAT WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
C. NINE YOUR BILL DOES ENJOYED
PASS. TO APPROPRIATIONS OR WILL
BE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE GONNA BE
TAKEN APPROPRIATIONS AND I THANK
YOU IN ADVANCE FOR ACCEPTING
THOSE- WHICH I THE CLOSENESS
LEVINE. YEAH I THINK YOU VERY
MUCH MR SURE THANK YOU MEMBERS
THIS BILL IS A FINE PRINT BILL
YOU'VE GOT TO READ THE FINE
PRINT ON YOUR INSURANCE AND SO
WHEN COMMERCIAL CARRIERS HAVE-
SOME RIGHTS THAT. THOSE ON MEDI
CAL DON'T HAVE AND WE'RE
EXPANDING MEDIKAL AND YOU'RE
CONSIDERING. EVEN MORE
EXPANSIVE- WAYS TO COVER ALL
CALIFORNIANS. READ THE FINE
PRINT MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ON
THOSE PROGRAMS HAVE. THE RIGHTS
OF OTHER PEOPLE I LIKE WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE IN THIS BILL.
TO EXPAND INDEPENDENT MEDICAL
REVIEW THANK YOU ARE STRUCK
CLASS FOR NINE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR LEVINE- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WE HAVE A
MOTION BY. WE DON'T HAVE A
MOTION YET WE HAVE. WE HAVE A
MOTION NOW BY MISTAKE HERE KERR
IN THE SECOND BY MISTER FLORA-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHAT I WOULD HI
ROBERT RIVAS. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE BURKE. CARILLO.
FLORA FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN
MCCARTY MCCARTY I THIS AREA.
THREE OF US RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
HI SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO AYE
WALDRON WALDRON I. NINE ZERO
NINE ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS TO
ADD ON THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU AGAIN TO YOUR
STAFF AS WELL AS MEMBERS. THANKS
MISTER LIVING. MISTER NGUYEN.
YOU HAVE AB THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR. THANK HERE. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AB THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR WOULD
REQUIRE GENERAL ACUTE CARE
HOSPITALS TO ESTABLISH POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES TO SCREEN
PATIENTS FOR SUICIDE RISK
CALIFORNIA IS CONFRONTING A RISE
IN THE NUMBER OF SUICIDE
ATTEMPTS BUT DATA HAS SHOWN THAT
WE CAN WE CAN CHANGE THAT
DYNAMIC AND SAVE LIVES BY
INCREASING SCREENING FOR SUICIDE
IN MEDICAL SETTINGS WE MUST TAKE
THIS CRITICAL STEP TO IMPLEMENT
SUICIDE SCREENING IN OUR
HOSPITALS TO IDENTIFY LOVED ONES
WHO MAY BE STRUGGLING AND
CONNECT THEM TO SERVICES TO HELP
SAVE LIVES. WITH ME IN SUPPORT
IS DR JONATHAN GOLDFINGER CEO OF
D. HIRSCH MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
HELLO WE SERVE ROQUE OF AMERICAN
FOUNDATION FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE WILL MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES
FOR OUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON- EVERYONE
CHAIRPERSONS LED BY SHARE MAYES
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS JOHN GOLDFINGER AND I'M
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THAT
INCREDIBLE ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR. AS THE CEO
OF THE HARSH MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WHAT YOU MAY KNOW IS
THE HOME OF OUR NATION'S PREMIER
SUICIDE PREVENTION CENTER. WE
BOTH WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA GALING OF NINE EIGHT
EIGHT AT THE LARGEST PROVIDER ON
THE NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE. AND PARTNER WITH
NUMBER OF HOSPITALS ACROSS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO ENSURE
SUICIDE SPECIALIZED MENTAL
HEALTH CARE. FOR THOSE WHO NEED
IT. I'M ALSO HERE AS THE FATHER
OF TWO YOUNG CHILDREN A
PEDIATRICIAN AND THE COLLEAGUES
TO SO MANY IN OUR EMERGENCY ROOM
TODAY. WEIGHTLIFTING THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS UNFOLD. YOU
KNOW I HEAR ABOUT SUICIDE EVERY
DAY AND THAT'S EXCEEDINGLY HARD
ON ME EVEN AT THAT POSITION SO I
CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT.
WITNESSING LAST READ ANOTHER
DAMAGE THE BODIES AND MINDS
ALIKE. LIKE FOR MY COLLEAGUE.
TODAY I WANT TO REFLECT YOU WHAT
REALLY ACT NOW IT NAFTA TO
ENSURE THE APPROACH TO IT FOR. A
CALIFORNIA AND I KNOW YOU'LL
HEAR FROM A COLLEAGUE AT THE
AMERICAN FOUNDATION FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION JOINING ME IN THAT
TESTIMONY. I DON'T HAVE TO
BELIEVE OF THE DEVASTATING
MENTAL HEALTH IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC HIGHLIGHTED TODAY AND
STUDY AFTER STUDY THE SPECIALLY
THE YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
RECENTLY HIGHLIGHTED BY THE
HOOVER COMMISSION THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS AND UNITED
STATES SURGEON GENERAL. I ALSO
PROBABLY DON'T NEED TO REPEAT
WHAT YOU'VE READ ABOUT
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN SUICIDE
ATTEMPT. SUICIDE AND OVERDOSE IS
ESPECIALLY IN OUR YOUTH AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHO ARE
NOTABLY THE ONLY POPULATION DIED
BY SUICIDE AT HIGHER RATES
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
LAST CALENDAR YEAR. THE BILL IS
ABOUT PREVENT ATTEMPTS OFFICE
EVERYTHING IN OUR STATE. AND
EVERY PROVIDER WHO COMES IN
CONTACT WITH THE KIDS AND
ADULTS. CURRENTLY KNOWING THAT
OUR FRAGMENTED HEALTH SYSTEM
WILL LET THEM DOWN. YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY WITH AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FOUR TO ENSURE OUR
HOSPITALS AND EMERGENCY ROOMS
NEVER LET ANYONE DOWN. AND I
CAN'T TELL YOU AT THE DOCTOR WHO
STARTED AS A FIRST RESPONDER HOW
DEVASTATING IT CAN BE TO KNOW.
YOU COULD HAVE PREVENTED THE
LOTS OF A LOT IT INTO. KNOWING
THAT SOMEONE'S FATHER MOTHER
SISTER BROTHER IT REALLY AREN'T
YOU. OUR FIRST RESPONDERS AND
FRONTLINE WORKERS IN HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH CARE HAVE MIGHT
ENORMOUS GRATITUDE. AND THEY'RE
BRINGING EVERY LAST OUNCE OF
STRENGTH TO SERVE A WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE OUT OR WITHIN A
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE IS BEING
DRIVEN BY BURN OUT AND REALLY
ALL OF THIS TRAUMA. WE KNOW THIS
TAX READING WILL BEGIN TO CREATE
THEIR ABILITY TO GET PACKED IN
IMPACT THOSE AT RISK BEFORE IT
GETS. TOO LITTLE TOO LATE-
INCLUDING AND NOT LIMITED TO
THOSE FOR WHOM THE REASON FOR
THE VISIT. OR HOSPITALIZATION
WAS NOT SUICIDE. IN FACT THE ONE
STUDY. THE MOST IMPORTANT RESULT
AT SCREENING ACROSS STAKEHOLDERS
WHETHER PROFESSIONALS USE HERONS
OTHER ADULTS. WHAT THE ABILITY
TO ACCESS SHORT LEARN LONG TERM
FOLLOW UP AND TREATMENT OFFERED
ALBEIT THEY RECOGNIZED IT TO BE
A COMPLEX. OPPORTUNITY WHAT
EVERYONE AGREES WHAT IMMEDIATELY
FEASIBLE AS WHAT WE KNOW THE
STUDY AFTER STUDY ABOUT
UNIVERSAL SCREENING. THAT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EDUCATE THE
PATIENT. IS VERY FEASIBLE AND IN
MY EXPERIENCE CAN BE ENOUGH TO
CHANGE THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IN
A WAY THAT CAN MAKE ALL THE
DIFFERENCE. AND LET OUR
PROVIDERS IN OUR PATIENTS FEEL
THAT WE ARE THERE. FOR THEM.
UNIVERSAL'S ALSO BE TO STIGMA.
MENTAL HOW AND WE THAT YOUR
PASSED THE QUESTION AND MAKE IT
AND FORM. READ THE BARRIER TO
OUR CASE ARE ONES ACCESS CARE.
ACROSS THE- AND THAT WILL BE TO
LIVE A- CERTAIN A STANDARD I
TOOL THAT. SENSITIVE DEVELOPMENT
APPROPRIATE IT'S FEASIBLE AS A
BEEN DEMONSTRATED BY MULTIPLE
STUDIES IN PEDIATRIC EMERGENCY
ROOM. AND OUR EXPERIENCE IT'S
REALLY ABOUT HOW YOU INTRODUCED
QUESTION WHAT SHOULD BE
COMPETENCY. IN THE TRAINING THAT
HOSPITAL EMBARK UPON. INCLUDING
HERE'S MY CALL SERVICES URGES
ALL MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE TO ENDORSE AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FOUR CREATING THAT
CRITICAL PATHWAY TO CONFRONT THE
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS IN OUR
STATE. SPECIFICALLY THE RISING
SUICIDES AND ATTEMPTS. AND
RECOGNIZES THE ROLE THAT OUR
HOSPITAL PLAY DAY IN AND DAY OUT
TO SUPPORT OUR LOVED ONES WHO
MAY BE STRUGGLING AND THEIR
ABILITY TO SAVE THEIR LIFE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. GERMAN
WEDDING COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE
AMERICAN FOUNDATION FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION AFSP TESTIFIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR. WHICH WILL
HELP CONNECT CALIFORNIANS AT
RISK PERSON FINDS A LIFESAVING
RESOURCES BY REQUIRING GENERAL
ACUTE CARE HOSPITALS TO ADOPT
UNIVERSAL OKAY THANK GRADING
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES. EMPATHY
IS THE LEADING NATIONAL
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
EXCLUSIVELY DEDICATED TO SAVING
LIVES AND BRINGING HOPE TO THOSE
AFFECTED BY SUICIDE. SEVEN LOCAL
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS CARRY OUT
THIS MISSION ACROSS THE STATE.
FIVE CAN BE THROUGH EARLY THAT
OF INDIVIDUAL WHO ARE AT
INCREASED RISK BY CONNECTING
THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR
FAMILIES TO RESOURCES IN
TREATMENT. SCREENING AND
ASSESSMENT ALLOW FOR
INTERVENTION AND CAN SAVE LIVES
IN MANY CASES PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING SUICIDAL THOUGHTS
WILL NOT DISCLOSE THOSE BOX AND
LYFT PASSED EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS PRESENT A KEY
OPPORTUNITY TO IDENTIFY AND
TREAT THE INDIVIDUAL. AT THE
HIGHEST AND MOST IMMEDIATE RISK
FOR SUICIDE BASIC SCREENING AND
INTERVENTION CAN PROVIDE A
SAFETY NET FOR OUTBREAKS AT RISK
PATIENTS SEEN IN EIGHTY YEARS.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
APPROXIMATELY 40% OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO DIED BY SUICIDE PREVIOUSLY
VISITED AN EASY FOR REASONS
OTHER THAN A MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION OR SUICIDAL IDEATION
AND FORTUNATELY ENOUGH CASES. TO
FIGHT RENT OFTEN GOES UNDETECTED
AND ONLY 50% ANSWERED BY
DEFENDANT RESIDENT EIGHTY WITHIN
A YEAR OF THEIR DEATHS WERE
RECOGNIZED AS HAVING A MENTAL
HEALTH PROBLEM AFTER VISIT.
OVERALL APPROXIMATELY 6210% OF
ALL ADULT PATIENTS. ARE
EXPERIENCING SUICIDAL THOUGHTS.
TIMELY ACCESS MEANT HEALTH AND
CRISIS SERVICES CAN PAY LIVES.
AB THIRTEEN NINE FOUR WERE THAT
PATIENTS ABOUT AGE OF ARE
SCREENED FOR STIS RISK AS PART
OF THEIR OVERALL MEDICAL
SCREENING. OKAY SHOW SIGNS OF
SUICIDE RISK MUST BE PROVIDED
WITH INFORMATION ON AVAILABLE
CRISIS HOTLINE. WE ARE FOR A
LIST OF COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
AGENCIES WHERE PATIENTS CAN
ACCESS FURTHER EVALUATION
COUNSELING AND CARE. CRISIS
CENTERS CAN BE PARTNERS TO EDS
AND CARING FOR PATIENTS WITH
MIGRAINES. THE JOINT COMMISSION
AND NATIONAL STRATEGY FOR
SUICIDE PREVENTION BOTH
RECOMMENDED THAT EVERY ET
PATIENT WENT TO FIND REST CAN BE
HANDED WRITTEN INFORMATION WITH
THE PHONE NUMBER OF THE NEAREST
CRISIS CENTER BEFORE DISCHARGE.
AB THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR ALSO
ENCOURAGES HOSPITALS TO ADOPT
GUIDELINES SIMILAR TO THOSE
DEVELOPED BY THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE FOR MENTAL HEALTH.
REGARDING SCREENING FOR SUICIDE
RISK AND CARL CALLED. THE FOLLOW
LIMITATION EXHIBIT SIGNS OF
BEING AT. IMMINENT RISK FOR
SUICIDE. PROTOCOLS DESCRIBE HOW
TO SUPPORT PATIENTS- POSITIVE
ARE. BRIEF EDM. INTERVENTION
LIKE SUICIDE FIFTIETH. SAVE
PLANNING. AND FOLLOW UP CALLS
POST DISCHARGE CAN FURTHER
INCREASE SCREENING EFFECTIVENESS
AND SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE
SUBSEQUENT SUICIDE RISK WITH
LIMITED ADDITIONAL STOCK TIME.
MEMBERS AND THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
WE ALL HAVE A ROLE IN PREVENTING
SUICIDE THE EMBASSY CALIFORNIA
CHAPTERS ARE GRATEFUL FOR
CONSIDERATION AND I NOW ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND MOVING AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE DO HAVE ONE WITNESS A
REGISTERED WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION- PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN
YOU'RE READY. WITH THE MISTER
ALICE HAWTHORNE ARE YOU OUT
THERE. IF YOU'RE OUT THERE
SOMEWHERE BUT ARE YOU ON THE
PHONE. WE WHAT WHAT WILL WHAT
I'LL DO IS WE'LL MOVE ON TO
OTHER WITNESSES AND IF MISTER
HOPPER COMES ON THE PHONE WE
WILL ALLOW HIM TO DO HIS
TESTIMONY WHENEVER HE HE
APPEARS- THIS POINT IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE CHAMBER WHO. WOULD
LIKE TO. WAS SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION FOR THE BILL. SEE NO
ONE ANYONE AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SAY. NO ONE THERE OKAY
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE PHONES
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL AND ANY ORGANIZATION IF
YOU REPRESENT ONE- WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY MISTRUST REITER.
GOOD LINE TO FIFTY SEVEN.
NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE DO HAVE LINE
TO FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON ADRIAN SHELTON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND WE HAVE LINE TO EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
SAMANTHA FEELING AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF ALL CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS AND I'M CALLING TO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND WE HAVE
LINED TWO OH SEVEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS SANDY MERTENS LANCASTER
COUNTY AND I SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. EIGHT WE
HAVE LINE TO SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ZACH
COULDN'T- CONSTITUENT ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT TWENTY FIVE IN OUR
HIGHER WHICH- YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE
ONE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHE GETS ON THE KALIAN FROM
PASTOR COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. SIX
COLOR PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE TWO
OH FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRED SALAS SOUTH ON
THE TO CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION A LITTLE CONFUSION
WE'RE NOT OPPOSE FRACTION A
SUPPORT AMENDED POSITION JUST TO
ENSURE THAT OUR STAFF CAN USE
THEIR CLINICAL EXPERTISE AND
DISCRETION WHEN SCREENING
PATIENTS LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR ON THIS.
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BILL. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE
LINE ONE FIFTY THIS GUY. HI MY
NAME IS JERRY HICKS- WOULD
CALIFORNIA'S DISABILITY RIGHT
I'M I'M ALSO WITH THAT SUPPORT
OF AMENDED THINK I JUST WANTED
TO TALK TO HIM ABOUT IT.
ACCESSIBILITY TO MATERIALS FOR
PEOPLE WITH MENTAL ILLNESS. AND
PUT SOME TYPE OF TWENTY POINT
EIGHTY EIGHT CON- PLEASE HOLDERS
IN THERE OTHERWISE WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE- WE'RE GOOD WITH THE IDEA
WE JUST WANT MARK SENSIBILITIES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE CALL. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. HAVE LINE ONE TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FINALLY LET ME
HAVE A CALIFORNIA COUNSELOR
COMMUNITY BE THE HEALTH AGENCY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE HAVE ALIGNED TO
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN
GOVERNMENT PLASTER COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE THANK YOU THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. AND WE HAVE LINE TO
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD WELL
THIS FIVE. I'M NOT BE HAPPY
CALIFORNIA. HOPE. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. AND THERE ARE CURRENTLY
NO FURTHER COLLARS AND YOU VERY
WELL THANK YOU BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE MR
RODRIGUEZ. YES THANK YOU I WANT
TO THANK THE MEMBER FOR BRINGS
BILL FORD. YOU KNOW ONE OF THE-
CALLERS WHO CALLED IN THE
BEGINNING IN CALLING SUPPORT
MADE THE REFERENCE OF BEING A
FOR SPONSOR I THINK. AND THEY
JUST BROUGHT BACK A LOT OF
MEMORIES TO ME YOU KNOW IVE
WORKED OVER THIRTY YEARS AS A
FIRST RESPONDER. AND IT JUST
BROUGHT MEMORIES THAT HORRIFIED
MUSE OF SINNERS AND STORIES THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
PICKED UP THE- COMMITTED SUICIDE
FROM A NUMBER OF REASONS. THE
MOST DEVASTATING ONES WERE THE
KIDS RIGHT THAT WE PICKED UP-
AND WHAT THEY DID TO THEMSELVES
AND THE STORIES AND MAYBE FOLKS
MAY NOT BE. PREVIOUS TO THIS BUT
AS A FIRST RESPONDER SOMETIMES
WHEN WE GO TO PEOPLE'S HOUSES.
THAT HAVE COMMITTED SUICIDE.
THEY LEAVE NOTES. DIDN'T NEED
LOTS OF TO SAY WHY THEY DO WHAT
THEY DID. AND THERE'S BEEN MANY
TIMES I GOT TO SEE THOSE NOTES.
AND IT SEEMS LIKE IN THE STORIES
THEY WERE TALK ABOUT THEY DID
THE REACHING OUT FOR HELP AND
HELP WAS NEVER THERE FOR THEM.
BUT LOOK FOR THIS BILL PROVIDING
HELP AND GUIDANCE TO OUR- FOLKS
IN HOSPITAL SETTINGS TO HELP.
LOOK AT SOME OF THESE PATIENTS
THAT COME IN THE MAY HAVE SIGNS
OF SUICIDAL. TENDENCIES OR
THOUGHTS TO GET HIM THE HELP
THEY NEEDED. TO HELP STOP AND
PREVENT. ANYMORE SUICIDES GOING
ON IN OUR COMMUNITY SO I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU FOR BEING THIS
BILL FORD. AND LIKE TO BE SEE IF
I COULD JOIN AS AUTHORS WELL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR THE FOR THE AUTHOR
. C. NONE THE BILL DOES ENJOY A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION TO PASS
TO PREPARATIONS WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER FLOOR IN THE SECOND BY
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY WHICH I CLOSE
THE SERVICE I- APPRECIATE THE
THAT THE COLORS AND THE
WITNESSES- THE STATISTICS DON'T
LIE MOST OF. THE MOST OF THE
PEOPLE THAT. ATTEMPT SUICIDE
HAVE MADE MEDICAL VISITS 38%
WERE IN THE HOSPITAL- THE WEEKS
THEY ATTEMPTED SUICIDE SIXTY
FOUR IN THE MONTH THE 95% IN
THAT YEAR SO. AT BEING ABLE TO
IDENTIFY THOSE PEOPLE- DURING
MEDICAL VISITS IS CRITICAL AND I
JUST APPRECIATE WHAT- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ SAID IS THAT
JUST SOME. ABILITY TO HAVE
SOMEONE TO REACH OUT TO AND
SOMEBODY TO TALK TO AND IS IT
MAKES ALL THE DIFFERENCE. AND SO
I THINK IT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
I C. H. A. AS US SUPPORT IF
AMENDED WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH THEM AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK. TO GET THEM TO A PLACE
THAT DAY- FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH IRWIN-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHAT I WOULD I
ROBERT RIVAS. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM AYE BURKE. CORREO RIO
AYE FLORA FLORA HIGH MAIENSCHEIN
MCCARTY A PARTY OUTSIDE THIS
AREA. THREE OF US THREE OF US HI
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON WALDRON I.
ELEVEN ZERO YOUR BILL HAS ELEVEN
VOTES IT'S OUT LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON. THANK
YOU MR ONE. MURATSUCHI. YOU HAVE
AB FIFTEEN OH TWO SO WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR. WELL BEFORE I
GO ANY FURTHER I'D LIKE TO A
STATE FOR THE RECORD THAT I
ACCEPT ALL COMMITTEE
MEASUREMENTS GIVE AND I WANT TO
START OFF BY THANKING YOU-
MISTER CHAIR. FOR ALL YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE- AND
FOR ALL YOUR JOINT AUTHORSHIP OF
THIS BILL. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
LARA FLYNN ARE YOU LARA FLYNN NO
OKAY. I WANT TO THANK LARA FLYNN
FOR ALL HER WORK ON THIS BILL
AND- FOR. THE EXCELLENT
COMPREHENSIVE- COMMITTEE REPORT
SUMMARIZING THE LONG. TROUBLED
HISTORY OF THE STATE OVERSIGHT-
OVER OR NURSING HOMES. IN A
RECENT ARTICLES. AND CALMATTERS
AS WELL AS THE SACRAMENTO BEE.
AND OTHERS I HAE HIGHLIGHTED
THE WOEFULLY INADEQUATE CURRENT
STATE LICENSING AND OVERSIGHT
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE. FOR NURSING
HOME OWNERS AND OPERATORS-
COMMITTEE REPORT SUMMARIZES THE
STRING OF AUDITS THAT HAVE BEEN
CONDUCTED AT THE FEDERAL STATE
AND LOCAL LEVELS. AGAIN
HIGHLIGHTING THE WOEFULLY
INADEQUATE OVERSIGHT OVER THE
QUALITY OF CARE BEING PROVIDED
IN OUR NURSING HOMES AND WE SAW
DURING THIS PANDEMIC THAT OUR
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS ARE.
AMONG THE MOST VULNERABLE- NOT
ONLY TO THE PANDEMIC- BUT TO- SO
MANY OTHER. HEALTH CRISES HEALTH
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE. THE
ARTISTS THAT ARE SUMMARIZED IN
THE COMMUTER REPORTS. SUMMARIZE
HOW NURSING HOMES FOR TOO LONG
AND FOR A TO MANY I HAVE
OPERATED WITH UNLICENSED OWNERS
AND OPERATORS. AND THAT OWNERS
OF THE CHAINS OF NURSING HOMES
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
. ARE ALLOWED TO PURCHASE NEW
FACILITIES NEW HOW ARE NURSING
HOMES DESPITE THEIR LENGTHY AND
WELL DOCUMENTED HISTORY OF
VIOLATIONS. WE NEED TO CHANGE
THIS CERTAINLY BEFORE IT'S TIME
FOR ALL OF US TO CONSIDER OUR
NURSING HOME OPTIONS. AB FIFTY
NO TWO WILL PERFORM THE
OWNERSHIP AND MANAGEMENT OF
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES. BY
PROPOSING SEVERAL THINGS ONE
REQUIRING OWNERS AND OPERATORS
TO OBTAIN A LICENSE FROM V.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH BEFORE THEY ARE ABLE TO
ACQUIRE OPERATE- NURSING HOMES.
NOW THAT MAY SOUND OBVIOUS IT'S
SOME OF YOU MAY BE BEAVAN
WONDERING DOESN'T THAT ALREADY
HAPPENED WELL IT DOESN'T. AND I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
ON THIS COMMITTEE UNDERSTANDS
THAT THERE ARE CURRENTLY NURSING
HOMES THAT ARE BEING OPERATED
THAT ARE UNLICENSED. AND WE NEED
IT WE NEED TO CORRECT THAT. THIS
BILL WILL ALSO GIVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
STRONGER AUTHORITY TO DISQUALIFY
OWNERS AND OPERATORS WHO DO NOT
MEET SUITABILITY AND
QUALIFICATION STANDARDS. AND
LASTLY THIS BILL WILL PROHIBIT
THE USE OF INTERIM MANAGEMENT
AGREEMENTS TO CIRCUMVENT THE
MOST BASIC OF LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS. TESTIFYING ON THIS
BILL IN SUPPORT. IS IT TONY SHE
COULD TELL. WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM. AND WENDY YORK AND ELDER
ABUSE ATTORNEY. THANK YOU MISTER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
RESEARCHING WILL GO TO OUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK MY NAME IS TONY CHICKEN
TELL AND I'M THE SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY FOR CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM. WITH THE SPONSORS OF AB
FIFTEEN OH TWO WHICH IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT PERSON ON THAT WE'VE
HAD IN DECADES WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MARTUCCI AND CHAIRPERSON WOULD
FOR YOUR AUTHORSHIP AND CRITICAL
SUPPORT IN LEADERSHIP. AS YOU
ALL KNOW NURSING HOMES THAT HAD
A PRETTY ROUGH TIME IN THE LAST
TWO YEARS. MARKED BY ISOLATION
UNDERSTAFFING AND DANGEROUS
NEGLECT. RESIDENTS CUT OFF FROM
VISITORS AGAIN LAST WEEK BY
STATE ORDER ARE TOTALLY
DEPENDENT ON THE ABILITY OF
FACILITY OPERATORS TO PROVIDE
ALL THE CARE THEY NEED LARGELY
ON AN HONOR SYSTEM WITH NO
OVERSIGHT. WHO ARE THE OPERATORS
THAT RESIDENTS AND THEIR LOVED
ONES ARE DEPENDING ON THE
OPERATOR'S RECEIVING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF STATE MONEY. WELL THE
GROWING NUMBER OF NURSING HOMES
ARE RUN BY SQUATTERS THESE ARE
ON REPORTED UNVETTED AND
UNLICENSED OPERATORS. CALIFORNIA
DISGRACEFUL OWNERSHIP APPROVAL
SYSTEM. WAS EXPOSED BY A NUMBER
OF IMPORTANT MEDIA STORIES IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE SYSTEM
ALLOWS ANYONE TO TAKE OVER
NURSING HOME APPLY FOR A LICENSE
WHENEVER THEY FEEL LIKE GETTING
AROUND TO IT. AND PROVIDE CARE
TO THOUSANDS OF AUDIBLE
RESIDENTS ALL WHILE THE STATE
APPROVAL IS PENDING OR EVEN
WORSE AFTER THEIR APPLICATION
HAS BEEN DENIED. THE
DISINTEGRATION OF THIS LICENSE
SYSTEM INVITES OPERATORS WHO PUT
GREED OVER CARE. FACILITIES RUN
BY SQUATTERS ARE NOT JUST RUN OF
THE MILL THAT OPERATORS THEY ARE
ALMOST INVARIABLY THE WORST
OPERATORS. THAT WERE STAFFING
MORE DEFICIENCIES. AND LOWER
GOVERNMENT RATINGS. THE
SQUATTERS TAKE CARE OF MORE
PEOPLE WHO ARE POOR AND OF
COLOR. AND UNSURPRISINGLY
SQUATTER FACILITIES HAVE HAD
SOME OF THE WORST COVERT
NINETEEN OUTBREAKS IN THE
HIGHEST NUMBER OF COVERT DEATHS
. AB FIFTEEN OH TWO IS MUCH
NEEDED REFORM IN THREE PARTS.
PART ONE WILL FINALLY AND IT
NURSING ON SQUATTING BY
CLARIFYING THAT OPERATORS HAVE
TO HAVE APPROVAL BEFORE THEY
START TAKING CARE OF RESIDENTS.
PART TWO OF AB FIFTEEN OH TWO
WILL RAMP UP THE STATE'S
SUITABILITY STANDARDS FOR
PSUITABILITY STANDARDS ARE
LEADING TO SITUATIONS LIKE THAT
AT HEALDSBURG SENIOR LIVING IN
SONOMA COUNTY. A NURSING HOME
THAT HAS HAD TERRIBLE INSTANCES
OF ABUSE AND NEGLECT AND WAS
RECENTLY DECERTIFIED. NOW THE
FACILITIES REMAINING RESIDENTS
ARE ON THE PRECIPICE OF DISASTER
. THIRD AB FIFTY NO TO INCLUDE
STRONG ENFORCEMENT MEASURES TO
CRACK DOWN ON SQUATTERS AND THAT
BAD OPERATORS KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA IS NO LONGER OPEN FOR
THEIR KIND OF BUSINESS. AB
FIFTEEN OR TO REST ON A SIMPLE
PREMISE. GOOD OPERATORS RUN
GARDNER GOOD NURSING HOMES AND
THAT OPERATORS SHOULD GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE. WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO APPROVE AB FIFTEEN
OH TWO. BECAUSE IT WILL
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVE NURSING
HOME QUALITY FOR THOUSANDS OF
RESIDENTS EVERY YEAR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS WENDY YORK
AND I AM A CIVIL LITIGATOR WHOSE
PRACTICE IN THE AREA AND ELDER
NEGLECT AND ABUSE IN NURSING
HOMES FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS
I AM OFFERING TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN OH TWO AND
KNOW FIRST HAND THAT THE TYPES
OF- KEREN CONTACT- THAT OCCURS
WHEN YOU'RE SEEN HOME OWNERS ARE
ALLOWED TO OPERATE NURSING HOMES
WITHOUT A LICENSE. I REPRESENT
MULTIPLE VICTIMS AND THEIR
FAMILIES WHOSE LOVED ONES DIED
AT A NORTHERN CALIFORNIA NURSING
HOMES THAT IS BEING OPERATED
TODAY BY AN OWNER OPERATOR WHO
WAS DENIED DENIED A LICENSE TO
OPERATE THIS FACILITY FOR YEARS
AGO I'M HERE TO SHARE WITH YOU
WHAT CAN HAPPEN IF CALIFORNIA
ALLOWS UNLICENSED NURSING HOME
OWNERS AND OPERATORS TO OPERATE
NURSING HOMES IN OUR STATE. IN
THE FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE NURSING HOME RESIDENTS DIED
AT WINDSOR READING CARE CENTER.
DISABILITY IS BEING OPERATED BY
THE LARGEST FOR PROFIT NURSING
HOME OWNER OPERATOR IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THERE WERE
WARNING SIGNS THAT THE TWENTY
FIVE DESK WE'RE GOING TO OCCUR.
FOUR YEARS EARLIER WHEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
TONIGHT THIS IS- OWNER OPERATOR
LICENSE IT STATED THAT THE
REASON IT WAS DENYING THAT THE
OWNER OPERATOR LICENSE WAS DUE
TO ITS PRIOR HISTORY. OF
VIOLATING- HEALTH AND SAFETY
REGULATIONS AND OTHER SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES WHICH
INCLUDED TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FIVE FEDERAL REGULATORY
VIOLATIONS IN JUST THREE YEARS
WORSE WHEN IT'S NURSING HOME
OPERATOR PURCHASED THE FACILITY
YET. DID NOT GET A LICENSE AND
OPERATED WHEN YOU'RE READY CARE
CENTER THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH SUBSTANTIATED AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
TWO COMPLAINTS SIXTY ONE OF
WHICH INVOLVED NEGLECT AND ABUSE
FIVE OF WHICH INVOLVED INFECTION
CONTROL ISSUES. IN JULY OF
TWENTY TWENTY THE CALIFORNIA DPH
CONDUCTED A CO THEY NINETEEN
INSPECTION OF THE FACILITY AND
FOUND THAT IT WAS NOT COMPLIANT
AS THE FACILITY WAS NOT TESTING
RESIDENTS WERE COMING FROM
HOSPITALS AND STAFF WERE NOT
WEARING THEIR APPROPRIATE PP
EQUIPMENT. IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
TWENTY A MONTH LATER THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
CONDUCTED ANOTHER CODE NINETEEN
FOCUSED INFECTION CONTROL
INSPECTION OF THE FACILITY AND
AGAIN FOUND IT DID I'M LICENSE
OWNER OPERATOR WOULD NOT
COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL AND
STATE REGULATIONS. RELATED TO
INFECTION CONTROL- BIKE THAT CAN
. GUESS WHAT. SIXTY RESIDENTES
CON. CORONA RESIDENTS THAT WERE
CONTRACTED- THE COSBY NINETEEN
WERE MOVED TO THE FACILITY TO
READ DOWN THE TO READ SOMEONE
AND- STAFFED- DIGI KEY AND
PATIENTS WERE NOT GETTING
ASSIGNED STAFF TO TAKE CARE OF
THEM. NURSING STAFF DID NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THEIR ELECTRONIC
MEDICAL RECORD SYSTEM. DOCTORS
WERE NOT BEING NOTIFIED OF THE
PATIENTS CHANGES IN CONDITIONS.
THERE WERE EIGHTY FOUR SHIPS
WERE THE NURSES DID NOT CONDUCT
COVERT ASSESSMENTS AT ALL. ON
SEPTEMBER TWENTY FIFTH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
CONDUCTED ANOTHER CO THAT
NINETEEN AN INSPECTION. THIS
DIDN'T THIS TIME DECLARING THAT
THIS NURSING HOME WAS- IN
VIOLATION OF INFECTION CONTROL
AND THERE WAS NO IMMEDIATE
JEOPARDY WHICH MEANS THE
REGULATORS DETERMINED THAT THE
VIOLATIONS COULD CAUSE INJURY OR
DEATH. SO LET ME TO PATIENTS WHO
EXPERIENCED THIS PERSON. AND MY
HEART AND THE HEART HERSELF
WORKED IN THE HEALTHCARE
INDUSTRY FOR FORTY YEARS SHE
STARTED AS A CNA. PUT HERSELF
THROUGH COLLEGE AND BECAME AN
LPN WORKED IN NURSING HOMES. FOR
ANOTHER THIRTY YEARS AFTER AND
RETIRED SHE HAD A STROKE AND SHE
WAS ADMITTED TO WINTER READING
CARE CENTER. BUT AND THEN HER
FAMILY BEFORE THE PANDEMIC SAW
THAT THERE WERE CRACKS AND HOW
THIS NURSING HOME WAS BEING
OPERATED BY THIS OPERATOR SHE
WAS LEFT- LAYING IN HER FECES
AND URINE FOR HOURS WHILE HER
CALL LIGHT WILL NOT RESPONDED TO
SHE WAS LEFT IN HER BED- ALLOWED
TO. DEVELOP A LARGE PRESSURES
ARE ON HER BOTTOM FROM MS
PERSPECTIVE THIS NURSING HOME
WAS UNDERSTAFFED AND STAFF ARE
NOT BEING TRAINED BUT SHE TRIED
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT. FROM
WITHIN AS A PATIENT SHE MAKE
CALLS TO THE OMBUDSMAN'S OFFICE
HE MADE CALLS THE DEPARTMENT OF
KUMBLE. DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. IN SEPTEMBER OF TWO
TWENTY. AND I WAS EXPOSED TO.
AND TESTED. AND I WOULD MOVE TO
THE RED ZONE THREE DAYS AFTER
SHE WAS ALREADY POSITIVE WITH OF
THE NINETEEN MANY OTHER NON.
OTHER TIONS WERE BEING EXPOSED
TO CO THE NINETEEN. AND THEN.
REMAINED IN THE RED ZONE FOR
FIVE DAYS WHERE SHE RECEIVED NO
NURSING ASSESSMENT AFTER BEING
DIAGNOSED WITH OTHER NINETEEN
SHOULD TRANSFER TO THE HOSPITAL
WHERE SHE WAS INTIMATED
INTEGRATED AND PUT INTO
ISOLATION SHE DIED ON OCTOBER
FIRST ALONE. AND I WAS THE
MOTHER OF TWO DAUGHTERS AND FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN AND SURVIVED BY
THREE SISTERS. ANOTHER ONE OF
WINTER READING- NURSING PATIENT
HOME PATIENTS WITH ART TRENARY
AND ARE HIS WIFE WHO HAD HAD
EIGHT CHILDREN THAT THEY RAISED
OUTSIDE OF READING. AND AFTER A
STROKE ART WAS TRANSFERRED TO
THE SAME WINTER READING CARE
FACILITY. BUT BEFORE HIS FAMILY
MOVED ARE INTO THIS NURSING
FACILITY THEY CALL THE FACILITY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE FACILITY
HAD NO BECAUSE THEY CASES. WHEN
THEY ASKED IF THERE WAS ANY
BECAUSE THE CASES THIS IS A LEE
TOLD THEM THERE WERE NONE BUT IN
TRUTH THEIR WORK. AND TO THE
FACILITY IN THE FAMILY
UNFORTUNATELY MOVED. INTO THE
FACILITY HE WAS TESTED POSITIVE
FOR COCAINE ON SEPTEMBER TWENTY
FIFTH AND THEN THE NEXT SIX
DAYS. THE FACILITY DID NOT
PERFORM ANY NURSING ASSESSMENT
FOR HIS CO THE NINETEEN HE. DIED
ON OCTOBER FOURTH. WE CAN TURN
THIS TRAGEDY INTO SOMETHING BY
THE- POSITIVE BY MAKING SURE
THAT UNLICENSED NURSING HOME
OWNERS AND OPERATORS ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO OWN FOR MANAGING
NURSING HOMES IN CALIFORNIA. WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY FIFTEEN OH TWO FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WE DO HAVE ONE REGISTER
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
PERSISTENTLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
JENNIFER SNYDER. WHEN I'M
SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES- WE REPRESENT THE
MAJORITY OF THE ELEVEN HUNDRED
STILL NURSING FACILITIES IN THE
STATE. IF YOU KNOW TO A LET ME
FIRST SAY THAT AND PASSAGE OF
VERY MUCH APPRECIATIVE OF THE
OPEN DIALOGUE WE HAD WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF. I WOULD
STRONGLY AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR
AND THE SPONSORS THAT THE CHANGE
OF OWNERSHIP PROCESS FOR SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES NEEDS TO BE
REFORMED. WE ALSO AGREED THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
SHOULD HAVE THE NECESSARY TOOLS.
INFORMATION ACCORDING TO
DETERMINE IF A POTENTIAL
OPERATOR IS BENEFICIAL TO
CALIFORNIA AND WILL PROVIDE
QUALITY PERRANCE LONG TERM CARE
PATIENTS. CALIFORNIA WE
UNDERSTAND THAT CALIFORNIA'S
ACTUALLY ONLY STATE A NATION
THAT AS A CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP
PROCESS FOR NURSING FACILITIES
WHEREBY. A POTENTIAL OWNER IS
ASKED BY THE DEPARTMENT TO FIRST
COMPLETE. THE TRANSACTION THE
PROJECT. WITH THE KERN OPERATOR
AND THEN IF THE POINTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AS
THE INTERIM MANAGER. IS ONLY
AFTER THE COST OF THE CURSE THE
PUBLIC HEALTH THEN REFUSED A
LICENSE APPLICATION. THE NEW
MUST OPERATE WITHIN THE-
OPERATING IT NUCLEAR WITHOUT AN
APPROVED LICENSE AND WITHOUT
DIRECT ACCESS TO. REIMBURSEMENT
PAYMENTS FOR MONTHS IF NOT
MULTIPLE YEARS. THE LICENSURE
PROCESS IS BACKWARD AND IT'S AN
APT AND IT NEEDS TO BE. CHANGED
TO COMPLETE HER CAR PARTS YOU
WANT FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE. SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS ON THE BILL WE
HOPE THAT WE CAN- WORK THROUGH
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE
HAVE AT LEAST. THE WAY THAT YOU
KNOWTO A CURRENTLY WRITTEN
WRITTEN AND- THEY CAN BE KINDA
NARROWED INTO THREE PARTICULAR
POCKET ON THE FIRST. IS REALLY
TO DETERMINE WHAT HAPPENS IF THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH DOESN'T
DO THEIR JOB- WHAT STATE FORTY
SIX MONTHS DOWN THE ROAD. AND A
NEW OPERATOR DIDN'T TAKE OVER
FACILITY ESPECIALLY FACILITY
THAT STRUGGLING AND THE NEW
OWNERS WAITING WHAT WE DO ABOUT
THE SITUATION. AND TECHNICAL IS
THERE ARE- EXTENSIVE DISCLOSURE
EVIDENCE REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN FIFTEEN MINUTES
YOU. AND INFORMATION IN MANY
CASES WITH GOVERNMENT HIGHER
RELIC BOXES AND BOXES. IN OTHER
CASES IT REQUIRES EVIDENCE
CERTAIN EVIDENCE WITHOUT CLEAR
GUIDANCE FOR HOW THAT EVIDENCE
SHOULD BE QUANTIFIED IT
JUSTIFIED. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR- NEW POTENTIAL OWNERS
HAVE SOME CLEAR DIRECTION AS TO
WHAT THEY NEED TO PROVIDE TO THE
APARTMENT SO THEY CAN QUALIFY
FOR OWNERSHIP. IN CALIFORNIA AND
THIRTY LAST- THE WAY THAT
CURRENT CURRENTLY THAT
CONNECTION IS WRITTEN IT HAS
CERTAIN PROHIBITIONS THAT. WOULD
ACTUALLY- LIMON THE BILL FOR
MOST CURRENT OWNERS IN
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY APPLY OR
EVEN APPLY FOR CHANGE OF
OWNERSHIP AND THESE PROVISIONS
DON'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT WHERE WE
HAVE VERY COMPLEX OF REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENTS IN CALIFORNIA. NOR
DID THEY LOOK AT- OWNERS THAT
MIGHT HAVE MULTIPLE FACILITIES
THAT THEY'RE. CURRENTLY RUNNING
IN CALIFORNIA. SO I JUST WANNA
AND BY SAYING CATCHES VERY MUCH
COMMITTED TO SEEING A PART
CHANGE- AND USING YOU KNOW AND
TO DO TO THE VEHICLE THAT PART
CHANGE. AND WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMIT TO WORKER US ON NOV YOU-
WE LOOK FORWARD TO ACHIEVING
GOAL TODAY. AT FUTURE
DISCUSSIONS ON WITH BILL IS A
FOR THANK YOU. THANK VERY MUCH-
WILL GO. ON TO. SEE IS THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE CHAMBER PLEASE
COME FOR JUST YOUR NAME YOUR
POSITION IN ANY ORGANIZATION YOU
MIGHT REPRESENT. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRAND NUMBERS MY NAME
IS ROSCO OKAY YOUNG YOUNG
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF FAVOR
SENIORS NETWORK AND TO VOCAL
BECKLES ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA
TRANSIT DIRECTOR. IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WE NEED IT
NOW THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
THE CHAMBER. I UNDERSTAND
THERE'S NO ONE AT OUR REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITES SO WE'LL GO TO
THE PHONES FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. TO THE BILL- JUST
YOUR NAME YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL AND ANY ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE SO WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY MISTRUST FREIGHTER. ANY IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK ON THIS
LEGISLATION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. AND OUR FIRST LINE IS PLAN
NUMBER. TWO NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS BETSY
MORRISON SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
GREAT PANTHERS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS VERY MUCH. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THE NEXT CALLER
IS LINE THREE OH SIX WAS QUITE.
I CAN COME UP WITH WHAT THE
COUNTY AND I AGREE WITH THIS
BILL THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND WE HAVE LINE THREE
TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS
IS LISA COLEMAN- REPRESENTING
THAT CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION- WE DO SO
THE COURTS THIS BILL BUT WE DO
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT. THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE AN UNFUNDED
MANDATE FOR THE LOCAL PARK THANK
THANK YOU I'M JUST YEAH
APPRECIATE THAT- WITH JUST TO
NAME POSITION AND ORGANIZATION
PLEASE THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE HAVE A LINE EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS KEITH
AMADO COCHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED AMERICANS
WE SPEAK IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AND YOU MIGHT CONSIDER
A BUDGET AUGMENTATION TO
IMPLEMENT SOME OF THE- OTHER
TARNISHES. THANK YOU JUST JUST
NAME AND POSITION IF YOU HAVE
ADDITIONAL IT'S ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY OR COMMENTS WE WELCOME
TO SEND A LETTER TO OUR POOR AN
EMAIL THROUGH OUR PORTAL. BUT
THIS POINT IS JUST YOUR NAME
POSITION AND ORGANIZATION TO
REPRESENT ONE SO THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE LINED
THREE ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE THREE ELEVEN YOU'RE YOU'RE
OPEN. THAT ISN'T ME. HOW
CENTROLEGAL. ALL RIGHT MY NAME
IS. YEAH AND- HOW TO COPE. WITH
GEORGE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND WE HAVE LINE
ONE OH EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE ANALYSTS HERE SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY NTN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER. WE HAVE LINED
TWO SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EXACTLY MCDONOUGH I'VE WORKED IN
REGULATORY COMPLIANCE
DISTRIBUTION FACILITIES- AND I
SUPPORT THAT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE TO
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
HI MY NAME IS CESAR ESPINOSA
PRESENCE- AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE
LINED ONE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
. CRAINIC CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
RIGHTS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE
LINE TWO OH SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES HI SANDY MARC HAS
THEM IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
THANKS CALLER. WE HAVE LINE TO
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN BURKE
YOU'RE A ROCK ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF PASADENA IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE THREE OH
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. DAVID
FEINBERG REPRESENTING ANY R. P.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. YOU HAVE LINE THREE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THEY REMOVED HERSELF FROM Q.
LINE FOR YOURSELF AND PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE YOUNG I SERVE ON THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED
AMERICANS AND WE STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT CALL. WE
HAVE LINE THREE TWENTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS WILL GUANO
WESTBROOK AND I'M IN SUPPORT FOR
SB FIVE OH TO MY MOM'S NEGLECTED
IN A NURSING FACILITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE TO EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWO
EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE
HAVE LINE. THREE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LEGAL AND
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALL PLEASE. WE
HAVE ONE LAST ONE IS JUST
GETTING A LINE NUMBER ONE
MOMENT. THANK YOU.
AND SORRY
THAT LAST ONE IS LINE THREE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE THREE THREE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONCE
AGAIN LINE THREE THREE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE WHITE ONE
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. A MORE
CALLERS MISTRUSTED AND WITH THAT
. THERE ARE NO MORE COLORS IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL BRING
YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MR MCCARTY
THIS IS YOUR KERN. YEAH THANK
YOU- MR MURATSUCHI THIS IS- THIS
IS A GOOD BILL BUT MORE POORLY
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL-
HAVING FLASHBACKS BECAUSE AS A-
BABY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SEVEN YEARS
AGO I AUTHORED. VERY SIMILAR
BELL AND I'M LOOKING AT THE
ANALYSIS IN THAT. ACTUALLY IT'S
HERE AND- THERE IS A BIG SERIES
IN MY LOCAL NEWSPAPER ABOUT
THIS. OPERATOR WHO YOU KNOW WAS
IT DOING RIGHT BY SENIORS AND
JUST REMIND PEOPLE WE HAVE A
THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT TURNED
FIFTY FIVE EVERY DAY IN
CALIFORNIA. SO MORE AND MORE OF
OUR LOVED ONES ARE GOING TO BE
GOING THESE FACILITIES. AND- YOU
KNOW I WAS SHOCKED SEVEN YEARS
AGO THAT WHEN YOU CAME OUT OF AN
OPERATOR. HAS A SHADY TRACK
RECORD THEY TRY TO GET A NEW
RESTAURANT A BAR THAT CARD CLUB
THE STATE GOES AFTER YOU AND
SAYS NOW. YOU GO AND GET MORE
AND MORE- NURSING HOMES IN THIS
OPERATOR FORGET HIS NAME- DON'T
DISPARAGE ANYBODY BUT I CAN'T
PRONOUNCE THE NAME BUT I THINK
YOU KNOW THE SAME OPERATOR. THIS
STILLMAN. SEVEN YEARS LATER AND
PEOPLE ARE DYING. AT THE
FACILITIES ITSELF I THINK THE
EFFORT THAT I TRY TO DO IS A
LITTLE STRONGER BUT THIS IS
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT I
FULLY- CAN GET THAT AND MY
SUPPORT BEHIND IN TRYING TO MAKE
SURE WE PROTECT CONSUMERS. AND
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
UP THIS MEASURE IT TO DOCTOR
WOULD FOR JOINING TO MAKE IT A
REALITY THANKS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS AGUIAR-CURRY. YEAH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I MEAN THERE'S NO DOUBT
ABOUT IT IS FRUSTRATING. AND
IT'S SHOCKING. AND WHEN I READ-
THE ANALYSIS AND THINGS I JUST
WAS REALLY EVEN MORE UPSET IN
THE TESTIMONY TODAY REALLY HIT
HOME. THE LAST THING WE WANT TO
DO IS PUT OUR LOVE ONES IN A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY AND NOT
EXPECTING TO GET THE CARE THAT
THEY ARE HAVING- HI MY TO MY
UNDERSTAND YOUR CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS BILL- THEN THAT'S VERY
HELPFUL- ALSO- COULD YOU CLARIFY
WHEN YOU COME BACK OR WHAT. IS
THE WHAT THE- DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE INTERIM IT MANAGES OUR- WITH
OUR- AUTHORIZED TO DO. AND THE
MANAGEMENT COMPANIES OR WHAT
THEY'RE AUTHORIZED TO DO AND THE
OTHER THING IS. IS THAT I'M
SHOCKED NOT STREAMLINING THIS.
GRAHAM IT MAKES NERVOUS DON'T
GIVE THE DEPARTMENT HELP ENOUGH
MONEY TO DO THE STREAMLINING
PROCESS AND THAT'S A WHOLE
NOTHER. A WHOLE NOTHER THING BUT
THE PAST STILL DO THIS ON PAPER.
IS REDICULOUS. AND HOW CAN
ANYBODY GIVE GOOD SERVICE IF WE
CANNOT ACCESS THE DATA. ON THESE
EMPLOYEES SO I HOPE YOUBRING
THAT BACK WHEN YOU HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS GOING FORWARD.
AGAIN I'LL BE HERE TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE. C.
NINE I THOUGHT FIRST WELL I
THINK LIKE YOU THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEMBER
MURATSUCHI FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
TO THIS ISSUE- AND- AND I'M- I'M
PROUD TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
YOU AS A JOINT AUTHORS ON THIS
BILL. MANY OF YOU MAY KNOW WE
HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE HEARING ON
THIS ISSUE IN OCTOBER A VERY
EMOTIONAL HEARING- BY THE WAY.
WE DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW SERIOUS
THIS ISSUE REALLY IS AND HOW
MUCH WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
REFORM THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY LICENSING PROCESS. WE
HAVE A COMMITMENT. WE GOT IT
THAT DAY FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH THAT THEY WILL
ENGAGE WITH US ON THIS PROCESS
AS IT MOVES FORWARD. AND WE WILL
ABSOLUTELY HOLD ON TO THAT
COMMITMENT I'M I'M EXPECTING
THAT WE WILL GET TECHNICAL
SUPPORT PRIOR TO THIS BILL BEING
HEARD IN THE SENATE. AND I THINK
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
IMPORTANT POINT HERE SO. I'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU- AND
THE STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE A MORE
STREAMLINED PROCESS- AND THAT
PROTECTS OUR BILLABLE NURSING
HOME RESIDENTS AND I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS- THE BILL
DOESN'T ENJOY A DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YES AT THANK
YOU. AGAIN FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
HI AND NEGLECTED TO MENTION- THE
HEARING THAT YOU HAD CONDUCTED
TO FOCUS ON THIS ISSUE AND- YES
YOU WERE ABLE TO- GET THE
COMMITMENT ON THE RECORD FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. THAT THEY WILL-
ENGAGE- TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
THIS BILL WANT TO THANK GOODNESS
MCCARTY FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE AND- BUT WOULDLOVE
TO- TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU
AND- MS AGUIAR-CURRY- YOU
HIGHLIGHT THE ISSUE THAT THAT IS
FLAG IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS-
I CAN. GO MORE INTO DETAIL IN
TERMS OF- MAKING SURE THAT WEEK
WE CLARIFY THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE INTERIM MANAGER AND
THE MANAGEMENT COMPANY BUT- YEAH
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE. CANCER AND- THE
LICENSING REQUIREMENT BY USING-
AN INTERIM MANAGERS. AS WELL. AS
A ADDRESSING THESE OTHER ISSUES.
WE ARE ABSOLUTELY TO CAN WORKING
WITH THE TELEPHONE ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH FACILITIES. AGAIN OUR
GOAL IS TO KEEP GOOD NURSING
HOMES OPERATING KEEP THEM OPEN-
AND JUST CRACKED DOWN ON THE BAD
ACTORS. AND WE WANT TO WORKABLE
SOLUTIONS SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MURATSUCHI WITHOUT- WE NEED A
MOTION ACTUALLY- THE MOTION BY-
MISS OF HIS CAREER- I THINK IT
WAS A MISTER MCCARTY SAID YES IS
THAT- MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT. HI WHEN I. ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I THANK OUR CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE CUNNINGHAM. BURKE
CARILLO HI FLORA. MAIENSCHEIN
MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
THREE OF US THREE OF US HI
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON. YEAH YOUR
BILL HAS NINE VOTES IT'S OUT WE
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI- OUR
NEXT BILL IS BY. SENATOR WIENER
THE ONLY SENATE WE'RE HEARING
TODAY. PLEASE COME ON UP. THE.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR THANK
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN FOR SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HEARING THIS BILL- IN
JANUARY A VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
OF ENJOYED WORKING WITH YOU-
OVER THE LAST SIX OR NINE MONTHS
ON THIS BILL AND HAVING SOME
REALLY GREAT DIALOGUE NUMBER
APPRECIATE IT FOR THE TIME. AND
ENERGY THAT YOU PUT INTO THIS-
BILL- AND- WE'RE HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AND ANALYSIS OUR
COLLEAGUES ARE SENATE BILL FIFTY
SEVEN WHICH IS A BILL THAT YOU
HAVE SEEN IN DIFFERENT
ITERATIONS OVER THE YEARS- SOME
VENISON REMEMBER- EGGMAN I
INTRODUCED THIS BILL IN VARIOUS
FORMS OVER TIME WITH DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS AS- AS PILOT
PROGRAMS- BUT THE WHOLE EVEN
THOUGH THIS. BILL HAS APPEARED
IN DIFFERENT ITERATIONS OF THE
HEART OF THE BILL IS ALWAYS THE
SAME- IT'S ABOUT SAVING LIVES
AND. AND SAVING PEOPLE FROM
OVERDOSE. IF YOU HAVE ANY DEATHS
. HI SIR SB FIFTY SEVEN WILL
HELP US TO ADDRESS WHAT IS A
WORSENING. EPIDEMIC OF OVERDOSE
DEATHS AND IT WILL DO SO BY
GIVING SAN FRANCISCO- THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES AND OAKLAND THE LEGAL
ABILITY- TO AUTHORIZE SAFE
CONSUMPTION SITES. TO BE CRYSTAL
CLEAR AND I APOLOGIZE FOR MY
VOICE. THREE CLEAR NO CITY CAN I
HAVE HOLE IN ONE MOMENT. TO BE
CLEAR BECAUSE THEY'RE CALLING IT
WILL BE REQUIRED TO MOVE OUT.
LIFE RATHER THAN AUTHORIZES THE
PILOT PROGRAM IS YOUR. THE IT IS
A LOCAL SCHOOL. THANKS FOR
VISITING. THESE ARE THE A.
THIRTY EACH OF THE FOUR JURIST
HAS REQUEST TO BEING. WITH
UNANIMOUS VOTES BY THE L. A.
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THE
SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THE OAKLAND CITY
COUNCIL AND A FOURTEEN TO ONE
VOTE BY THE LA CITY COUNCIL OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES ARE
DESPERATELY ASKING US FOR THIS
TOOL. PLEASE SAFE CONSUMPTION
SITES ARE PROGRAMS WHERE PEOPLE
MAY USE CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES
UNDER THE SUPERVISION
SUPERVISION OF STAFF WHO ARE
TRAINED TO PREVENT AND TREAT
OVERDOSES. SEVENTY SITES ALSO
HELP DISTRIBUTE CLEANING
SUPPLIES- TO PREVENT HIV AND
HEPATITIS INFECTION- A HELP
PEOPLE OUR TESTER DRUGS TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THEY HAVE BEEN
LACED WITH FENTANYL- AND THEY
FACILITATE ENTRY INTO SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER TREATMENT AND OTHER
SERVICES. CALIFORNIA IS IN THE
MIDST OF AN UNPRECEDENTED
OVERDOSE CRISIS THAT IS
AFFECTING FRANKLY THE WHOLE
COUNTRY AND IT HAS TO BE TREATED
AS A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS- IN
THE CONTEXT OF KUVIN NINETEEN WE
KNOW THAT IN THE LAST FEW YEARS.
OVERDOSES AND OVERDOSE DEATHS
HAVE GOTTEN WORSE- APPROXIMATELY
ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY OF THESE
SAFE CONSUMPTION SITES EXIST
CURRENTLY IN TEN COUNTRIES- AND
THEY HAVE BEEN RIGOROUSLY
RESEARCHED AND STUDIED. AND HAVE
BEEN SHOWN TO REDUCE HEALTH AND
SAFETY PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED WITH
DRUG USE INCLUDING PUBLIC USE-
TO REDUCE DISCARDED SYRINGES
SYRINGES LETTER- AND TO REDUCE
HIV AND HEPATITIS INFECTIONS AND
OVERDOSE DEATHS. THERE HAS NEVER
BEEN A SINGLE RECORDED OVERDOSE
DEATHS IN ANY OF THESE
FACILITIES AROUND THE WORLD OVER
A PERIOD OF DECADES NOT A SINGLE
RECORDED OVER THE STUFF. OVER AN
EIGHTEEN MONTH PERIOD- A STUDY
THAT WAS CONDUCTED IN SIGHT IN
VANCOUVER. THERE WERE THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
OVERDOSES- IN THE AT THAT SAFE
CONSUMPTION SITE NONE OF THEM
FATAL THEY'RE ALL REVERSED HOW
DOES HAPPEN ON THE STREETS. WE
KNOW THAT A PERCENTAGE OF THOSE
PEOPLE WOULD HAVE DIED AND THEY
ARE ALIVE TODAY BECAUSE THEY
WERE USING IN A SUPERVISED
CONSUMPTION SITE. STUDIES ALSO
SUGGEST THAT STATE CONSTRUCTION
SITES REDUCE THE BURDEN ON
EMERGENCY SERVICES BOTH
AMBULANCES AND EMERGENCY ROOMS
THAT TRADITIONALLY RESPOND TO
OVERDOSES. THIS REDUCES STRESS
ON WHAT WE KNOW IS AN
UNBELIEVABLY STRESSED EMERGENCY
RESPONSE SYSTEM- IN AN
EVALUATION OF AN UNSANCTIONED
SAFE CONSUMPTION SITE IN THE
UNITED STATES PUBLISHED LAST
YEAR. NOT A SINGLE PERSON WHO
POST- WAS TRANSFERRED TO AN
OUTSIDE MEDICAL INSTITUTION THEY
WERE ABLE TO DEAL WITH IT THERE
AND RELIEVE THAT STRESS ON OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. ADDITIONALLY
THERE'S NO INCREASE IN CRIME OR
VIOLENCE OR DRUG TRAFFICKING IN
THE AREAS AROUND THESE PROGRAMS.
A STUDY PUBLISHED LAST YEAR
EXAMINING- THE SAME UNSANCTIONED
SITE IN THE US ACTUALLY
DOCUMENTED THE CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
DECREASED RATHER THAN INCREASED
IN THE AREA AROUND THE CITY
CONSUMPTION SITE. AND STUFF
STUDIES SHOW A REDUCE REDUCTION
IN SYRINGE LETTER- AND INJECTION
RELATED LITTER IN GENERAL-
TOMORROW A NEW PEER REVIEWED
EVALUATION OF AN UN SANCTIONS
SAFE CONSUMPTION SITE- WILL BE
PUBLISHED THAT'S TOMORROW- I. AM
NOT AT LIBERTY TO PUBLICLY SAY
WHAT THE RESULTS ARE BUT WE WILL
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE RECEIVE
THOSE THAT INFORMATION- IF THE
RESULTS ARE VERY VERY PROMISING-
ADDICTION TREATMENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE PHYSICIANS
WHO TREAT ADDICTION. OR SUPPORT
THIS BUT- BECAUSE KNOW THAT IT
INCREASE ACTS TO RECOVERY AND
SAVE LIVES. SINCE SB FIFTY SEVEN
SINCE I INTRODUCED THIS BILL
LAST YEAR I WROTE ISLANDS HAS
PASSED LEGISLATION AUTHORIZING
SAFE CONSUMPTION SITES. I'M THE
FIRST TO- PUBLICLY KNOWN SAFE
CONSUMPTION SITES IN NEW YORK
CITY I RECENTLY OPENED AND IN
THE FIRST THREE WEEKS THAT THEY
WERE OPEN- FIFTY NINE OVERDOSES
WERE REGION WERE REVERSED- THE
SITES ALSO SAVE MONEY- AND THAT
HAS ALSO BEEN THE RESULT OF A
STUDIES IN TERMS OF FEWER PEOPLE
IN AMBULANCES AND YARS. I'M TO
BE CLEAR THIS BILL DOES ENSURE
THAT BOTH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS
HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE BY
REQUIRING A PUBLIC HEARING
BEFORE THE CITY OXEN- INCLUDING
THESE INVOICES. THE BILL SUNSETS
IN SIX YEARS AND UNDER THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TO
PARTICIPATING JURISDICTIONS WILL
BE REQUIRED. TO PRODUCE A PEER
REVIEWED STUDY IDOLIZING THE
PERFORMANCE OF THESE SITES. OUR
COLLEAGUE THIS BILL IS SPONSORED
BY DRUG TREATMENT AND PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE. AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG
PROGRAM EXECUTIVES- IT IS A-
BILL WHOSE TIME HAS COME AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. I TESTIFYING TODAY R.
DAVID KAHN MD WHO IS AN
ADDICTION PSYCHIATRIST AND THE
IMMEDIATE PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE. AND THIS GUY SEN WHO
IS THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
HEALTH RIGHT THREE SIXTY AS WELL
AS THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL. AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR WINNER WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES NOW FOR OUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU- CHAIRPERSON WOULD
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY AT THE
POT I'M DOCTOR DAVID KAHN AND
I'M THE PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE OFTEN THAT DISCONTENT.
HE HAS OVER HUNDRED AND FIFTY
PETITIONS AND ALLIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. THE VOICE OF
ADDICTION TREATMENT- WALL OVER
WHERE THE VOICE OF EVIDENCE
BASED TREATMENT AND WE ARE
PROPERTY COSPONSORED AT THIS
CRITICAL PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS ABUSE SUBSTANCES TAKE
TIME TO CHANGE IT WILL BE NEEDED
TO MATCH THE AVAILABILITY OF
TREATMENT SERVICES BUT THE MAN.
IN THE HISTORICAL PAST TO WORK
TOWARDS WILL BECOME ABSENT BUT
WE UNDERSTAND THE CRITICAL NEED
FOR HARM REDUCTION. IN THE ARAB
DENTINAL OUR CRITICAL TASK IS
TO- BURKE CRITICAL PATH IN
EDUCATION MEDICINE IS TO KEEP
PEOPLE ALIVE AS A SENATOR PETER
REFERENCED THE RECENT DATA THAT
WE'VE SEEN THAT AMONG UNITED
STATES EXPECT AT EXPERIENCE WITH
THE CONSUMPTION SIDE INCLUDES A-
MENTION FIFTY NINE OVERDOSES PER
. WERE WERE FIRST AT YORK'S WITH
THE THREE WE- THE STUDY THAT
MENTIONED CHAU DISTANCE INCREASE
IN IN MARCH THE- AS WELL AS-
PATIENTS FOR PRACTICE WITHIN.
SUPERVISED CONSUMPTION SITES. IS
A CRITICAL ESPECIALLY DURING THE
TIME A CO BID FOR OUR MEDICAL
SYSTEM IS STRETCHED TO THE
BREAKING. BOB PREVENTION.
PRODUCE DRUG THE THEY REDUCE
CAROL DISCARDED SERVE. AND WE'RE
H. AT AND HEPATITIS IN OF. THERE
AS MENTIONED THERE'S NOT BEEN A
SINGLE OVERDOSE DEATHS WITHIN A
SUPERVISED CONSUMPTION SITES
PERHAPS ON THE MOST PROMISING
THINGS DETECTION. BUT PEOPLE TO
PARTICIPATE 3% MORE LIKELY ENTER
TREATMENT AND STOP USING DRUGS.
OVERDOSE PREVENTION PROGRAMS ARE
TREAT THAT THIS FORM OF
PREVENTION BACK PROVIDE ACCESS
THOSE BAPTIZED THE DETECTION
PSYCHIATRIST. IN AB TREATMENT
FOR THIS PUBLIC HEALTH ACTION.
THERE'S NO CONFLICT TO PROVIDE
USE STOPPING DRUG USE AND
OVERDOSE PREVENTION PROGRAMS ARE
PART OF BACK YOU CARE. AT THE
POSITION AND THAT THE MEMBER OF
THE FAMILY BUSINESS OUR
PRODUCTION WELL ABSENT FORM THE
PROMPT ACTION OUR FIRST JOB IS
TO KEEP PATIENTS. PHOTOS
PREVENTION PROGRAMS MEET
PATIENTS WHAT PERHAPS THAT'S
HIGHLY GROUP AND THAT'S THE
IMPACT WITH MY OWN EYES THANKS
STRONG LEADER DR BOTH ON THIS
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
REMOVE TO OUR NEW WITNESS.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THIS
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS THE GUY
I'VE BEEN ON THE FIELD
HEALTHCARE THREE SIXTY BASED IN
SAN FRANCISCO WAS TAKING IT
COMPANIES USE DISORDER TREATMENT
PROVIDER IN MULTIPLE COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE ALSO ON THE
BOARD THAT CAN'T BE TO STATE
ASSOCIATION. WITH IT COMPRISES
BOTH ORGANIZATIONS ARE CO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL I'M ALSO A
FORMER INJECTION HER USER AND
HAVE BEEN WORKING IN THE FIELD
FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS. ADDICTION
TREATMENT HAS. OVER THE YEARS
AND ALL HEALTHCARE SERVICES MUST
ACCORDING BOBBY SCIENCE.
TREATMENT IS EFFECTIVE BUT IT IS
NOT AFFECTED THE SAME FOR
EVERYONE. AND FOR THOSE FOR WHOM
WE HAVE NOT SUCCESSFULLY REACHED
WE NEED TO BE WILLING TO DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENTLY. NO LESS
THAN DR NORA VOLKOW HEAD OF
NIGHT AT THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE
OF DRUG ABUSE. AND ONE OF THE
NATION'S FOREMOST EXPERTS ON
CERTAIN DISORDER AT SENTENCING
IN HER WE CAN ARTICLE. IN HEALTH
AFFAIRS BUREAU. PERMIT FRIEDMAN
PRIOR PROVIDER PUSHED. OVERDOSE
PREVENTION. HAVE TO CRITICAL
PURPOSES. THREE TO GO TO ME NOT
. INTO BRENT PEOPLE FROM DYING
WE CAN REACH THEM IT IS REALLY
THAT SIMPLE. AS A LONGTIME
TREATMENT PROVIDER YOU SEE THE
SERVICES OF A MISSING ELEMENT IN
THE CONTINUUM OF TREATMENT
SERVICES. TO THOSE WHO SAY WE
SHOULD BE SPENDING MORE MONEY ON
TREATMENT INSTEAD OF THIS WE SAY
YES WE SHOULD BE SPENDING MORE
MONEY ON TREATMENT. AND THIS IS
A PART OF TREATMENT IS A FALSE
ECONOMY DISABLED YOU WANT YOU'RE. NOT COMMITTED TO THE OTHER.
AVAILING PEOPLE WHO WORKED WITH
THE MUST HIT BOTTOMBEFORE THE-
CARE. WELL LET ME DEBUNK MYTH
YOU MANY PEOPLE WHO STRUGGLE.
WITH THEIR SE ARE. IN ADDS.
MISERY AND WE CAN GROUP. MAKES
HIM MISERY. CRIMINALIZATION AND
COURSE. A DEMONSTRABLY FAILED.
RESPONSES TO ADDICTION. ONLY
FLOWING OUR PRISON POPULATION.
AND DISPROPORTIONATELY
NEGATIVELY IMPACTING BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES. AND COUNTLESS
PEOPLE ON THE- DIED ON THEIR WAY
TO THIS MYTHICAL BOTTOM. NEVER
GETTING AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
TREATMENT NO MISERY AND SHAME DO
NOT LEAD PEOPLE TO RECOVERY.
ONLY HOPE IN CONNECTION WITH THE
HEARING. OVER THE PREVENTION
PROGRAMS BUILD CONNECTIONS AND
LEAD TO HOPE AND MEDICARE.
EVALUATIONS OF OTHER SUCH
PROGRAMS. IN CANADA HAVE SHOWN
THIS TO BE TRUE. AND IN FACT THE
DOCTOR. IS A CRITICAL BIG ABOUT
IN NEW YORK CITY. WHICH IS THE
NATION FIRST EVER THANK YOU OVER
THIS PREVENTED SITE. BY FIFTY
NINE DRUG OVERDOSES WERE
PREVENTED. THIS IS A LIFE OR
DEATH MATTER SINCE THE
LEGISLATURE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
FIRST HEARD A BILL LIKE THIS ONE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. MORE THAN TWO
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED PEOPLE.
DIED OF A DRUG OVERDOSE IN SAN
FRANCISCO THESE INDIVIDUALS
SOMEBODY TO LOVE A CHILD SOMEONE
FILLING AND FAMILIES PARENTS.
THE OVERDOSE CRISIS. YOU CAN.
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY IT IS TO
DO SOMETHING. PLEASE VOTE YES.
REPORT SB FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WE DO HAVE TO REGISTERED
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ACTED
LIKE TO. COME FORWARD. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
CHAIRED A COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THIS TIME MY NAME
IS TACK ALLEN AND I AM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE INTERNATIONAL
FAITH BASED COALITION AS WELL AS
THE PRESIDENT OF THE CONGRESS OF
RACIAL EQUALITY. THIS BILL HAVE
EVOLVED SINCE ITS INTRODUCTION.
BUT STILL FALLS FLAT IN SPACES
THAT HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COUNT THE MOST. IT ALSO ADDS
THROUGH AND PERMITS THE PERFECT
PERPETUATION OF PROBLEMS.
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. SHOVEL
WITH WHILE TAKING A SERVICE
LEVEL APPROACH TO RESOURCING.
THAT SOUNDS BETTER IN THEORY.
BUT WILL HAVE HARMFUL BY
PRODUCTS. AND MINIMAL MITIGATION
PRACTICE. CHIU HARM REDUCTION IS
NOT AS SIMPLE AS MAKING A SAFE
SPACE UTILIZED DRUGS IN A
FACILITY TO ASSURE SAFETY. FROM
OVERDOSE. IT CONSIST OF
ACTIONABLE FOR. SUCH AS ON SITE
COUNSELORS AND REQUISITE TO THE
SERVICES. I'VE BEEN SERVING OF
MY LIFE WITNESSING. MY FATHER
THE LATE BISHOP RON ALLEN
BATTLING ADDICTION TO CRACK
COCAINE. IN THE MOMENTS HE FELT.
HE ADMITTED. THERE IS NO WAITING
FOR THE NEXT TIME THE SEARCHES
INSTEAD. AS SOON AS YOU GET THAT
FIRST ONE YOU NEED ANOTHER AND
THEN ANOTHER AND ANOTHER. HE WAS
PUT UNDER THE CARE OF ONE OF HIS
FRIENDS TO SUPERVISE ALTHOUGH
THE PASTOR THAT WAS SUPERVISED
HIM HIS CONSUMPTION AND GIVE HIM
EDUCATION INFORMATION THAT WOULD
HELP HIM TO GET HIS USAGE THIS
ATTEMPT ALSO FELT. IT WASN'T
UNTIL HE WAS PUT INTO ROBUST
COUNSELING AND REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS HE MAY HAVE JUST BEEN
DUE FOR THE CYCLE OF ADDICTION
FOR THE REST OF HIS LIFE THE
REST OF MY LIFE KNOWING HIM.
INSTEAD HE LIVED TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS CLEAN AND SOBER THIS
OPPORTUNITY SHOULD BE AFFORDED
TO EVERYONE IN THE STATE.
FURTHERMORE THIS BILL SEEMS TO
HAVE INTENTIONALLY OVERLOOKED
THE UNINTENDED HARMS TRUST FUND
RIGHT OUTSIDE OF THE DOORS OF
SINNERS IN THE OTHER COUNTRIES.
NOTICE THE PROVIDE KEEP SPECIFY
METRICS WITHIN THE FACILITY.
STUDIES FROM BOTH THE
NETHERLANDS CANADA BOTH
VANCOUVER AND ALBERTA GRADUALLY
HAVE SHOWN A STRUGGLE WITH
OVERDOSES THAT TAKE PLACE
DIRECTLY OUTSIDE OF THE SAME
PROPERTY OF SITE. DEREK THE
INTERVENTION FROM MY MEDICAL.
THESE OVER GO BOTH REPORTER AND
ENTRY BY PEOPLE WITHIN THE
CENTERS AND STUDIES AT THE PORT
OF SUCH SITES. DO NOT OUTLINES
OVERDOSES BECAUSE THEY ARE
TOTALLY FOCUSED ON OUTCOMES ONLY
WITHIN THE WALLS OF THOSE
SYSTEMS. NOT THE BY PRODUCT OF
THE FINISHED TESTIFYING RIGHT
OUTSIDE THE DOOR. THIS IS WHY
STUDIES IN SUPPORT ONLY SUGGEST
THIS COULD TAKE STRESS OFF OF
RESPONDENTS. NOT CONFIDENTLY.
ADDITION OF THE BATTLE WITH
INSTANT GRATIFICATION AND THE
YOUNG FOR IT. USERS SIMPLY USE
OUTDOORS AND DO NOT FALL WITHIN
THE REALM OF METRICS TAKEN
WITHIN THE CENTERS. ONCE THEY
HAVE DONE SO. WE CANNOT IGNORE
THE FACT DRAW MORE USERS WHO DO
ENGAGE IN DRUG CONSUMPTION AND
UTILIZATION RIGHT OUTSIDE. WHILE
CREATING MORE WASTE WITH
SYRINGES LARGER CALL THE
NINETEENTH ONE NUMBERS OF ALL
POTENTIAL ISSUES FOR NEIGHBOURS
AND HABITS INTO ACCOUNT IN YOUR
LETTER. WE ALSO CANNOT IGNORE
THE COMMUNITY SIMPLY DO NOT WANT
FACILITIES OF THE STORE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS. MOST THAT IS IN
FAVOR OF THE STAFF OUTLINED IN
THE COMPLAINTS WHICH ALSO BRINGS
CONCERNS ABOUT FIVE. MINUTES IS. TO DO SOMETHING OF THIS SORT
ALREADY STRUGGLING COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE. A I URGE A. M.
OPPOSITION VOTE FOR THIS AS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ALREADY
STRUGGLE WITH THE CIRCUMSTANCES
AND UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL IS
NOT NECESSARILY ADDRESSING THE
UNDERLYING BEHAVIORAL CAUSES
THAT LEAD TO SUBSTANCE ABUSE BUT
IT'S ALSO NOT REQUIRING THAT
EACH PERSON THAT ENTERS THE
CENTER'S UTILIZES PROPER
TREATMENT COUNSELING
REHABILITATION SERVICES NOR ARE
THE METRICS REVOLVED AROUND OR
DISCLOSING IN FULL THAT THERE
ARE ISSUES OUTSIDE THE DOORS OF
THE CENTERS THAT ARE NOT AN
ACCOUNT OF FOR. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE ANOTHER
WITNESS OF CENSORSHIP CAN HELP
MOVE THE MICROPHONE DOWN IF YOU
NEED TO OUR- THE NEW YORK HERE.
NOW HIT HIM OF IT FOR HELPING ON
THEIR SOMETHING CAN'T TOUCH IT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOHN
LEVEL AND I'M TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
NARCOTIC OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
THE COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY
CHIEFS AS WELL AS THE- CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS- FIRST OF
ALL I'D BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T-
COMMENT ON THE ANALYSIS THAT WAS
DONE BY MISS BABCOCK. TRULY AN
EXCELLENT PIECE OF WORK- IT JESS
UNRUH IS A FAMILY FRIEND OF OURS
AND HE USED TO TALK ABOUT THE
INCREDIBLE STAFF THAT WOULD COME
WITH A FULL TIME- LEGISLATURE.
HE CLEARLY HAD THAT KIND OF WORK
IN MIND IS JUST EXCEPTIONAL- THE
- THIS BILL NOT BECAUSE WE WANT
TO ARREST ANYONE OR PUT THEM IN
JAIL THAT'S A FALSE DICHOTOMY WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE THE
PREMISE OF THIS BILL IS
FACTUALLY INACCURATE. OF THE
HOUSE- FOR EXAMPLE. IN VANCOUVER
OF THE IN THE LAST EIGHTEEN
YEARS. THE INCREASE INCREASE NOT
DECREASE INCREASE IN- OVERDOSE
DEATHS 1000% IN ALBERTA PROVINCE
INCREASE IN OVERDOSE DEATHS 65%
IN- OF THE NETHERLANDS INCREASE
IN TWO SEPARATE- LUMPS THE FIRST
IN THE FIRST FIVE YEARS OR SO
DOUBLE OVERDOSE DEATHS IN IN THE
SECOND TEN YEARS DOUBLED AGAIN-
AND- NORWAY. THERE REALLY WASN'T
MUCH OF A CHANGE IN OVERDOSE
DEATHS BUT YOU HAVE TO CONSIDER
THAT EVEN THAT IS BECAUSE NORWAY
HAS THE LARGEST PERCENTAGE OF
OVERDOSE DEATHS IN ALL OF-
WESTERN EUROPE- SIMILARLY IN
FRANKFORT GERMANY. INCREASE IN
OVERDOSE DEATHS IT'S AND HERE'S
WHY THE REASON IS THAT MOST
PEOPLE DO NOT USE THE- MOST MOST
PEOPLE DO NOT USE THE INJECTION
SITE ON A CONTINUOUS BASIS THAT
NUMBER FOR EXAMPLE IN CANADA IS
ONLY FIVE PERCENT. BUT YOU GET A
MAGNET AFFECT OR OTHER PEOPLE
WITH THIS ADDICTION COME IN AND
THEY USE IT OUTSIDE AND THAT'S
WHERE THE DEATHS GO P THERE IS
NO STRATEGY FOR GETTING
PEOPLE INTO THE OF THE CENTERS
-- TO -- TO -- TO HAVE THIS
KIND OF THING ONE FINAL NOTE
-- THE CHAIR MADE ENORMOUS
AND VERY PROPER REFERENCE TO
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO WITH THE
COVERT NINETEEN -- EPIDEMIC OR
PANDEMIC NOW IN THIS HEARING
IS THERE ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM
WHO BELIEVES THAT THOSE SAME
SAFEGUARDS WILL RESULT WITH
THE MAGNET EFFECT OF FROM --
-- INJECTION SITES WELL LET
ME TELL YOU -- THE CANADIAN --
AT ONE OF THE MAJOR CANADIAN
NEW SERVICES SAID THAT THE
DOWNTOWN EAST SIDE HAS -- THE
HIGHEST RATE OF COVERT NINETEEN
INFECTION IN ALL OF WESTERN
CANADA GIVEN WHAT'S GOING ON
RIGHT NOW WITH THE PROBLEMS
HERE WITH THE OF THE CURRENT
-- OF COVERT -- PANDEMIC WHY
ARE WE DOING THIS NOW WHY
ARE WE RUSHING TO JUDGMENT
ON THIS WHEN WE COULD HAVE A
MORE -- -- A MORE SOBER AND
PROBLEM SOLVING LOOK AT THIS
WE ARE NOT WE ARE WE BELIEVE
IT IS POSSIBLE TO STRUCTURE
SOMETHING THAT REALLY DOES WORK
BUT THE MODEL THAT IS BEING
POSITIVE DOESN'T WORK GOVERNOR
BROWN GOT IT RIGHT WHEN HE
VETOED A PRIVATE PRIVATE PRIOR
CURATION OF THIS BILL WHEN HE
POINTED OUT ITS UNIQUE LACK
OF A COMMITMENT TO TREATMENT
I'M GOVERNOR BROWN SAID IN
HIS LETTER WITHOUT TREATMENT
THIS WILL NEVER SUCCEED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RESERVE
ANYONE ELSE IN THE CHAMBER
WHO WOULD LIKE TO PLEASE
COME FORWARD AND JUST WORK
COMPORT TO THE MICROPHONE
THERE JUST YOUR NAME YOUR
POSITION AND ANY ORGANIZATION
IF YOU REPRESENT ONE
MY NAME IS DEBORAH WRITTEN
HEALTH AND I DO A LOT OF
COMMUNITY ACTIVITIES AND
VOLUNTEERING FOR MANY MANY
YEARS I WAS AN ACTIVIST IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY BACK IN THE
EIGHTIES AND -- I LIKE TO SAY
THAT I TALKED TO THE PEOPLE ON
THE STREET THE HOMELESS PLEASE
PLEASE JUST YOUR POSITION
WE'VE WE'VE HAD JUST SUPPORTER
APPETITE I IN IT IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
A GREG BIRD WITH A CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU
LINDA RIDGE PLAZA
COUNTY RESIDENT I OPPOSE
THIS IS WELL THANK YOU
THANK STEPHANIE'S UELE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY RESIDENTS
THAT'S FAIR AND I OPPOSE
THIS COMPLETELY THANK YOU
ST A LARGE WITH PLASTER COUNTY
NAY POSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
CATHERINE MESMERIZED PLUS
OUR FREEDOM COALITION IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE IN THE CHAMBER
YOU KNOW WANT TO GO TO
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE
HE WANTED TO REMOTE
TESTIMONY SAY NO ONE
OKAY THANK YOU BRING BACK
TO THE TELEPHONE -- MISTER I
MISTRUST READER PLEASE WE ARE
GONNA JUST FOR IT JUST FOR AS
I STATED FROM THE BEGINNING
-- ON THIS ONE WE ARE WE DO
WE ARE LIMITING ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY TO TWENTY MINUTES SO
-- WILL KEEP WE GOT UP WE HAVE
A STOPWATCH UP HERE SO -- AS WE
GO FORWARD JUST RECOGNIZE IT --
IF YOU ARE NOT ABLE TESTIFIED
WITHIN THE TWENTY FIFTH MINUTE
PERIOD WEEK WE WILL GLADLY
ACCEPT YOUR YOUR WRITTEN
COMMENTS -- THROUGH OUR EMAIL
CORAL OR -- IN ACTUALLY ON
PAPER IF YOU CHOOSE TO DO THAT
AS WELL SO -- SO THAT WOULD
HAVE THE OPERATOR GO AHEAD AND
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IS JUST
NAME POSITION AN ORGANIZATION
IF YOU REPRESENT ONE THANK YOU
AND PLEASE PRESS ONE AND AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME AND OUR FIRST
LINE IS MINE TWO FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON
ARE WHEELCHAIR NUMBER SHERRY
DAILY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PORTION OF ADDICTION PROGRAMS
AND PROFESSIONALS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALL
IN PLACE OUR NEXT LINE IS
TWO EIGHTY THREE AGAIN TO
EIGHTY THREE WAS CUTS THANK
YOU CHAIRED MEMBERS COLLINS
WORSE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANKS CALLER
AT OUR NEXT LINE IS THREE FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SYLVIA SO WE SHOP
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES THANK YOU TO SENATOR
WIENER FOR ALL OF THIS WORK ON
THE MEASURE THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND OUR NEXT LINE IS LINE'S
TWO EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
SHARE NUMBERS ON THE WRESTLING
MEET AS ON BEHALF OF OAKLAND
MAYOR LIBBY SCHAAF THE
OAKLAND CITY COUNCIL FOR
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND OUR NEXT LINE IS THREE
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
MEMBERS CHRIS THOUGHT YOU
DON'T ON BEHALF OF THE NAME
OF MAYOR LONDON BREED AND CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
IN STRONG SUPPORT SB FIFTY
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
WE HAD A LINE OF ONE FIFTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD WHERE
SHALL CONNOR LEGISLATIVE
LIAISON FOR CONCERNED WOMEN
FOR AMERICA PAST PRESIDENT OF
THE PROJECT OUTLETS FOUNDATION
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU
OUR NEXT LINE IS TWO
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS
ENTIRE BILL WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND NEXT WE HAVE A LINE TO
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS
COVERING THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ALCOHOL AND
DRUG PROGRAM EXECUTIVES WORKOUT
COSPONSOR THE MAPS THE CITY
SEVEN IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE WE HAVE LINE
THREE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
ELIANNA BENDER ON BEHALF
OF CRIED IN FRANCISCO IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THAT SB
FIFTY SEVEN THANK THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE TWO EIGHTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WHO SHALL MATURE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AT EIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINED THREE FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
AFTERNOON REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONALIST ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE THREE FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON CARD
POKER ON BEHALF OF H.
L.
A.
HEALTH AND LOS ANGELES
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE A WIND THREE SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JAN ONE
BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE A LINE THREE FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
AFTERNOON GOING BACK IS
FOR TWO ORGANIZATIONS THE
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS AS MARK JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE THREE SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK
YOU MISTER CARE NUMBER STATE
CALMLY WITH THE L.
A.
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE THREE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHAEL DEALER
WOULD CENTER FOR MEETING AND
LEARNING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SP TWO TWO SEVEN THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE THREE SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU TIMOTHY
HOLIDAY FORMER BOARD MEMBER
KAPLAN JOINED COMMUNITY COLLEGE
I STRONGLY OPPOSE SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE THREE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON GAVE THE
CHáVEZ RESIDENT OF THE
CITY OF ANAHEIM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY SEVEN
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
LINE THREE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS MAX PERRY ON
THE AFTER THE CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
ALSO IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
HAVE LINE THREE SEVENTY FOUR
HI THIS IS GABRIELLE
INGROWN WITH YEAH SACRAMENTO
COUNTY WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU THIS CALL PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE TWO EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE CALL AT
HELLO YES PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI MY NAME IS SAMANTHA SILLY
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
ALL CALIFORNIA CITIZENS AND
I'M CALLING RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE TWO OH
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YEAH HI MY NAME IS SANDY
MARQUEZ POSTURE COUNTY AND I
ALSO STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINED THREE
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GOD
FOR MORE ON OPEN BASED
OFF OF THAT AND FISCAL IF
FOUNDATION AT FIVE THIRTY
BONTA AND SUPPORTED WITH
THE THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE ONE NINETY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
AGAIN LINE ONE NINETY
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES THANK
YOU MY NAME'S HEATHER KELLER
FROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
OKAY THANK YOU THANKS CALLER
PLEASE WE HAVE LINED THREE
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
CALLED ON THE RUNS FROM
SAN FRANCISCO ON BEHALF OF
THE COULD BE A PROJECT IN
STRONG SUPPORT SB FIFTY SEVEN
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE TWO FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS THIS
IS RANDALL HAGER REPRESENTING
THE PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIANS
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA WERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
HAVE LINE THREE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI CATHERINE CULLEN CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
HEALTH LAW PROGRAM WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT IT'S LIKE
BABY BELL THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE THREE SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
DEMINT COMMITTEE I AM
CONSTITUENT OF DISTRICTS
FORTY THIRD STRONG SUPPORTER
SB FIFTY SEVEN THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE THREE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
WE FEEL WILL WORK ON BEHALF OF
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE A PROUD
CO SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE A LINE ONE FIFTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD SUCH CALIFORNIANS
DISABILITY RIGHTS DON'T SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALL PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE THREE EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
SAN DIEGO COUNTY IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINED THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO YES PLEASE GO AHEAD
-- YES I'M THE CALL YOUNG
CHAPTER CHAIR AFTER COUNTY
MOMS FOR LIBERTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINED THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
SACRAMENTO PRIMARY CARE
DOCTOR IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE TO SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
DONNA BECAUSE I THINK OUR
CONSTITUENT ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
TWENTY FIVE WHAT THE SPELL
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE THREE FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD HI THIS
IS DIANA YOU CAN RESIDENT
OF PLASTER COUNTY SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS OPPOSED SB
FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE THANK YOU
WE HAVE A LINE THREE NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
BUT PRESENT IN PLASTER
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB FIFTY SEVEN OKAY THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
AND WE HAVE LINE TO
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
YEAH
OKAY THEY GET LINE TO
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THANKS CALLER PLEASE
YEAH
AND WITH THAT THERE ARE NO
FURTHER -- LINE THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
IT HAS NOT BEEN MOVED TO SO
IT MOTION BY MISTER NAZARIAN
THE SECOND BY MISS CARILLO
OR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MISS KOREA
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING YET AGAIN THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT BILL ACROSS
THE LEGISLATURE REMEMBER
COMING INTO OFFICE AND WORKING
WITH NOW SENATOR EGGMAN ON
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THE IMPORTANCE OF LOOKING
AT DRUG ADDICTION THROUGH A
VERY DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE
-- AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR CONTINUING THAT WORK IN
PROUD TO ALSO BE A CO AUTHOR
OF THIS BILL NOW MULTIPLE
TIMES NOW IS WE TRY TO GET IT
TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK -- I'M
GLAD THAT IT'S -- REGIONAL
APPROACH IN TERMS OF SOME
OF THE MOST -- -- COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE THAT HAVE
SEEN A DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT
OF FOLKS THAT HAVE -- BEEN
SEVERELY IMPACTED BY DRUG
ADDICTION AND ARE CURRENTLY
PART OF OUR ON HOUSE TO
POPULATION IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES IN THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES WHICH I REPRESENT I'VE
SPOKEN TO MANY PEOPLE THAT WORK
DIRECTLY WITH FOLKS -- THAT
NEED SERVICES THAT SAY WE CAN'T
CONTINUE TO DO THE SAME THING
OVER AND OVER AND EXPECTING
DIFFERENT RESULT OF MANY FOLKS
THAT I'VE CONNECTED TO IN THE
PAST FEW YEARS I HAVE SAID IF
ONLY THERE WAS A SPACE RIGHT
I KNOW THAT I NEED SUPPORT
AND I NEED HELP AS I TRY TO
GET OFF SOME KIND OF SUBSTANCE
OR SEEK ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE
AND I THINK THAT THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO TO THINK
ABOUT WELLNESS HEALTH WELLNESS
AND DRUG ADDICTION HOW WE
HELP COMMUNITIES THAT NEED
SUPPORT AND PEOPLE THAT NEED
SUPPORT ULTIMATELY TO CREATE
A DIFFERENT SPACE IN WHICH --
THEY ARE ABLE TO DO SO -- AND
THERE IS THIS BILL DOES HAVE A
SUNSET SO IT ALLOWS FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO SEE IF THIS WORKS
AND HOPEFULLY IF IT DOES AND
I'M I FEEL CONFIDENT THAT IT
WILL THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
SAVE LIVES IN THE PROCESS AND
I KNOW THAT IT IS CHALLENGING
AND DIFFICULT I TO THINK
DIFFERENTLY ABOUT WHAT THIS
COULD POTENTIALLY LOOK LIKE FOR
SOCIETY BUT WE CAN'T CONTINUE
TO DO THE SAME AND EXPECT A
DIFFERENT RESULT AND SO I'M
I'M GLAD TO BE SUPPORTIVE I'M
GLAD TO BE A CO AUTHOR AND
THANK YOU FOR CONTINUING THIS
WORK MISTER GERRY CURRY YEAH
THANK YOU CENTER FOR BRINGING
THIS -- AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT YOU LIMITED TO THE THREE
MAJOR CITIES THAT HAVE AGREED
TO GO FORWARD WITH THIS --
I CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE BEING
A COUNCIL MEMBER OR A BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS THERE WITHOUT
HAVING SOMEBODY HAVE MY BACK
AND TRY TO MAKE THE TRY TO LOOK
AT THAT THIS AT A DIFFERENT
ANGLE WITH A DIFFERENT VIEW
AND I THINK WE NEED TO GIVE
IT A SHOT AND I THINK THAT
THE -- THE COMMUNITIES THERE
WERE SHOULD BE GRATEFUL THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO LOOK AT THIS
DIFFERENTLY I KNOW YOU'VE HAD
A TOUGH TIME WITH THIS ONE BUT
I WANT TO I'M LENDING YOU MY
SUPPORT I'M GOING TO VOTE FOR
THIS BILL TODAY BECAUSE I THINK
OF THIS WORKS IN THE WORLD
TO SEE THAT IT CAN WORK -- I
HAVE BEEN -- I WENT TO ANOTHER
COUNTRY THIS YEAR BUT I SAW
SOMETHING VERY SIMILAR AND I
WAS SHOCKED HOW WELL IT WORKS
AND WE HAVE TO STOP SAYING IT
WON'T IT WON'T LET'S GIVE IT A
SHOT AND SINGING OUT WILL ALSO
BEGIN I THINK ON THIS GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT THIS OF
THE A DIFFERENT POVERTY THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING AFFORD
THANK IN ANYONE ELSE
I WOULD JUST -- I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU CENTER
WINNER AND I AND I APPRECIATE
YOU BEING A LITTLE PATIENT
WITH ME ON THIS IT'S TAKEN
ME A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME
TOGETHER TO DO MY PROCESS AND
GATHER INFORMATION I WOULD
NOTE THAT OVERDOSE DEATHS IN
THIS COUNTRY OR IN AN ALL TIME
HIGH -- REGARDLESS OF WHERE
WE ARE AND IT'S CURRENTLY VERY
ACUTE IN LARGE URBAN AREAS LIKE
THAT THAT THAT YOU REPRESENT
BUT IT IS ALSO HAVING SOME
OF THE COUNTIES THAT HAVE THE
LARGEST PER CAPITA OVERDOSE
DEATHS -- IT I FIND IT A
CUTELY REALLY PROBLEMATIC AS
WELL SO RECOGNIZING THAT --
HE THE CURRENT APPROACHES ARE
NOT COMPLETELY WORKING FOR
EVERYONE YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S
TIME THAT WE LOOK AT SOMETHING
THAT FOR SOME PEOPLE SEEMS
COUNTER INTUITIVE -- AND AND
I UNDERSTAND MY RECOLLECTION
FROM -- SENATE WENT NOW CENTER
EGGMAN WAS THAT IN VANCOUVER
-- THE IDEA IS TO CREATE A
SAFE ENVIRONMENT FOR PEOPLE
TO COME IN IT TAKES TIME FOR
PEOPLE TO BUILD TRUST AND AND
TO GET THOSE SUPPORT SERVICES
THAT THEY NEED THEY NEED TIME
TO KNOW THAT THEY'RE IN A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT I BELIEVE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IS CREATE
THAT SAFE ENVIRONMENT AND
GIVE PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE FAITH THAT THERE ARE
PEOPLE THERE TO SUPPORT THEM
AND WHEN THEY DO THEY HAVE A
CHANCE TO RECOVER FROM THEIR
ADDICTION AND SO I I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS -- AND
-- I WOULD LIKE TO WE DO HAVE
A MOTION MOTION FOR MISTER
IS ARIANNA SECOND FROM MISS
CARILLO EMOTION DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO PUBLIC SAFETY BUT
I'D LIKE TO COMMUNICATE CLOSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND COLLEAGUES AND I
DO I I MENTIONED CENTER EGGMAN
EARLY ON BUT I REALLY WANNA
-- JUST EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE
TO TO CENTER AND MEN WHO SHE
FIRST INTRODUCES BILL IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN BEFORE I AND MANY
MEMBERS HERE OR EVEN MEMBERS
OF THIS LEGISLATURE SOME OF
YOU WERE I KNOW AND SOME OF
US WARRANT SHE -- WENT THROUGH
THREE DIFFERENT LEGISLATIVE
TO YOUR SESSIONS WITH THIS
BILL THE FIRST TIME I THINK I
BELIEVE IT DID NOT MAKE IT OUT
OF THE SINGLE COMMITTEE AND
THAT EVERY TIME A GAIN MORE
TRACTION -- AND SO SHE'S JUST
DONE AMAZING WORK AND SHOW THAT
THIS COULD GET SUPPORT NUMBER
GRATEFUL FOR HER PARTNERSHIP
AND COLLABORATION -- YOU KNOW
THERE ARE SOME IS AN ATTITUDE
THAT IF YOU HAVE THE SAFETY
CONSUMPTION SITES PEOPLE WHO
AREN'T USING DRUGS ARE GOING TO
BE USING DRUGS AND WE KNOW THAT
THAT'S JUST NOT HOW IT WORKS
PEOPLE ARE USING DRUGS NOW
-- THEY'RE OVERDOSING NOW AND
ARE DYING NOW -- AND THEY'RE
DOING IT ALL TOO FREQUENTLY
ON OUR STREETS I'M IMPACTING
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITY AND
IN A VERY UNHEALTHY SETTING
AND IF WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HELP BRING THEM INSIDE TO
GIVE THEM SUPPORT AND -- WE
HOPE GET THEM INTO RECOVERY
AND CERTAINLY SAVE THEIR LIVES
WE ABSOLUTELY SHOULD DO THAT
I THINK ALL TOO OFTEN IN THE
SOCIETY WHEN IT COMES TO DRUG
ADDICTION FULL SOCIETY VIEWS
PEOPLE WHO ARE ADDICTED AS A
THROW THROW AWAY PEOPLE PEOPLE
WHO JUST DON'T MATTER AND IT'S
NOT WORTH TRYING TO SAVE AND
WE KNOW THAT SO MANY PEOPLE I
KNOW SO MANY PEOPLE IN MY LIFE
YOU HEARD FROM THIS GUY SEN
WHO WAS IN AND WHO IS A HEROIN
USER MANY YEARS AGO BEFORE SHE
TURNED HER LIFE AROUND I KNOW
SO MANY PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO TURN THEIR LIVES AROUND
AFTER METH ADDICTION HEROIN
ADDICTION AND WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER TO HELP
THEM DO THAT SAFE CONSUMPTION
SITES ARE PART OF THE SOLUTION
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR WINNER OF THE BILL AS
I SAID HAS A DO PASS AS AMENDED
-- TO PUBLIC SAFETY MOTION
HAS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE CHAIR -- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT I WOULD HI ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
NO BURKE BURKE I CARILLO
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA
NO MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY
THIS AREA HI NAZARIAN AYE
THREE OF US THREE OF US I
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO
AYE WALDRON WALDRON NO
IS IT MISTER WINNER YOUR BILL
HAS A VOTERS OUT OF COMMITTEE
-- I BELIEVE THE REAL OPEN
FOR OTHER STAT ON THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY I'D LIKE TO -- SEE IF
WE COULD MOVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE TWO ITEMS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR AB
AB NINETY THREE AND EIGHTY
EIGHT NINETY FIVE -- MOTION
BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY THE
SECOND BY MISS CARILLO I
BELIEVE IT IS NOW -- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
-- EIGHT AB EIGHT AB NINETY
THREE ITEM NUMBER ONE AND ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB EIGHT NINETY FIVE
WHAT HI WOULD I ROBERT RIVAS
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE ARAMBULA CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM AYE BURKE BURKE
I CARILLO HI FLORA FLORA
I MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY
THIS AREA NAZARIAN
AYE THREE OF US
THREE OF US I RODRIGUEZ
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE
WALDRON WALDRON HI
IS THERE A TOP TEN ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT -- AND
WITH THAT WE'LL GO AHEAD MÑI
I IF YOU KNOW OTHER MEMBERS
SITE YOU KNOW WE'RE WHO ARE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO PLEASE
COME OVER AND -- LISTEN TO
AND PARTICIPATE IN THE DEBATE
-- AS WE MOVE FORWARD -- WE
ARE MOVING ON TO OUR FINAL
ITEM LITTLE DIFFERENT WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE TODAY ON THIS
PARTICULAR ITEM WE'RE GIVING
THE SUPPORT AND THE OP WE
HAVE OBVIOUSLY THE OP AUTHOR
WILL PRESENT I BELIEVE -- MR
SANTIAGO WILL PRESENT WITH
HIM AS WELL WHO HAVE SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
FIFTEEN MINUTES M.
WE WILL HAVE NINETY MINUTES
MAXIMUM -- PUBLIC COMMENT AND
FOR THOSE PEOPLE WATCHING --
PLEASE UNDERSTAND THAT WE WILL
BE ASKING FOR YOU JUST WHEN YOU
WHEN YOU TESTIFIED THAT NINETY
MINUTES IS JUST YOUR NAME YOUR
POSITION IN ANY ORGANIZATION
YOU YOU MIGHT BELONG TO --
THAT'S OUR PROCESS HERE I KNOW
THAT THAT MAY NOT BE TOTALLY
SATISFYING TO EVERYONE BUT
REST ASSURED THAT WE WILL AND
WE ALWAYS DO ACCEPT WRITTEN
COMMENT TO OUR PORTALS WE TAKE
WHAT LANCE YOUR PHONE CALLS IT
IS A IT IS A NOT MEANT IN ANY
A SLIGHT ANYWAY AND -- BUT WE
-- WE WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
DO THE BUSINESS OF THE HOUSE
-- EFFICIENTLY AND AND -- WITH
RESPECT TO EVERYBODY INVOLVED
SO WITH THAT -- MISTER KALRA TO
LIKE TO PRESENT A B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED
YEAH EVEN WITH
ALL RIGHT IN THE AREA HI THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS I WANT TO START
BY THANKING YOU -- ASSEMBLY
WOULD AND YOUR STAFF FOR THE
TREMENDOUS WORK YOU PUT INTO
THIS NOT JUST NOW BUT OVER
THE PAST FEW MONTHS -- AND I'M
GREATLY APPRECIATIVE OF THAT
ALMOST A YEAR AGO I INTRODUCED
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN HUNDRED
I DID SO AFTER MUCH DEEP
THOUGHT KNOWING THAT IT WOULD
GARNER A LOT OF ATTENTION AND
NOT ALL THE POSITIVE I ALSO
KNEW THAT I WAS UNDERTAKING
SOMETHING THAT HAVE BEEN TRIED
AND FAILED MANY TIMES BEFORE
SO WHY WOULD I ENTER INTO SUCH
TREACHEROUS TERRITORY WHERE
FAILURE IS THE MOST LIKELY
OUTCOME I ENTERED INTO A LIFE
OF PUBLIC SERVICE ARE ONE
REASON ABOVE ALL ELSE TO REDUCE
SUFFERING AND THE REALITY
IS THAT IN OUR STATE AND OUR
NATION WE HAVE A HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM THAT AS FAR AS FAR
TOO MUCH SUFFERING EMBEDDED
INTO IT PARTICULARLY HERE IN
THE WEALTHIEST STATE IN THE
WEALTHIEST NATION ON EARTH
GIVEN THE RESPONSIBILITY GIVEN
TO ME BY THE VOTERS I COULD
NOT LIVE WITH MYSELF IF I DO
NOT DO EVERYTHING IN MY POWER
TO ADDRESS THESE FUNDAMENTAL
ISSUES IN OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
NOW THIS IS NOT TO SUGGEST THAT
THE CHAIR FOR OTHER ESTEEMED
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE HAS
CHOSEN TO IGNORE SOME SUFFERING
QUITE TO THE CONTRARY IN
FACT JUST YESTERDAY WE SAW AN
EXPANSION OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
WHEN A DOCTOR ARAMBULA HAS
WORKED ON FOR MANY MANY YEARS
-- THERE'S BEEN IMPORTANT WORK
THAT WILL FURTHER HIGHLIGHTS
THE NEED FOR STRUCTURAL CHANGE
THE CHAIR SPECIFICALLY HAS
BEEN ENGAGED ON HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY ENHANCE OUR
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE USING
NURSE PRACTITIONERS HAS
WORKED TO SET UP A ROBUST
DATA COLLECTION WITHIN ALL
PAIRS DATABASE TO BE ONLINE
IN THE NEAR FUTURE AND MUCH
MUCH MORE A NUMBER OF THESE
EFFORTS ISRAELI WERE OPPOSED
BY THE SAME GROUPS THAT OPPOSE
A BEFORE TWO HUNDRED BECAUSE
IT IS A LOT EASIER FOR SOME
TO SUPPORT A STATUS QUO THEY
BENEFIT FROM THEN TO CHANGE
FOR THE BENEFIT OF OTHERS
WHAT IS THE STATUS QUO AND
WHY IF AT ALL DOES IT NEED
TO CHANGE WHILE ALMOST TWENTY
PERCENT OF OUR NATION'S GDP
IS RELATED TO HEALTH CARE
SPENDING IN A TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE STUDY OVER HALF
OF CALIFORNIA'S WERE WORRIED
ABOUT UNEXPECTED MEDICAL BILLS
IN OUT OF POCKET COSTS AND
MORE CALIFORNIANS WERE WORRIED
ABOUT THEIR MONTHLY HEALTH
INSURANCE PREMIUM THAN THEIR
RENT OR MORTGAGE AND WHY IS
THAT WELL HEALTH INSURANCE
PREMIUMS HAVE GONE UP FORTY
SEVEN PERCENT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN FAR OUTPACING
WAGES OR INFLATION THAT EQUATES
TO THE AVERAGE COST OF FAMILY
PREMIUMS FOR EMPLOYER SPONSORED
HEALTH CARE HEALTH PREMIUMS
EXCEEDING TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR BUT WORKERS
PAYING FOR ABOUT SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF THAT TAB THIS IS AN
UNSUSTAINABLE BURDEN ON WORKERS
AND EMPLOYERS AND THAT'S
JUST THE PREMIUMS THE AVERAGE
DEDUCTIBLE IS GOT NINETY TWO
PERCENT OVER THE PAST DECADE
NOW IT OVER SIXTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR INDIVIDUALS THOSE
WORKING FOR COMPANIES OF LESS
THAN TWO HUNDRED EMPLOYEES
AVERAGE ALMOST TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED AND UNDATEABLES A
THOUSAND DOLLARS MORE THAN
THOSE IN LARGER COMPANIES AND
THIS ALL APPLIES IF YOU'RE
LUCKY ENOUGH TO BE EMPLOYED
AND HAVE EMPLOYER COVERAGE IF
YOU'RE NOT EMPLOYED OR HAVE
TO SELF INSURE YOUR SITUATION
IS EVEN MORE DIRE IF YOU HAVE
TROUBLE PAYING FOR INSURANCE
AND PURCHASE THE BRONZE PLAN ON
THE COVER CALIFORNIA EXCHANGE
YOUR FAMILY DEDUCTIBLE IS
SIXTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR EIGHTY TWO HUNDRED IF
YOU'RE SINGLE AND BY THE WAY
THIRTY PERCENT OF COVERED
CALIFORNIA ENROLLEES AND TWENTY
TWENTY HAD THE BRONZE PLAN I
NEARLY THREE POINT TWO MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ARE ALMOST TEN
PERCENT OF THE POPULATION
UNDER SIXTY FIVE WILL REMAIN
UNINSURED IN TWENTY TWENTY
TO NOW IF ONE WERE TO ASK ME
IF I'M HAPPY ABOUT GOVERNOR'S
SOME SPENDING MEDICARE OUT
ALL CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS BY
PROGRESS POSSIBLE ABSOLUTELY
YES FIRST IT INCREASES STATE
INVESTMENT IN OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM BY TWO POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR THAT'S
TO TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS LESS
WE'LL HAVE TO FIND THE BOND
A SINGLE PAYER PROGRAM IN THE
FUTURE AND FRANKLY COMPASSION
DICTATES THAT AS LONG AS THE
SYSTEM WE ARE WORKING WITH
IS EXCLUDING ANYONE WE SHOULD
WORK TO BRING THEM INTO THE
SYSTEM HOWEVER DO NOT MISTAKE
COMPASSION FOR ACCEPTANCE OF A
STATUS QUO THAT ULTIMATELY IT'S
BUSINESS FISCALLY UNSUSTAINABLE
UNREASONABLY INEFFICIENT
AND MORALLY INDEFENSIBLE
WITH CALCULATOR WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE CALIFORNIA
TO A SINGLE PAYER SYSTEM TO
PAY FOR HEALTHCARE SERVICES
THE SYSTEM THAT COUNTLESS
REPUTABLE ACADEMIC STUDIES HAVE
CONCLUDED TIME AND AGAIN WILL
SAVE OUR STATE TENS OF BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS A YEAR AND HEALTH
CARE COSTS AND WHAT IS THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT FOR TODAY'S
HEARING THAT'S HOW WE CAN SET
UP A SYSTEM OF RESPONSIBLE
GOVERNANCE A CLEAR DESCRIPTION
OF THE COMPREHENSIVE CARE
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD EXPECT IN A
SINGLE PAYER HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
ALONG WITH THE STRUCTURE FOR
PAYMENT OF SERVICE PROVIDERS
WITH PROVISIONS FOR COST
CONTAINMENT OF COURSE YOU
SHOULD BE AWARE AS DESCRIBED
IN THE STOP ANALYSIS ABOUT THE
INTRODUCTION OF A CA ELEVEN
WHICH IS INTENDED TO RAISE
THE NECESSARY STATE REVENUES
TO CLOSE THE FUNDING GAP AND
ADDRESS CONSTITUTIONAL ELEMENTS
FOR RAISING THESE REVENUES
FOR A SINGLE PAYER SYSTEM THE
REASONING OF INTRODUCING A
SEPARATE BILL IS THREE FOLD ONE
AS WAS DETAILED TO ME DIRECTLY
WHEN I WENT TO WASHINGTON DC
IN OCTOBER AND MET WITH THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR POLICY
OVERSEEING THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT WAIVER PROCESS FOR THE
APARTMENT HEALTH HUMAN SERVICES
HE AND HIS TEAM MADE IT CLEAR
THAT LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY WAS
REQUIRED PRIOR TO THE STATE
APPLYING FOR A FEDERAL THIRTEEN
THIRTY TWO WAIVERS ESSENTIALLY
A POLICY BILL MUST BE PASSED BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR WHAT STATE FUNDING
WILL NEED TO BE KNOWN BEFORE
HHS APPROVES THE WAIVER FUNDING
DOES NOT NEED TO BE FINAL FOR
APPLICATION OR INCLUDED IN
THE POLICY BILL THIS MAKES
SENSE SINCE THE FEDERAL WAIVER
PROCESS WILL HELP DETERMINE
HOW MUCH A STATE WILL NEED
TO RAISE AND FUNDS TO FULLY
FUND THE PROGRAM SECONDLY THIS
ALLOWS A FULL VETTING FOR THE
FINANCING MECHANISM WITHOUT THE
CONSTRAINTS OF A TO YOUR BILL
TIMELINE OVER THE YEARS THE
UNRELENTING QUESTION WHENEVER
A SINGLE PAYER HEALTHCARE BILLS
INTRODUCED IS HOW WE GONNA
PAY FOR IT AS ELEVEN MAKES AN
ATTEMPT TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION
UNLIKE ANY OTHER EFFORT IN THE
PAST OF COURSE THAT IS WHAT HAS
BEEN PUT FORTH IS AND SHOULD
BE OPEN TO DEBATE DISCUSSION
AND STAKEHOLDER INPUT AND
NOW WE HAVE TIME TO ALLOW FOR
THAT FINALLY BEING IN A CA
THE FUNDING MECHANISM ALSO
WE GO BEFORE THE VOTERS ONCE
A POLICY BILL HAS HOPEFULLY
BEEN PASSING A WAIVER PROCESS
IS BEING NEGOTIATED WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CALIFORNIA
VOTERS WILL KNOW WHAT IT IS
THEY CAN EXPECT A SINGLE PAYER
SYSTEM AND WHAT WILL COST A
CHANGE FOR THIS IMPORTANT THE
MAGNITUDE SHOULD ULTIMATELY
BE DETERMINED BY THE WILL OF
THE VOTERS AND THEY DESERVE TO
HAVE THE FULL PICTURE OF THE
SYSTEM AND POLICY THERE'D BE
PAYING INTO NOW TO FOURTEEN
HUNDRED WHAT WHICH IS WHY WE'RE
HERE TODAY YOU'RE LIKELY TO
HEAR A FEW COMMON THEMES IN
THE OPPOSITION FIRST THEY WILL
FOCUS ON THE COST OF THE SYSTEM
BECAUSE OF TAXES THE USUAL
PUSH BACK WE'VE COME TO EXPECT
THAT'S RECOGNIZE ONE THING
THE DATA SHOWS VERY CLEARLY WE
ARE ALREADY PAYING THE HIGHEST
HEALTH TAX IN THE WORLD YOU
MAY REFER TO IT AS PREMIUMS
DEDUCTIBLES CO PAYS THE
NILE CARE AND THIS CORPORATE
BUREAUCRACY BUT IT'S AS CLEAR
AS DAY WE'RE BEING FLEECED AND
FAR TOO MANY UNDERSTANDABLY
FEEL HELPLESS ABOUT WE KNOW
CHARACTER WILL BE CONSIDERED
OF IT WILL BE CONSIDERABLY
LESS EXPENSIVE THAN OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM WE CAN DRIVE DOWN COSTS
FAR BELOW OUR CURRENT SYSTEM
WHILE EXPANDING CARE SECOND
YOU MAY HEAR THE GOVERNMENT
IS BAD THEY CAN'T RUN OUR
HEALTH CARE AS OFFICIALLY AS
PRIVATE INDUSTRY ALL THIS IS
ALSO WHERE WE NEED TO BE VERY
CLEAR THIS IS NOT A GOVERNMENT
TAKEOVER OF HEALTHCARE YOU
STILL HAVE THE SAME ACCESS TO
THE SAME DOCTORS AND NURSES
AND CLINICS YOU ACCESS TO NOW
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE OF THE
TAB WILL BE PICKED UP BY THE
STATE HEALTHCARE MY FATHER
HAS GONE TO THE SAME DOCTOR
AND UNFORTUNATELY ON OCCASION
HOSPITAL FOR DECADES HE'S
ON MEDICARE FOR OVER A DOZEN
YEARS HE HASN'T CHANGED WHERE
HE GOES FOR CARE ONE BIT THE
ONLY DIFFERENCE IS THAT IS
LESS BUREAUCRATIC NOW THAT
HE SIMPLY SHOWS HIS MEDICARE
CARD FOR CARE AND LET'S NOT
BE UNDER THE ILLUSION THAT
DEALING WITH PRIVATE INSURANCE
COMPANIES AS A JOY IT IS
PAINFUL ESPECIALLY WHEN SOME
UNKNOWN CORPORATE BUREAUCRAT
IGNORES THE SCIENTIFIC EDUCATED
DIAGNOSIS OF A NURSE OR DOCTOR
AND OVERRULES THE TREATMENT
PRESCRIBED AND THEN THE DOCTOR
OR INSURANCE COMPANY TELLS YOU
TO START A GO FUND ME ACCOUNT
IN THE WEALTHIEST STATE IN THE
WEALTHIEST NATION ON EARTH THIS
SHOULD NOT BE HAPPENING YOU MAY
HEAR THE LOSER CHOICE WHAT'S
YOUR CHOICE NOW DO YOU HAVE
YOU HAVE FREE REIGN TO CHOOSE
YOUR DOCTORS AND HOSPITALS --
ARE YOU NEARLY LIMITED BASED
UPON THE PLAN OR GROUP YOU'RE
PART OF WE WANT TO GET RID
OF THE OUT OF NETWORK MADNESS
GO TO THE DOCTOR HOSPITAL
CLINIC MOST CONVENIENT TO
YOU THAT WE WANT TO INCREASE
CHOICE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT TO RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES WHERE THERE ARE
LIMITED OPTIONS YOU'LL HEAR
BUT NOW IN THE MIDDLE OF CODE
IS NOT THE TIME ACCORDING TO
OPPOSITION IS NEVER THE TIME
HOWEVER I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
THE COVER CRISIS IS PERFECTLY
EXEMPLIFIED WHY OUR EMPLOYER
BASED MULTI PAYER USUALLY
PROFITABLE FOR THE VERY FEW
SYSTEM IS AN OUT LIAR IN THE
WORLD A QUARTER OF CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES HAVE CUT BACK ON FOOD
CLOTHING OR IN COURT CREDIT
CARD DEBT OR OTHER FINANCIAL
HARDSHIPS BECAUSE THEY WERE
UNABLE TO PAY MEDICAL BILLS OUR
RESIDENTS ARE DELAYING MEDICAL
TREATMENT CUTTING PILLS IN HALF
TO MAKE THEIR MEDICATION LAST
LONGER WE ALREADY HAVE HEALTH
CARE RATIONING WITH THE STATUS
QUO AND THAT'S WHY EIGHTY
FOUR PERCENT OF CALIFORNIANS
RATE MAKING HEALTH CARE MORE
AFFORDABLE AS AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT OR VERY IMPORTANT
PRIORITY FOR THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE AND WE LOOK AT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIA'S
THE SITUATION IS EVEN MORE
DIRE BUT THEIR HEALTHCARE WE
DON'T THAT HEALTH CARE JUSTICE
IS AN ECONOMIC JUSTICE ISSUE
WE KNOW HEALTHCARE JUSTICE
AS A RACIAL JUSTICE ISSUE WE
KNOW HEALTHCARE JUSTICE IS AN
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE ISSUE THE
ISSUE OF HEALTH CARE JUST AS
BEING A SOCIAL TRUST JUSTICE
ISSUE WAS FIRST IDENTIFIED
DECADES AGO BY DR KING
UNFORTUNATELY DISPARITIES
GOTTEN WORSE SO I ASK YOU TO
KEEP AN OPEN MIND MIND OF WHAT
IS POSSIBLE NOT WHAT WE ARE
COMFORTABLE WITH OR WHAT WE
KNOW BECAUSE THERE'S A WHOLE
WORLD OUT THERE THAT KNOWS A
DIFFERENT REALITY AND YET I
DON'T WANT TO FALL THE MODEL
A SINGLE PAYER THAT IS DONE
BY OTHER COUNTRIES I WANT US
TO DO BETTER THAN ANY OTHER
PLACE IN THE WORLD WE'RE
CALIFORNIA AND WE SHOULD EXPECT
NOTHING LESS OF OURSELVES
ALL RIGHT TO HAND IT OVER
TO JOIN AUTHOR AS A MEMBER
SANTIAGO FOR A FEW COMMENTS
THANK YOU AND I'M I THINK THE
CHAIR FOR ALLOWING ME TO MAKE A
FEW COMMENTS EVEN THOUGH WE'RE
UNDER THE CONSTRAINT TO COPE IF
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATED L.
COMING TO TAKE A DIFFERENT
ROUTE TO UP NOT JUST ASK FOR
A VOTE HERE AND EXPLAIN A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT IT BUT BUT
ALSO TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
PARTICULARLY UNDER MISTER WOULD
LEADERSHIP FOR THE WORK THAT
WE'VE DONE BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT RECOGNIZE THAT
WE'VE TAKEN SOME STEPS FORWARD
AND INTO IMPROVING -- HEALTH
CARE ACCESS IT SOME OF THOSE
MAJOR STEPS DID INCLUDES SOME
OF YOUR WORK -- IT IN TURN
TURN TO PAY TO DELAY SO THAT
PHARMACEUTICAL OF PRESCRIPTIONS
WOULD BE MUCH MUCH LESS COSTLY
PEOPLE THAT'S AND THAT'S A BIG
STEP THAT WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
WE WE RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT
IN THIS COMMITTEE WE FOUGHT
-- TO PROTECT NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS -- IMPACTS ONE OF THE
FIRST PIECE OF THE WORK THAT
I DID WOULDN'T MIND NOT WHEN
WE GOT HERE WILL WAS UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF THIS COMMITTEE ON
THE PARTICULAR MISTER WOULD TO
INCREASE AT THE AGE OF OF THOSE
WHO COULD VIE BY -- TOBACCO T.
O.
ABOUT THE AGE OF TWENTY
ONE WHICH HAD TREMENDOUS --
IMPACTS ON THE HEALTH OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND IF THE RECALL
SURPRISE BUILDINGS AND I CAN
GO ON BECAUSE WHEN I SAT HERE
BEFORE THINKING ABOUT WHAT I
WOULD SAY -- AND MADE ABOUT A
TWO DOZEN LIST OF THINGS THAT
THIS COMMITTEE IS DONE AND
THIS IS HOUSES DONE TO IMPROVE
AND INCREASE ACCESS -- THAT
LIST WOULDN'T BE COMPLETE IF
I DIDN'T MENTION -- GIVING
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS --
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE WHICH BEGAN
-- BACK IN FIFTEEN OR SIXTEEN
AND -- WHEN WE DID A TWENTY SIX
AND BELOW AND HAS NOW INCREASED
TO FIFTY AND YESTERDAY WE SAW
A REMARKABLE OF A CONVERSATION
ABOUT IT FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AS IT RELATES TO ALL
GETTING HEALTHCARE COVERAGE
THIS IS ALL TO SAY THAT WE HAVE
ALREADY MOVED IN A DIRECTION
OF LOOKING ABOUT HOW TO GET
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE A TO ALL
THIS IS SO IT'S ALL PART OF A
LARGER CONVERSATION NOW THAT
WERE ENGAGED AS A HEALTHY
CONVERSATION AND PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO HAVE QUESTIONS AND
YOU SHOULD HAVE BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT CREATES GOOD PUBLIC POLICY
SO FOR THE QUESTIONS THAT I
THINK WILL HELP TO INFORM IF
WE ARE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO MOVE
FORWARD IT HELPS US TO ALLOW
TO CREATE PUBLIC POLICY THAT
IS ACTUALLY SOUND -- AND AND
THAT IS STRENGTHENED BY THE
CONVERSATIONS THIS COMMITTEE SO
OVER TAKE A LOOK AT THE A.
B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED CAL CARE
-- EIGHT IS THERE AN OPEN
INVITATION TO INCREASE TUESDAY
TO MAKE GOOD PUBLIC POLICY
THAT GETS US TO GIVING HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE FOR ALL YES
ARE WE GONNA BE SERIOUS ABOUT
LISTENING AND TRYING TO ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS ABSOLUTELY YES
IS THIS THE FIRST STEP TOWARDS
A LARGER CONVERSATION -- IS
A CONVERSATION THAT HOPEFULLY
GETS US -- PASS THE PROCESS
AND ULTIMATELY BEING SUCCESSFUL
ABSOLUTELY THE FIRST STEP AND
LOOK AT IT I THINK THAT WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT THIS EVEN AFTER
COMING OUT OF A HEALTHCARE
CRISIS LIKE HOPE IT I THINK
IT'S MORE IMPORTANT ASK IS
THERE A BETTER WAY OF DOING
HEALTHCARE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION IS
THE NATIONAL CONVERSATION BUT
WE'RE HERE IN CALIFORNIA LET'S
TALK ABOUT CALIFORNIA AND BY
AND LARGE PEOPLE SAY YES WHEN
WE BEGAN THIS WE WERE FORTUNATE
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ALLOWED FOR FUNDS A TO COPE
WITH THE COVER COLD RELATED
-- MEDICAL TREATMENTS SUCH AS
TESTING SUCH AS VACCINES SO
WHEN WE TOOK ONE TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT WHAT MORE CAN WE DO THIS
IS PART OF THAT WHEN FOLKS N.
IT'S BEEN SAID BY MY COLLEAGUE
I HAVE A CHOOSE BETWEEN RENT
HOW MANY PILLS THEY TAKE A DAY
-- OR THE FOOD ON THE TABLE
FOR KIDS THAT'S A PROBLEM OR
WHEN FOLKS IN ONE EMERGENCY
COLUSA HOME THAT IS A MAJOR
PROBLEM LOOK I'M NOT GOING
TO BE TO MAKE THE LIST OF
WHAT'S WRONG WITH OUR CURRENT
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM TODAY --
AND THAT LISTINGS EXPENSIVE
DEPENDING ON WHICH CONSTITUENTS
TO TALK TO OR THROUGH OUR
LIVED EXPERIENCES LIKE IN MY
CASE BEING A KID IN THE ONLY
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE I COULD
GET WAS GOING TO A CLINIC
BUT THAT BUT THAT STRENGTHENS
THE COMMITMENT TO SAY THAT A
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM CAN WORK
WE JUST NEED TO INVEST IN
IT SO WE CAN GIVE HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE THE ALL IN A WAY THAT
IS DIGNIFIED AND THAT IS HOLD
TO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO AND
I THINK THAT THIS CONVERSATION
AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED ALLOWS US
IN AND ONCE AGAIN MISTER CHECK
-- YOU HAVE BEEN YOU HAVE BEEN
SERIOUS ABOUT THIS AND TO A
LARGE DEGREE WE HAVE THE CREDIT
YOU TO VOTE FOR THE ABILITY
TO BE HERE BECAUSE YEARS AGO
YOU DID -- YOU OR YOU LED THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A COUNCIL
THAT WOULD TAKE A LOOK AT --
FUNDING HEALTH CARE -- THE
THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM FOR ALL
A YEARS AGO AND I THINK THAT
THAT THAT HASN'T BEEN MENTIONED
ENOUGH SO THANK YOU FOR THE
ABILITY TO HAVE A SERIOUS
POLICY CONVERSATION -- THAT
WILL HELP US TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT HEALTHCARE
-- BEING HUMAN RENDON AND THAT
HEALTH CARE SHOULD BE FOR ALL
SO THEY COMMIT TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- AND TO ALL WHO IS
ENGAGED IN A IN THIS YEAR'S
POLICY DIALOGUE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MR SANTIAGO THANK YOU THE
CUSTOMER SANTIAGO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF TWO WITNESSES
UP IN THE FIRST WITNESSES ADI
BARKAN CO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE HERO PACK AND FOLLOWING
MR BARKING WOULD BE CLIMBING
CONSTI POLICY SPECIALIST THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
SPONSORED THE BILL SO WHENEVER
MISTER BARTON MY TAKE A
MOMENT FOR THIS DEPARTURE
DATE TO CHIME IN INTERESTED
IN THANK YOU WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY IS FINE YOUR WORK ON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOUR WORD AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO TESTIFY TO THAT
MY NAME IS ARE YOU PARKING I
AM THIRTY EIGHT YEARS OLD AND
I LIVE IN SANTA BARBARA WITH
MY BRILLIANT WIFE RACHEL AND
OUR CHILDREN CARL AND WILLOW
RACHEL IS A PROFESSOR AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SANTA BARBARA AND I AM THE CO
DIRECTOR OF THE AT EURO HELP
JUSTICE ORGANIZATION SIX YEARS
AGO I WAS A HEALTHY THIRTY
TWO YEAR OLD LOW YOU'RE AT THE
PEAK OF MY CAREER FIGHTING OR
ECONOMIC AND RACIAL JUSTICE
RACHEL AND I FELT LIKE WE HAD
REACHED THE MOUNTAINTOP WE HAD
FULFILLING CAREERS AND HAD JUST
BROUGHT HOME ARE HAPPY NEWBORN
BABY WE COULD SEE DECADES OF
HAPPINESS STRETCHING OUT BEFORE
US AND THEN OVERNIGHT I WAS
HANDED A DEATH SENTENCE THE
DOCTOR DIAGNOSED ME WITH THE L.
S.
HIS NEUROLOGICAL ILLNESS I
WAS TOLD I HAD THREE TO FOUR
YEARS LEFT TO LIVE TODAY I AM
NEARLY COMPLETELY PARALYZED AND
I'M TYPING THESE WORDS USING
TECHNOLOGY THAT FOLLOWS THE
MOVEMENT OF MY EYES I CAN NO
LONGER EAT SPEAK OR BREATHE ON
MY OWN I AM FED THROUGH A SMALL
HOLE IN MY BELLY I LOOKED UP TO
A VENTILATOR TWENTY FOUR HOURS
A DAY AND RELY ON A TEAM OF
CARE GIVERS TO STAY ALIVE AND
AT HOME I KNEW OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM WAS BROKEN BEFORE MY
DIAGNOSIS BUT HAVING A SERIOUS
ILLNESS CLARIFIED JUST HOW
CRUEL OUR SYSTEM REALLY IS A.
L.
S.
IS A PROGRESSIVE DEGENERATIVE
DISEASE THAT PUTS INTO
PERSPECTIVE HOW TIME IS THE
MOST VALUABLE RESOURCE WE HAVE
BUT RACHEL AND I WASTED AWAY
SO MUCH OF THAT EARLY PRECIOUS
TIME ON THE PHONE WITH OUR
INSURANCE COMPANY NAVIGATING
INFURIATING BUREAUCRACIES
THAT ARE SET UP TO DENY US
HERE MY INSURANCE DENIED ME A
VENTILATOR STATING THAT IT WAS
EXPERIMENTAL AND THEN TWO WEEKS
AFTER THAT THEY REJECTED ACCESS
TO AN FDA APPROVED PAIN L.
ESTRADA EVEN GOOD HEALTH
INSURANCE WHICH I HAVE DOES
NOT COVER THE COST OF THE CARE
I NEED TO SURVIVE HANGING OUT
OF POCKET WOULD HAVE LEFT US
BANKRUPT AND SO FOR TOO LONG
AFTER MY DIAGNOSIS WE TRIED TO
GET BY WITHOUT HOLD HERE WHICH
PUTS THE BURDEN ON RACIAL TO
HEAR PROPOSED YOUNG CARL AND I
I LIVE IN EXPERIENCE ORGANIZER
HAVING EARNED SIGNIFICANT
MEDIA ATTENTION FOR LEADING
A NATIONAL CAMPAIGN TO REFORM
THE FEDERAL RESERVE AND SO I
DECIDED TO ORGANIZE ON MY OWN
BEHALF AND PROTESTED INSIDE
THE HEADQUARTERS OF MY HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANY UNTIL THEY
AGREE TO MEET WITH ME AFTER
SUING THEM IN FEDERAL COURT
WE EVENTUALLY SECURE TWENTY
FOUR HOUR HOLD HERE -- HERE
HAS BEEN LIFE CHANGING NOT
ONLY BECAUSE IT ENABLES ME TO
LIVE WITH MY FAMILY BUT ALSO
BECAUSE IT SAVED MY MARRIAGE
ALLOWING RACHEL AND I TO BE
PARTNERS AND CO PARENTS AGAIN
INSTEAD OF PATIENT AND CARE
GIVER BUT IT SHOULDN'T TAKE A
VIRAL MOMENT A TEAM OF LAWYERS
AND AN EXPERIENCED ACTIVISTS
TO GET THE HELP HERE YOU NEED
TO SURVIVE MY OUTCOME IS THE
EXCEPTION BUT THE CHALLENGES
WE FACE FIGHTING INSURANCE
COMPANIES FOR SERVICES WE
ARE RIGHTFULLY OWED ARE NOT
ONE IN FOUR AMERICANS HAVE A
DISABILITY ON THE DAY WE ARE
BORN AND ON THE DAY WE DIE AND
ON SO MANY DAYS IN BETWEEN ALL
OF US NEED MEDICAL CARE AND YET
IN THIS COUNTRY THE WEALTHIEST
IN HISTORY WE DO NOT HAVE A
FAIR OR EFFECTIVE SYSTEM FOR
DELIVERING THAT YEAR THE HIGH
COST OF CARE AND INFURIATING
BUREAUCRACY BURDENS ALL OF US
INCLUDING NURSES AND DOCTORS
WORKING FAMILIES AND SMALL
BUSINESSES THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO
BENEFIT FROM THIS ABSURD SYSTEM
ARE THE CORPORATE EXECUTIVES
WHO PROFIT OFF OF OUR PAIN
AND SPENT DECILLION OF DOLLARS
TRYING TO STOP YOU FROM MAKING
LIFE MUCH BETTER FOR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS ABOUT ARE CRUEL
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR SAID THIS
OF ALL THE FORMS OF INEQUALITY
INJUSTICE IN HEALTHCARE IS
THE MOST SHOCKING AND INHUMANE
IN SOLIDARITY WITH DR KING
AHEAD OF HIS BIRTHDAY WE OWE
IT TO OURSELVES TO RETAIN OUR
SENSE OF SHOCK AND MARSHALL IT
TO BUILD A BELOVED COMMUNITY
WHERE EVERYONE GETS THE CARE
THEY NEED THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE CAN CELEBRATE HIS
LEGACY BY PASSING A B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED UNDER KELP
HERE SENIORS AND DISABLED
PEOPLE WOULD HAVE THE FREEDOM
TO LIVE SAFELY AT HOME WITH
THE SAME CARE THAT ALLOWS ME
TO BE HERE WITH YOU ALL TODAY
ALL CALIFORNIANS WOULD RECEIVE
THE CARE THEY NEED REGARDLESS
OF THEIR EMPLOYMENT IMMIGRATION
OR MARITAL STATUS AND WE
WOULD PROMOTE HEALTH EQUITY BY
INVESTING IN CARE FACILITIES
IN OUR MOST UNDERSERVED AND
RURAL COMMUNITIES AT OUR BEST
CALIFORNIA CAN LEAD THE NATION
TO AVOID JUST FUTURE LIKE WE
HAVE DONE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AND MARRIAGE
EQUALITY WE SHOULD DO THE SAME
ON HEALTHCARE YOU HAVE IN FRONT
OF YOU A HISTORIC OPPORTUNITY
AND I URGE YOU TO SEIZE A S.
A.
B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED HEALTHCARE IS
A HUMAN RIGHT AND CALIFORNIA
HAS THE DUTY AN OPPORTUNITY
TO FINALLY ENSURE THAT ALL
OF US HAVE BEEN HERE WE
NEED TO DRIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR BARKAN -- WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
WITNESS -- CARMEN CONSTI
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'M COMING
CONSTI LEAGUE REGULATORY
POLICY SPECIALIST ON BEHALF OF
THE MIGHTY CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION WHICH REPRESENTS
OVER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
REGISTERED NURSES ACROSS THE
STATE CNA IS A PROUD SPONSOR OF
EIGHTY FOURTEEN HUNDRED WHICH
WOULD ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA
GUARANTEED HEALTHCARE FOR
ALL PROGRAM ACCOUNT HERE A
SINGLE PUBLIC PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD GUARANTEE AND PAY FOR
HIGH QUALITY COMPREHENSIVE
CARE FOR EVERY CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT IN OTHER WORDS A
SINGLE PAYER FOR HEALTH CARE
IN OUR STATE EVERY DAY NURSES
WITNESS PREVENTABLE HEALTHCARE
TRAGEDIES THAT RESULT FROM OUR
CURRENT FRAGMENTED TO SOME OF
INSURANCE AGENTS FOR GO THE
MEDICATIONS AND CARE THEY NEED
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY CANNOT
AFFORD IT MEANWHILE INSURERS
AND HEALTH PLAN MIDDLEMAN
DENYING AND LIMIT CARE AVOIDING
COVERAGE OF THE SICKEST
RESEARCHING PROVIDER NETWORKS
CREATING FINANCIAL BARRIERS ALL
TO MAINTAIN CORPORATE BOTTOM
LINE AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED WOULD
ESTABLISH THE POLICY FRAMEWORK
THAT WOULD TRANSFORM OUR PROFIT
DRIVEN HEALTH INSURANCE SYSTEM
INTO A SYSTEM THAT PRIORITIZES
PATIENT CARE I'LL PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF KEY ELEMENTS OF
THE BILL AND THE HEALTHCARE
PROGRAM AND I'M HERE TO ANSWER
ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS LATER THE
BILL ESTABLISHES AND GUARANTEES
UNDER CAL CARE UNIVERSAL HEALTH
CARE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS AT THE
RATE EVERY CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
PROGRAM REGARDLESS OF ABILITY
TO PAY WITHOUT BEING TIED TO
A JOB OR IMMIGRATION STATUS
AND REGARDLESS OF WHETHER AN
INSURANCE COMPANY DEEMS THEM
TO BE A LIABILITY TO CORPORATE
POCKETBOOKS ALL HEALTHCARE
PAYMENTS WILL BE PAID THROUGH
THE COW CARE PROGRAM REPLACING
MULTIPLE PRIVATE AND PUBLIC
PAYERS MEDICARE MEDICARE AND
COVER CALIFORNIA WOULD BE
INCORPORATED INTO HEALTHCARE
IN A MANNER THAT IS SEAMLESS TO
THE PROGRAM BENEFICIARIES AND
THAT'S PERMITTED UNDER FEDERAL
APPROVALS ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
NOTED FEDERAL WAIVERS CAN ONLY
BE OBTAINED AFTER THE POLICY
BILL OF CALCAREOUS PASSED
HEALTHCARE IS GOVERNED BY A
NINE MEMBER BOARD OF HEALTH
CARE EXPERTS WITH APPOINTMENTS
SPLIT BETWEEN THE LEGISLATURE
AND GOVERNOR THE SECRETARY
OF HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
WOULD SERVE AS A NON VOTING
EX OFFICIO MEMBER THE BOARD
IS CHARGED WITH MANAGING THE
TRANSITION IMPLEMENTATION M.
AND ENROLLMENT PROCESSES FOR
CAL CARE AND THE BOARD IS GIVEN
AUTHORITY TO APPLY FOR ANY
NECESSARY FEDERAL APPROVALS THE
RESULT TO BE A PUBLIC ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WITH A ROTATING SEAT
ON THE BOARD AND THEN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ON LONG TERM SERVICES
AND SUPPORT THE BILL ALSO
ESTABLISHES A DESIGNATED CAL
CARE TRUST FUND AND AS OUTLINED
IN CHAPTER NINE THE COW CARE
PROGRAM DOES NOT BECOME FULLY
OPERATIVE UNTIL THE TRUST
FUND HAD SUFFICIENT REVENUE
TO IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM THE
COW CARE BENEFITS PACKAGE
DETAILED IN CHAPTER FOUR IS
TRULY COMPREHENSIVE AND WOULD
BE BETTER THAN ANY EXISTING
PRIVATE OR PUBLIC HEALTH PLAN
HEALTHCARE WOULD PAY FOR ALL
NECESSARY AND APPROPRIATE
CARE FOR CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
INCLUDING MEDICAL DENTAL VISION
HEARING SERVICES AS WELL AS
PRIMARY AND PREVENTIVE CARE
REPRODUCTIVE CARE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND MORE BENEFITS
ALSO INCLUDE COMPREHENSIVE
COVERAGE OF LONG TERM SERVICE
INSISTS AND TO IT FOR PEOPLE
LIVE LIVING WITH DISABILITIES
AND OLDER ADULTS AND WHEN IT
COMES TO RECEIVING CARE EIGHTY
FOURTEEN HUNDRED ENSURES THAT
EVERYONE GETS THE CARE THEY
NEED BY ELIMINATING FINANCIAL
AND INSURANCE CARRIERS WITH
NO COST SHARING UNDER THE
PROGRAMME CARE WOULD BE
FREE AT THE POINT OF SERVICE
NO COPAYS NO DEDUCTIBLES
AND NO PREMIUMS A.
B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED WOULD
ELIMINATE NARROW PROVIDER
NETWORKS AND THERE WOULD BE
NO PRIOR AUTHORIZATION OR
REFERRALS REQUIRED SO I'M
LIKE OUR CURRENT SYSTEM WHERE
INSURERS LIMIT WHICH DOCTORS
WE CAN SEE AND ONE HUNDRED
HEALTHCARE WITH ONE NETWORK
OF PROVIDERS SPENDING THE
STATE EVERYONE WOULD HAVE TRUE
FREEDOM TO CHOOSE OUR DOCTORS
AND PROVIDERS IMPORTANTLY
PROFIT MOTIVES AND FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES WOULD NO LONGER
DETERMINE CARE RATHER DECISION
ON DECISIONS ON CARE ARE UNDER
CAL CARE WOULD BE BASED ON
PATIENT NEED THE NECESSARY
AT AND APPROPRIATE CARE FOR
EACH PATIENT IS DETERMINED
BY THE PATIENTS TREATING
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONAL AND
WOULD BE COVERED UNDER THE
PROGRAM THIS MEANS THAT CAL
CARE PUTS DECISIONS OF CARE
INTO THE HANDS OF PATIENTS
AND THEIR DOCTORS NURSES AND
OTHER HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS
AS OPPOSED TO INSURANCE
COMPANIES AND CORPORATE BOARD
ROOMS CHAPTER FIVE OF THE
BILL ESTABLISHES PROVIDER
PARTICIPATION AND PAYMENT
STRUCTURES FOR HOSPITALS AND
OTHER INSTITUTIONAL PROVIDERS
THEY WOULD BE PAID THROUGH
INSTITUTIONAL GLOBAL BUDGETING
PROCESS THESE WERE OPERATING
BUDGETS ARE NEGOTIATED ANNUALLY
BETWEEN CAL CARE AND EACH
INSTITUTIONAL PROVIDER THESE
BUDGETS WOULD BE PAID AND
REVIEWED QUARTERLY ALIGNING
HOSPITAL PAYMENTS WITH COST
THESE GLOBAL BUDGETS ARE
TAILORED TO MEET AND RESPECT
THE CARE AND ACCESS NEEDS
OF THE PATIENT SURVEY EACH
HOSPITAL FOR DOCTOR GROUPS
AND INDIVIDUAL PROVIDERS THEY
CAN CHOOSE BETWEEN -- TO BE
PAID THROUGH SALARY PAYMENTS
OR A FEE SCHEDULE THAT WOULD
BE SET BY NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN
PROVIDERS AND HEALTHCARE
EACH YEAR NOW I ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT EIGHTY FOURTEEN
HUNDRED WHAT CONTROL COSTS
WITHOUT HAVING TO RESORT TO
CARE RATIONING AND -- DENIAL
STUDY AFTER STUDY HAS SHOWN
THAT A SINGLE PAYER SYSTEM LIKE
HEALTHCARE IS THE ONLY SOLUTION
THAT WOULD PROVIDE UNIVERSAL
COMPREHENSIVE BENEFITS TO ALL
WHILE ALSO REDUCING OVERALL
HEALTH CARE SPENDING WE WOULD
GET MORE COVER EVERYONE AND
PAY LESS AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED
WITH TASTE CALIFORNIA TIME
THE BILLIONS EACH YEAR BY
ELIMINATING ADMINISTRATIVE
COMPLEXITY OF OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM AND BY LEVERAGING OUR
COLLECTIVE BUYING POWER UNDER
THE SINGLE PAYER OF HEALTHCARE
TO NEGOTIATE FAIR PRICES FOR
EVERYONE YOU'RE BOTH BALK
NEGOTIATIONS HEALTHCARE WOULD
AND HIGH PRESCRIPTION DRUG
PRICES AND INSTEAD OF PAYMENTS
GOING TOWARD INFLATED PRICES
ADMINISTRATIVE COMPLEXITY AND
HEALTH INDUSTRY PROFITEERING
OR HEALTHCARE DOLLARS WILL
GO TOWARDS CARE CRITICALLY
WITH A SIMPLIFIED AND UNIFIED
CLAIMS PROCESS HEALTHCARE
WOULD NOT ONLY SAVE MONEY
BUT IT WOULD IMPROVE THE
LIVES IN PRACTICE OVER HEALTH
CARE PERFECT PROFESSIONALS
OUR DOCTORS AND OUR NURSES
PROVIDERS AS WELL AS PATIENTS
WOULD SPEND LESS TIME MONEY AND
RESOURCES NAVIGATING A WEB OF
INSURANCE SYSTEMS AND DOCTORS
AND NURSES WOULD HAVE MORE
TIME TO DO WHAT THEY DO BEST
CARE FOR PATIENTS THEY COULD
PROVIDE CARE BASED ON THEIR
BEST PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT
WITHOUT INSURANCE CORPORATION
INTERFERENCE RESULTING IN
BETTER CARE ADDITIONALLY UNDER
A SINGLE STATEWIDE SYSTEM
ACCOUNTABILITY BECOMES EASIER
THE BILL FOLD EXISTING MEDIC
HOW CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
AND THE COW CARE AND IT IT
ESTABLISHES ADDITIONAL PROGRAM
STANDARDS AND PROTECTIONS
AGAINST FRAUD AND ABUSE FOR
EXAMPLE HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
ARE PROHIBITED FROM MAKING
GET ENGAGING IN A CODING
PRACTICES AND ARE PROHIBITED
FROM ENGAGING IN FINANCIAL
INCENTIVE SCHEMES THAT
INTERFERE WITH PATIENT CARE
THE BOARD WILL ALSO DEVELOP
INTO INDEPENDENT MEDICAL REVIEW
PROCESS HE'S IN CONSULTATION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE AND NOTABLY THE BILL
PROHIBITS PROVIDERS AT -- AND
THE COW CARE SYSTEM FROM THE
DYING CARE REDUCING BENEFITS
OR OTHERWISE DISCRIMINATING
AGAINST CALIFORNIANS BASED ON
THEIR INCLUSION IN A PROTECTED
CATEGORY AND ONE LAST IMPORTANT
PIECE OF THE BILL IS THAT CAL
CARE CREATES THE FRAMEWORK TO
TARGET AND DISMANTLE HEALTH
INEQUITIES THAT OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM IS BUILT UPON THE
BOARD IS CHARGED WITH ENSURING
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS RECEIVE
CULTURALLY LINGUISTICALLY AND
STRUCTURALLY COMPETENT CARE AND
TO BRING US CLOSER TO ACHIEVING
HEALTH EQUITY HEALTHCARE
WITH AND EXISTENCE OF CARE
BY PLACING EVERYONE UNDER THE
SINGLE ROOF OF CALCAREOUS WITH
THAT WITH A SINGLE STANDARD
OF CARE FOR ALL AND TO ADDRESS
DISTRIBUTIONAL DISPARITIES IN
OUR HEALTHCARE INFRASTRUCTURE
EIGHTY FOURTEEN HUNDRED
CREATE A SPECIAL PROJECTS
BUDGET TO HELP BUILD RENOVATE
AND STASHED FACILITIES AND
RURAL UNDERSERVED AND HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL SHORTAGE AREAS CAL
CARE WILL ALSO ADDRESS PROVIDER
RATE AND PRIORITIZE PROJECTS TO
IMPROVE HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND
QUALITY AND TO ADDRESS HEALTH
INEQUITIES FOR BLACK INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AS WELL AS
INEQUITIES BASED ON GEOGRAPHY
DISABILITY SOCIO ECONOMIC
STATUS AND FOR NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING COMMUNITIES GENDER NON
CONFORMING COMMITTEE AND OTHER
ARE UNDERSERVED GROUPS TOGETHER
THESE PROVISIONS UNDER CAL CARE
WOULD ENSURE THAT ALL HOSPITALS
AND CLINICS NO MATTER WHO THEY
SERVE HAVE THE RESOURCES THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO STAY
OPEN AND THIS MEANS WE CAN
FINALLY ADDRESSED THE ONGOING
CRISIS OF HOSPITAL CLOSURES AND
HEALTH CARE DESERT THAT HAVE
EXACERBATED HEALTH DISPARITIES
IN CLOSING PIECEMEAL EFFORTS
TO FIX OUR MULTI PAIR QUAGMIRE
OF INSURANCE HAVE NOT AND WILL
NOT AND OUR HEALTHCARE CRISIS
WE CANNOT EXPECT A SYSTEM
THAT IS DESIGNED TO SQUEEZE
EVERY DOLLAR AND CENT FOR MORE
HELP FROM THE PAIN MISERY AND
ELEMENTS OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS
TO PUT PATIENTS OVER PROFITS
UNDER CAL CARE THERE WOULD
BE NO MORE DETAILS OF CARE
NO MORE PRICE GOUGING AND
NO MORE EXTRACTING CORPORATE
WEALTH FROM OUR HOUSE THIS
COMMITTEE MUST ACT URGENTLY
TO PASS EIGHTY FOR WORKING
HUNDRED ANY DELAY WILL BE
PAID TO THE HEALTH AND LIVES
OF CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- WILL NOW
MOVE ON WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES
A REGISTERED IN OPPOSITION
MISTER CHRISTIAN YOUNG IS
HERE IN PERSON AND WE HAVE
MISTER WILLIAM MARTIN A BILL
BARCELONA BARCELONA ON THE
PHONE SO YOU COME UP IF YOU
LIKE YEAH THE PROPOSAL THE
FIRST OKAY WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY MISTER BARCELONA THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
-- BILL BARCELONA WITH
AMERICA'S PHYSICIAN GROUPS
LIKE TO WISH EVERYONE A HAPPY
AND HEALTHY NEW YEAR AND HOPE
FOR A BETTER TWENTY TWENTY TWO
HERPES ENDING WORKING NIGHT
INTEGRATED POSITION GROUPS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA UNITED STATES
TODAY AND I'M GOING TO SPEAK
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE FIRST I ASKED
THE COMMITTEE TO REMEMBER OUR
DEDICATED HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
THAT ARE CARING FOR
CALIFORNIANS AFFECTED BY THE
COVERT PANDEMIC IN OVERCROWDED
HOSPITALS AND PHYSICIAN OFFICES
AS WE MEET HERE TODAY COBIT
IS TAKING A HUGE TOLL ON OUR
PROVIDERS THE NEW MAYO CLINIC
SURVEY JUST RELEASED TODAY
A TWENTY TWO THOUSAND HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS INDICATES THAT
THIRTY PERCENT OF U.
S.
DOCTORS AND NURSES INTEND TO
REDUCE THEIR HOURS OVER THE
COMING YEAR WITH THIS IN MIND
WE SHOULD BE MINDFUL OF THE
IMPACTS THAT ARE HEALTH POLICY
PROPOSALS HAVE ON THE PEOPLE
WHO CARE FOR US AND OUR LOVED
ONES ON A DAILY BASIS I'D
LIKE TO START BY RECOGNIZING
THE TREMENDOUS PROGRESS
MADE BY THE GOLDEN STATE
IMPLEMENTING THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT SOMETIMES IN THE
FACE OF STUBBORN OPPOSITION
FROM OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IN CONGRESS I WAS GREATLY
PLEASED TO HEAR OUR GOVERNOR
STATE YESTERDAY WE WILL NOW
CLOSE THE REMAINING FINAL
COVERAGE GAP BY TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR HGV UNIVERSAL COVERAGE
SYSTEM UNDER THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT IN OUR STATE WE HAVE
MUCH TO BE THANKFUL FOR IN
TERMS OF OUR PROGRESS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA I CAN SUMMARIZE
MY MEMBERS CONCERNS OVER THIS
MEASURES FOLLOWS MY MEMBERS
ARE NOT A PART OF THE SOLUTION
PROPOSED UNDER A.
B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED HE ORGANIZED
INTEGRATED POSITION GROUPS
OF THE CALIFORNIA DELEGATED
MODEL WOULD BE PROHIBITED FROM
PARTICIPATING IN A SINGLE PAYER
SYSTEM AND WOULD THUS BE PUT
OUT OF OPERATION THIS IS A
TREMENDOUS STEP BACKWARDS FOR
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
AND FRANKLY I DON'T SEE THE
POINT IT WAS A CALIFORNIA
DELEGATED MODEL THAT PIONEERED
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SAME
DAY APPOINTMENT ACCESS OVER
TWENTY YEARS AGO OUR MEMBERS
WERE THE FIRST TO ADOPT
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORDS ON
A MASS SCALE AN ELECTRONIC
PATIENT PORTALS TO MAKE
LIFE EASIER FOR PATIENTS TO
NAVIGATE IN THE SYSTEM IN
ORDER MEMBERS PLAYING YOUR
POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT
BEFORE IT WAS EVEN A COMMONLY
USED TERM IN HEALTHCARE POLICY
CIRCLES OVER THIRTY YEARS
AGO BUT THIS BILL DOES AWAY
WITH ALL OF THE UNDERLYING
FOUNDATION THAT PRODUCE THIS
UNIQUE MODEL OF CARE THAT
OTHER STATES AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NOW SEEK TO EMULATE
AND PROPAGATE AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED OFFERS TWO CHOICES TO
POSITIONS IN OTHER CLINICAL
PROVIDERS ACCEPTING MEDICARE
FEE SCHEDULE FOR SERVICE RATES
OR BECOMING EMPLOYED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA UNDER
SALARY SYSTEM NEITHER OF THESE
CHOICES IS BEING PROPOSED --
ADVOCATED ANYWHERE ELSE OR
BY THE MEDICARE SYSTEM HAS
PREFERRED OPTIONS TO IMPROVE
THE HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM STILL REDEPLOYMENT
OF POSITIONS HAS BEEN SHOWN
TIME AND TIME AGAIN TO REDUCE
PHYSICIAN PRODUCTIVITY OVER
TIME PROPONENTS CITE THAT
THEY WOULD SEEK WAIVERS FROM
THE CMS CENTERS FOR MEDICARE
AND MEDICAID INNOVATION FOR
THEIR DELIVERY SYSTEM REFORMS
BUT MY ASSOCIATION HAS BEEN
INTIMATELY INVOLVED WITH
CMMI POLICY FOR TWO DECADES
IN THE DIRECTION OF THE CMMI
HAS BEEN AND REMAINS TO SHIP
PROVIDERS AWAY FROM PEOPLE
SERVICE PAYMENT MODELS TOWARD
FINANCIAL RISK SHARING IN ORDER
TO IMPROVE PATIENT OUTCOMES
IT IS DIRECTIONALLY OFF THE
SET OF THE PROPOSAL IN THIS
BILL ABANDONING THE ADVANCED
POSITION PAYMENT MODELS OF
THE CALIFORNIA DELEGATED
MODEL WILL BE A STEP BACKWARD
TOWARD A MORE FRAGMENTED
CARE DELIVERY ENVIRONMENT IN
CALIFORNIA HE WILL ALSO RAISE
OVERALL HEALTH CARE COSTS
FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE SEEN IN
THE ACTIONS OF THE PRECEDING
CONGRESS AND EFFORTS TO
DISMANTLE THE ACA WHICH
THANKFULLY DID NOT HAPPEN ANY
FUTURE CONGRESS WOULD NOT BE
BOUND BY THE PAST AGREEMENTS
THANK COULD VERY WELL BE
CALIFORNIA READ -- WHICH
REDUCED FUNDING TO OPERATE
SUCH A SYSTEM ESPECIALLY IN
THE COMPLEX PLANS OUTLINED
IN THIS BILL DO NOT NEED A
SMOOTH TRANSITION S.
AND FORTUNATELY VERY
LIKELY THANK YOU I THINK
IT WAS BARCELONA WILL
MOVE ON TO MISTER YOUNG
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PRESTON
YOUNG FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE HERE TODAY
IN OPPOSITION TO AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED FIRST AND FOREMOST
I WANT TO MAKE IT ABUNDANTLY
CLEAR WE ABSOLUTELY AGREE
THAT EVERY CALIFORNIAN IS
ENTITLED TO RECEIVE HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE AND NOT JUST
ANY HEALTH CARE COVERAGE IT
IS FUNDAMENTALLY IMPERATIVE
THAT THEY RECEIVE AFFORDABLE
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE HOWEVER
AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
AND SINGLE PAYER GOVERNMENT
RUN HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
ARE TWO COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
TOPICS IF WE'RE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT SINGLE PAYER HEALTH CARE
THAT IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT THE PAYER EVERYONE
CAN AGREE THAT THE PROPOSALS
CONTAINED WITHIN AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED WELL TAX CALIFORNIANS
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS THIS IS
COMPLETELY ANTITHETICAL TO
AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE THIS
UNSUSTAINABLE TAX BURDEN FALL
DIRECTLY ON THE SHOULDERS
OF CALIFORNIA'S EMPLOYERS
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY
OPPOSITION SO FIRST LET'S TALK
ABOUT COSTS IT'S INDISPUTABLE
AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED WOULD
INCREASE TAXES FOR CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES BY
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS AS THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT
CALIFORNIA'S TOTAL HEALTH CARE
EXPENDITURES WERE AN ESTIMATED
THREE HUNDRED AND NINETY NINE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TO
PUT THIS INTO PERSPECTIVE
THAT'S THIRTEEN POINT TWO
PERCENT OF THE STATE'S GDP
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ALSO
POINTS OUT THE CALIFORNIA'S
PER CAPITA HEALTHCARE SPENDING
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
WITH TEN THOUSAND EIGHTY
SIX DOLLARS EVEN ASSUMING
FEDERAL FUNDING STAYS IN PLACE
AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED WOULD
REQUIRE A SIGNIFICANT TAX
CONTRIBUTION EACH CALIFORNIANS
EVEN PARTIALLY APPROACH THESE
FIGURES IT SHOULD ALSO BE NOTED
THAT PROPONENTS OF A PUBLICLY
QUOTED AS SAYING ECA ELEVEN
WOULD RAISE A HUNDRED SIXTY
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY AS A COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS APPLICANTS OUT THIS
WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY UNDER FUND
A SINGLE PAYER SYSTEM WHICH
MEANS ALL OF US WOULD ACTUALLY
PAY MORE TAXES AND CURRENTLY
PROPOSED PREMIUMS DEDUCTIBLES
AND TWENTY CARE COST WE'VE DONE
AWAY WITH UNDER AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED THE SIMPLY BE REPLACED
A TAX OBLIGATIONS UNDER ACA
ELEVEN NOW LET'S PUT THIS
INTO PERSPECTIVE AND GIVE IT
A LITTLE CONTEXT CALIFORNIA
ALREADY HAS THE HIGHEST
GAS TAX RATE IN THE NATION
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
SALES TAX RATE IN THE NATION
PERSONAL INCOME TAX RATE IN
THE NATION CALIFORNIA HAS THE
EIGHTH HIGHEST CORPORATE TAX
RATE UNITED STATES THE HIGHEST
IN THE WESTERN UNITED STATES
NOW AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED AND
EASY ELEVEN PROPOSED EARLIER
THE BIGGEST TAX INCREASE IN
STATE HISTORY NOT ONCE BUT
ANNUALLY YEAR AFTER YEAR
AFTER YEAR ON THE STRUGGLING
CALIFORNIANS ATTEMPTING TO GET
THROUGH PANDEMIC SO THE STATE
CAN TAKE OVER ONE OF THE MOST
COMPLEX SYSTEMS THAT EXISTS
IN THE MIDST OF AN UNRELENTING
COBA NINETEEN PANDEMIC ALSO
THE PAYROLL TAXES MENTION AN
AC ELEVEN WILL COMBINE OF THE
PAYROLL TAX INCREASES COMING
NEXT YEAR DO ARE YOU AYE FUND
INSOLVENCY FURTHERMORE THE
TAX INCREASES WOULD BE STATIC
UNDER AC ELEVEN THEY WOULD
HAVE TO INTEGRATE WITH HEALTH
CARE COSTS YEAR AFTER YEAR
MANY THE ENORMOUS TAX INCREASES
WOULD HAVE AN UNREMITTED PACE
OF GROWTH NEXT WE OPPOSE AB
FOURTEEN HUNDRED BECAUSE IT
WILL DRIVE EMPLOYMENT ELSEWHERE
AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED WILL
RADICALLY FREEDOM OF CHOICE
FOR CONSUMERS WILL HEAVILY
TAXING EMPLOYERS TO EXPAND
THE CALIFORNIA SINCE THIS
WILL BE A STATE SYSTEM AND
NOT NATIONALIZED HEALTHCARE
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES WOULD
BE FREE TO LEAVE THE STATE AND
THEY COULD LEAVE THE STATE SO
THAT THEY COULD USE THEIR OWN
PRIVATE HEALTH CARE RATHER THAN
BEING FORCED TO PARTICIPATE IN
STATE BUREAUCRACY BELIEVED TO
AVOID THE HIGHEST TAXES IN THE
COUNTRY EMPLOYERS BELIEVED TO
AVOID ENORMOUS GROSS RECEIPTS
TAXES PAYROLL TAXES WILL BEING
ABLE TO EXPAND ELSEWHERE THIS
EXIST WILL PUNISH THE REMAINING
CALIFORNIANS WITH HIGHER TAXES
IN ORDER TO OFFSET OFFSET
THE FUNDING SHORTFALL LAST AS
MENTIONED EARLIER CALIFORNIA'S
APPROACHING NEAR UNIVERSAL
HEALTHCARE RENDERING EIGHTY
FOURTEEN HUNDRED UNNECESSARY
AS ANNOUNCED YESTERDAY
GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S BUDGET BRINGS
CALIFORNIA ONE STEP CLOSER
TO UNIVERSAL COVERAGE NO MAKE
CALIFORNIA THE FIRST STATE TO
OFFER HEALTH CARE COVERAGE FOR
ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE RESIDENTS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS IN CLOSING WELL OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM CAN IMPROVE
IN MANY WAYS COMPLETELY
ABOLISHING THE CURRENT SYSTEM
IN THE FACE OF AN UNRELENTING
PANDEMIC BI ANNUALLY TAX IN
CALIFORNIA HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IS NOT THE SOLUTION
PATIENTS NEED RELIABLE ACCESS
TO CARE RIGHT NOW IT IS NOT A
TIME TO EXPERIMENT A BRAND NEW
STATE RUN BUREAUCRACY FUNDED
BY UNSUSTAINABLE TAXES PLACED
ON EMPLOYERS TRYING TO SURVIVE
A PANDEMIC FOR THESE REASONS
OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION TO THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH THAT
WE WILL GO TO WITNESSES IN THE
CHAMBER ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SAY SOMETHING -- REMEMBER
WE'RE GOING TO BE JUST ASKING
FOR YOUR NAME YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL AND ANY ORGANIZATION
IF YOU REPRESENT ONE SO PLEASE
PLEASE COME FOR PLEASE DON'T
TOUCH THE MICROPHONES EITHER
PLEASE YEP THAT'S PERFECT THANK
YOU HELLO MY NAME IS STELLA
AND I AM A LATIN TWENTY THREE
YEAR UNION REPRESENTED HOSPITAL
NURSE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS FINANCIALLY DESTRUCTIVE
AND EXPENSIVE BILL THANK YOU
IN FUTURE TESTIMONY JUST YOUR
POSITION ENOUGH WITHOUT THE
EXTRA PIECES THANKS MY NAME
IS REBECCA I'M A REGISTERED
NURSE AND I OPPOSE THIS COSTLY
LEDGE LEGISLATION CLOSER
BUT YOU KNOW THANK YOU HI
MY NAME IS TO MICAH AND -- A
-- REPRESENT THE PEOPLE WHO
DON'T WANT COMMUNIST HAVE CARE
IN THIS STATE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
HELLO MY NAME IS TRAIL
LATCH THREE KNOWN FROM
PLASTER COUNTY WITH PLASTER
COUNTY FREEDOM MOMS AND
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
ACROSS THE STATE JUST
CHANGES ON THE BILL AB FORTY
SINGLE PAYER PROGRAM
THIS IS YOUR FOUR YEARS
AGO -- REGARDING ABOUT
THE NUMBER OF THIS
PLEASE JUST YOUR POSITION AN
ORGANIZATION WE'VE HAD WE'VE
HAD WE'VE HAD TESTIMONY FROM
BOTH SIDES JUST YOUR POSITION
YOUR NAME IN YOUR ORGANIZATION
MY NAME IS SERRA DOT BORN
AND RAISED IN CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY I REPRESENT MYSELF
AND MY SMALL BUSINESS AND
VARIOUS PROPERTIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS THANK YOU
MY NAME IS KATHERINE
MCBRIDE PLUS YOUR FREEDOM
COALITION WE OPPOSE USHERING
IN NEW TAXES AND A MORE
SPECIALIST HERE IS VOTE NO
AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU
MY NAME IS LINDA
RICH AS A CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS I OPPOSE A.
B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED AS
LONG AS WE STILL HAVE
AN INVASION OF THANK YOU
YEAH IF THANK YOU I THINK
WE'RE DONE THANK YOU
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
NUMBERS NINE EIGHT THIS ROUGH
GO OKAY ANG -- SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF SAVE OUR SENIORS
NETWORK AND JUMP OFF THE BACK
GOALS ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA
TRANSIT DIRECTOR AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FORTY FIVE IF WE
DO THIS NOW THANK YOU THANK YOU
WE WILL NOW GO TO THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE WE HAVE ANYBODY
AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE
NOBODY THERE OKAY BUT
WHAT WE DO PLEASE GO
AHEAD WITH THEIR YEAH
PLUG IN NEAR ME YES HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU HI MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
AND I COMPLETELY OPPOSE THIS
BECAUSE YOU NEED TO FIX OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM BEFORE YOU
TRY TO DO SOMETHING THANK YOU
YEAH GO AHEAD HI GUYS ARE
YOU GUYS HEAR ME YES SIR I'M
JEALOUS GILES THE RESIDENTS
SACRAMENTO AND I OPPOSE AB
ONE FOUR ZERO ZERO THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU
MY NAME IS TJ MCCARTY
ALL RIGHT MY NAME IS TJ
MCCARTY AND I OPPOSE -- ONE
FOUR ZERO ZERO THANK YOU
YEAH YOU GIVE ME A SIGNAL HOW
DO I KNOW CAN I SEE MYSELF
CAN I SEE MY SON MURATSUCHI
ONE OF MY LOOK YOU DON'T
NEED TO LOOK JUST JUST USING
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
-- YOUR SUPPORTERS
AND WE'RE LIKE YEAH
NUMBER TEN IN THE
NEXT WITNESS PLACE
YEAH YEAH I DON'T I
DON'T KNOW WHAT SHE'S
SAYING BUT YEAH YEAH YEAH
WE ASK ALL OF OUR WITNESSES
THE SAME THING THE NAME THEIR
POSITION AND ORGANIZATIONS
THEY REPRESENT ONE IF THEY
CHOOSE TO NOT PARTICIPATE
THAT WAY THEN WE'RE GOING TO
THEN WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT WITNESS AND SHE'S
CHOSEN NOT TO PARTICIPATE SO
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED SO THE
RESPECT OF OUR PROCESS PLEASE
WELL I CAN READ LIPS TO YEAH
I CAN READ THAT ONE TOO YEAH
RIGHT NEXT WITNESS PLEASE ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES AT
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY SIDERS
SHE THE LAST WITNESS WE ARE
NOW THANK YOU OKAY WE'LL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES NOW -- PLEASE
YOUR NAME YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL IN YOUR ORGANIZATION
ONLY PLEASE I'M ASKING YOU
-- ANYTHING MORE AND WE'RE
JUST GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT WITNESS SO WE'VE AGREED
WITH WHAT I HAVE I'M WE'RE
GONNA GIVE NINETY MINUTES UP
TO NINETY MINUTES HERE WHICH
IS THE LONGEST I'VE EVER EVER
DONE THAT I CAN RECALL ITSELF
SO -- SO PLEASE MR OPERATOR
-- GO AHEAD OPEN THE LINES
FRANKLY PARDON OKAY I'M SORRY
WHAT YES PLEASE I'M SORRY YES
YES YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS ALREADY HUGELY MANY BERSERK
-- I AM SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC AMERICAN
LABOR ALLIANCE SACRAMENTO
CHAPTER I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU THAT'S A PERFECT EXAMPLE
OF THE TESTIMONY WE WOULD LIKE
TO HEAR NEXT NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THE NEXT LINE IS WHITE THREE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
WHY THREE FOURTEEN
YOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
BERMAN STERN MEMBERS NICK
LEWIS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
HAVE LINE TWO EIGHTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND US ARMY DOES ON BEHALF
OF THE CITIES OF OAKLAND
BERKELEY EMERYVILLE AND
CONFERENCE THAT'S GOING
TO SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE TO TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOU CAN HEAR ME YES WHERE
DO YOU LIVE IN ONE EQUITY
PARTNERSHIP IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND IMPERIAL
COUNTY -- IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
WE HAVE LINE TO
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
-- KEVIN TO DRAW THE
REPRESENTING NFIB -- WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALL PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOUR OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOU'RE A MEMBER ON BEHALF OF
THE FOLLOWING CLIENT CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION SANTA
MONICA IN THE BORDER THERE BY
THERE'S A CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANKS CALLER
WE HAVE LINE THREE THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS BRANDON MARCHING
ON BEHALF OF THE NEARLY
FIFTY THOUSAND MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU XCURRENT
WE HAVE LINE THREE NINETY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO THANK YOU MY NAME IS
BETSY MORRIS I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED ON BEHALF OF THE EAST
BAY GRAY PANTHERS I'M ALSO
A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RETIRED
AMERICANS WHICH ALSO SUPPORT
THANK YOU YES NEXT CALLER
AT LINE ONE SIXTY TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD GOOD EVENING GENTS
GLORY ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
WE HAVE LINE TO
TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO JENNIFER MY ONLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
WE HAVE A LINE THREE FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS IS
ROSS BARKLEY ON BEHALF
OF THE SACRAMENTO OR
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
AND WE DO HAVE LINE THREE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF
OF THE CONSUMER FEDERATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER
WE HAVE LINE TO EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
EVENING MY NAME AT THAT THE
HARDWOOD RESOLUTE ON BEHALF
OF BILLS AFFORDABLE FASTER
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE THREE THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
EVENING YES CLEAN PALETTE
ON BEHALF OF HELD BACK
THE CALIFORNIA SUPPORT IN
CONCEPT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
WE HAVE LINE ONE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO MY NAME IS JEFF
GREEN ON WITH ANYONE EQUITY
PARTNERSHIP INVOICING
SUPPORT THANK YOU SIX COLOR
WE HAVE LINE OR TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MARK VAN LAND DO IT ON BEHALF
OF OUR REVOLUTION EAST BAY
AND PASSIONATE SUPPORT OF
AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER WE HAVE
A LINE THREE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO THIS
IS REBECCA GONZALEZ OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOR FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
TRUMP'S
FOUR FORTY ONE YEAR OPEN HI MY
NAME'S ROB COPELAND FROM OUR
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL SACRAMENTO
VALLEY CHAPTER STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU THE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE WE HAVE
A LINE FOR FORTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD HELLO MY NAME IS
AMBER SURE GILL ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS THAT DON'T WANT
TO GO BANKRUPT IF WE GET SICK
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE WE HAVE LINE
FOR EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
RIGHT FOR EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THE CARD I REPRESENTS CFA THE
GROUP WAS INSERTED IN FACT
BECAUSE THE NUMBERS TO SYSTEM
YOU'RE A STRONG SUPPORT IF
YOU COULD NOT GOOD THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOR EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD THIS GUITAR
MEMBERS HE'S THE MODEL ON THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED
AMERICANS HEARING STRONG
BORDER MAYBE THIRTEEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE THREE SIXTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
THREE SIXTY TWO
YES CORRECT HELLO
PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO YEP
WE'RE HERE THIS IS EXISTENCE
JUMPSTARTED KENYA -- STRONG
SUPPORT EXPERIAN KERA POWELL
THAN OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
DOGFIGHT AMONG THEM THANK YOU
SIX COLOR PLEASE THEY HAVE LINE
FOR EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD EVENING THIS IS JAN ONE
BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION THAT
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE WE HAVE LINE THREE
HUNDRED PLEASE CALL AT KELLY
TEAM ON BEHALF OF HEALTH NET OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION TO AB
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE
AB LINE FOR FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
ANYTHING CHEN MEMBERS NAME
APPEAR ON ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
INSURANCE AND FINANCIAL
ADVISORS IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANKS CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE THE LINE FOR TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE
BALLING CREWS ON THE POP
UP SHOP FOR FOR ALL LOS
ANGELES CHAPTER IN GSA LOS
ANGELES HEALTHCARE JUST
NEEDED A STRONG SUPPORTER
OF AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE A LINE FOR EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
OBVIOUSLY EIGHT PEOPLE TO DEATH
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE A LINE FOR
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
AFTER AN ACCIDENT GALLAGHER
I'M HAPPY THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE A LINE THREE NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI MY NAME IS SCOTT I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF ALL
OF THE EMPLOYEES WORKING
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
IN PASSIONATE OPPOSITION
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE A LINE THE SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HERE MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO
OH FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
ALEX OSBORN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINED THREE SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD HI
COMMITTEE HOLIDAY DISABLED FOR
THIRTY ONE YEARS WHEELCHAIR
BOUND -- FORMER BOARD MEMBER
GOVERNMENTS LIKE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
HAVE LINE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD YES GOOD EVENING
YEAH I NEED TO THE CENTER
OF CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE
HAVE THE LINE NUMBER
AT NINETY FOUR
-- YES SLOGANEERING BECAUSE
YES MY NAME IS RICHARD ROBY ACT
MY NAME IS RICHARD ROBY ACT I'M
IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL AND I'M WITH THE ALLIANCE
OF IF THE DISABLED AMERICAN
VETERAN MATTERED HE WOULD
LISTEN TO WHAT WE HAVE TO SAY
NEXT CALLER PLEASE BLIND THREE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
BY THREE SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
TWENTY THREE SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THANKS CALLER PLEASE WELL
THEN WE HAVE LIKE FIVE ALL
ONE OKAY NO I'M SORRY WE'LL
FIND FIVE OR WHAT IS GOING ON
AS CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN LINGER
ON BEHALF OF AMERICA'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS AND ANTHEM
BLUE CROSS IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU SIX COLOR PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE ONE FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND HOW WE
GOT THEM DOLLARS ON BEHALF
OF KAISER PERMANENTE A IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU X.
COLOR PLEASE WE HAVE LINE THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
I LINE IF IT IS YES IT IS A
LOCAL YOUNG I'M CALLING BEHALF
ON ALL ITS DAY TAX PAYERS
AND CALIFORNIA AND THE MIDDLE
CLASS TAXPAYERS AND STRONG
OPPOSITION AT THE L.
THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOR EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO MY
NAME IS JOE IN AWHILE I LIVE
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA --
I REPRESENTS ALL OF THE --
OUR MINORITY TAXPAYERS --
WOMEN IN THE WORK MULTIPLE
JOBS AND BECAME REALLY STRONG
ABSOLUTELY STRONG OPPOSITION
OKAY THANK YOU DO NOT TAKE
THANK YOU NEXT CALL PLEASE
OUR NEXT LINE IS LIKE
TO SIXTY SIX WAS QUIET
MARLAY STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOR FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS MAX
CARL AND OFFERED TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF UNITE HERE LOCAL
FORTY NINE IN THE CITY OF
SEASIDE IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU SIX COLOR PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FIVE OH SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD EVENING
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
MENDEZ CONSTITUENT OF FORTY
THIRD DISTRICT IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED THANK YOU PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOR
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS DR
KARAN FOR CONEY AND I'M CALLING
IN ON BEHALF OF PHYSICIANS
FOR A NATIONAL HEALTH PROGRAM
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE BURKE
WE HAVE LINED ONE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD EVENING REX W.
HEIM ON THE APPLE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES DESTINATION
I YES THE BUILDING OWNERS AND
MANAGERS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
AND NOW CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINED THREE
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI MY NAME IS KAYLA CARDING
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE VALLEY INDUSTRY AND
COMMERCE ASSOCIATION PIKE
AT IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOR TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
YES THIS IS JOHN DOUGLAS
I REPRESENT THE THE SOCIAL
JUSTICE MINISTRY OF LIVE
OAK UNITARIAN UNIVERSALIST
CONGREGATION AND KHALIFA AND
THE SANTA BARBARA CHAPTERS
OF THE ESSAY OF P.
AND H.
P.
THE PHYSICIANS FOR A NATIONAL
HEALTH PROGRAM AND HEALTH
CARE FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR A
BI FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOR NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD EVENING
SAY FORGET ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA AGENTS AND HEALTH
INSURANCE PROFESSIONAL OPPOSED
EIGHTY FOURTEEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE TWO OH
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YES HELLO THIS IS SANDY MARC
COUNCIL POSTURE COUNTY AGAIN
AND I AM IN OUR OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL SO I ASK YOU
TO PLEASE OPPOSED IN YOUR
VOTING THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU SIX NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOR SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
LIKE FOR SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YES NAY THAT IS USER YES
HI THIS IS JON KATZ PRESIDENT
SANTA MONICA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY I'M CALLING BECAUSE THE
MEMBERSHIP VOTED UNANIMOUSLY A.
B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOR SEVENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD GOOD EVENING THIS IS
CAROL MANNING I'M A CONTRACTOR
RESIDENT BUSINESS OWNER AND
TAXPAYER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED ON BEHALF
OF SMALL BUSINESSES AND MIDDLE
CLASS TAXPAYERS IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINES OF FOUR EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD HI MY
NAME IS NOW IN THE NATION
I'M REPRESENTING MYSELF MY
FAMILY IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO EIGHTY FOURTEEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOR TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS A LEASE ACCOUNTING
I'M AUTHORIZED TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF STAND THE ARK SHE
WAS JEWISH ACTION SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND
STUDENTS FOR A NATIONAL HEALTH
PROGRAM CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR A BI FOURTEEN
HUNDRED THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
YES LINE FIVE FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD YES MY NAME IS ERNEST
ISAACS I'M A PSYCHOTHERAPIST
AMP AND SPEAKER PSYCHOTHERAPIST
FOR SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY
AND THE HEALTH CARE ACTION
COMMITTEE IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THINK
IT'S STRONG SUPPORT OKAY
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
-- WE HAVE LAND TO SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI THIS IS
JACK MCKENNA -- AND I'VE BEEN
AUTHORIZED TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF SILICON VALLEY DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALISTS OF AMERICA IN BEING
FACULTY SUPPORT THE B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIX CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE TO
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI MY NAME IS TYLER BAGLEY ON
BEHALF OF THE PLASTER COUNTY
FREEDOM COALITION HIRED YOU
TO STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOR FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD EVENING
MISTER TURN MEMBERS ANTI
MINORITY HERE ON BEHALF OF
CIGNA IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOR FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD THIS IS
ISABEL STORY REPRESENTING
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA --
COALITION EIGHTY GROUPS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE BLIND FOUR OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD EVENING
I'M SURE MEMBERS MATTHEW ALEC
WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL OKAY
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
HAVE LINE
IT LINE FIVE OH TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
OF OUR KNOWING HE CHECK ON
BEHALF OF BLUE SHIELD OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE
HAVE LINE FOR SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD GOOD EVENING THIS
IS JIM ASTON SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE MENDOCINO COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC CENTRAL COMMITTEE
AND WE SUPPORT A.
B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE ALIGNED FOUR
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD
YES IT IS CORPORATE CASH
-- FROM AMERICANS FOR
DEMOCRATIC ACTION SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER SPEAKING
IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR A
BI FOURTEEN HUNDRED CAL
CARE THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT NEXT CALLER PLEASE
AND WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD EVENING CARE NUMBERS
THIS IS BENJAMIN LEE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY FOURTEEN HUNDRED
BECAUSE IT WOULD REQUIRE
THE LARGEST TAX INCREASE
IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
YEAH LINE ONE SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD
MANY THANKS CALIFORNIA TO
DISABILITY RIGHTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE
YEAH ONE FOUR ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI MY NAME IS SEAN STARKEY I'M
LEGISLATIVE DEBATE PER LA CITY
COUNCILMEMBER KEVIN DALY I'M
CALLING TO SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE THE BLIND FOR FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
EVENING THIS IS BLINDNESS
AUDIO MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
PLANO HERE AND KERN COUNTY
CALLING SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE A LINE SEVENTY EIGHT
LET'S GO AHEAD ROBERT CURTIS
PRESIDENT OF THE CITY OF
SAMBAR TO DINO RETIRED PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION WITH
MEMBERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
MIST -- TAX CREATING BILL ALONE
AFTER THAT THE OPPOSE SECTION
THIRTEEN THIRTY TWO WAIVERS
NEXT CALL NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOR
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
FOUR EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
SEKHMET THAT YOU'RE A MEMBER
STEPHANIE WADKINS ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOR FIFTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
ONE FOUR FIFTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
EIGHT INCHES OCCUPATIONAL
ORGANIZER AND MEMBER ALL
I EAT IS ESPECIALLY LIKELY
CONCORD CALIFORNIA INSTRUCT
THE POINT AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
YOU HAVE LINE FOR SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
THE RAIN ON THE L.
AND AYE OPPOSED A.
B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOR SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
EVENING MEGAN LOPER ON
BEHALF OF THE UNITED HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOR TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
FOUR TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
IN LINE FOR TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
NINE FIVE FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
HEY THIS IS ELENA HOUSE
THERE WITH LOS ANGELES CITY
COUNCILMEMBER MIKE BONIN IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
LINE FOR NINETY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
THIRTY MEMBERS SLOWLY MASSAGING
WITH CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS
AND TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK
YOU THE NEXT PASSCODE PLEASE
IF LINE ONE SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA INDIVISIBLE
STATE STRONGLY IN STRONG
SUPPORT TO FOURTEEN HUNDRED B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINED THREE
NINETY SIX WAS GO HEAD
NINE THREE NINETY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE IF YOU GO AHEAD
IF YOU'RE IF YOU WANNA
SAY SOMETHING PLEASE
AGAIN LIKE THREE NINETY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
OKAY MOVE ON NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THE NEXT LINE IS FIVE THREE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI JENNIFER JOHNSON TAXPAYER
PLASTER COUNTY A STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO COME THIS BILL AB
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOR TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO MY NAME IS ANYTHING
THAT FLOW THAT ARE IN A PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSE CALLING ON BEHALF
OF MY PATIENTS FOREMOST AND
IF YOU ORGANIZATIONS I'M
AUTHORIZED TO SPEAK ON BOTH
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY OF CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY OUR CENTRAL
COMMITTEE AND THE CONTRA COSTA
CENTRAL LABOR COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FLICKING YEAH
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOR EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
EVENING -- ANTHONY LEE
WITH THE LOS ANGELES AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU NEXT CONFERENCE
WE HAVE LINE FIVE OH THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI MY NAME IS
COLIN SPEAKING FOR MYSELF AND A
FEW ON HOUSE NEIGHBORS OF MINE
WHO ARE TOO SCARED TO GO TO THE
HOSPITAL IN STRONG SUPPORT A.
B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOR FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE DIRECTOR DAN
KELLY CALLING FROM SIMPLY
DISTRICT TWO IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE FOURTEEN HUNDRED ON
BEHALF OF YOU GUYS HAD A
SURE GRIP THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
S.
LINE FIVE SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD
HIS NAME THEIR THINKING
FOR INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
AND NEXT IN LINE FIVE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
RIGHT FIVE THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THANKS CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOR SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
I LIVE IN THE MOMENT
FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND
IS A MEMBER CALLING ON
THE STRONG SUPPORT THE
GIVES ITS COLOR PLEASE
F.
LINE TWO SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YEAH -- TREATING PERSON
BURKE CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE MEDIA ALLIANCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOR TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD YES THIS IS
DOCTOR BILL HUNTINGTON CALLING
ON BEHALF OF PROGRESSIVE
DEMOCRATS AMERICAN CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE V.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINED FIVE
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
JESSICA TUNIS ARE REPRESENTING
OUR EVOLUTION NORTH BANK IN
STRONG SUPPORT Q.
X.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE THREE
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD
IN LINE THREE NINETY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE FOR LIFE FOR
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
IT'S A VERY NARROW CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION MEMBERS OCHRE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THEY HAVE LINE FOR THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
THIS IS GREG MILLER FROM
THE SENATE CLARA COUNTY
SINGLE PAYER HEALTHCARE
COLLECTION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FOUR OH
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GET LINE FOUR OH SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD
I AM C.
TAYLOR I STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO FOURTEEN HUNDRED I'M AN
INDEPENDENT BUSINESS OWNER
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE FIVE TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI MY NAME IS HE REPEATED HELLO
COUNTY CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
AND I AM STRONG SUPPORT EIGHTY
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
HAVE LINE TWO EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI MY NAME IS SAMANTHA
SEELEY AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE ALL CALIFORNIA
CITIZEN AND I CANNOT SUPPORT
SOCIALIZED MEDICINE AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAD A LINE FOUR THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
I CAN'T WAIT FOR THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
NEXT CALLER PLEASE
TECH NEXT CALLER PLEASE
ARE YOU STILL WITH US MR PRATER
I AM OKAY ALLIED FIVE OR
SIX IS OPEN CURRENTLY MISTER
MEMBERS PRIMARY SUMMIT AFTER
UNITED HEALTH GROUP -- IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO A.
B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED AND IT'S
BECAUSE FUNDING MECHANISM
ACLS THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THEY HAVE LINED FIVE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
JOHN DOLLARS MEREKA CITY
ATTENDED ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY ASSEMBLY BILL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINED FIVE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI THIS IS
PETER SHAPIRO I AM THE TAXPAYER
AND A BOARD MEMBER OF HELP THE
CALIFORNIA NOW IT'S STATEWIDE
COALITION WITH AMENDMENT WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
F.
ONE FIVE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
WHAT DOES IT -- FROM THE
TWENTY FATHERS AND ALSO THE
PEOPLE WHO EAT RAW VEGETABLES
AND OPPOSE THE ALLOPATHIC
MEDICINE MEDICINE AND I AM
SUS -- AND STAUNCH OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINED FIVE THIRTY
SIX PLEASE CALL AND
MY NAME IS RACHEL LADD AND
I REPRESENT MYSELF MY FAMILY
AND REBUILD CALIFORNIA DOT
COM IN STRONG OPPOSITION OKAY
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WEHRLEIN FIVE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
HEY THIS IS JEREMIAH
LOCKED IN WITH YOU A W.
LOCAL TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
WHICH REPRESENTS NINETEEN
THOUSAND TEACHING ASSISTANTS
TUTORS AND CRATERS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE ORANGE COUNTY
CHAPTER OF THE DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALISTS OF AMERICA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANKS THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THEY HAVE LINE TWO TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD HI THERE
ARE MANY HELLO YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD OKAY SORRY MY NAME
IS THE ENTITLED RUDE I'M A
CO CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE FOR THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY WHICH
REPRESENTS THREE MILLION
REGISTERED DEMOCRAT AND A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WHICH
REPRESENTS THE DEMOCRATS
AND BOTH ORGANIZATIONS
STRONGLY ROBOTICALLY
SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU NEXT CALL PLEASE
HAVE LINE FIVE FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU AT THE RATE
OF PRESENT ON THE
HARVEY MILK LGBT Q.
DEMOCRATIC CLUB CALLING
STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINED FIVE FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
THIS IS CORRESPOND FROM THE
BUTTE COUNTY HEALTH CARE
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED OKAY
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
HAVE A LINE FOR TWENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD HI MY NAME IS BRANDON
KARAMI AND I AM REPRESENTING
OAKLAND COUNCIL PRESIDENT
PRO TEM SHANK HOW IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED
I HOPE YOU HAVE A GOOD NIGHT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINED FIVE FIFTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD BOB MICHAEL RIDE
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THEY HAVE A LINE FOR FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI THIS IS
GABRIELLE ENGRAM REPRESENTING
STAND THAT SACRAMENTO COUNTY
IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINED FIVE FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD TO THE
LEFT HELLO BUT THE THING
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA EIGHT
WHITE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINED FIVE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
RIGHT THIS IS N.
B.
WATSON WITH NATIONAL UNION OF
HEALTHCARE WORKERS THANK THAT
WE SUPPORT WITH AMENDMENTS
ADDRESSING THE INTEGRATED
MANAGED HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THANK
YOU NEXT NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THEY HAVE LINED FIVE FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI ARE YOU LOCATED ON BEHALF OF
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY DEMOCRATIC
CENTRAL COMMITTEE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINED FIVE FORTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
SO
HOW ON
YEAH
I'M HERE -- ALL
OPERATOR THE NEXT
HE'S LIKE I'M WE HAVE LINE FOR
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD HI
MY NAME IS MADE POWERFUL I'M A
RESIDENT OF YELLOW COUNTY AND
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
I HAVE ONE FIVE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD I JUST SEE
IF YOU GUYS WERE WAKE HI MY
NAME IS CRYSTAL BALL TORY IN
THE POLITICAL ORGANIZER FROM
THE STOPPING OF THE CLERKS
COUNCIL AND I'M HERE CALLING
TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE RIGHT
WE HAVE LINE FIVE NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI MY NAME
IS THAT IF YOU'RE NOT WELL
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEMOCRATIC
PARTY GENTLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND THE FEDERAL HEALTHCARE
CAPITALIST BUT EIGHT PEOPLE AT
YONGE ST BERKELEY DOWN THREE
POINT ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
BUT NEXT COMBAT MARC
WE HAVE LINED FIVE NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD MY
NAME IS FRANCESCA WANDER I
AM A TAX PAYING CALIFORNIANS
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA STATE
STRONG INDIVISIBLE INDIVISIBLE
SAN FRANCISCO INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO INDIVISIBLE YELLOW
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
WE HAVE LINE SIX OH
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO HELLO MISTER SORRY
THIS IS JORDAN THREE SAN ON
BEHALF OF ALL HARD WORKING TAX
PAYING CALIFORNIANS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
YES LINE SIX OH
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
I'M GOING TO BE ON BEHALF OF U.
A.
W.
WESTERN STATES STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALL
AND WE HAVE A LINE SIX
OH TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI MY NAME IS TANYA ELEVEN
CALLING FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY CENTRAL
COMMITTEE IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AND ON BEHALF OF
THE GENERAL HOSPITAL SOAP
OPERA PODCAST AND I JUST WANT
TO STAND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
HAVE A LINE FIVE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
IN THE MEANTIME CARE NUMBERS
ROMANTIC ARMATO ELLIOT
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF ALAMEDA AND MARK
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER
AS A LINE SIX TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD
I THOUGHT
THE REASON THAT I
COUNTY WELL ONE THING
PLEASE PLEASE JUST
YOUR NAME IN A POSITION
I HAVE A I CAN
HEAR ME YES I CAN
RIGHT THIS IS LIKE TRAGOPAN
VICE CHAIR OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
A DELEGATE THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY FOR
IDENTIFICATION PURPOSES
FOR ME BOTH ARE IN INTO THE
ASPECTS APART AB FOURTEEN
HOT CREEK THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINED SIX TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI MY NAME IS LAURIE BOB RYAN
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA STATE
STRONG AND I ALSO AND WE
ARE ALSO ENTHUSIASTICALLY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
HAVE A LINE SIX TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YES MY NAME
IS CHERYL AND STAPLETON AND
THE PUBLIC POLICY OFFICER FOR
THE HOLLYWOOD CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR WOMEN
WE ARE IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB FOURTEEN K.
HUNDRED THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE
YEAH THE LINES ARE A SORRY LINE
THREE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
NUMBER EIGHT -- EIGHT YEAR OLD
SHE IS YEAH
NEXT NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINED SIX FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
FIVE SIX FOUR IT IS OPEN YUP
HI I'M CALLING I'M CALLING
IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE ONE SIX TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI MY NAME IS ALEX AND I'M
WITH THE SIERRA CLUB I'M NOT
TAXPAYERS THEY NOTED THAT
CALIFORNIA DRAWING SUPPORT
EIGHTY FOUR TWO HUNDRED
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE SIX THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO MY NAME
IS SHARON KRAMER CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES YES MA'AM I'M FROM SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND THE TAXPAYER
I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
URGE YOU TO OPPOSE A.
B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINED FIVE FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD HI A
MINING HOIST AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF OUR REVOLUTION
GUARDINO ACROSS A.
L.
A.
IN THE COURT THANK
YOU ITS COLOR
WE HAVE LINE SIX SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD HERE'S MY MY
NAME IS DR WILLIAM BRONSON
-- I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY EIGHT PEOPLE WHO DIED
IN THE LAST TWELVE MONTHS
THE LACK OF COVERAGE HI I'M
GONG SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER SIX FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD I DID
TO TAKE OUR COUNTRY IT'S
BEHALF OF MYSELF AND I AND
AND STRONG SUPPORT FOR TWO
HUNDRED THANK YOU NEXT CONCRETE
WE HAVE LINES FIVE SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YES HI
MY NAME IS PAUL RUBIN FORTY
FIVE YEARS STARK WHITE THEY'RE
FOR SELF INSURED FARTHER THAN
NOW ADULT DISABLED PERSON
I WAS RAISED IN A SINGLE
PAYER JURISDICTION I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
OKAY THANK YOU NEXT NEXT
CALLER PLEASE THANK YOU
WE HAVE LINE FIVE SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD YES MY NAME IS
TOM ADLER AND I SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF SMALL BUSINESSES EVERYWHERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND THE GAY AND
LESBIAN PAGES HI WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FOUR TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN
HUNDRED BUT THANK YOU FOURTEEN
HUNDRED I'M SORRY PERFECT THANK
YOU NEXT NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE A LINE FOR THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
BY FOUR THIRTY NEXT LINE IS A
OKAY NEXT CALLER PLEASE
LINE FIVE NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
HELLO THIS IS JOHN I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THOSE CALIFORNIA
OVER HER COLLEAGUES TO JOIN
THE MOTOR QUALITY AND MILITARY
SOURCES OF AMERICA SUPPORT OF
AB FORTY UP FOURTEEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINED SIX SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI MY NAME IS
PRAVEEN SINHA I'M A RESIDENT OF
SAN FRANCISCO AND IT PROBABLY
SELF EMPLOYED NOW SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER I AM CALLING
IN STRONG AND ENTHUSIASTIC
FAVOR OF AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE SIX SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY THAT'S
ME HI I'M PATTY HARVEY AND I
AM REPRESENTING AS CO CHAIR OF
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL OF HUMBOLDT
CHAPTERS OF HEALTHCARE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIA AND PHYSICIANS
FOR A NATIONAL HEALTH PROGRAM
AND WE ARE ENTHUSIASTICALLY
IN SUPPORT OBVIOUSLY OF
FOURTEEN HUNDRED EIGHTY
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
HAVE LINE SIX SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI GOOD EVENING AARON NOTED
ON BEHALF OF INDEPENDENT
INSURANCE AGENTS AND
BROKERS OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE CALIFORNIA POOL AND SPA
OPPOSITION AND OPPOSITION
IF YOU COLLECT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
EXCEPT ONE FIVE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
IN LIGHT FIVE THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
NEXT CALL PLEASE
HAVE LINE SIX EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN HI MY
NAME'S MIKE ON THE BEHALF
OF THE TAXPAYERS DIME THIRD
JOHNNY WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
FOURTEEN HUNDRED AND PICK YOU
S.
WINE SIX FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD HI I'M BARBARA
COMMON A REGISTERED NURSE I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BERNIE CRAPS AND WE
ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF AB PORT
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
LINE SIX NINETY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
FIVE SIX NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN HI MY NAME IS MATTHEW
SNYDER I'M A CO FOUNDER OF
THE TWENTY EIGHT ORGANIZATION
GET MONEY OUT OF POLITICS AND
I'M LOVING SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
HELP LINE SIX SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI MY NAME
IS ERIC SAMPSON A MEMBER
OF THE MEDICARE FOR ALL
COMMITTEE OF THE STATE DSA
IN ANTISEPTIC SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE SEVEN
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD
BY NINETEEN CARTER AND I'M
THE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN YOUR
POCKET AND ON BEHALF OF
FIFTEEN YEARS IN CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT A.
B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
FIVE SEVEN OH THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD EVENING THIS IS
EMILY VALENTINE WITH THE
QUALITY COUNTY DEMOCRATIC
CENTRAL COMMITTEE AND WE IN
FACT WE SUPPORT A.
B.
FOURTEEN HUNTER AT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
LINE SEVEN OH SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD YES MY NAME IS
JANET THOMAS I'M CHAIR OF
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY AND A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND I'M CALLING TO
EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT OKAY
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE SEVEN OH FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI THIS IS
THE DEREK MARSHALL CALLING
CANDIDATE FOR CONGRESS IN
CA TWENTY THREE THE HIGH
DESERT I'M CALLING TO --
TO OFFER MY STRONG SUPPORT
THAT THE -- COMMITTEE ALIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE SEVEN OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD EVENING
MY NAME AT THE CORE OF THIS
NARAL I'M NOT HERE IN THE
TRI COMMUNITY DEMOCRATIC CLUB
AND CAN IT BE STATE ASSEMBLY
AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN UNDER
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINED SIX EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO MY
NAME IS KETAN CAN'T COME
FROM ALAMEDA CALIFORNIA IN
TOTAL SUPPORT AND EIGHTY
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
HAVE LINE SEVEN
TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YES MY NAME IS DAISY AND
I'M A RESIDENT OF ANAHEIM
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE SEVEN OH ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI MY NAME
IS HOLLY AND I AM A LIFELONG
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT FROM
LOVE LIFE ON CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES SPENDING VERY
VERY STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
LIFESAVING EIGHTY FOURTEEN
HUNDRED THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE CLIENTS SEVEN FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD YES MY NAME
IS MARLENE GILLESPIE AND
I'M SPEAKING FOR ALL OF
THE THOUSANDS OF WORKERS IN
OUR STATE THAT HAVE TO WORK
TWO THREE JOBS IN ORDER TO
HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
BECAUSE THEIR EMPLOYERS TO
LIMIT THEIR HOURS SO THEY
DON'T HAVE TO PROVIDE HEALTH
CARE THANK YOU THANK YOU AT
THE NEXT NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE LINE SEVEN
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
ALL RIGHT I'M WITH ANY RIGHT
THINKING ABOUT ALONG WITH OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS I AB PARKING
OKAY YES AB PARKING BOXX I
CAN'T WELL NOBODY ELSE WELL
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
I KNOW FOR THE CALLERS IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME OKAY THIS POINT WE
WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC COMMENT
I KNOW THIS IS UNUSUAL BUT I'M
GONNA BE THE FIRST PERSON ASK
QUESTIONS OR MAKE COMMENTS THAT
-- THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
KALRA THREE PERCENT IN THE
BILL THANK YOU MISTER SANTIAGO
I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
AND I HAVE SOME COMMENTS
SO -- THE FIRST QUESTION IS
CAN YOU GIVE -- A.
N.
A ROUGH IDEA OF SOME SORT OF
AN ESTIMATE OF HOW LONG YOU
THINK THIS POLICY WOULD TAKE
TO IMPLEMENT THE REASON I
ASK THAT IS THAT I CONSTANTLY
HEAR SINGLE PAYER NOW MMHM
AND AND -- WE JUST HAD THIS
NOW I I JUST WANNA HEAR YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON THAT BECAUSE
I THINK YOU KNOW THAT EVEN
THE SIMPLEST OF POLICIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA CAN
SOMETIMES TAKE YEARS TO GET THE
PART GET GET THE REGULATIONS
WRITTEN THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
THE NOVEL OF ALSO TRYING TO
BE VERY CLEAR -- OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL MONTHS -- WHEN I'VE
SPOKEN PUBLICLY AND SPOKEN TO
COLLEAGUES ABOUT THE PROCESS
-- THE THE FEDERAL WAIVER
PROCESS ITSELF ALLOWS A FIVE
YEAR RUNWAY A KIND OF FOR THE
TECH TO GET A PROGRAM SET UP
AND SO AT THE END OF THE DAY
THIS IS A POLICY BILL AS I
INDICATED THE GETTING IS YOUR
STOP AND ALSO PROBABLY MENTION
MR CHER -- THERE'S ALSO A
SEPARATE FUNDING MECHANISM
BILL A LOT OF DIFFERENT STEPS
WOULD HAVE TO OCCUR IN ORDER
FOR -- TO GET TO THE POINT OF
OF OF OF A FULL SINGLE PAYER
PROGRAM SO THIS IS A FIRST
STEP -- AND IF ALL THINGS GO
WELL AND IS ABLE TO GET TO
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK AND SIGNED
BY THE GOVERNOR AND ALLOWING
THEM THE ADMINISTRATION TO
APPLY FOR FEDERAL WAIVERS I
DO WITH THEN SIMULTANEOUSLY
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
A CA THAT'S A SUITABLE TO OUR
COLLEAGUES AND SUITABLE TO
STAKEHOLDERS THEN GO TO THE
VOTERS AND AND SO -- WHICH
WOULD LIKELY BE A TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR AS OF I'M KIND OF LAYING
IT OUT THERE IN A REASONABLE
TIME LINE THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
BE A RELATIVELY QUICK TIMELINE
AND SO I THINK WITHIN THE FIVE
YEAR PLAN APPEARED THAT THE
WAIVER PROCESS ALLOWS FOR -- IS
PROBABLY THE THE AMOUNT OF TIME
IT WOULD TAKE TO GET A PROGRAM
-- IN THE BILL EVEN INITIALLY
UP AND RUNNING AND THAT'S IF
EVERYTHING WENT WELL THANK YOU
SO DID I SO DO YOU ANTICIPATE
THE ACA NOT MOVING FORWARD THIS
YEAR DID I HEAR THAT CORRECTLY
-- I HOPE IT DOES BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY YOU KNOW WE HAVE
OUR CHAIRED REVENUE TAXATION
HERE WE HAVE A LOT OF OTHER
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE HAVE TO
BE A STAKEHOLDERS WITHOUT THE
ENGAGE WITH BUT ULTIMATELY
EVEN IF IT WERE TO GO FORWARD
THAT DOESN'T MEAN NESTLE GOES
ON ABOUT THIS YEAR HE'S HE'S
CAN BE SET FOR DIFFERENT --
DIFFERENT TIME PERIODS AND SO
ULTIMATELY THE WAY THAT THIS
HAS BEEN SET UP AS IN A MANNER
THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH WHAT
WE LEARNED FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN TERMS OF THE
TIMELINE OF WHAT NEEDS TO GO
FIRST WITHOUT A POLICY NOTHING
CAN GO FORWARD AND THAT'S WHY
EIGHTY FOURTEEN HUNDRED MOVING
FORWARD AT THIS MOMENT -- IS
THE MOST CRITICAL STEP FIRST
STEP TO ALLOW FOR THE ACA THAN
TO BE MORE PROBABLY DISCUSS
BECAUSE AGAIN AS I MENTIONED
MY INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS --
THE POLICY AND GOING THROUGH A
WAIVER PROCESS HELPS TO INFORM
THE FUNDING PIECE AS WELL SO --
I WANT TO GO BACK TO -- MISTER
BURSON MISTER BARCELONA'S
COMMENTS ABOUT AMERICA THE THE
REP THE ORGANIZATION REPRESENTS
A PEACHY -- AND IT HE HE TALKS
ABOUT -- TALKED ABOUT THE --
THE WAY THEY PROVIDE CARE OF
WHICH IS MORE GLOBAL IN NATURE
-- WE ALSO -- SEE THAT OUR
MEDICARE PROGRAM IS GONNA GOING
IN THAT DIRECTION YET WE WE
KIND OF HAVE YOU HAVE A FEE FOR
SERVICE COMPONENT HERE AND A
SALARY COMPONENT AND THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY CONSISTENT WITH THE
WAY HEALTH CARE IS IS INVOLVING
ON ON A LARGE SCALE THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN MILLION PEOPLE IN
MEDICARE WE'RE WE WE'VE MOVED
AWAY FROM FEE FOR SERVICE
SO HOW DO YOU ADDRESS MR
BARCELONA'S CONCERNS IT IS UP
AS LAID OUT IN THE LEGISLATION
ALLOWS FOR A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT TYPES INCLUDING
GLOBAL BUDGETING PARTICULARLY
FOR OF ENTITIES SEVEN HOSPITALS
WHAT HAVE YOU -- AND I'LL PASS
IT OVER TO COMMON COMES TO YOU
AS A PLAYER ROUTED TO ANSWERING
GREATER DETAIL HOW YOU CAN
STILL HAVE FEE FOR SERVICE AS
PART OF THE OVERALL MENU OF
OPTIONS OF PAYMENT PARTICULARLY
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
IN COMMUNITIES THAT MAY NOT
HAVE A HOSPITAL OR MAY NOT
HAVE ENTITIES WERE THE GLOBAL
BUDGETING MAKES AS MUCH SENSE
HELLO IS MISS
COMES DOWN THE LINE
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES OUR --
SO THE ASSUMPTION THAT --
THAT THE RISK BASED MODEL OF
MANAGED CARE -- THAT IT IS A
MODEL THAT WE SHOULD KEEP ON
PUSHING FORWARD AND EXPAND IN
CALIFORNIA IS IS ONE THAT WE
SHOULD REALLY QUESTION BECAUSE
THAT THE IDEAS MANAGED CARE
THAT YOU KNOW WE CAN DO COST
SAVINGS BY -- INTEGRATING THAT
FINANCIAL INTEREST OF A PLAN
AND WITH THE FINANCIAL INTEREST
OF A PROVIDER THAT CREATES A
FUNDAMENTALLY ETHICAL QUESTION
WE'RE ASKING PROVIDERS TO --
TO WAIT THE FINANCIAL LIABILITY
OF PROVIDING CARE -- WITH HOW
THEY ACTUALLY PROVIDE CARE SO
THIRD THROUGH THE FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTION THERE AND I THINK WE
CAN ASSUME THAT MANAGED CARE
IS NECESSARILY GOING TO GET
US TO TO UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO
TAKE CARE AND IMPORTANTLY --
YOU KNOW MANAGED CARES REALLY
TOUTED AS A SOME SORT OF COST
SAVINGS AND -- MODEL OR SOME
MODEL THAT WOULD IMPROVE CARE
BUT BOTH OF THOSE THINGS HAVE
BEEN -- HAD NOT BORNE OUT
IN PRACTICE -- AND I I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO --
EMPHASIZED THAT -- THAT THE
COST SAVINGS POTENTIAL FOR
A DIRECT PAYMENTS MODEL THAT
INCLUDES GLOBAL BUDGETING
INCLUDES THAT FEE FOR SERVICE
AT THAT INCLUDES A MIX OF THESE
TYPES OF DIRECT PAYMENT MODELS
-- AND YOU KNOW VERY WELL --
-- DOCTOR WOULD AS BOTH YOU
AND I SERVE ON THE HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL COMMISSION
AND WE DISCUSSED THIS AT LENGTH
-- THE OUR CONSULTANTS ON THE
COMMISSION HAVE FOUND THAT THE
-- THE DIRECT PAYMENTS MODEL
WOULD ACTUALLY SAVE MORE THAN
A MANAGED CARE MODEL IN TERMS
OF COST SAVINGS SO -- AT THAT
IS A REALLY KEEP OUR QUESTION
TO ALWAYS KEEP IN MIND ONE
PICK ONE FOLKS SAY THAT IT
WOULD SAVE CALIFORNIA MORE
MONEY TO EXPAND MANAGED CARE
ON THE SUBSTANTIVE MATTER OF
MANAGED CARE YOU KNOW BECAUSE
THEY THE MODEL IS BASED ON A
RISK BASED TYPE OF -- INCENTIVE
PAYMENT -- WE'RE REALLY RELYING
ON THAT THE INSURERS AND THE
PLANS -- TO TWO WOMEN AT THE
KNIGHT CARE IN ORDER -- --
IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE -- THEIR
PROFIT MARGINS AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO GO
AWAY FROM -- WITH OUR HOSPITAL
GLOBAL BUDGETING AND THE SALARY
PAYMENTS ALONG WITH IF YOU
FOR SERVICE -- PAYMENTS SO --
BUILDER LARGELY -- QUESTIONS
THAT THAT REALLY -- CHANGING
THE PAYMENT MODEL ON CHANGING
THE PAYMENT STRUCTURE IS HOW WE
-- ENSURE THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
GETTING -- PAYMENTS TOWARDS
CARE RATHER THAN -- BLOWING
TOWARDS THINGS OTHER THAN CARE
AND WE HAVE LOTS OF STUDIES
THIS STUDY -- FROM -- OUR
CONSULTANTS ON THE COMMISSION
-- RICK KRONIG EVEN SAID THAT
THESE EXTRA PAYMENT -- THESE
-- THE ACT ACCESS PAYMENTS
ABOVE -- WHAT IS ACTUALLY
PAID FOR CARE IN MANAGED CARE
MODELS -- PARTICULARLY AND
MEDICARE ADVANTAGE MODELS AS
AS AN EXAMPLE THEY ACTUALLY
GO TOWARDS -- HOSPITAL PROFIT
MARGINS AND NOT BACK TOWARDS
PATIENTS SO THERE ISN'T REALLY
PROOF THAT MANAGED CARE REALLY
EFFECTIVELY GET MORE CARE OR
THAT IT COMPENSATES COST FOR
THE FOR THE STATE OKAY --
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT
FOR THAT ANSWER -- HOW DO YOU
ENVISION MAKE WHO COULD YOU
ENVISION ADMINISTERING FOR
THE NUTS AND BOLTS OF OF THIS
-- GOING FORWARD ARE YOU KIND
ARE YOU OPEN TO AN ENTITY LIKE
COVERED CALIFORNIA OR OR DO YOU
ENVISION A A DEDICATED STATE
AGENCY TO TO TO ADMINISTER
THIS THIS PLAN YES -- UNDER
THE LEGISLATION IT WOULD SET
UP THE CAL CARE BOARD THAT
ARE APPOINTEES HOWEVER IT DOES
NOT LIMIT THEIR ABILITY TO
HAVE YOU KNOW OTHER KIND OF
AT THAT THE OTHER ENTITIES OR
OTHER BOARDS OR SUBCOMMITTEE'S
TOP OPERATED AND I THINK THAT
RIGHT NOW IT DOES ALLOW FOR YOU
THEY'RE ALREADY JUST LIKE AN
APARTMENT MANAGE HEALTHCARE OR
WHAT HAVE YOU THERE'S NO REASON
WHY THE EXISTING ENTITIES
THAT CURRENTLY EXIST CAN ALSO
BE PART OF THE MANAGEMENT
OF THE SYSTEM AND THAT'S
SOMETHING WHERE YOU KNOW THE
THE CAL CARE BOARD CAN HELP
TO DEVISE THE SET UP THAT
ALLOWS FOR THAT AND I WOULD
ASK MISS KANSI TO MOVE INTO
ALLOWED RIGHT ON THAT AS WELL
SURE -- I THINK WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW WHO
WOULD BE ABLE TO MANAGE THE
PROGRAM YOU KNOW WE'RE REALLY
GIVING FLEXIBILITY AND IN
THE THE BILL -- FOR THE POOR
PROTECT YOU KNOW INCORPORATE
IF NECESSARY -- EXISTING
GOVERNMENT STRUCTURES AND --
OUR OUR OUR OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES
OFFICES THAT ALREADY EXIST --
FOR EXAMPLE I THINK A REALLY
GOOD EXAMPLE IS THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTH CARE -- AS
I MENTIONED IN MY TESTIMONY
-- FOR -- INDEPENDENT MEDICAL
REVIEWS -- THAT THE BOARD WOULD
CONSULT WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTH CARE SO YOU
KNOW IT IS NOT PART WE COULD
TRY TO BRING IN THE THE SYSTEMS
THAT EXIST ALREADY -- AND AND
NOT NECESSARILY RECREATE THE
REGULATORY WILL -- AND YOU KNOW
FOR THE MHC -- THAT WHAT WOULD
BE HAPPENING THERE IS THAT
YOU KNOW INSTEAD OF MANAGING
A HUNDRED PLUS PLANS -- THE
PEOPLE MANAGING ONE PLANNED SO
YOU KNOW THAT THEIR STRUCTURES
THERE -- YOU KNOW WERE ALSO AT
AND MANY PART TIME IN THE BILL
WE REFER TO EXISTING STATUTE
AGAIN LIKE MEDICAID THE MEDIC
HOW -- CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
-- AND YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO BUILD OFF OF WHAT WE
HAVE AND AND OF COURSE THERE'S
THERE'S YOU KNOW IF WE HAVE
SOMETHING THAT IS WORKING THAT
WE WANT TO BRING IT INTO THE
ACCOUNT HERE PROGRAM OKAY THANK
YOU AND -- YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
OUR ANALYSIS LAYS OUT A LOT
A LOT OF QUESTIONS AND AND
-- AND WHEN I GET TO THAT IN
MY COMMENTS BUT I WANT FOR
THE QUESTION THAT I HAVE SOME
COMMENTS AND SO I THINK THE
COMMITTEE FURTHER INDULGENCE
THIS IS A -- OBVIOUSLY A LONG
HEARING BUT THIS IS I THINK A
VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC AND THAT
IS A SIMPLE QUESTION ABOUT
PORTABILITY WHAT HAPPENS IF
YOU'RE CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA
AND HAVE CAL CARE AND GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE AND THE REASON
I ASK THIS QUESTION IS THAT IF
YOU'RE A CITIZEN OF CANADA AND
COME HERE YOUR COVERAGE IS VERY
LIMITED FOR EXAMPLE -- IF YOU
GET FIFTY DOLLARS FOR EMERGENCY
ROOM VISITS TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
FOR A HOUSE OF THE DAY FOR A
HOSPITAL STAY SIMILAR IN IN
IN THAT THE NATIONAL HEALTH
SERVICE AND IN THE U.
K.
SO HOW DO YOU ENVISION WHAT
DO YOU ENVISION FOR PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN CALIFORNIA WHO TRAVEL
TO ANOTHER STATE ON BUSINESS
OR VACATION OR WHATEVER ALSO
THAT THE SOUL OF HEALTHCARE
CONTEMPLATES THAT IN ORDER
TO QUALIFY YOU DO HAVE TO BE
A RESIDENT OF OF CALIFORNIA
HOWEVER ALLOWS UP TO NINETY
DAYS -- MOVE FOR TRAVEL
SOMEWHERE IF YOU GO TO BUSINESS
WHAT HAVE YOU THAT YOU WOULD
STILL BE -- YOU STILL QUALIFY
FOR A PLAN CARE UNDER CAL CARE
IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE THAT
THE PAYMENTS ARE MADE FROM
THE CAUCUS SYSTEM TO COVER ANY
UNEXPECTED MEDICAL EVENT THAT
WOULD OCCUR OKAY WELL I'M GONNA
I'M GONNA GO INTO MY COMMENTS
NO NINE I SUSPECT MY COMMITTEE
MY COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL HAVE
QUESTIONS AS WELL SO -- YOU
KNOW I BEEN INVOLVED IN HEALTH
CARE YOU KNOW MY PROFESSIONAL
LIFE -- I CHOSE TO PRACTICE
DENTISTRY IN A SMALL TOWN IN
A RURAL COMMUNITY BECAUSE OF
THE REALLY HIGH NEED THEIR
-- OVER THE YEARS -- I WAS A
MEDICAL PROVIDER -- AS WELL
I WISH I COULD HAVE TAKEN
MORE CARE MORE I GAVE AWAY
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO CARRY
YEAR BECAUSE IT WAS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO I TOOK AN OATH
WHEN I I GOT MY LICENSE AND
GRADUATE FROM DENTAL SCHOOL
THE TO PUT THE PATIENT FIRST
AND I'VE ALWAYS DONE THAT AND
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE IS TO PUT
PATIENTS FIRST CONSUMERS FIRST
I FEEL LIKE THE ENTIRE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM IS
KIND OF FORGOTTEN THAT
OATH AND LOST ITS WAY
WE LIVE IN A WORLD WHERE
PROFITS SHORT TERM LONG
TERM WHATEVER SEEM TO BE THE
DRIVING MOTIVATION FOR AN
ENTIRE SYSTEM CALIFORNIANS
NEED QUALITY AFFORDABLE HEALTH
CARE THERE BEYOND IMPATIENT
THEY'RE ANGRY THEY'RE SCARED
AND THEY'RE DESPERATE I THINK
YOU HEARD SOME OF THAT THIS
EVENING I THINK THEIR ANGER
IS JUSTIFIED WE NEED TO HEAR
THEM AND WE NEED TO RESPOND
YOU HEARD FOR THOSE OF YOU WERE
LISTENING -- EARLIER THANK AT
THE PIPE I ACTUALLY TEXTED MR
DAILY TO MAKE HIM UNDERSTAND
THAT I WASN'T LASHING OUT
AT HIM IN HIS BILL AB NINE
THIRTY THREE BUT I'M LASHING
OUT AT THE SYSTEM THE SYSTEM
HAS A PERVERSE INCENTIVE ON
MEDICATIONS IT'S CRAZY THAT
A DRUG MANUFACTURER PRODUCES
A DRUG AND THEN A MIDDLEMAN
DECIDES IF IT CAN GO ON YOUR
FORMULARY SO THAT YOU AS A
CONSUMER CAN GET IT AND WE
KNOW FROM OUR RESEARCH THAT
THOSE MIDDLEMAN THE PHARMACY
BENEFIT MANAGERS TAKE THE
HIGHEST PRICED DRUGS BECAUSE
THEY GET THE BIGGEST REBATES
FOR THAT NOT THE LOWEST LOWER
PRICED DRUGS IT MAY BE MORE
EFFECTIVE THEY TAKE THE HIGH
ONES BECAUSE THAT'S HOW THEY
MAKE THEIR MONEY IT IS NO
ACCIDENT THAT THE THREE LARGEST
PBMS IN THE UNITED STATES WITH
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF BUSINESS OUR
FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED COMPANIES
ANYWAY ORIGINALLY THEY WERE
DESIGNED IN A WAY TO ACTUALLY
BRING A VALUE BUT SOMEWHERE
ALONG THE WAY THEY WENT OFF IN
A DIRECTION THAT ISN'T HELPFUL
FOR CONSUMERS CAN I HAVE A
I'M A FAMILY MEMBER WHO -- YOU
KNOW CALLED ME AND SAID HEY
I'M GONNA HAVE TO HAVE TO HAVE
SOME SURGERY AND -- -- HOW DO
I FIND OUT HOW MUCH IT'S GONNA
COST AND I SAID WELL YOU CAN
TALK YOU CAN ASK YOUR DOCTOR
AND I SAID -- AND I SAID AND
THEN YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
HOUSE THE HEALTH FACILITY WAIT
THE OUTPATIENT SURGERY CENTER
WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO GET
THAT AND BY THE WAY YOU MIGHT
NOT MEET THE ANESTHESIOLOGIST
UNTIL THE DAY OF THE SURGERY
SO YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO FIGURE THAT ONE OUT
WE PUT OUR FAITH IN THE
SYSTEM AND WE DON'T HAVE A
CLUE WHAT IS GOING TO COST TO
ME GO WHAT ELSE IN OUR WORLD
DO WE ACTUALLY DO -- WHERE
THAT WILL BE DUE THAT WE PUT
TREMENDOUS FAITH IN THE SYSTEM
AND OUR WONDERFUL PROVIDERS
HOSPITALS PROVIDE INCREDIBLE
SERVICES DRUG COMPANIES PROVIDE
INCREDIBLE LIFESAVING DRUGS
DOCTORS DO WONDERFUL THINGS TO
HELP SAVE LIVES YEAH WE CAN'T
TELL PEOPLE WHAT IT'S GOING
TO COST YOU KNOW THERE WAS
A BILL PASSED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT LAST YEAR THAT
SAID THAT HOSPITALS NEED TO
DISPLAY THEIR PRIDE THERE THEIR
PRICES IF THE TRANSPARENCY
BILLS A YEAR LATER HALF OF THE
HOSPITALS IT EITHER IGNORED
THAT WERE BURIED SO DEEP THAT
THE AVERAGE CONSUMER CAN'T
FIND IT WE'RE JUST DECIDED
THAT THE FINES ARE WORTH THE
COST OF DOING BUSINESS THESE
ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
DRIVE ME ABSOLUTELY CRAZY
IT FEELS MORE AND MORE THAT WE
ARE SECOND WE ARE SACRIFICING
TO HELP THE PATIENTS AND THEIR
PRIORITIES FOR PRESERVING THE
STATUS QUO IN OUR INSURANCE
COMPANIES TELL PEOPLE WHAT
THEY CAN AND CANNOT HALF
THE PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES
CONTINUE TO INCREASE PRICES
AND MY FRUSTRATION WITH THE
BILL THAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT EARLIER IS THERE IS
NO INCENTIVE FOR THE DRUG
COMPANIES TO ACTUALLY LOWER
PRICES AND I FEAR THAT THE
POLICY MIX WOULD DRIVE PEOPLE
MORE TOWARDS HIGH PRICE DRUGS
RATHER THAN GENERICS THAT
MIGHT BE AVAILABLE BECAUSE
THEY MIGHT GET A REBATE
THAT'S A PERVERSE INCENTIVE
POTENTIALLY AND WE'LL SEE HOW
THAT COULD HAVE THAT PLAYS OUT
OBVIOUSLY I JUST SAT HOSPITALS
IGNORE TRANSPARENCY LAWS --
PHYSICIANS DON'T WANT THEIR
DECISIONS QUESTION BY ANYONE
AND THAT'S CERTAIN THAT'S A
REALITY I SPENT SEVEN YEARS
IN THE LEGISLATURE TRYING TO
MAKE IT WORK FOR PATIENTS SPENT
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS BEFORE THAT
DELIVERING DIRECT PATIENT CARE
THE BATTLES IN THIS BUILDING
HAVE BEEN BRUTAL AND ALTHOUGH
WE'VE HAD SIGNIFICANT SUCCESSES
EACH ONE OF THE PLAYERS
IN A MAJOR PIECE ELECTION
LEGISLATION THAT I TAKE THAT
I'VE ACCOMPLISHED HAVE BEEN
REWARDED WITH A LAWSUIT TO
DELAY THE IMPLEMENTATION ONE
REGULAR OR FORTY OR CONTINUING
REGULATORY CHALLENGES TO DELAY
THE IMPLEMENTATION SO THEY CAN
KEEP CONTINUE THESE PRACTICES
AND PROTECT THEIR PROFITS
FIXING INDIVIDUAL SEGMENTS
OF THE SYSTEM AND HOPING IT
IMPROVES THE WHOLE NO LONGER
SEEMS TO BE AN EFFECTIVE
APPROACH THAT'S WHY AFTER
NEARLY EIGHT YEARS OF TRYING TO
MAKE HEALTH CARE WORK FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS SOMETHING HAS TO
GIVE AND JUST MAYBE A SINGLE
HEALTH SINGLE PAYER HEALTH
CAN BE THE CATALYST FOR THAT
CHANGE I SPOKEN WITH ENOUGH
OF MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES
TO KNOW THAT THEY TO BELIEVE
THE SYSTEM IS BROKEN AND I AM
OPEN TO WHAT THEY MIGHT HAVE
A SOLUTION FOR ANYBODY WHO
OPPOSES WHAT'S HAPPENING OFFERS
A SOLUTION NO IS NOT THE ANSWER
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY
TIMES IN MY CAREER FROM THIS
DíAS AND FROM MY OFFICE I'VE
ACTUALLY SAID THAT I DO HAVE
CONCERNS YEP I'VE SHARED WITH
YOU IS THE AS AN AUTHOR YOU
SEE THE CONCERNS IN THE IN THE
ANALYSIS AND MANY AND AND I'M
SURE THE SIMILAR CONCERNS WITH
YOUR MANAGER CO AUTHORS I HOPE
YOU GIVE SERIOUS CONSIDERATION
TO TO ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES
THEY ARE REAL ISSUES AND THEY
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED IF WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE THIS POLICY
FORWARD -- TOO I THINK THIS
WILL SOLVE ALL OF OUR PROBLEMS
NOW THAT'S WHY I CONTINUE TO
WORK HARD THIS YEAR TO PASS AB
ELEVEN THIRTY WHICH WILL CREATE
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY WE'RE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
ON THIS TO ADDRESS HEALTH CARE
COST SAVINGS BY HAVING EVERY
SEGMENT OF THE HEALTH CARE
IMPROVE IT IS SYSTEM PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON COSTS AND USE
THAT INFORMATION TO ESTABLISH
ENFORCEABLE COST TARGETS ANY
MAJOR HEALTH CARE REFORM AND
WE LEARNED THIS FROM FORMER
GOVERNOR PETER SHUMLIN --
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND WE
NEED HARD POWER SPENDING OUR
MONEY WE NEED TO FIND A WAY
TO BEND THE COST CURVE FROM
INCREASING -- THAT'S THE KIND
OF INFORMATION THAT WILL HELP
US IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR
PATIENTS AND WE DESPERATELY
NEED A SYSTEM WHERE YOU TRAVEL
TO ANOTHER PART OF THE STATE
AND YOUR WAY FOR YOUR DOCTOR
THAT SOMEBODY ON THE OTHER
RENT COULD SAY OH THIS IS
WHAT YOU NEED AND AND WITHOUT
HAVING TO RUN COUNTLESS TESTS
THAT THAT THAT PLACE NO VALUE
THERE THAT'S BASIC THAT'S
BASIC BASIC INFORMATION IN
YET HEALTHCARE ENTITIES FIGHT
THAT THEY DON'T WANT TO GIVE
UP THE INFORMATION THEY DON'T
WANT TO COOPERATE BECAUSE AS
PART OF THEIR BUSINESS MODEL
TO PROTECT WHAT THEY CONSIDER
PROPRIETARY THAT IS NOT THE
KIND OF THING THAT IS IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF PATIENTS AND
THAT'S THE KIND OF THING THAT
THAT ABSOLUTELY NEEDS TO AND
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE SO YOU HAVE
OUR ANALYSIS WHAT WE POINT OUT
A REAL CHALLENGES AND I DON'T
HAVE THE SOLUTIONS FOR THOSE
AT THIS POINT BUT IF WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD THOSE
SOLUTIONS NEED TO BE CONSIDERED
AT SOLUTIONS TO THOSE ISSUES
NEED TO BE CONSIDERED AND --
-- I WANT AT THIS POINT I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY
OBVIOUSLY -- AND -- LIKE TO
MOVE MOVE UP AND GET MY UP MY
UP FELLOW COMMITTEE MEMBERS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK QUESTIONS
AND MAKE A STATEMENT MISCREANT
I I DON'T I I WON'T WITH THE
BILL SOMEONE ELSE WITH THE
BILL THAT'S JUST THE PROCESS
HERE BY SOMEBODY WANTS TO
MOVE THE BILL PLEASE GO AHEAD
ISRAEL WAS A BILL MISTER
NAZARIAN SECONDS A BILL MISTER
MISTER OF COMMENT IN THE
QUESTION AND MISTER NAZARIAN
I ACTUALLY DON'T KNOW IF MISTER
EIGHTY PARKING IS STILL ON THE
LINE I HAD A QUESTION FOR HIM
SPECIFICALLY THE MESSAGE TO
THE CHAIR IS MISTER BARTON IS
ALREADY BACK ON THE LINE STILL
HI THIS IS CARMEN AND I AM
HERE WITH BODY AND IT'LL TEST
IF YOU COULD COME BACK HIM
IN A COUPLE MINUTES WITH YOUR
QUESTION HE IS STILL ON THE
LINE OKAY SO YOU JUST NEED
A COUPLE MINUTES OKAY THANK
YOU CENTER COMPLETED OKAY
WE'LL WE'LL COME BACK TO MISS
CARILLO THAT MISTER NAZARIAN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS -- FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU -- TO THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
THANK YOU FOR ASKING ME TO
JOIN YOU IN YOUR EFFORTS AS
WELL I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THIS AND AND AND
IN PREVIOUS ITERATIONS WE WERE
COLLABORATING AT DIFFERENT BILL
AS WELL -- AND AGAIN MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR DUE
DILIGENCE AND WANTING TO SEE
THIS MOVE FORWARD AND FOR THE
TIME YOU'VE SPENT AN AND IN
WORKING ON THIS I'VE ALONG WITH
MAYBE ABOUT TWO OR THREE OTHER
COLLEAGUES HERE HAVE BEEN ON
HEALTH COMMITTEE FOR NINE YEARS
AND ONE OF THE REASONS WHY WHEN
ELECTED I WANTED TO SERVE ON
THIS COMMITTEE WAS EXACTLY TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THAT GAP BETWEEN
QUALITY CARE AFFORDABILITY
AND ACCESS THE THE THREE MAIN
IMPORTANT PILLARS OF MAKING
HEALTHCARE WORK IN OUR STATE
IN OUR COUNTRY BUT AT LEAST IN
OUR STATE AND AND SO IF I VERY
MUCH THANK YOU FOR THE TIME --
YOU'VE PUT INTO THIS BECAUSE
I'VE BEEN IN MANY COUNTLESS
HOURS OF HERE EDUCATIONAL
HEARINGS INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS
WHERE WE'VE LEARNED ABOUT
SOMETIMES THE DOWNSIDE OF OUR
HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY AS WELL
IN THE STATE AND THE HIGH
PERCENTAGE ALSO OF SOMETIMES
NOT WILL SPEND DOLLARS -- AND
SO -- YOU'VE HAD THE BENEFIT
OF OF OF KNOWING THAT -- AND
THEN FORCED TO LEARN BETTER
FROM THESE HEARINGS SO WITHOUT
BELIEVE BRING THE POINT -- IBM
THE THE ONLY OTHER THING BY
THE WAY THAT ACTUALLY I WANTED
TO ADD TO THE COMMENTS THAT
YOU WERE MAKING MISTER CHAIR
OF THOSE THREE PBMS LET'S NOT
FORGET THAT ONE OF THEM IS
OWNED BY AN INSURANCE COMPANY
AS WELL SO IT'S A REMARKABLE
THAT THE VERY INDUSTRY THAT IS
COVERING THE HEALTHCARE COSTS
IS ALSO IN THE BUSINESS OF
OWNING A NEGOTIATING ARM THAT
THEN -- -- THAT THAT THAT TAKES
THOSE VERY BENEFITS AWAY FROM
THE CONSUMERS THAT ALTERNATELY
SHOULD BE BENEFITING FROM
SO I WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND THE CONCEPT I
KNOW THAT CHANGE IS GOING TO
BE DIFFICULT -- AND AND ALSO
IMPLEMENTING SOMETHING LIKE
THIS IS GONNA TAKE SOME TIME
SO I'M FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS -- THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD -- AND I DO
WANT TO SAY THAT -- ONE OF THE
INSPIRATIONS FOR HEALTH CARE
FOR ME WAS A LOCAL CONSTITUENT
BY THE NAME OF JOHN GLASS WHO
PASSED AWAY THE YEAR THAT I
RAN FOR OFFICE -- AND THAT IT
HAD BEEN HIS LIFE'S MISSION
TO -- MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
WAS -- DID GET HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE AND SO TO HIS -- --
I JUST WANTED TO SHOUT AT HIM
AND HIS WONDERFUL WIFE JUDITH
CLASS OF WHO IS STILL WITH US
AND -- -- I WANTED TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL IN HIS MEMORY AND HIS
-- FIVE DECADES OF WORK TOWARDS
THIS ISSUE SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD THANK YOU
MR FOR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND -- IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY
SO I'M GONNA KEEP MY COMMENTS
-- FAIRLY SHORT TERM BECAUSE
I KNOW THERE'S MORE QUESTIONS
COMING BUT I DO WANT TO DRESS
THE THE LABOR ASPECT OF THIS
-- UNITED SERVED ON LABOR
FOR A LONG TIME TOGETHER AND
I KNOW YOUR COMMITMENT TO
WORKERS AND WORKERS RIGHTS AND
HAS NEVER BEEN DEBATED BUT I
AM VERY CONCERNED HOW DO YOU
RECTIFY TAKING AWAY ONE OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES THAT
LABOUR FUSES IN COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING NEGOTIATING THEIR
HEALTHCARE THROUGH THAT SYSTEM
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN WE'RE
IN THE STRIP THAT FROM THEM
AND WE'RE GONNA PUT HIM ON A
STATE RUN PROGRAM AND THERE'S
COUNTLESS STORIES I MEAN
I'VE GOT FAMILY MEMBERS THAT
HAVE BEEN UNION DISH TENDERS
-- THEIR ENTIRE LIVES THEY
STAYED IN THAT JOB BECAUSE
THEIR WIVES HAD M.
S.
-- EXPENSIVE TO TREAT HE
RETIRED ABOUT A DECADE AGO SO
WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO A FAMILY
MEMBER AND SAY CONGRATULATIONS
-- YOUR LESSEN HEALTH ANYMORE
YOU'RE GONNA BE ON A REGULAR
PLAN THERE'S NOTHING THERE'S
NO INCENTIVE THERE'S NO
PROTECTIONS FOR THAT WHAT ABOUT
THE CALPERS MEMBERS IT MOVED
OUT OF STATE WHAT ARE THEY
GONNA DO PEOPLE THIS SPEND
THEIR ENTIRE LIVES IN INTO THE
SYSTEM AND WE'RE GOING TO RIP
THE CARPET OUT FROM UNDERNEATH
THEM FOR A PROGRAM THERE IS
EVEN FUND WE DON'T EVEN HAVE
A CLUE WHAT THIS THING'S GONNA
COST BECAUSE WE HAVE AN ALLOW
THE BUILDING TO DO A COST
ANALYSIS ON THE SOME I AM
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
THERE IS SO MANY UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS AND THERE IS A LOT
OF INCREDIBLY SMART PEOPLE THAT
I THINK CAN FIGURE IT OUT BUT
IF WE CARE ABOUT WORKERS LIKE
I KNOW THAT WE DO HOW ON EARTH
DO WE GO BACK TO THEM AND SAY
YOU KNOW WHAT NOW WE'RE GONNA
CUT TO PENSIONS NO THAT'S LIKE
A IT'S A IT'S A PRINCIPLE WE
WOULD NEVER GO DOWN BUT WE'RE
DOING IT FOR THE HEALTH CARE
AND FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT PART OF THEIR
RETIREMENT NOT ONLY THESE
PEOPLE ON A FIXED INCOME RIGHT
NOW WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO
DO SO I GUESS DO THEY HAVE AN
ABILITY TO KEEP THE CARE THAT
THEY WALK THAT THEY HAVE NOW
SO HOW SICK OF THESE I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR RECOGNITION
OF OF MY COMMITMENT TO WORKERS
OBVIOUSLY IS CHAIR LABOR WE
BOTH -- BUT A LOT OF WORK IN
THAT REGARD -- CALVET LABOR
FEDERATION DOESN'T DOORS AND
SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED
PART OF THAT IS A COMMITMENT
TO WORK WITH LABOR -- GOING
FOR NOT GOING FOR THE OPTION
IT WITH MANY TIMES OF OF OVER
THE MONTHS BUT THERE'S A COUPLE
THINGS ON A READ UP ON THE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO NEGOTIATE
ABSOLUTELY BUT THIS REMEMBER
BUT WITH LEGISLATIVE DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE NEGOTIATED IT'LL
MEAN BY THAT IS IF YOU HAVE
GUARANTEED QUALITY CARE WHAT I
WAS ON THE CITY COUNCIL SPENT
OVER HALF OUR TIME THE GOSHEN
COPAYS PREMIUMS AND TRYING TO
KEEP THE COSTS DOWN IF THAT IS
OFF THE TABLE BECAUSE YOU HAVE
HIGH QUALITY CARE THE NOW YOU
CAN GO SHAVE OTHER THINGS SO
THAT'S THAT THAT HAS TO DO WITH
IN TERMS OF NEGOTIATING CURRENT
CONTRACT I'M NOT TALK ABOUT
FUTURE NEGOTIATIONS LITTLE I
UNDERSTAND ABOUT THINGS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN NEGOTIATED BY THE
THERE'S ANOTHER POINT YOU KNOW
I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU MENTION
NEGOTIATIONS I WANT TO MENTION
THAT SECONDLY SAYING -- PEOPLE
STAY IN THE JOB BECAUSE THEY
HAVE GOOD HEALTH CARE THAT'S
A PROBLEM THAT SHOULD BE THE
IDEAL THAT SOMEONE STAYS IN
THEIR JOB BECAUSE OF THE LEAVE
IT THEY LOSE THEIR HEALTHCARE
THAT'S A MAJOR PROBLEM WITH
EMPLOYER BASED HEALTH CARE
IN OUR COUNTRY UNION OR NOT
IS THAT IF YOU LEAVE YOUR
JOB YEAH YOU YOU STAY WITH
YOUR JOB BECAUSE YOU ALONG
WITH YOUR HEALTH CARE IS A
MAJOR FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM BUT
OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM NOW
WHEN IT COMES TO THOSE THAT
ALREADY HAVE HEALTH CARE AND
HAVE HEALTHCARE GUARANTEED
ABSOLUTELY THOSE ARE THINGS
WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE THE SAME ACCESS SAME
QUALITY OF CARE AND THE REALITY
IS UNDER CAL CARE WHAT IS
BEING WHAT IS BEING PUT FORTH
AND CAL CARE AND THE LEVEL AND
THE OF THE RANGE OF SERVICES
INCLUDING LONG TERM CARE OR ARE
OUR TOP ITS COMPREHENSIVE CARE
TO EVERYONE NOT JUST TO SOMEONE
THAT MAY HAVE A GOOD PLAN OR
A BAD PLAN OR TO A LABOR CAMP
PLAN BUT ONE THING WE WILL
WORK AND AND IN TERMS OF OUT
OF STATE ALL THAT THOSE ARE ON
CALPERS THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
WE WILL ALSO TALK WITH LABOR
ABOUT TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
NOT LEAVING ANYONE OUT THAT
IS EARNED THAT IS EARNED THOSE
BENEFITS BUT ALL THE OTHER
PEOPLE THAT WE ARE WORKING ON
CONTINUE TO DO SO -- BURKE OF
LABOR ON THE ALREADY HAS SOME
CONVERSATIONS ON IT ALREADY
OVER THE PAST FEW MONTHS ARE
THERE ON HEALTH TRUST FUNDS
WHICH IS ANOTHER ISSUE IF THOSE
DO GET IS ALL YOU WANT TO MAKE
SURE THEY GET DISSOLVED AND
FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE WORKERS
I'M NOT THE EMPLOYERS ARE AS
THOSE IN A WIDE RANGE OF ISSUES
THAT UP THAT APPLIES TO LABOR
OTHER I'M VERY WELL AWARE OF
THAT WE'VE ALREADY STARTED
CONVERSATIONS ON ARE GOING TO
GET YOU TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
ON TO MAKE SURE WHETHER IT'S
A CURRENT UNION EMPLOYEE OR
RETIREE THAT THEY'RE NOT LEFT
HOLDING THE BAG THEY DON'T
LOSE OUT ON ANYTHING THEY
HAVE A GREAT QUALITY CARE AND
ULTIMATELY IF FUNDS ARE IN
SOME WAY DISSOLVED IS RESOLVED
IN A WAY THAT'S BENEFICIAL
TO THE WORKER SO IS THERE A
PROVISION IN FOURTEEN HUNDRED
RIGHT NOW THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
KEEP THE CARE THAT THEY HAVE
NOW THE IMPORTANT IN EIGHTY
FOUR TWO HUNDRED EVERYONE WILL
BE ON THE COUNTER OKAY SO IT
IS GOING TO CHANGE THAT WELL
YOU CAN'T WE DON'T KNOW I MEAN
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE GOING
TO PASS A POTENTIALLY PASS A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY AND THROW
A COMPLETE MONKEY WRENCH AND
A TON OF UNCERTAINTY INTO THAT
ALREADY THE SYSTEM IS ALREADY
GOT A TON OF UNCERTAINTY IN IT
RIGHT NOW SO NOW WE'RE GONNA
THROW THIS ON TOP OF IT WITH
NO FUNDING SOURCE OUR UNION
FRIENDS ARE GONNA BE WONDERING
WHAT ON EARTH THEY'RE GOING TO
DO IN THE FUTURE WE'RE ADDING
INSULT TO INJURY AND IF THERE
IS SOMETHING THAT WE COULD
DO LIKE WHY ISN'T THE FUNDING
SOURCE IN HERE LET'S HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION IF WE'RE GOING
TO DO THIS LET'S DO IT BUT
OTHERWISE WE'RE JUST GONNA
PASS OUT PUT EVERYBODY IN A BAD
SPOT FOR WHAT FOR WHAT FOR A
PRESS RELEASE I'M SORRY BUT IT
JUST SEEMS LIKE A AND A LITTLE
BIT -- THERE'S A REASON IT
WAS TABLE FOR NUMBER OF YEARS
THE REASON IT WASN'T AND RULES
FOR A LONG TIME AND HERE WE
ARE AGAIN AND NOW WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
WE CAN HAVE THIS CONVERSATION
A LOT BECAUSE I DO ABSOLUTELY
BELIEVE THE MEN AND WOMEN THAT
SERVE OUR STATE -- AND ALSO
JUST BE FOR THE PUBLIC SAFETY
SIDE OF THINGS LIKE THERE IS NO
CHANCE THAT WE SHOULD FEEL GOOD
ABOUT PASSAGE ANYTHING COMING
OUT OF THIS BUILDING THAT'S
GOING TO RIP THE CARPET OUT
FROM UNDERNEATH HER LEGS WHEN
THEY SPENT AN ENTIRE CAREER
PROTECTING EACH EVERYONE'S BUT
THAT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN THAT'S
ALSO NOT GONNA HAPPEN ONLY TO
THERE'S THERE'S TWO POINTS OF
THAT OLDER SON IS THIS ISN'T
GOING TO AFFECT AND TOLD THE
FUNDING IS RESULT IT IS A IT
IS THAT WAS INTENTIONALLY PUT
INTO THE BILL TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE NOT TAKING SOMETHING AWAY
WITHOUT ENSURING THAT WE HAVE
THE SAME QUALITY OF CARE BETTER
AVAILABLE -- AND SO THAT'S
WHAT YOU KNOW AND THAT INCLUDES
GO DISABILITY IT INCLUDES ALL
THE ISSUES THAT SO MANY OF
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY REPRESENT
BY THE WAY IT'S GREAT TO SEE
HOW PASSIONATE ABOUT WORKERS
ARE HOPING TO BE LIKE THAT
ON ALL OF BILLS THAT PROTECT
WORKERS -- -- BUT -- YOU KNOW
-- UNLIMITED ALAS ACTION IS
CONSTANT REGARDS TO BARGAINING
-- IT UNION BARGAINING IN TERMS
OF FOURTEEN HUNDRED AS WELL
IF YOU DON'T MIND RESEARCHER
M.
SO YOU DON'T TO ANSWER WHAT
THE TIMELY MEMBER KALRA SAID
YOU KNOW AND -- SOMEONE WHO
REPRESENTS NURSES REPRESENTS
UNION NURSES ACROSS THE STATE
-- GETTING HEALTH CARE ACROSS
THE BARGAINING TABLE WOULD BE
GAME CHANGING THE VAST MAJORITY
OF STRIKES ARE ABOUT HEALTHCARE
BENEFITS AS EMPLOYERS SHIFT
MORE MORE COSTS ONTO WORKERS
UNION WORKERS DURING CREEK
PREMIUMS AND COPAYS ALL THE
STRIKES WOULD END UNDER EIGHT
FOURTEEN HUNDRED WORKERS WOULD
HAVE MORE BARGAINING POWER IT
WOULD BE BETTER FOR WORKERS
BECAUSE WE COULD BARGAIN FOR
BETTER WORKING CONDITIONS
WHICH WOULD BE ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL FOR ALL OF THESE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS WERE IN
UNIONS WERE FIGHTING FOR CODE
PROTECTIONS THIS WOULD MEAN
YOU KNOW FOR MANY MANY PEOPLE
WEEK WE COULD GET BETTER
WORKING CONDITIONS BETTER --
-- OTHER TYPES OF BENEFITS
WE COULD END THESE TYPES
OF STRIKES THAT OUR OUR OUR
EMPLOYERS ARE PUTTING HONEST
AND TRYING TO -- LEAN DOWN THE
THE POWER OF WORKERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND IT WOULD BE A
BOON TO CALIFORNIA'S WORKERS
AND ANSWERED PLAYERS BECAUSE
IT WOULD SAVE ON PREMIUM
BOTH ON THE EMPLOYER SIDE AND
ON THE EMPLOYEE SIDE SO YOU
KNOW IT WOULD BE A WIN WIN
FOR BOTH WORKERS AND AND AND
EMPLOYERS BECAUSE WE WILL AT
THAT OFFER THE BARGAINING TABLE
BUT I JUST HAVE ONE MORE
FINAL COMMON WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT LIKE THE STATE DOESN'T
HAVE A REAL GREAT TRACK
RECORD RECENTLY PROVIDING
A BETTER SERVICE FOR WELL
ANYTHING RIGHT NOW SO WHAT
ARE HEALTHCARE IN THE STATE'S
HANDS MEASURES AGREED PLAN
I'M SORRY GO AHEAD GO AHEAD MR
CUTTING HIM THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SIT IN A TODAY I WANT TO
FOCUS ON TWO THINGS BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT MY CONSTITUENTS
AND OUR SENIORS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DESERVE
SOME ANSWERS TO SOME VERY
FUNDAMENTAL AND VERY IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS TO THEM ROUGHLY
THIRTY SEVEN PERCENT OF MY
CONSTITUENTS ARE ON MEDICARE
I DON'T KNOW THE STATE MY
NUMBER BUT IT'S PRETTY HIGH
AND THE PEOPLE THAT ARE ON IT
AND PEOPLE ARE AGING INTO IT
EVERY SINGLE DAY YOUR BILL AB
FOURTEEN HUNDRED WOULD SUBSUME
MEDICARE IT WOULD TAKE IT AWAY
WOULD PUT EVERYTHING AS YOU
STATED IN YOUR ANSWER THE LAST
QUESTION I WOULD PUT EVERYTHING
UNDER CALCULAR SO THAT RAISES
SOME FUNDAMENTAL AND IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS TO ME THE FIRST IS
MEDICARE IS A IS A COMPACT
IT'S AN INTERGENERATIONAL
CONTACT SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE EVERYBODY THAT WORKS
FROM YOUR FIRST JOB BACK AT
MCDONALD'S OR STARBUCKS OR
TARGET OR WHAT HAVE YOU ALL THE
WAY UP UNTIL YOUR RETIREMENT
YOU PAY A PAYROLL TAX AND
YOUR EMPLOYER PAYS A PAYROLL
TAX AND THAT MOSTLY FUNDS THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM IN ADDITION
TO SOME SUPPLEMENTAL GENERAL
TAX REVENUES FROM CONGRESS
SO YOU PAY INTO THAT AND IF
YOU'RE NEARING THE AGE WHERE
YOU QUALIFY TO MEDICARE OR
YOU'RE ALREADY IN THE SYSTEM
LIKE MY PARENTS FOR EXAMPLE
YOU'VE PAID YOUR ENTIRE WORKING
LIFE INTO THAT SYSTEM AND
NOW IF I UNDERSTAND YOUR BILL
CORRECTLY WHAT AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED WOULD DO IS SAY YOU
DON'T GET MEDICARE ANYMORE IF
YOU LIVE IN CALIFORNIA YOU'VE
GOT TO BE UNDER CAL CARE AN
UNTESTED UNTRIED EXPERIMENTAL
SYSTEM IN A STATE THAT BROUGHT
YOU TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS A
FRAUD WITH THE ET DE RECENTLY
AN INTERMINABLE PROBLEMS WITH
THE DMV GOING BACK THE ENTIRE
TIME I'VE BEEN IN OFFICE SO
THAT SEEMS LIKE A RAW DEAL FOR
OUR SENIORS MEDICARE THEY'VE
HAD FIFTY PLUS YEARS TO WORK
THE KINKS OUT FOR GETTING
MEDICARE BENEFITS PEOPLE
AREN'T GENERALLY SPEAKING
HAPPY WITH THEM THERE ARE SOME
ISSUES THERE TOO THEY PAY THE
TAXES TO FUND THAT IN THEIR
ENTIRE WORKING LIFE HOW ARE
THEY MADE WHOLE BECAUSE THEY
ALREADY PAID FOR IT THEY'RE
GETTING THE MEDICARE BENEFIT
NOW AND NOW THAT'S TAKEN
AWAY FROM THEM AND THEY'RE
GETTING HANDED IF THEY STAY IN
CALIFORNIA A LOT OF THEM LEAD
BY THE WAY BUT THEY'RE GETTING
HANDED A MASSIVE UNPRECEDENTED
TAX INCREASE IN A PLAYER TO
BE NAMED LATER IN WHICH IS
CURRENTLY IF I UNDERSTAND AC
ELEVEN SO BYE BYE BARGAINED
FOR BENEFITS LIKE THE UNIONS
IT'S A SIMILAR TYPE OF THING
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO MAKE THEM
WHOLE THEY PAID DECADES INTO
A SYSTEM THEY'RE GETTING CARE
FOR THAT SYSTEM THEY FOUR WENT
ADDITIONAL PAY BECAUSE THEY
BARGAINED IN MANY MANY CASES
TO HAVE BOTH PUBLIC SECTOR AND
PRIVATE SECTOR UNION WORKERS
THE BARGAIN TO TAKE LESS PAY
AND IT IT IN ORDER TO GET
BETTER HEALTH CARE AND NOW
THAT'S BEING STRIPPED AWAY I
DON'T SEE ANYTHING IN THIS BILL
THAT MAKES THEM HOLE FOR THAT
THAT SEEMS LIKE A VERY VERY RAW
DEAL BOTH FOR OUR SENIORS ON
MEDICARE AND THE OTHER QUESTION
I'D LIKE YOU TO ADDRESSES YOU
KNOW WHY DO WE THINK HEALTHCARE
IS GOING TO BE BETTER THAN
MEDICARE WHAT WE ALREADY HAVE
A FEDERAL SYSTEM THAT'S FUNDED
BY EVERYBODY IN THE COUNTRY
THREE OR TWENTY MILLION PEOPLE
FROM THE DAY THEY START WORKING
TILL THE DAY THEY RETIRE AND
AND THAT'S AN ASSURANCE TO THEM
THAT'S A COMMITMENT THAT'S AN
INTERGENERATIONAL COMMITMENT
AND WE'VE BEEN GOING STRONG
ON THAT FOR FIFTY FIVE PLUS
YEARS SO WHY ARE WE DOING THIS
OTHER THING IN CALIFORNIA AND
REMOVING THAT FROM PEOPLE THEY
DON'T GET A CHOICE THEY'RE
JUST PUSHED IN THE CAL CARE
THERE YOU GO HERE'S YOUR TAX
BILL GOOD LUCK I JUST DON'T GET
IT SO THE GOVERNMENT MAYBE IF
YOU ACTUALLY READ CULTURE YOU
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BETTER I
READ WHERE THE WILD AND THEN
THEN YOU WOULD UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS IS WHAT I'M MISSING
I'M I'M I'M TRYING TO YOU OF
MEDICARE AND MY FATHER'S ON
MEDICARE HE HAS TO PAY EXTRA
TO BE A MEDICARE ADVANTAGE AND
STILL -- PAYS OUT OF POCKET FOR
A NUMBER OF EXPENSES INCLUDING
PHARMACEUTICALS HE HAS TO
PAY ON HIS OWN FOR DENTAL AND
VISION -- HE DOESN'T HAVE LONG
TERM CARE THERE ANY ISSUES
THAT ARE GONNA HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO PAY FOR CALCULAR
COVERS ALL THOSE THINGS SO
WHAT YOU SAY KICK ME OUT OF
THIS KICK ME OUT OF THAT WHAT
CALGARIANS IS ADDITIVE IT'S NOT
SO SHOCKED OF WHAT SOMEONE GETS
A MEDICARE ACTUALLY GET A WHOLE
LOT MORE WITHOUT PAYING CO
PAYS OR PREMIUMS OR DEDUCTIBLES
OR PAYING FOR PHARMACEUTICALS
OR PAYING FOR LONG TERM CARE
AND SO WE CAN USE FEAR AND I
UNDERSTAND THE FEAR IS A GREAT
MOTIVATOR TO TRY TO GET PEOPLE
TO NOT WANT TO CHANGE TOTALLY
GET THAT ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO SENIORS HIGH END OF
THE THAT THAT'S A VERY COMMON
REFRAINS IS TO USE FEAR BUT
THE REALITY IS THAT IF YOU
UNDERSTOOD OUR CURRENT MEDICARE
SYSTEM ABOUT PEOPLE QUALIFY
FOR AND LOOK NOT EVERYONE CAN
AFFORD MEDICARE ADVANTAGE MY
FATHER'S FORTUNE ENOUGH THAT
HE CAN'T AND IF YOU CAN'T EVEN
HAVE A LOT MORE EXPENSES AND
WHAT HAPPENS IS SENIORS AND UP
RATIONING AND MANY OF THEM DIED
PREMATURELY BECAUSE THEY DON'T
GET THE HEALTHCARE THEY NEED
EVEN WITH MEDICARE MEDICARE
IS A SAFETY NET MEDICARE'S NOT
COMPREHENSIVE CARE NOT IN THE
WAY THAT CALCAREOUS AND SO I
WOULD SAY TO EVERYONE THAT NOT
ONLY ARE YOU NOT AND AND AND
IF YOU'RE ON MEDICARE -- THAT
YOU'RE NOT WORKING YOU'RE NOT
GETTING UP THE PAYROLL TAX
NOT BECAUSE IT'S NOT GOING
TO IMPACT YOU IN FACT YOU
COULD HAVE A CALL HUGE COST
SAVINGS FOR NOT HAVING TO BUY
SUPPLEMENTAL INSURANCE NOT
TO BUY THAT OCCURRED VANTAGE
NOT PAPER PHARMACEUTICALS
NOT PAPER COPAYS AND PREMIUMS
BUT IN ANY FORM OR FASHION
AND SO THE END OF THE DAY YOU
ARE HAVING A DRAMATIC COST
SAVINGS WITHIN EXPANSION AND
THE SERVICES PROVIDED TO YOU
AND THAT'S WHAT CALCULATES
OUT QUITE CLEARLY AND IF
YOU UNDERSTOOD THAT MEDICARE
IS NOT THIS COMPREHENSIVE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AS IT COULD
BE AND SHOULD BE -- THEN YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT CALCULATE
ACTUALLY BE FAR BETTER FOR
SENIORS THAT ARE ON MEDICARE MY
OTHER QUESTION IS UP REGARDING
THE IMPACT THIS BILL WOULD
POTENTIALLY HAVE ON OUR ABILITY
TO RECRUIT QUALIFIED MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS PROFESSIONALS TO
MOVE TO CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT ISSUE BECAUSE IT'S
WELL WELL DOCUMENTED IN CERTAIN
PLACES IN THE STATE BASICALLY
EVERYWHERE THAT'S RURAL MOST
OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY A LOT OF
PLACES YOU CAN'T GET QUALIFIED
DOCTORS NURSES TO MOVE HERE
FOR PRACTICALLY ANYTHING IT'S
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT WE HAVE
MASSIVE SHORTAGES WE HAVE A
MAJOR MISMATCH BETWEEN THE
DISTRIBUTION OF DOCTORS MEDICAL
SPECIALISTS TO MEET PEOPLE
WHERE I LIVE -- YOU KNOW THEY
DRIVE THREE AND A HALF HOURS TO
SEE A SPECIALIST RIGHT BECAUSE
THERE AREN'T ANY AROUND SO THE
HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY EMPLOYS
ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION WORKERS
IN CALIFORNIA ROUGHLY TEN
PERCENT OF OUR WORKFORCE RIGHT
NOW AND OUR STATE HAS THIS WELL
DOCUMENTED SHORTAGE SO IF CAL
CARE BECAME LAW A.
B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED PASSED HOW
DO YOU THINK IT WOULD IMPACT
THE ABILITY FOR CALIFORNIA TO
RECRUIT AND RETAIN ALL FIVE
MEDICAL PROVIDERS IT OCCURS TO
ME THERE ARE SEVERAL PROBLEMS
FOR ONE THIS IS THE HIGHEST
COST OF LIVING STATE IN THE
COUNTRY I TALKED TO A GOOD
FRIEND OF MINE DOES MEDICAL
RECRUITING FOR DOCTORS FOR
HOSPITALS HE SAYS EVERY WINTER
I GET CALLS FROM A DOCTOR IN
MICHIGAN OR WISCONSIN AND THEY
WANT TO MOVE TO SANTA MARIA
CALIFORNIA TO BE A DOCTOR AND
THEN THEY REALIZE THEY'RE GONNA
GET PAID LESS THEY'RE GONNA
PAY THREE TIMES AS MUCH FOR
THEIR HOUSE AND WE CAN'T GET
HIM TO COME HERE NOW WE HAVE
A LOT OF GREAT DOCTORS NURSES
AND MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
THAT ARE HERE AND WILLING TO
HEAR THAT AND AT THAT POINT
TO STAY AND THAT'S GREAT BUT
WE WE NEED TO RECRUIT MORE
THAN AND THEN INDUCE THEM TO
COME HERE NOW IF THEY COME
HERE AND THEY DON'T HAVE THE
ASSURANCE THAT THE SERVICES
THEY PROVIDE ARE GOING TO BE
ADEQUATE ADEQUATELY REIMBURSED
IF FOR ANY STATE SYSTEM THAT IS
ESSENTIALLY CONTROLLING COSTS
BY RATIONING CARE BECAUSE I
THINK YOU HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
IT EVERYWHERE IN THE WORLD
HAS SINGLE PAYER HEALTHCARE
INCLUDING CANADA WHICH IS
HELD UP AS THE GOLD STANDARD
BY MANY PEOPLE ON SINGLE
PAYER HEALTHCARE IN CANADA
THE AVERAGE TIME I LOOK THIS
UP THIS IS A FOR A FACT THE
AVERAGE TIME BETWEEN DIAGNOSIS
AND GETTING AN ORTHOPEDIC
SURGERY BACK SURGERY KNEE
REPLACEMENT HIP REPLACEMENT
ETCETERA IT'S FORTY EIGHT WEEKS
THAT'S QUITE A WHILE I MEAN
THEY RATION CARE IN CANADA
THAT'S WELL DOCUMENTED AND I
THINK HEALTHCARE MIGHT LEAD TO
A SITUATION WHERE CALIFORNIA
IS DOING SIMILAR THINGS TO
CONTAIN COSTS AND THAT STRIKES
ME AS A TOUGH SELL TO ALL OF
THE MEDICAL SCHOOL GRADUATES
NURSES AND PEAS ALL THE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS THAT WE NEED TO
BRING INTO OUR STATE SO THAT WE
HAVE ENOUGH SERVICE PROVIDERS
HERE TO SERVE OUR POPULATION
SO HOW WOULD YOU ADDRESS THAT
CONCERN WAS A LOT OF LESSONS
WE CAN CERTAINLY LEARN AS I
SAID I'M MY INTEREST IS NOT
TO CREATE A SYSTEM LIKE AND
LIKE LIKE ANY OTHER I DO HAVE
A CHANCE IN OCTOBER TO VISIT
ONTARIO AND QUEBEC AND AND MET
WITH REPRESENTATIVES FROM BOTH
THEIR HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS I ALSO
WENT TO RULE COMMUNITY ACTUALLY
LIVED IN BACK IN THE SEVENTIES
WITH FORTY TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE
TO LEARN MORE ABOUT HOW THEY
OBSERVE RURAL COMMUNITIES IN
CANADA WHICH OBVIOUSLY HAS A
LOT OF RURAL COMMUNITIES OF
THE NORTH OF THE -- OF THE
POPULATION BASE -- AND LOOK I
AGREE THAT WORKFORCE SHORTAGE
IS A PROBLEM WITH TODAY'S
SYSTEM -- AND AN EIGHTY FOUR
HUNDRED DESIGNED TO REMOVE
SOME OF THE SYSTEMIC ISSUES
AND REALLOCATE RESOURCES TO
AREAS WITH WITH THE MOST NEED
-- OR IMPROVED EFFICIENCIES
AND SO YOU KNOW HOW MUCH WE PAY
A HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONAL CAN
INFLUENCE THE REPLACE SHORTAGE
FOR EXAMPLE WE TEND TO PAY MORE
TO SPECIALIST AND PRIMARY CARE
DOCTORS AND WE SEE SHORTAGES IN
PRIMARY CARE DOCTORS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
-- AND VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
-- BUT THAT IS UNDER OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM WE SEE IN OTHERS
BUDGET CUTBACKS CORPORATE
GREED A LACK OF SUPPORT STAFF
BURNOUT THE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
NURSING SHORTAGE AND ATTEMPT TO
MINIMIZE THE BECAUSE HOSPITALS
ARE WILLING TO I'M GOING
TO HIRE A SUFFICIENT AMOUNT
OF HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS
AND AND I GIVE YOU A PERFECT
EXAMPLE LAST OF LAST YEAR --
ACTUALLY IN TWENTY TWENTY IN
THE IN IN MAY OR JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY RIGHT ON THE PENTAMETER
ME THAT WAS HITTING US ALL HARD
HOSPITAL CORPORATION AMERICA
CLOSE THE WOMEN'S HEALTH
CENTER IN EAST SAN JOSE THAT'S
THE MATERNITY WARD NEONATAL
PRENATAL THEY SHUT DOWN THE SAN
JOSE THAT'S UNDER OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM OF ALLOWING THOSE THAT
ARE LOOKING FOR PROFIT THIS
DICTATE WHO AND HOW IT'S GOING
TO GET SERVED AND SO BY THE
THE COUPLE THINGS ONE IS BY
ELIMINATING ADMINISTRATIVE
COMPLEXITY BE ALLOWED DOCTORS
AND NURSES SPEND LESS TIME ON
BILLING AND CODING MORE TIME
TO DO WHAT THEY LOVE BEST WAS
CARING FOR PATIENTS THEY CAN
ALSO ALLOW DOCTORS TO HAVE
MORE PATIENCE -- YOU KNOW
THAT THEY CAN POTENTIALLY SEE
RATHER THAN HAVING TO DEAL
HOP THAT DATE WITH INSURANCE
COMPANIES -- EIGHTY FOUR TWO
HUNDRED DOES HAVE PROVISIONS TO
INCREASE PAYMENT RATES IN AREAS
THAT ARE PROVIDER SHORTAGES
INCLUDING RURAL AND MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREAS SECTION ONE
ZERO ZERO SIX FOUR FOUR PERMITS
THE BOARD TO INCREASE PAYMENT
RATES TO IMPROVE THE ABILITY
AND ACCESSIBILITY OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES SESSION ONE ZERO
ZERO SIX FOUR SEVEN ALLOWS A
SPECIAL PROJECTS BUDGET TO BE
USED INCREASED PAYMENT RATES
TO IMPROVE THE AVAILABILITY AND
ACCESSIBILITY OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND RURAL OR MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREAS THE BOTTOM
LINE IS WE'RE NOT TALKING A
MEDICAL REIMBURSEMENT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE CHARACTER
SYSTEM WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
REIMBURSING FOR THE COST OF
CARE THE DOCTORS HOSPITALS
NURSES ARE ACTUALLY PROVIDING
A AND THE OTHER THING IN TERMS
OF BRINGING WORK FORCE IS IS
A LONG DEBT STUDENT LOAN DEBT
BETWEEN MEDICINE MEDICAL SCHOOL
AND A CUSTOM I KNOW THAT THE
CHAIR HAS WORKED A LOT ON AND
WITH THE SAVINGS WE GET FROM
THE CHARACTERS SYSTEM WITHOUT
FUND WE CAN WE CAN WORK WITH
THE CHAIR TO ENSURE THAT AS
PART OF THE PROGRAM THE PAY
DOWN THAT DEBT SO THAT THOSE
TO COME TO WORK IN CALIFORNIA
ANOTHER MEDICAL ON THAT ALSO
FOR THE BILL FOR GIVEN IT AND
AND A RAISED FOR A COMMITMENT
IN WORKING HERE IN CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY THE GO TO RURAL
OR UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
IF I GET CIRCLE BACK IN THE
I APPRECIATE THE CHAIRS AND
DILIGENCE IS MY LAST QUESTION
IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE YOU HAVE
NOT YET WORKED OUT TELL ME IF
I'M WRONG WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
MONEY THAT HAS ACCRUED AND
THE PENSION TRUST FOR EXAMPLE
THAT IS EARMARKED FOR THE
PROVISION OF HEALTH CARE THAT
WORKERS HAVE PAID INTO OVER
MANY DECADES OF WORK IT SOUNDS
LIKE THERE IS NO PROVISION
IN THIS BILL THAT DICTATES
OUR DETERMINES WHERE THAT
MONEY GOES AND M.
I.
WRONG ABOUT THAT THE IN SECTION
ONE ZERO ZERO SIX ONE TWO IT
SPEAKS TO A COMEDY INCLUDE
BENEFITS AND FOR AND RETIREES
SO ESSENTIALLY NO LATER THAN
TWO YEARS AFTER THE EFFECTIVE
DATE OF THE SECTION OF THE
BORDER WILL BE REQUIRED TO
DEVELOP PROPOSALS THAT FORK TO
ACCOMMODATE EMPLOYER RETIREE
HEALTH BENEFITS FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN MEMBERS OF THE PERS
SYSTEM -- BUT LIVE AS RETIREES
OUT OF STATE AS WELL SO WE'RE
GOING TO GIVE THAT POWER TO
THE NINE MEMBER BOARD THAT'S
GONNA RUN CAL CARE AND FIGURE
THAT OUT LATER THAT'S THAT'S
IT'S ACCOUNTED FOR OKAY -- I
EVER ASK CARMEN IS -- IS --
MISTER BARKIN AVAILABLE OFFER
FOR MISTER CARILLO QUESTION
YES HE IS AVAILABLE ALL RIGHT
MISS ON THAT LET ME OKAY OKAY
CAN YOU HEAR AT YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU OKAY GREAT I'M HERE
WITH ATTY OKAY THANK YOU GO
AHEAD MR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND THANK YOU MR BURKE AND
FOR BEING ON THE LINE FOR FOR
THIS AMOUNT OF TIME INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION AND I
THINK WITH ANYTHING THAT WE
DO IN THE LEGISLATURE WE HELP
TO HUMANIZE THE WORK THAT
WE DO AND AND LEGISLATION
THAT ULTIMATELY HOPEFULLY
POSITIVELY IMPACTS PEOPLE
I'M YOU STATED THAT YOU RELY
ON TWENTY FOUR HOUR A HOME
CARE TO SURVIVE IF YOU CAN I
WOULD LOVE FOR YOU TO TELL US
MORE ABOUT THE CARE THAT YOU
RECEIVE HOW YOU PAY FOR IT AND
WHAT THE OPTIONS ARE FOR CARE
OUT THERE FOR CALIFORNIANS
I LIKE YOURSELF WITH SERIOUS
ILLNESSES OR DISABILITIES AND
WE AGAIN REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION AND FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT MY TESTIMONY TODAY MY
TEAM OF CARE GIVERS ENABLES
ME TO LIVE AT HOME WHERE I GET
TO BE AN ACTIVE PARTICIPANT
IN MY FAMILY'S LIVES MY CARE
GIVERS ARE HIGHLY SKILLED AND
DO EVERYTHING FROM MAKING SURE
THERE ARE NO BLOCKAGES IN MY
BREEDING TO FIXING THE TABLETS
ARE USED TO COMMUNICATE THANK
SERVE AS AN EXTENSION OF MYSELF
HELPING ME DO THINGS LIKE
UNLOAD THE DISHWASHER OR OFFER
AGAINST THE GLASS OF WATER
TASKS I WOULD DO IF I WERE
NOT PARALYZED PRIVATE HEALTH
INSURANCE RARELY COVERS HOLD
HERE AND NEITHER DOES MEDICARE
UNABLE TO PAY FOR MY CARE
ONLY BECAUSE I SUCCESSFULLY
COURSE MY HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANY TO PAY FOR MOST OF IT
WITHOUT THIS MY FAMILY LIKE
TOO MANY OTHERS WOULD LIKELY
GO BANKRUPT FROM THE COST OF
MIKE HERE WHEN HOME CARE IS NOT
ACCESSIBLE WHICH IS THE REALITY
FOR MOST HAITIANS ARE FORCED
INTO NURSING HOMES DANGEROUS
INSTITUTIONS WHERE PEOPLE ARE
MERELY WAREHOUSE AND ISOLATED
FROM THEIR LOVED ONES SINCE
THE PANDEMIC BEGAN NEARLY TEN
THOUSAND DISABLED CALIFORNIANS
HAVE DIED IN NURSING HOMES DUE
TO THE CORONA VIRUS MANY OF
THESE DEATHS COULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED IF PEOPLE RECEIVING
SERVICES IN NURSING HOMES HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE
CARE SAFELY AT HOME THE LOSS
OF THESE TEN THOUSAND LIVES
ARE A MORAL FAILURE AND A
DIRECT RESULT OF THE FOR PROFIT
SYSTEM UP HERE THAT CORPORATE
LOBBYISTS LIKE THOSE HIRED
BY THE NURSING HOME INDUSTRY
WORKS HARD TO MAINTAIN ONE
IN FOUR AMERICANS LIVE WITH A
DISABILITY AND ONLY A SINGLE
PAYER SYSTEM WOULD POSSESS
THE SKILL AND RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO GUARANTEE HOME
AND COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES
FOR ALL THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CURRENTLY REQUIRES STATES TO
FUND NURSING HOME CARE FOR
EVERYONE ELIGIBLE THIS IS NOT
THE CASE WITH REGARDS TO HOME
AND COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES
AND BECAUSE STATES MANAGE
THEIR OWN HEALTHCARE PROGRAMS
THROUGH MEDICAID ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS AND SERVICES
AVAILABLE VARY WIDELY ACROSS
STATES IT'S BY DEFAULT AND
DESIGN THAT SO MANY AMERICANS
WHO REQUIRED HERE ARE FORCED
INTO ON STATE INSTITUTIONS
LIKE NURSING HOMES BUT UNDER
A SINGLE PAYER SYSTEM HOME
AND COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES
WOULD BE PRIORITIZED OVER
INSTITUTIONALIZATION THIS IS
THE GOAL AND YET AGAIN ANOTHER
REASON WHY WE NEED TO PASS A B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO GERMANY
OTHERS HAVE A FOLLOW UP PLEASE
GO AHEAD MR TRIGGERING QUEUE
THANK YOU MR BARKING FOR THAT
VERY DETAILED DESCRIPTION AS
TO WHAT YOU GO THROUGH EVERY
DAY AND THE IMPACT OF THAT
THE HOME CARE PROVIDERS HAVE
ON YOUR AND YOUR FAMILY AND
YOURSELF AND YOUR HEALTH CARE
BASED ON YOUR ADVOCACY YOUR
OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE HOW
DO YOU IMAGINE A.
B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED AS A
CALIFORNIA STATE POLICY COULD
HAVE A A NATIONAL IMPACT AT
TO THE HEALTHCARE LANDSCAPE
-- FOR THE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES
ARE WE
IT MAY TAKE A MORE PROMINENT
WITHOUT A QUESTION FOR
ATTY WHAT KIND AUDIO AND
FORTUNATELY WILL CUTTING IN
AND OUT A LITTLE BIT YES YES
IT WAS I'LL HAVE A REPEATED
THAT'S OKAY THANK YOU AGAIN
MISS HEALTHCARE AT MIKE MY
QUESTION WAS BASED ON --
MISTER BARKAN'S EXPERIENCE
HIS OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
WITH HOME CARE PROVIDERS AND
THE IMPACT THAT IT'S HAD ON
HIS OWN PERSONAL ADVOCACY
WITH HIS INSURANCE COMPANY --
TO RECEIVE THAT TYPE OF CARE
WHICH IS NOT NORMALLY AVAILABLE
WHICH IS WHY HIS TESTIMONY I
THINK FOR THIS COMMITTEE ON
THIS BILL IS SO INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT HOW WOULD AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED BASED ON WHAT HE'S
EXPERIENCED AND SEEN HAVE
AN IMPACT ACROSS OUR NATION
WHEN IT COMES TO PROVIDING
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL AMERICANS
THANK YOU FOR THIS QUESTION I
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA
CAN PAVE THE WAY FOR A NATIONAL
SINGLE PAYER HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
WE DON'T NEED TO LOOK FAR FOR
PROOF THAT THIS IS FEASIBLE
CANADA FOR EXAMPLE THE RURAL
PROVINCE OF SASKATCHEWAN
WAS THE FIRST TO ESTABLISH
A SINGLE PAYER SYSTEM IN
CANADA AND FORGED A PATH FOR
THE REST OF THE NATION TO
FOLLOW IN NINETEEN FORTY FOUR
VOTERS IN SASKATCHEWAN ELECTED
POLITICIANS THAT CAMPAIGN
ON GUARANTEEING HEALTH CARE
AS A BASIC HUMAN RIGHT THREE
YEARS LATER ADVOCATES AND
POLITICIANS IN THE PROVINCE
SUCCEEDED IN THEIR OVER ALL OF
THEIR PRIVATELY RUN HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM USING TAXES TO COVER
ALL HOSPITAL CARE THE SINGLE
PAYER SYSTEM GAIN SO MUCH
WIDESPREAD POPULAR SUPPORT THAT
EFFORTS MADE BY THE OPPOSITION
TO RETAIN A PRIVATELY INSURED
AND BONDED SYSTEM BECAME PUPIL
THE INITIAL VICTORY SPARKED A
MOVEMENT AND IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR THE CANADA HEALTH ACT
WAS PASSED WHICH ESTABLISHED
THE NATIONAL HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
KNOWN AS MEDICARE FOR OVER
ONE HUNDRED YEARS GUARANTEED
HEALTHCARE HAS REMAINED
ELUSIVE IN THE UNITED STATES
DESPITE INCREASINGLY POPULAR
SUPPORT FROM THE PUBLIC THAT'S
BECAUSE THE CORPORATIONS THAT
PROFIT OFF OUR SUFFERING HAVE
SPENT INORDINATE AMOUNTS OF
MONEY ON ANTI HEALTH REFORM
PUBLIC RELATIONS CAMPAIGN AND
LOBBYING EFFORTS TO REINFORCE
THE STATUS QUO ACCORDING
TO REPORTS COMPILED BY THE
NONPROFIT CONSUMER ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION PUBLIC CITIZEN
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
THE PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY
HAS SPENT TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS ON LOBBYING IN
WASHINGTON CONTRIBUTING FORTY
FOUR PERCENT TO COMPRESSIONAL
REPUBLICANS AND FIFTY SIX
PERCENT YOUR CONGRESSIONAL
DEMOCRATS MANY OTHER COUNTRIES
LESS RESOURCES THAN OURS HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO ENACT A SYSTEM
OF UNIVERSAL CARE SO IT IS
CERTAINLY POSSIBLE TO DO SO
HERE IN THE RICHEST NATION IN
THE HISTORY OF THE WORLD WE
HAVE THE POLITICAL POWER AND
WHILE YOU'RE IN CALIFORNIA
TO ESTABLISH A SINGLE PAYER
SYSTEM WHEN WE LEAD ON BOLD
AND PROGRESSIVE POLICIES WE
GIVE THE COUNTRY COURAGE TO
FOLLOW GUARANTEED HEALTHCARE
FOR ALL THESE WITHIN OUR
REACH AND SO ONCE AGAIN I
URGE YOU TO PASS A B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER
MARK AND MUCH APPRECIATED
-- THIS MS AGUIAR-CURRY
AND THEN MR RODRIGUEZ
TWENTY ALONG WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU INTRODUCED
FIFTY FIFTY FOURTEEN HUNDRED
ALMOST A YEAR AGO IN THE TIME
SINCE THEN I CHECK YOUR TURKEY
WORD THE YOU'VE CONSULTED WITH
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE ACROSS THE
STATE AND COUNTRY AND OTHER
COUNTRIES SHORTLY AFTER YOU AND
INTRODUCED THIS LEGISLATION I
APPROACHED YOU PERSONALLY WITH
QUESTIONS OUT OF CONCERN FOR MY
CONSTITUENTS ALL CALIFORNIANS
AND INDEED THE COUNTRY I NEVER
GOT AN ANSWER TO ONE OF THEM
SO I SUPPOSE I'M GETTING AN
ANSWER OF SORTS WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING TO THIS COMMITTEE IS
THAT AFTER ALL THE CONSUL THE
PATIENTS HUNDREDS OF QUESTIONS
AND CONCERNS FROM YOUR YOUR
COLLEAGUES AND STAKEHOLDERS
OVER THE LAST ELEVEN MONTHS YOU
THINK YOU'VE GOT THE PERFECT
BILL TO REPLACE HEALTH CARE IN
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
YOU'RE TELLING US THE YOU THINK
ANY SINGLE QUESTION OR CONCERN
WAS WORTHY OF ANY CHANGE TO
YOUR LEGISLATION BEFORE ASKING
FOR A VOTE IN THE ASSEMBLY
HEALTH COMMITTEE NOT ONE NOT
ONE OF MINE NOT ONE OF SOME OF
OUR COLLEAGUES I WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SHARE YOUR CONCERN ABOUT
GETTING REAL HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE TO EVERY RESIDENT IN
THE STATE AND WHEN I SAY FOR
ALL THAT MEANS THE UNDERINSURED
HAVE NO HEALTH INSURANCE YOU
KNOW THE GOVERNOR YESTERDAY
A PROPOSED A BUDGET THAT
WILL COVER EVERY CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF AGE OR STATUS
I WOULD GUESS AND YOU LIKELY
AGREE WITH THAT WE ASPIRE TO
MORE BUT THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE
PLACE FOR US TO START IMPROVE
OURSELVES CAPABLE IF YOU HAVE
PRESENTED A BILL THAT WOULD
HAVE ASSURED HEALTH CARE
HEALTH INSURANCE FOR ALL THOSE
WHO ARE AN IN UNDERINSURED
I HAVE CELEBRATED THE EFFORT
AND GLADLY OFFERED MY SUPPORT
JUST LIKE I HAVE EVERY BILL
TO EXPAND HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
DURING MY TIME IN THE ASSEMBLY
WELL I AGREE WHO SHOULD PROVIDE
PUBLIC COVERAGE FOR ALL SOME
DAY I CANNOT AGREE WITH THAT
OUR FIRST STEPS WE SHOULD BE
TAKING IT AWAY FROM THOSE WHO
HAVE AMPLE COVERAGE I SINCERELY
BELIEVE THAT OPERATING THE
WAY YOU ARE YOU'RE PUTTING
THOSE WHO DESPERATELY NEED
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE AT
SIGNIFICANT RISK OF LOSING
OUT AGAIN AND I PASSIONATELY
REJECT THE ARGUMENT THAT IF
IF ONE DOESN'T BELIEVE THIS IS
THE WAY TO REFORM OUR BROKEN
HEALTH INSURANCE AND HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS DO YOU SUPPORT
THE STATUS QUO FOR THOSE WHO
MAKE THAT INTELLECTUALLY LAZY
ARGUMENT YOU'RE NOT HELPING
THOSE OF US WHO ARE FIGHTING
TO IMPROVE THE SYSTEM AND OUR
DEMOCRACY MISTER CARL I WILL
GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CHANGE THE WAY YOU ARE WORKING
ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE AGAINST
MY BETTER JUDGEMENT I WILL
CAST A RELUCTANT I WROTE FOR
YOU TODAY BUT MR CARL I WILL
VOTE NO ON THIS ON THE FLOOR
YOU CANNOT TELL ME THAT A
PRODUCT THAT WILL BE COMPLETELY
CHANGE THE HEALTH SYSTEM FOR
FORTY MILLION CALIFORNIANS
WAS PERFECT THE DAY IT WAS
INTRODUCED I'M NOT WILLING TO
TAKE A FLYER AND CAST MY LOT
WITH PLATITUDES GIVING SOMEONE
ELSE DIRECTION DO FIGURE IT
ALL OUT I'M ALSO NOT VOTE FOR
A BILL THAT DOES NOT DEPEND ON
UPON A FUNDING MECHANISM FOR
ENACTMENT THAT WOULD BE A LIE
TO WORK INSTANCE CONSTITUENTS
WHO BELIEVE YOU'RE FULFILLING A
PROMISE OF HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS
OF SPENDING ON THEIR FAMILIES
VERY LIVES I NEED TO KNOW HOW
THE STATE BUREAUCRACY THAT
HAS RESISTED MY EFFORTS TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
THROUGH SUCH PROVEN METHODS
THIS TELEHEALTH IS SOMETHING
GOING TO APPROVE ALL THE
PROCEDURES CURRENTLY BEING
REJECTED BY PRIVATE INSURANCE
COMPANIES THE PROMISE ADVOCATES
SAY THAT YOU HAVE MAY I NEED
TO KNOW HOW YOUR BILL WILL
GUARANTEE GREATER ACCESS TO
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND HEALTH
FACILITIES IN SMALLER CITIES
IMPORTANT RURAL COMMUNITIES
LIKE THOSE IN MY DISTRICT
THIS IS ANOTHER PROMISES
SUPPORTERS CONTEND YOU HAVE
MADE WE BOTH KNOW THAT HEALTH
COVERAGE IS NO GUARANTEE OF
HEALTHAXIS SHOULD WE HAVE A
PUBLIC SYSTEM FOR PROVIDING
HEALTH CARE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SUNDAY ABSOLUTELY
BUT I BELIEVE IT SHOULD COME
AFTER WE HAVE DEVELOPED THE
PLANS NOT GIVEN OPEN INTO
FORTY AND LITTLE DIRECTION
TO IT AS YET ON APPOINTED
BOARD THE NATION'S WATCHING
THIS EXPERIMENT COLLEAGUES
WE WE CAN SHOW THEM THE WAY
BY BUILDING ON THE SYSTEM
WHERE EVERYONE IS GUARANTEED
SUFFICIENT COVERAGE AND THEN
ARE ENCOURAGED TO LEAVE EVER
GROWING COST FOR INSUFFICIENT
HEALTH CARE BEHIND US YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A COUPLE WEEKS
AND I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
FOR YOU DIRECTLY MISTER KALRA
I REGARDING WORKFORCE IN THE
LANGUAGES STATES THE BOARD
SHALL ADOPT REGULATIONS
IN REGARDS TO MAINTAINING
OPTIMAL WORKFORCE THE HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES NECESSARY
TO DELIVER QUALITY EQUITABLE
HEALTH CARE HOWEVER THAT'S
NOT A PLAN IT'S THE BOARD WILL
WORRY ABOUT WORKFORCE PROBLEMS
MY CONSTITUENTS ALREADY FACE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES IN ON
THIS AND MANY OTHER CONCERNS I
KEEP GETTING TOLD I WILL SAVE
DON'T FIX THAT LATER WE'LL
FIGURE IT OUT LATER WILL GET
BETTER CAN YOU TELL ME HOW
THIS BILL WILL IMPROVE ACCESS
TO MY SMALL TOWN AND RURAL
CONSTITUENCIES I DON'T EXPECT
AN ANSWER NOW I EXPECT BEFORE
WE GO TO THE FLOOR THE LANGUAGE
ALSO INCLUDES A SPECIAL
PROJECTS FUND FOR THE BOARD
TO USE IN AREAS WITH ACCESS
PROBLEMS BUT AGAIN THERE'S
NO PLAN AS YOU KNOW MISTER
KALRA INCREASING COVERAGE
DOES NOT INCREASE ACCESS
-- HOW WILL THEY BE TO FOURTEEN
HUNDRED SURE PATIENTS HAVE
TIMELY AND EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
HEALTH SERVICES SPECIFICALLY
IN RURAL AND URBAN UNDERSERVED
AREAS HELLO DISC DECREASED
A DISPARITIES IN THE HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM -- YOU CAN EXPECT
CAN YOU EXPLAIN YOUR PLAN FOR
SWITCHING RESOURCES CURRENTLY
COMMITTED TO FUNDING THE
PRIVATE SYSTEM INTO A NEW
PUBLICLY RUN SYSTEM OR ACL
EVANS TAX INCREASES MEANT TO
REPLACE OR SUPPLEMENT WHAT
EMPLOYERS EMPLOYEES CAN NOW
CONTRIBUTE TO HEALTH CARE
PLANS AND LASTLY NEARLY SIX
MILLION CALIFORNIANS ARE
ROLLED AND PRIVATE HEALTH
COVERAGE REGULATED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND ROLLING
THEM INTO HEALTHCARE COULD
REQUIRE A CHANGE IN FEDERAL
REGULATORY LAW AND WOULD LIKELY
REQUIRE CHANGES TO THE STATE
CONSTITUTION WHICH IN ADDITION
TO PASSING TAX INCREASES COULD
FOR SINGLE PAYER BACKERS TO
OBTAIN VOTER APPROVAL THERE'S
NO GUARANTEE THAT A C.
ELEVEN WILL MAKE IT THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE AND IF IT
DOES THERE'S NO GUARANTEE THE
VOTERS WILL VOTE FOR IT IF THE
ACA DOESN'T PASS MISTER KALRA
WHAT HAPPENS WHAT HAPPENS I
DON'T WANT TO BE SITTING HERE
TO MAKING PROMISES A RECAP
OF FILL THEM WE DO THAT A LOT
HERE AND SO THAT'S ONE OF MY
BIGGEST CONCERNS IT'S EASY AS
WE SAY IN MY OFFICE IT'S EASY
FOR PEOPLE TO HAVE BROUGHT
THREE TO BUY A NEW CAR IF
THERE'S NO DISCUSSION WHERE
THE MONEY IS COMING FROM AND
I THINK THE HEALTH OF FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE IS JUST A BIT
MORE IMPORTANT AND COMPLICATED
TO FIND THE FAMILY CAR
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU THANK YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ
THANK RESEARCHER THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA YOU KNOW
WHAT -- IF YOU'VE BEEN A VERY
STRONG SUPPORTER AND CHAMPION
FOR THIS MEASURE -- BUT I TO
SHARE A LOT OF CONCERNS I THINK
-- ALSO MY COLLEAGUES ALREADY
TOOK THE WORDS OUT OF MY MOUTH
WHEN HE TALKED ABOUT SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT CONCERNS ALWAYS
YOU BIGGEST THING OF RETIREES
WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM -- WHAT
THEY'VE BEEN RECEIVING AND WHAT
HAPPENS TO THEM THE TRANSITION
TO THIS NEW -- CALIFORNIA
CARE PROGRAM WE CANNOT I KNOW
WE'RE WE TALKED ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION THE TAXES WHAT
HAPPENS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
IF WE HAVE A NEW ADMINISTRATION
AND WE WE GET THE THE WAIVERS
RIGHT AND WE'RE INTO THIS IN
A NEW ADMINISTRATION COMES
UP AND THEY REVOKING CANDOR
REVOKE THEM -- WE HAVE BUDGET
SHORTFALLS YOU KNOW HOW THINGS
WE GO GOOD YET SOME YEARS
OR SOME YEARS AGO ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN OUR BUDGET TAKES
IT A DUMP AND AND HOW DOES
THAT AFFECT THE FINANCING FOR
-- CAL CARE IT DO WE GO BACK
TO INCREASING TAXES ONCE AGAIN
NOT EVERYBODY ACROSS THE BOARD
BECAUSE REALLY IT ISN'T FREE
IMAGE SOMEHOW HAS TO GET PAID
FOR AND A FORTUNE IT'S GOING
TO BE SPREAD AMONGST DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND PEOPLE --
I CAN GO ON AND ON I THINK I
READ THE THE NOTICES AS WELL
SIXTY ONE PAGES AND IT LEAVES
ME A LOT MORE QUESTIONS I
DIDN'T GET A CHANCE TO TALK TO
YOU ABOUT THEM BECAUSE I TOOK
UP TODAY TO READ THEM AND I'M
STILL NOT THERE ARE A HUNDRED
PERCENT BUT ALL I COULD SAY
IS THAT HOPEFULLY YOU WORK ON
ALL THESE ISSUES AND CONCERNS
THAT OUR PAPER BRING IN FORT
IF I LOOK TO SUPPORT IT TODAY
I WOULD HOPE THAT WE HAVE A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING WHEN IT
GETS TO THE FOR THAT YOU COULD
ADDRESS OUR ISSUES OUT -- AND
I GET RESERVE MY RIGHT TO TO
VOTE FOR IT THERE IF IT GETS
TO THAT POINT -- BUT ONCE AGAIN
I WANT TO TAKE TOO MUCH TIME
OF WE'VE BEEN HERE FOR A LONG
TIME NOW WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE FOR A COUPLE YEARS
IT IS A NEW IT'S IN EVERYBODY'S
RADAR BUT ONCE AGAIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PLEASE LOOK AT THESE
CONCERNS AND ISSUES PEOPLE ROB
FORD AND THE THINGS IN THE NOW
THIS IS A ONCE AGAIN IF I DO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY I'M
GOING TO RESERVE MY RIGHT NOT
TO SUPPORT ON THE FLOOR IF I
DON'T GET A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING
OF HOW THE ROLLOUT TAKES
EFFECT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISS WALDRON THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR YOU WOULD HAVE BEEN
ANNOYING CROSSED OUT SEVERAL MY
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN ANSWERED SO
I'LL TRY NOT TO REPEAT WHAT'S
BEEN SAID IN LIGHT OF SITTING
HERE FOR SEVEN HOURS ALREADY
-- BUT I WAS WONDERING IF YOU
WOULD ALLOW THE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION TO COME FORWARD TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS MISTER YOUNG
LIVES OUT THERE YEAH YOUR ARMS
AND WHILE HIS COMING UP --
OF THOSE PURPOSES I WANTED TO
ASK HIM ABOUT HE HAD TOUCHED
ON OF ONE OF THE ISSUES WITH
THE BOARD THAT WOULD BE SET
UP THAT THIS THIS BOARD WOULD
BE -- PROVIDING BUDGETS FOR
HOSPITALS AND OTHERS AT ACTING
AS RATE SETTING BECAUSE THE
BOARD WILL NOW DECIDE WHAT
OPERATING COSTS WILL BE INSTEAD
OF WHAT THEY ACTUALLY ARE
AND I WAS WONDERING IF YOU
COULD COME ALIVE RATE YOU KNOW
WILLIS BOARD LOOK AT PROVIDER
RATES WILL THEY BE SENDING
HOSPITAL RATES -- WILL IMPROVE
PRICE CEILINGS -- YEAH HOW
DO YOU FORESEE THIS WORKING
THERE ANY -- JOB
CREATORS HOWEVER --
IF YOU COULD JUST REPEAT A
LITTLE BIT OF A QUOTE REAL
QUICK SERVICE COMING UP SORRY
THIS WASN'T SUING SO THE BOARD
ON THAT THAT WILL BE SET UP
-- WOULD PROVIDE BUDGETS FOR
HOSPITALS AND OTHERS IS AXES
RIGHT GREAT SITTING BASICALLY
BECAUSE THE BOARD WILL NOW HAVE
TO DECIDE WHAT THE OPERATING
COSTS WOULD BE INSTEAD OF
WHAT THE REALITY IS WHAT'S THE
ACTUAL COST VERSUS WHAT THEY
WOULD SAID WILL LEAD TO JUSTIN
PROVIDER RATES HOSPITAL RATES
ACCEPTABLE WITH THE PRICING
ON YEAH IT'S AN INTERESTING
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
I CAN TELL YOU RATE SETTING IS
SOMETHING THAT IS DISCONCERTING
-- OUR OPINION HAS CONSISTENTLY
BEEN THAT THE FREE MARKET
SHOULD SET WHAT THE RATES ARE
BECAUSE THAT BECOMES PATIENT
CENTRIC IN SO IF YOU DO HAVE
A PATIENT AT THE POINT OF
CARE WHO HAS THE ABILITY TO
MISTER OR DOCTOR WHICH POINT
EARLIER ABOUT -- TRANSPARENCY
IN PRICING IN PATIENTS KNOWING
WHAT THEY'RE GETTING INTO
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT THING
RATE SETTINGS NOT NECESSARILY
THE ANSWER THOUGH AND THE
REASON WHY IS IT IT BIFURCATES
-- PAYMENT SOURCES IT --
DOESN'T NECESSARILY REIMBURSE
FOR WORK THAT IS DONE AND I
THINK IMPORTANTLY IF DOESN'T
REIMBURSE FOR QUALITY CARE AS
OPPOSED TO -- MAYBE QUANTITY
OF CARE OR VOLUME OF CARE
-- I I THINK AND THEN I'LL
BE GOING TO REQUEST OKAY
-- THANK YOU AND THEN MY SECOND
QUESTION IS ABOUT THE FACT
THAT WE ALL AGREE THE STATUS
QUO IS NOT WORKING AND AND
THIS WOULD BE FOR THE AUTHOR
OR HIS SUPPORTER -- MEDICO
SYSTEM IS BROKEN THERE'S TOO
MUCH BUREAUCRACY WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH PROVIDERS WE CAN
ALL AGREE THERE'S A WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE OF PROVIDERS MEDICO
ACCESS TO CARE IS GROWING AND
IS AN EVER PRESENT PROBLEM
WHY NOT WORK ON STREAMLINING
IMPROVING AND FIXING MEDICO SO
THAT MORE PEOPLE CAN ACCESS IT
RATHER THAN KIND OF SCRAPPING
THE WHOLE SYSTEM STARTING OVER
A BIG ISSUE WITH MEDI CAL AS
THE FACULTY MEMBERS OF RATES
ARE TOO LOW AND YOU DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH PROVIDERS ARE GOING TO
TAKE THEM ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
AND UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
AND SO WE CAN AND I'VE ALWAYS
SUPPORTED EVERY EFFORT WHENEVER
YOU TRY TO INCREASE MEDICAL
REIMBURSEMENT REYES BECAUSE
AGAIN WITHIN THE CURRENT SYSTEM
WE HAVE THAT'S THE BEST WAY
OF RECREATING IN ACCESS BUT
THEN THE DAY IS NOT ENOUGH --
AND THE END BECAUSE MEDI CAL
IS ULTIMATELY COMPETING WITH
THE PRIVATE PAY SYSTEM THAT
IS NEVER GOING TO BE ABLE TO
CATCH CATCH UP AND SO RATHER
THAN HAVING A MAN HAVING A
CASTE SYSTEM WITHIN OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM WE HAVE FOLKS THAT
ARE ON MEDICARE L.
OR A CA BRONZE LEVEL GAME COVER
CALIFORNIA BRONZE LEVEL OR
SOME KIND OF LIKE PACKAGE OF
HEALTH CARE INSTEAD YOU HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY
INCREASE REIMBURSEMENT RATES
IF YOU HAVE EVERYONE IN ONE
SINGLE PAYER SYSTEM AND THEN
YOU CAN ACTUALLY NEGOTIATE
ON BEHALF OF FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS OF PHARMACEUTICALS
ON HEALTHCARE DELIVERY --
AND YOU'RE ABLE TO THEN PAY
PROVIDERS MORE ESPECIALLY
PEDIATRICIANS FAMILY DOCTORS
-- YOU KNOW OBGYN DOCTORS THAT
ARE NOT GETTING COMPENSATED
FRANKLY ENOUGH FOR THE CRITICAL
SERVICES PARTICULARLY INSURANCE
PREVENTATIVE CARE OTHER THEY
PROVIDE AND THAT'S WHY IN SO
MANY RURAL COMMUNITIES AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IT'S
HARD TO FIND DOCTORS THAT WILL
TAKE A MINUTE CAL AND THAT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT PAYING THEM ENOUGH AND SO
INSTEAD OF HAVING A OF OF A
SECONDARY LEVEL OF OF CARE --
AND AGAIN WHEN I SAY THAT I
DON'T NEED THE DOCTORS GETTING
A SECONDARY LEVEL CARE I MEAN
THAT THERE'S ONLY JUST SO SO
MANY PATIENTS THAT SOME OF THE
TAKES MEDICAL CONTENT G.
C.
AND SO THAT'S WHY YOU DON'T
HAVE NO DOCTORS TAKING -- EDIT
CAL PATIENTS ON TOP OF THAT
YOU HAVE MORE PEOPLE GOING
TO SPECIALTIES AND COMING
SPECIALIST BECAUSE THEY CAN
MAKE A WHOLE LOT OF MONEY
WE HAVE LESS OF A HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM WE HAVE MORE OF
THE DISEASE MANAGEMENT AND
CATASTROPHIC RESPONSE SYSTEM
WHERE WE GET WHERE FOLKS ARE
KIND OF DESTROYING ALONG BUT
THE BUT THE THE -- ALL LEVEL
OF CARE WHERE YOU HAVE DOCTORS
THAT USED TO BE ABLE TO SIT
DOWN WITH YOU FOR TWENTY
MINUTES NOW LOOKING AS IF
YOU WERE TWO MINUTES BECAUSE
THEY'RE DEALING WITH ALL THE
BUREAUCRACY AND PAPERWORK
OF INSURANCE COMPANIES AND
THEN ULTIMATELY SOMETHING
CATASTROPHIC HAPPENS AND THE
SPECIALIST COMES AND MAKES A
BOATLOAD OF MONEY AND PATCHES
YOU UP SEND YOU BACK OUT
WITHOUT EVER DEALING WITH THE
UNDERLYING ISSUES WE NEED A
FOOT THAT IN OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM AND THIS TYPE OF SYSTEM
HAS THE ABILITY TO DO THAT BY
FOCUSING WHERE THE RESOURCES
NEED TO GO IN A WAY THAT THEY
CAN FOCUS ON HEALTH OUTCOMES
NOT JUST WHETHER OF BILLS PAID
OR NOT SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT
PROVIDERS WOULD BE PAID MORE
UNDER THIS NEW SYSTEM YEAH
THIS IS NOT ABOUT PAYING PEOPLE
BETTER CALORIES ABSOLUTELY NOT
OKAY SO SPECIALIST WILL STILL
BE PAID MORE TO RECURSOS
RIGID PROCEDURES WOULD BE ALL
INDIVIDUAL OVER THE PROVIDERS
WILL BE PAID IT YOU KNOW
ACCORDING TO THE SERVICE THAT
THEY'RE PROVIDING WITHOUT
HAVING FOR EXAMPLE SITUATIONS
NOW WE'RE IN THE SAME HOSPITAL
FOR THE SAME PROCEDURE YOU CAN
HAVE A VARIANCE IN OF OF TEN X.
TEN TIMES FOR SOME OF MY
GET CHARGE SIX HUNDRED SIX
HUNDRED SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
OR SOMETHING SOMEONE ELSE THE
SAME HOSPITAL BE CHARGED SIX
OR SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
IT'S JUST A NONSENSICAL WAY
OF HAVING HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
OF IT IN OUR STATE AND SO WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO RIGHT SIZE
IT TOOK UNTIL AT LEAST HAVE
SOME SENSE OF ORDER WHERE THE
RESOURCES ARE ACTUALLY GOING
TO THE HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
YOU'RE NOT HAVING MASSIVE
PROFITS TAKEN OFF THE TOP OF
THAT CREATE ANY ANY ANY CALL
SYSTEM AND ALSO INCENTIVIZE
SPECIALIST OVER -- YOUR FAMILY
PRACTITIONERS AS WELL SO I
THINK WE COULD GO A LONG WAY
AND SAVE MONEY TOO WE WOULD
FINALLY AS THIS LEGISLATURE
INCREASE MEDICAL REIMBURSEMENT
RATES THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
DOING FOR A LONG LONG TIME
BUT I JUST HAVE SOME COMMENTS
FOR THE RECORD THANK YOU --
FOR THAT SO WE STUDIED SINGLE
PAYER FOR MANY YEARS NOW WE'VE
HAD A FEW BILLS COME FORWARD
WE YOU KNOW WE'VE HEARD A LOT
OF THE ARGUMENTS WE'VE SEEN
EVEN HAD A SELECT COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH DELIVERY SYSTEMS
AND UNIVERSAL COVERAGE THAT
SPENT MONTHS AND MONTHS GOING
THROUGH ITS WAS FABULOUS THANK
YOU DOCTOR WILL DOUBLE AS A I
OPENING AND I WISH WE COULD DO
THAT AGAIN -- THE FAX HOWEVER
MUCH OF A NETFLIX REYES IS
ONLY THIRTY FIVE HOURS SO THE
FAX HOWEVER NEVER DISAPPEAR
EVEN IF SOME ATTEMPT TO IGNORE
THEM THE COST IS IMPOSSIBLE
TO IGNORE AND THAT YOU KNOW
YOU GO THROUGH AND I WILL YOU
KNOW HAVE GONE THROUGH THIS
TENNESSEE'S TEN CARE KENTUCKY
CARE VERMONT ALL FAILED SYSTEMS
WITH HUGE PAYROLL TAX OPTIONS
THAT IT EVENTUALLY SHOT DOWN
THOSE SYSTEMS OR WEAKENED
THEM OR CHANGE THEM INTO
AMORPHOUS SYSTEMS L.
A.
O.
COSTA SIMMONS BLOW BY ANYTHING
THE STATE HAS TRIED BEFORE
THE SAME GOVERNMENT AS WAS
MENTIONED THAT BUNGLED EDT DMV
ETCETERA WHAT COULD POSSIBLY
GO WRONG SO YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN
ASKED TO FOCUS ON THE POLICY
ONLY AND NOT THE AMOUNT OF COST
SO MOTHER EARTH MY COMMENTS ARE
GOING TO IGNORE COSTS AND TALK
ABOUT THE ACTUAL DOCUMENTED
RESULTS OF THE SINGLE PAYER
TYPE OF CARE JUST FROM ACTUAL
THINGS THAT HAPPEN IN HISTORY
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO SEPARATE THE
POSITIVE CONCEPT OF GOVERNMENT
PROVIDED HEALTHCARE FOR ALL
BECAUSE COST CONTAINMENT AS
MAIN ROADBLOCK BUT IN ORDER
FOR ME TO PROVIDE COVERAGE FOR
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO THINK
THEY'RE GETTING A FREE NOTHING
IS FREE AND IT'LL ACTUALLY
INCREASE MORE PEOPLE COMING
INTO THE SYSTEM WHICH WILL
CREATE THAT ISSUE OF NOT BEING
ENOUGH -- NOT NOT BEING ENOUGH
CARE FOR THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
COMING IN AND THAT'S WHERE WE
GET TO THE RATE SETTING BY YOU
KNOW FORCING BUDGETS THAT ARE
NOT REALISTIC SO LET'S TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE RAMIFICATIONS
BRING IN THE SOUND DIFFERENT
THAN OUR SELECT COMMITTEES
THAT WE ARE SPENT MONTHS ON
WE DISSECTED THE ISSUE AND IS
SIMILAR VERSION UNIVERSAL CARE
FROM EVERY ANGLE INCLUDING
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEMS
GLOBALLY WHAT WE FOUND THROUGH
EXPERT AFTER EXPERT TESTIMONY
IS THAT EVERYWHERE SINGLE PAYER
WAS INSTITUTED THE VALUE OF
CARE DECLINES IN THE COST GOES
UP THE GOAL I GET IT IS TO
INCREASE ACCESS HAVE QUALITY
CARE AND HAVE A COSTS LESS
VOTE EVERY SYSTEM WE SAW IT
WITH DID NOT PAN OUT THAT WAY
ANY SYSTEM THAT REMOTELY WORK
INCLUDED SOME FORM OF A PRIVATE
PLAN ALTERNATIVE OUR HEARING
CALIFORNIAN PLAYERS SPONSORED
INSURANCE IS STILL THE BIGGEST
SOURCE OF COVERAGE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS ABOUT HALF OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS WOULD COVERAGE
ARE ON EMPLOYER SPONSORED AND
TOTAL UNDER JUST UNDER TWENTY
MILLION ABOUT EIGHTEEN POINT
NINE MILLION CALIFORNIANS ARE
WE TALKING ABOUT THIS WAS THE
NUMBER I GOT IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
FOR PRIVATE INSURANCE LET'S
TALK ABOUT MEDICARE IF AND IF
THE AFTER WE ACTUALLY GET A
FEDERAL WAIVER IN CALIFORNIA
AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE MEDICARE
COVERED SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE ABOUT EIGHTY
FOUR PERCENT OF SEWER SIXTY
FIVE PLUS SEVENTEEN PERCENT
UNDER SIXTY FIVE DISABLED IN
CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE MEDIC CAL OUR MEDICAID
SYSTEM COVERS ABOUT THIRTEEN
MILLION WITH NINETEEN PERCENT
IN FEE FOR SERVICE SO THAT'S A
LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO
LOSE THAT COVERAGE OVERNIGHT
TO MOVE INTO THIS NEW SYSTEM
IT'S A VERY BIG ENDEAVOR WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE MEDI CAL
BENEFITS INCLUDE MANDATORY
AND OPTIONAL CARE HOW LIST
PLAN PROCEEDS TO COVER ALL OF
THESE OPTIONAL BENEFITS FOR
EVERYONE WHETHER THEY'RE OVER
OR UNDER THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL -- DENTAL COVERAGE
DENTAL COVERAGE IS ALREADY
OVERLOOKED WHAT ABOUT THE
OTHER OPTION I WON'T EVEN TALK
ABOUT THE MANDATORY BENEFITS
OF THE OPTIONAL BENEFITS
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS CLINIC
SERVICES DENTAL IS A SAID
DENTURES PHYSICAL THERAPY REHAB
FOR STATIC SERVICES EYEGLASSES
PRIMARY CARE CASE MANAGEMENT
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITIES
FOR THEM THE MENTALLY ILL
INPATIENT PSYCHIATRIC CARE
FOR INDIVIDUALS UNDER THE
AGE OF TWENTY ONE HOME HEALTH
CARE OTHER SERVICES PROVIDED
UNDER HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
WAIVERS PERSONAL CARE SERVICE
HOSPICE SERVICE HOME HEALTH
SERVICE FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
CHRONIC CONDITIONS HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED ATTENDANCE
SERVICE SUPPORT THAT'S A
LOT A LOT THAT'S -- NEED HAS
TO GO INTO THIS CANADA SAYS
LET'S TALK ABOUT CANADA HI
RELATIVES IN CANADA I CAN
SPEAK TO ON A PERSONAL LEVEL
CANADA'S SYSTEM INCLUDES
GOVERNMENT SAID PAYMENTS AND
CANADIAN PHYSICIANS AND NURSES
ARE PAID LESS THAN HERE IN
AMERICA LEADING TO EVEN LESS
PROVIDERS AND NURSES INTERESTED
IN WORKING IN CALIFORNIA IF
THIS TYPE OF SYSTEM GO FORWARD
IN THE COMMITTEE WE -- THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WE FOUND THAT
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE WORK AND
HEALTH INSURANCE CLAIMS IN
OUR PRIVATE AND AND ALSO IN
MEDICAL INSURANCE ALL GOING
TO LOSE THEIR JOBS AND THE
MOSTLY WOMEN THAT'S ANOTHER
ISSUE I MEAN WHAT HAVE THE
SOULS WILL GOING TO LOSE THEIR
JOBS CURRENTLY IN CALIFORNIA
THE MEDICAL REIMBURSEMENT
RATE IS SO LOW THAT IN MANY
CASES THE COST FOR THE DOCTOR
TO PROVIDE THE CARE IS HIGHER
THAN THE REIMBURSEMENT WE'VE
BEEN ADVOCATING FOR YEARS FOR
IMPROVEMENT IN THIS AREA SINCE
THIS IS A STATE RUN PROPOSAL
PROVIDERS WILL LEAVE CALIFORNIA
PRACTICING THOUGH THE STATE'S
ALONG WITH RATIONAL CITIZENS
HOLDING TIGHT TO THE WALLETS
WAIT TIMES ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
LENGTHENED IN CANADA WAS
MENTIONED SOME NOT GONNA GO
INTO AS MUCH DEPTH OF THE
WATER WE HAD THE STUDY THE
STUDIES DONE ANNUALLY TITLED
WAITING YOUR TURN BY THE FRASER
INSTITUTE THE STUDY THE WAIT
LIST TIMES OVER TWO DECADES
WITH TWELVE SPECIALTIES AND TEN
PROVINCES I FIND THAT WEIGHTS
ARE A HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
PERCENT LONGER AFTER THEY PUT
IN THE THE NEW TYPE OF COVERAGE
THAT THEY HAVE IN CANADA LONGER
THAN IN NINETEEN NINETY THREE
WHEN IT WAS JUST NINE POINT
THREE WEEKS WE HEARD GETTING
ORTHOPEDIC SURGEON FORTY EIGHT
PLUS WEEKS THE WAITING MONTH
TO GET CARE THE WAITING OVER
A MONTH FOR ALMOST TWO MONTHS
JUST TO GET A DIAGNOSTIC
TEST WHICH IS NOT EVEN CARE
SO -- THE VALUE OF CARE IS
REDUCED ALL ULTIMATELY THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT THIS PROPOSAL
HOPES TO ACHIEVE WHAT WE ALL
WANT SO I'M JUST YOU KNOW ON A
PERSONAL LEVEL OF UNCLE KEITH
LOSING IN CANADA EIGHTY PLUS
YEARS OLD TWO YEARS AGO STEP
OF THE CURRENT BROKE SOME BONES
IN HIS LOWER LEG WENT TO THE
EMERGENCY ROOM THEY SAW HIM
THEY SENT HIM HOME AND THAT
HE NEVER GOT WE HAVE NEVER
GOT REALLY ANY CARE TO SPEAK
OF AND HE'S BEDRIDDEN WHEN HE
WAS ON THE GOLF COURSE BEFORE
THIS INCIDENT SO I AM NO ONE
WANTS THAT NO ONE SUPPORTS
THE STATUS QUO YOU KNOW NINETY
THREE PERCENT OF PEOPLE ARE
COVERED NOW THE COVERAGE
DOESN'T EQUAL CARE WE CAN FOCUS
ON THOSE THINGS -- AND I HAVE
A WHOLE LIST OF IDEAS SO I'M
NOT JUST VOTING NO I ACTUALLY
DO HAVE IDEAS AND ALWAYS TALK
ABOUT THEM ABOUT STREAMLINING
THE BURDENSOME SYSTEM THAT
WE HAVE NOW INCREASED AND
MEDICAL REIMBURSEMENT RATES
TO INCENTIVIZE MORE PROVIDERS
WE NEED ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE
SYSTEM WE NEEDED OUTCOME BASED
WE NEED VALID VALUE BASED
CARE WE NEED TO BRING MORE
TECHNOLOGY THAT ACTUALLY WORKS
INTO THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM SO
WE HAVE MORE DATA AND MAKE IT
MORE PERSONALIZED MAKES MORE
STREAMLINED WE NEED TO ALLOW
TO BURKE TO ANALYZE FIVE TO
TEN YEARS OR TWENTY YEARS OR
LIFETIME WHICH IS WHAT PRIVATE
PLANS DO BECAUSE I MET WITH THE
TO BERMAN ELSE THIS ANALYSTS
AND I UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY
DO AND HOW THEY DO IT WE CAN
GET A BETTER IDEA COULD WORK
ON KEEPING OUR COSTS LOWER IF
WE ARE MORE EFFICIENT AND IT
WE NEED MORE PRETENCE PARENTS
SEEING ANOTHER DOCTOR WOULD
SAID ONE OF THE TO COST GOING
IN THE BUREAUCRACY IS TOO BIG
STARTING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES BECAUSE TRY TO GET
ANY INFORMATION -- THERE WHEN
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO SOMETHING
SO YOU KNOW NO ONE SUPPORTS
THE STATUS QUO WE CAN DO SOME
THINGS AND I COULD GO ON AND
ON BUT I THINK A SEVEN OF FIFTY
SEVEN AND A HALF HOURS THANK
YOU THANK YOU -- THIS BIRTH
TERIA
I DON'T KNOW IF I'M SHAKING
BECAUSE I'M FREEZING ARE
IF -- GLEE THIS BILL BRINGS
UP A LOT OF FEELINGS FOR ME
AND IF YOU HAVE BEEN ON THIS
COMMITTEE SINCE YOU I'VE BEEN
HERE SINCE WE STARTED THIS
CONVERSATION YOU'VE HEARD
SOME OF THIS FOR ME BEFORE
I APOLOGIZE IF YOU HAVEN'T
THE STATE'S NEW FREEDOM --
I HAD MY FIRST MISCARRIAGE
WHEN I WAS SIX MONTHS PREGNANT
AND I ONLY BRING THAT UP
BECAUSE BACK IN THOSE DAYS THAT
MEANT I COULDN'T GET HEALTH
INSURANCE SO I KNOW FIRST HAND
WHAT IT'S LIKE WHEN YOU ARE
PHYSICALLY AND EMOTIONALLY
DEVASTATED TO HAVE THAT EXTRA
FIERER LAID ON TOP OF THE ON
BUT LIKE MOST IN THIS ROOM I'VE
TRIED TO USE THOSE HARD OUR
LIFE EXPERIENCES TO MAKE ME A
BETTER LEGISLATOR THAT BEING
SAID SO I BELIEVE UNIVERSAL
COVERAGE IS VITAL AND AFTER
LISTENING TODAY I DON'T THINK
THAT THERE'S ANYONE IN THIS
ROOM OR IN THIS LEGISLATOR
LET'S LET'S SHOW THE DISAGREES
THE QUESTION BEFORE US WITH
AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED IS WHAT
WILL THAT LOOK LIKE NOT JUST
POLITICALLY BUT POLICY WISE
THANK YOU WHAT CAN WE AFFORD
TO DO AND WHAT SHOULD WE DO
MORALLY DEMAND OF OURSELVES SO
I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS I WILL
MAKE THEM CLICK I HAVE CROSSED
OFF LIKE OTHERS I HAVE CROSSED
ON SOME OF MY QUESTIONS THAT
I AM HAVE BEEN ANSWERED I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY A FEW THINGS
SO IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING AND
PLEASE CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG
THAT THE UNIVERSE I'M UNINSURED
CALIFORNIANS THAT AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED SEEKS TO ADDRESS IS
ROUGHLY THREE POINT TWO MILLION
AND THE GOVERNOR'S RECENT
BUDGET PROPOSAL ANNOUNCED
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
FOR ALL STATE RESIDENTS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS BETWEEN THAT AND THE
CHAIR'S OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
FOR THE OF WHICH I HAVE BEEN
A CO AUTHOR IT SEEMS LIKE JUST
THIS WEEK CALIFORNIA HAS MADE
GREAT STRIDES TO ACHIEVE YOUR
STATED GOALS BUT THE AND THOSE
ARE NOW GOALS AS OPPOSED TO
SOME HOPE AND UNDERDEVELOPED
COSTS SO THAT RIGHT NOW
UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE AND COST CONTAINMENT
WITHOUT RAISING TAXES IS ON THE
TABLE IS THAT CORRECT BOTH OF
DECEMBER THIS IS LIKE I SAID
EARLIER IN MY COMMENTS I DO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AND AND THE WORK OF DR ROBERT
AND SO MANY OTHERS HERE THE
IN EXPANDING ACCESS BUT ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE IS NOT THE SAME
AS UNIVERSAL HEALTHCARE AND
THAT'S THE DISTINCTION IS THAT
MANY PEOPLE THAT HAVE INSURANCE
-- BECAUSE OF VERY HIGH
DEDUCTIBLES OF BECAUSE OTHER
COSTS -- THEY ARE THE RATIONAL
CARE I DON'T HAVE TO ACCESS
OR GO BANKRUPT EVEN WHILE THEY
HAVE INSURANCE -- AND SO THIS
IS ABOUT ACTUALLY CREATE BRING
COMPREHENSIVE CARE TO EVERY
CALIFORNIANS -- SO DOES THIS
OF THEIR WEALTH REGARDLESS OF
WHERE THEY LIVE -- AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE FALL SHORT OF
SO I'M NOT SAYING THAT YOU'RE
PROPOSALS ON THE TABLE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S NOW I'M SUGGESTING
THAT NOW ACCESS AND UNIVERSAL
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE IS ON THE
TABLE RIGHT NOW AND WITHOUT ANY
SORT OF TAX INCREASES IS THAT
CORRECT MMHM RIGHT AND IN GREAT
AND WILL BE WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WAS
WITHIN A COUPLE YEARS I THINK
THAT CREATING UNIVERSAL ACCESS
TO AND THE ONLY REMAINING
POPULATION DOCTOR ON THE FRONT
IS BETTER THAN I DO WOULD BE
THOSE THAT HAVE NOT SIGNED UP
TO COVER CALIFORNIA THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE THEN ALSO FOR MY
CLARIFICATION HAS ANYTHING FROM
THE HEALTH CARE TASK FORCE THAT
HAS WAS HOW MANY THIRTY SEVEN
HOURS THAT WE'RE GONNA WATCHING
NETFLIX -- HAVE ANY OF THE
SUGGESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
EITHER THAT OR FROM THE CHAIR
BEEN TAKEN IN THIS BILL THAT IS
IN FRONT OF US TODAY I CAN ASK
OF MISCONDUCT IS ALSO ON THAT
COMMISSION SHE'S A COMMISSIONER
AS WELL SO I JUST OF THE HOUSE
I DO KNOW THAT THERE WERE MORE
AND MORE THAN ONE ASSAM HEARD
OTHERS TO HAVE THE B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED AS PART OF THE
CONVERSATION MORE SPECIFICALLY
AS PART OF THE COMMISSION AND
AND -- BUT IF IF -- THIS TIME
SHE WANTS TO SHOW ANOTHER
TONIGHT BECAUSE SHE'S ACTUALLY
ON THE COMMISSION FOR PROJECT
JUST FOR CLARIFICATION I THINK
WHAT SHE'S ASKING AND IF I'M
WRONG PLEASE CORRECT ME MISS
BURKE IS THE QUESTION IS THE
COMMENTS ABOUT THE THIRTY FIVE
HOURS OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
THAT MATT IS THAT CORRECT
YES OKAY NOT THE HEALTH FRAUD
COMMISSION WHICH IS A DIFFERENT
WHICH HAS A VERY WHICH IS
FOCUSED ONLY ON THE FINANCING
A PUBLICLY UNIFIED FINANCING
SO SO THAT'S THAT THAT'S
EXACTLY THAT'S QUESTIONS SHE'S
ANGRY THANK YOU FOR THAT YES
AND ALSO ASK IS CONSTITUTED
AND WELL I GUESS IN THE SAME
TIME HAVE ANY OF THE COMMENTS
FROM THE CHAIR BEEN INCLUDED
IN THIS MEASURE AS OF TODAY
WELL THEY WILL BE BECAUSE IS
THE THE STAFF ANALYSIS JUST
CAME OUT AND WE'RE MORE THAN
HAPPY AND I'M MORE THAN HAPPY
TO WORK WITH THE CHAIR LOOK
AT THE END OF THE DAY IF THIS
MOVES FORWARD -- IT SURE WAS
GOING TO BE A PART OF WHAT IT'S
GONNA LOOK LIKE GOING FORWARD
ABSOLUTELY BUT THE FACT IS
IS THAT AFTER A YEAR NON HAVE
BEEN TAKEN IS THAT CORRECT
ALL THESE RECOMMENDATIONS WERE
PART OF THE ANALYSIS YET HAVE
YOU NOT MET WITH THE CHAIR
UP AND OVER THE LAST YEAR I
HAVE HAD IT WITH THE CHEN AND
HAVE ANY OF HIS COMMENTS IN
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OR YOUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOUR SPONSOR
IF THE I DON'T KNOW IF THE
RESPONSE -- -- BEEN INTEGRATED
INTO FOURTEEN HUNDRED AS WE
SEE IT TODAY AFTER ONE YEAR OF
BEING IN PRINT WILL NOT I MEAN
IT'S NOT A REALLY HARD QUESTION
THIS IS ACTUALLY ONE OF THE
EASIEST QUESTIONS WE'VE ASKED
TODAY I THINK OF MOST PEOPLE
I DON'T KNOW THE RESIDENT I
HAVE ALSO WERE PREFERRED PLUS
SPONSORS IN TERMS OF THE DEGREE
OF SPECIFICITY AS TO SOME OF
THE ISSUES I DO KNOW SOME OF
THE ISSUES -- MAY HAVE BEEN
WELL AWARE OF THE EVENTS BUT
THE DEGREE OF SPECIFICITY IS
THE STAFF ANALYSIS AS TO THE
ISSUES WERE RAISED AS WELL
AS SURE WHAT INDICATED -- ARE
THINGS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
WORK WITH THEM ON I'M THROUGH
THE CHAIR HAVE HAD THERE BEEN
ANY AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL
SINCE ITS INTRODUCTION TIME
NO OKAY THANK YOU -- SO THE
STATE HAS A FIFTEEN PERCENT
CAP ON HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES ADMINISTRATION FEES
THE REST MUST GO TO PATIENT
CARE I'M NOT SAYING THE
SYSTEM IS NOT BROKEN BUT I
DO WONDER WHAT ARE THE CONS
WHAT ARE THE COST CONTAINMENT
MEASURES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
IN THIS BILL THE DALLAS MISS
CONSTI THIS BECOMING SECURE
IF YOU'RE THERE I'M YES -- FOR
COST CONTAINMENT MEASURES YOU
KNOW I I I WENT OVER SOME OF
THEM AND AND AND AND CREATE
THE QUESTION -- -- THE THE COST
CONTAINMENT MEASURES YOU KNOW
ONE OVERALL IT'S IT'S A SYSTEM
OVERALL BY GETTING EVERYBODY
INTO ONE SINGLE RISK POOL --
THERE ARE -- YOU KNOW WE'RE
LOWERING THE COST -- COMPLETELY
TO TO THE SYSTEM -- AND YOU
KNOW KIND OF TO POINT TO THE
WORK ON THE COMMISSION AGAIN
YOU KNOW THE COMMISSION HANDS
-- HAS LOOKED INTO THE THE
COST OF THE VERY SIMILAR TYPE
OF SYSTEM AND YOU KNOW I'VE
WORKED VERY TIRELESSLY WITH
OUR CONSULTANTS TO ENSURE THAT
-- THE ANALYSIS OF THE DIRECT
PAYMENT SCENARIO THAT THAT THAT
THEY HAVE IN THEIR ECONOMIC
ANALYSIS INCLUDES MANY MANY
OF THE ELEMENTS OF AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED EVEN IF IT DOESN'T SAY
IT IN AND AND NAME -- HE -- FOR
EXAMPLE THE DIRECT PAYMENTS --
-- ANALYSIS FOR THE COMMISSION
INCLUDES GLOBAL BUDGETING --
GLOBAL BUDGETING -- FOR EXAMPLE
WOULD BE A COST CONTAINMENT
MEASURE BECAUSE IT WOULD BE
ENSURING THAT THE PAYMENTS THAT
ARE PAID TOWARD HOSPITALS ARE
CLOSER TO ACT THE ACTUAL COST
OF CARE RATHER THAN -- RATHER
THAN -- DOLLARS GOING TO TO
-- -- HOSPITAL PROFITING AND
ON TOP OF THAT THERE WOULD BE
A BETTER DISTRIBUTION OF THE
THE COST OF -- -- OF THAT CARE
-- AND IMPORTANTLY OF COURSE
THE COST CONTAINMENT MEASURES
CALM BECAUSE WE SIMPLY SIMPLE
FLYING -- THAT THE SYSTEM
ITSELF WE BEACH SIMPLIFYING
THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
SYSTEM -- AND YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE ONE OF THE STATISTICS FROM
THE HEALTHY CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
COMMISSION THAT I WANNA DRAW
FOR YOU FOR YOU ALL -- THAT WAS
PRESENTED TO US -- YOU KNOW --
ENTITIES -- WILL SPEND ABOUT
EIGHTY FIVE BILLION SERVICES
HOSPITALS PHYSICIANS AND OTHER
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES WILL
SPEND ABOUT EIGHTY FIVE BILLION
OR LESS IN ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS -- -- ONLY ON BILLING
AND INSURANCE RELATED COSTS IT
THERE IF THERE ARE OTHER COSTS
THAT -- THAT THE COST SAVINGS
FOR HOSPITAL CITIZENS AND AND
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS -- SO
THAT IS THE COST CONTAINMENT
-- QUESTION BREAK THERE IN
AND OF ITSELF ON ON EIGHTY ONE
THIRTY ADMINISTRATIVE SAVINGS
BECAUSE -- HOSPITALS WOULDN'T
HAVE TO DEAL WITH HUNDREDS
OF OF -- INSURANCE PLANS --
DOCTORS WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
HAVE TO DO THAT AND THERE'D
BE TIME SAVINGS ASSOCIATED
TO WHICH AGAIN WOULD BE -- --
ENSURING THAT -- THERE'D BE
MORE MORE ABILITY OF DOCTORS
TO PRIVATE PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
CARE -- AND ANOTHER HUGE PART
IS THE NEGOTIATING POWER OF
THE SYSTEM ITSELF TO NEGOTIATE
-- SAVINGS AND DRUG PRICES
AND AND -- AND RATES GENERALLY
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
SAID YOU KNOW THERE WOULD BE
PRICE NEGOTIATIONS -- BOTH
WAYS HOSPITALS DIRECTLY EACH
INDIVIDUAL HOSTER HOSPITAL
DIRECTLY AND WITH OTHER TYPES
OF PROVIDERS AND THAT WOULD
-- BE ABLE TO LOWER COSTS SO
THAT IT IT SO THAT WE HAVE SOME
SANITY IN AND IN HOW DOCTORS
ARE PAID TO THAT PART -- MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS WOULD BE PAID
MORE WHEREAS IF THERE ARE
PROCEDURE BASED TYPES OF CARE
THAT THAT WE COULD NEGOTIATE
LOWER PRICES IF IT IF IT'S
APPROPRIATE -- ALSO I'VE HEARD
YOU SAY THAT ACTUALLY EARLIER
TODAY I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS BESIDES BE A RADICAL COST
CONTAINMENT ARE THERE SPECIFIC
CAPS FOR THE STATE IN ALL OF
THIS IN THEIR SPENDING WE ARE
NOT WE DON'T HAVE A HISTORY OF
STAYING ON BUDGET UNFORTUNATELY
NOT IN OUR TECH PROJECTS NOT IN
ANY OF OUR PROJECTS REALLY SO
MY QUESTION IS I UNDERSTAND THE
THEORY I UNDERSTAND THAT SOME
OF IT'S ACTUALLY QUITE POSSIBLE
HOWEVER MY QUESTION IS IS WE
REQUIRE OTHERS TO HAVE SPECIFIC
CAPS HAVE WE DECIDED TO PUT
SPECIFIC CAPS ON OURSELVES
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT ARE I
WONDER RATE HERE SO WE HAVE
HAD THIS DISCUSSION THIS IS
THAT YOU KNOW I THE DISCUSSION
THAT WE'VE HAD IN THE HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL COMMISSION
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT HOW CAN
WE HAVE OVERALL -- OVERALL
COST CONTROLS OF THE SYSTEM
ITSELF AND YOU KNOW IT IT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT -- ONE WE'RE
HAVING THIS DISCUSSION TONIGHT
AND YOU KNOW I THINK WE WE CAN
HAVE MORE OF THESE DISCUSSIONS
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT -- ACA LEVIN
-- IT'S SET TO POTENTIALLY YOU
DON'T HAVE TO HAVE SOME SOME
GOLDEN TO MONITOR THE SYSTEM
-- NOW DO WE WANT EXPLICIT
CAP THAT THAT THERE WOULD BE
EXPLICIT SPENDING LIMITS I
THINK THAT WOULD BE DETRIMENTAL
TO THE SYSTEM BECAUSE THAT'S
HOW HE HOW WOULD THE SYSTEM MAY
NOT GROW APPROPRIATELY BASED ON
-- BASED ON THE CONSUMER PRICE
INDEX -- BUT BASED ON DIFFERENT
-- CHANGES IN HOW HEALTHCARE
STRUCTURED -- AND IT AND --
GDP GDP GROWTH -- ALL OF THESE
THINGS ARE REALLY IMPORTANT TO
CONSIDER AND YOU KNOW WE DON'T
ENVISION EXPLICIT -- EXPLICIT
COST CAPS WHERE THEY'RE
SPENDING LIMITS THAT WE HAVE
TO WE HAVE TO COME BACK TO ALL
OF YOU -- YEAR AFTER YEAR TO
INCREASE THE THE BUDGET I THINK
THAT WOULD BE DETRIMENTAL FOR
THE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
AND THAT'S HOW WE ACTUALLY END
UP GETTING INTO THE SITUATION
WHERE WE MIGHT HAVE A LIMITED
BUDGET -- WORD THERE MIGHT HAVE
TO BE SOME CUTS TO THE BENEFIT
AND AND THAT IS NOT WHAT WE
WANT AND I HATE TO SAY THIS
BUT NOW WE'RE STARTING USING
THOSE EXCUSES MAKES US TO START
SO MAKING THE HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANY SO WITH THAT AND
WE'VE HAD A YEAR TO HAVE THESE
DISCUSSIONS AND I THINK PART OF
THE FRUSTRATION I THINK YOU'RE
SEEING FROM NOT JUST MYSELF BUT
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES IS THAT
THESE CONVERSATION SHOULD HAVE
BEEN HAD OVER THE LAST YEAR THE
FACT THAT THIS BILL IS BEING
ASKED TO BE PASSED NOW AND HAVE
CONVERSATIONS LATER MAKES VERY
LITTLE LOGICAL SENSE BUT HAVING
SAID THAT I WOULD SAY THAT
HAVE THE OPPOSITION ACTUALLY
WORKED ON COST CONTAINMENT AND
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL WE PROBABLY
WOULDN'T STILL BE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION SO ON SOME LEVEL
I ACTUALLY APPLAUD CNA FOR
THEIR TENACITY IN PUSHING THIS
BILL AND THIS CONCEPT UNTIL
YESTERDAY THERE THEY REALLY
WERE THE ONLY ONES THAT IT
TAKEN PEN TO PAPER IN SEARCH
OF THIS OF A SOLUTION TO CHIEF
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE FOR THE
GREATEST NUMBER OF PEOPLE AT
THE LOWEST COST BECAUSE QUITE
FRANKLY WE WE AND WHEN I SAY
WE I MEAN ALL OF US HAVE FAILED
TO PRODUCE ANYTHING TO THE
CONTRARY THOUGH I HOPE THROUGH
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND THE
CHAIR'S OFFICE ACCOUNTABILITY
SOON A LOT OF THAT'S GOING TO
CHANGE TO THE AUTHOR'S COMMENTS
I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THE
ACA IS NOT REQUIRED TO PASS
THIS BILL AND IT IS A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR
TAX INCREASE NOT JUST FOR
BUSINESS BUT FOR THOSE MAKING
FORTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND UP THE TAXI THAT TAX
UBLE INCOME OF THOSE MAKING A
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE THOUSAND
AND UP WILL BE TAXED TWICE A
PAYROLL TAX AND AN INCOME TAX
AS WELL AS A SWIPE AT PROP
NINETY EIGHT EDUCATION FUNDS
BEGAN LIMIT PROP THIRTEEN
AND MAKING TAX FOR THIS ONE
MAJORITY VOTE INSTEAD OF TWO
THIRDS THAT BEING SAID IF AB
FOURTEEN HUNDRED PASSES THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY AND THE ACA IS
REFERRED WHICH IT SOUNDS LIKE
NOW IT'S NOT EVEN SOMETHING
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IT BEING
REFERRED -- IF IT'S IF IT'S
REFER TO MY COMMITTEE THEN WE
WILL HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
AND I WANT TO ASSURE EVERYONE
THAT THAT CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT WILL BE DISCUSSED I
THINK IF WE PASS THIS AND WE
DON'T DISCUSS PROPOSED FUNDING
MECHANISM WE ARE MAKING EVEN
MORE OF A MOCKERY OF THIS
PROCESS I WILL NOT SUPPORT A
CA AND ITS CURRENT FORM BUT
IF THIS BODY DEEMS IT FIT TO
PASS AND UNFUNDED SINGLE PAYER
BILL THEN WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO PAY FOR IT AND I
WANT TO ASSURE EVERYONE THAT
CONVERSATION WILL BE HAD HI
AND THIS IS THE HARDEST PART
FOR ME IS THAT THE TRUTH IS
IF WE DON'T WE ARE EXACTLY
WHAT THE PEOPLE DISTRUST ABOUT
THIS SYSTEM WE ARE PASSING
SOMETHING TO BENEFIT PEOPLE
BUT IT'S REALLY JUST AN MPC
SIMPLE SIMPLE IF IT'S NOT
JOINED TO A FUNDING MECHANISM
IT DOES NOT BRING HEALTH CARE
TO EVEN ONE MORE PERSON WITHOUT
TWENTY THIS BILL HAS BEEN SOLD
TO MY COMMUNITY THAT IT IS
GOING TO CHANGE THINGS NOW AND
THAT IT IS FREE AND NEITHER
ONE OF THOSE THINGS ARE TRUE
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND HIS STAFF FOR EVERYTHING
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN TOWARD
OVER THESE LAST FEW YEARS OF
THIS PROCESS AND UP UNTIL NOW
IT HAS BEEN A VERY THANKLESS
PROCESS AND I AM AWARE OF IT
BUT I TRULY HOPE THAT IN THE
WEEKS TO COME WE TRULY PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS IF WE CAN DO THAT
WE CAN MOVE FROM A PROMISE
TO CHANGE NVAX I BELIEVE IT'S
SOMETHING WE CAN BE PROUD OF
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS WHO
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
-- THE THERE IS A MOTION
-- BY MISTER MISS MISS
CARILLO A SECOND BY MISTER
NAZARIAN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
MISTER CAR WHICH WENT CLOSE
THANK THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
ONE OF THE DRESS A COUPLE
THINGS -- A PRETTY CLEAR
IMPLICATION THAT SOMEHOW I
HAD TO DO SOMETHING AND THEN
JUST LET IT SIT AND THEN JUST
BROUGHT IT BACK AND EXPECT YOU
TO PASS IT AND THAT SOMEHOW
-- I THINK THIS BILL OR THE
SPONSOR THINK THIS BILL IS
PERFECT AND NOTHING I TO
HIGHLIGHT IS PERFECT I WOULD
NEVER SUGGEST ANYTHING I BRING
-- BEFORE MY COLLEAGUES IS
HAD HUNDREDS OF HOURS OF THE
MEETINGS AND CONVERSATIONS
-- SPONSORS OUT AS WELL
I'VE SPOKEN WITH DOZENS OF
COLLEAGUES MOST OF THEM ON
THEIR OWN URGING AND THEY REACH
OUT TO ME AND I'VE TALKED TO
THEM -- AND YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
CALLED A LOT OF THINGS AND
ACCESSIBLE IS USUALLY NOT ONE
OF THEM BUT IF I FOR A REASON
-- YOU KNOW COLLEAGUES FEEL
THAT WAY I APOLOGIZE THAT'S
MY FEELING NOT THE FEELING
OF THE SPONSORS OR THOSE THAT
ARE ADVOCATING FOR THIS BILL
I WILL SAY THAT THERE WAS
NO ASSURANCES -- WHEN WHEN I
HELD THE BILL IN APRIL -- THAT
WOULD BE HEARD IT AND I KNEW
THAT AT THE TIME -- THERE IS
NO ASSURANCES THAT -- BUT WE
WOULD BE HERE TODAY AND I SAY
THAT BECAUSE WHAT THAT ALLOWED
FOR IN A GOOD WAY WAS FOR ME TO
NUMBER CONTINUE TO DO MY STUDY
-- TO BE ABLE TO GO IN AND MEET
WITH REPRESENTATIVES OF HHS
AND -- IN WASHINGTON DC I THINK
THAT HAD A POSITIVE IMPACT IN
IN THE BILL BEING REFERRED IN
SPEAKING WITH THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE FROM THE SPEAKER OF
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL WEEKS
AND MONTHS -- IT WAS UP TO ME
AND OF THOSE OF US THAT ARE
SUPPORTING FOURTEEN HUNDRED
TO GET A HEARING AND TO HAVE
IT REFERRED AND THE IN THE THE
WHEN I SAY THAT THE QUESTIONS
POSED BY THE CHAIR -- LOOKING
ON TOLD THE OF THE BILLS
REFERRED -- HELP ME STOP THIS
YEAR THEY DON'T KNOW WHETHER
IT IS GOING TO BE REFERRED AS
WHAT I'VE -- WHEN I MENTION ALL
THAT BUT I'M ESSENTIALLY SAYING
IS THAT WE ARE BEING POSED WITH
RESPONSIBLE SUGGESTIONS AND
THOUGHTS FROM THE CHAIR THAT
ARE NOT IGNORED QUITE TO THE
CONTRARY -- THE THE THE CHAIR
WILL BE INTEGRAL IN ENSURING
THAT -- THERE THERE'S A BILL
THAT WORKS AND MAKES SENSE HE
HAS HIS OWN OF LEVEL EXPERTISE
IS BROUGHT TO THE TABLE AND
YOU KNOW THE MY MY STAFF THE
SPONSORS HAVE RESPONDED TO
HUNDREDS OF QUESTIONS OVER THE
LAST FEW MONTHS -- THAT HAVE
COME TO THEM -- AND EVEN THE
QUESTIONS POSED BY MID DECEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY WE HAVEN'T WE HAVE
RESPONSES FOR THOSE QUESTIONS
AND AND ARE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
THEM -- NOW IN TERMS OF SOME OF
THE SPECIFICITY OF ACCOUNT IS A
PROGRAM INTO A BEER SEE THAT'S
THE THAT'S THE QUESTION AND
AND CERTAINLY IN -- SUNSCREEN
CONSULTATION WITH THE WITH THE
CHAIR AND HIS STAFF AS TO HOW
MUCH SPECIFICITY YOU WANT IN
A POSSIBLE THIS NATURE BECAUSE
THE MORE SPECIFICITY MEANS
ANYTIME YOU WANT TO CHANGE THAT
TO GO BACK LEGISLATURE AND IF
IT'S LINE ITEM BY LINE ITEM
THAT'S NOT ACTUALLY WHAT YOU
WANT IN A PROGRAM LIKE THIS
THOSE THE KINDS OF QUESTIONS
AND -- THAT THAT NEED TO BE
RESOLVED IN TERMS OF HOW MUCH
SPECIFICITY -- TO PUT INTO
THE BILL BUT I ASSURE YOU THAT
THE SPONSORS AND MYSELF HAVE
ABSOLUTELY PUSH FOR MANAGEMENT
OF TIME INTO PREPARING FEEDBACK
MMHM IN THE PHARMACY JORDANA
FEEDBACK YOU'VE GOTTEN HAS BEEN
ON FUNDING -- AND AS OPPOSED
TO ANY OTHER LEGISLATOR THAT
IS STILL IN THIS BUILDING IN
THE PAST WE PUT FOR FUNDING
NO ONE'S ON THE BEFORE IS A
PERFECT PEOPLE HAVE ISSUES WITH
IT THEY HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO
THE WHOLE POINT OF PUTTING IT
OUT THERE SO THAT YOU KNOW THAT
THAT THERE'S SOMETHING THAT
CAN BE ANALYZED AND DISCUSSED
AND DEBATED AND CHANGED --
ACCORDINGLY AND THEN SO THAT
THAT WAS REALLY THE THE PRIMARY
-- HOLD UP IN TERMS OF THE
BILL -- NOT BEING HEARD OF
LAST YEAR THAT IS SOMETHING
WE WORKED WE WE WORKED ON TO
TRY TO PUT SOMETHING FORWARD
-- THAT WE FEEL IS PROGRESSIVE
I KNOW THAT THE CHAIR BURKE
-- INDICATE SOME CONCERNS IN
THE THEIR LEGITIMATE CONCERNS
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT RIGHT
NOW EMPLOYERS PAY NINE POINT
NINE PERCENT OF PAYROLL FOR
HEALTHCARE EMPLOYEES PAY TWO
POINT SEVEN PERCENT THE BILL
FOR HEALTHCARE AND SAW ONE
POINT TWO FIVE PERCENT PAYROLL
TAX FOR EMPLOYERS IS FAR MORE
GENEROUS -- BUT AGAIN I KNOW
WE'RE NOT HERE TO DEBATE FACING
A LOT OF US WANT TO MENTION
THAT THESE CONSIDERATIONS HAVE
BEEN MADE IN TERMS OF THE FIRST
ITERATION HAS BEEN PUT OUT
THERE THAT DOES ALLOW US THE
TIME -- THE DIVE DEEPER INTO
IT -- AND IT IS CERTAINLY MY
INTENTION IF IT'S THE WILL OF
OF OF THE SERVER OF OF HAVE YOU
TAXATION TO HAVE THE BILL HEARD
IS NOT A IT WASN'T PUT FORWARD
A FOR ANY OTHER REASON BUT IN
TERMS OF THE ORDER OF THINGS AS
I MENTIONED EARLIER ABOUT WHERE
BIRTH FOLLOWING AN ORDER THAT
ALLOWS A WAIVER TO BE APPLIED
FOR -- IT WAS VERY DIRECTLY IN
THIS IS GONNA BE MET FOR WELL
OVER AN HOUR THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTH HUMAN SERVICES THERE
ARE VERY CLEAR THAT LEGISLATIVE
AUTHORITY THROUGH A POLICY BILL
NEEDS TO BE PASSED EVEN APPLY
FOR A WAIVER -- AND THE FISCAL
COMPONENT OF IT DOES NOT NEED
TO BE PART OF THAT AND THE
REASON WHY IS THAT THE WAIVER
APPLICATION PROCESS HOUSE TO
SPEAK TO THE LARGER FINANCING
AND WHAT YOU WOULD NEED IN
THE FINANCING ON ULTIMATELY
ABSOLUTELY VOTERS CAN VOTE
SOMETHING DOWN ABSOLUTELY --
SOMETHING MAY NOT MAKE IT ALL
THE WAY TO THE GOAL LINE --
AND YOU KNOW THAT THIS IS NOT
THE FIRST TIME THAT -- THIS
ENFORCEMENT TRIED I SAID THAT
THE BEGINNING AS WELL THAT
IT'S THIS IS NOT A MATTER OF
TRYING TO BE PERFECT IT'S A
MATTER OF UNDERSTANDING THAT
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IN OUR
SYSTEM EVEN WITH ALL THE
WORK THAT SURE WOULD AND SO
MANY YOU DON'T OVER THE YEARS
WERE STILL SEEING INCREASING
HEALTHCARE COSTS WERE STILL
SAYING LACK OF ACCESS WE'RE
STILL SEEING PEOPLE DYING WE'RE
STILL SEEING THAT THERE ISN'T
THAT MANY O'CLOCK THAT MEET
MEANINGFUL ACCESS AS OPPOSED
TO JUST HAVING INSURANCE
VERSUS REALLY GETTING THE
CARE -- OF THAT IS GOING TO
SAVE YOUR LIFE OR MAKERS I
PERSONALLY BETTER BOB THAT IS
WHY THE SINGLE PAYER HEALTHCARE
PROGRAM WHICH IS BEEN STUDIED
FOR YEARS -- AND I KNOW IT'S
EASY TO SAY POINT ONE COUNTRY
OTHER LOOK WE'RE NOT CANADA WE
HAVE MORE PEOPLE IN CANADA HAS
PROVINCIALLY RUN SYSTEMS NOT
A SINGLE PROVINCE IN CANADA
IS ANYWHERE NEAR THE SIZE OF
OUR STATE FOR THE SIZE OF OUR
ECONOMY AND SO -- YOU KNOW IT
IT I KNOW THAT WENDELL POTTER
OF FORMER INSURANCE INDUSTRY
EXECUTIVE -- SILVA SPEAKS OF
HOW HE WAS VERY INTENTIONALLY
HIT ATTENTIONAL PART OF THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY THE BEST
CANADA AND TO BASH IT IS TO
MAKE PEOPLE AFRAID OF DOING
ANYTHING THAT IS DIFFERENT --
I KNOW THAT NO ONE HERE EXCEPT
THE STATUS QUO AND THAT'S WHY
ALSO SAID IN THE INTRO THAT
WORK IS BEEN DONE HAS BEEN
CLEARED HAS MADE IT CLEAR THAT
THE STATUS QUO IS NOT ACCEPTED
BY THOSE IN THIS COMMITTEE OR
A BODY -- BUT WHAT I BELIEVE
TO BE TRUE IS THAT A SINGLE
PAYER HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND
IF IF THERE ARE ISSUES OF
THE THAT THE CHAIR I THINK
RAISES SOME ISSUES WITH --
FOURTEEN HUNDRED I THINK OUR
ARE REASONABLE -- ISSUES FOR
US TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON OTHER
OTHER FOLKS THAT HAVE LOOKED
AT IT AS AS KIM WANT TO TREAT
THIS SOME LANGUAGE ISSUE THERE
FOR GOVERNANCE ISSUES THOSE
ARE ALL THINGS THAT -- WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE TAKING IN AND MORE
THAN HAPPY TO NOT JUST TALK
ABOUT THE TO AMEND IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT IT'S A BILL THAT
WORKS BUT LIKE I SAID WITH
THIS BILL HAS BEEN AROUND --
FOR QUITE SOME TIME I'VE I'VE
I'VE SPOKEN TO MANY COLLEAGUES
ABOUT IT AND WE'VE GOTTEN VERY
OTHER THAN FROM THE CHAIR OF
THE STUFF ANALYSIS FROM WE
HAVEN'T GOTTEN DIRECT REQUEST
TO AMEND -- FROM COLLEAGUES
WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN MANY DIRECT
REQUEST TO AMEND FOR OUTSIDE
ENTITIES EXCEPT FOR THOSE THAT
OPPOSE IT -- AND SO YOU KNOW
I'M LOOKING OUT I'M I'VE BEEN
HERE I'VE ALWAYS BEEN HERE
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN MADE MYSELF
AVAILABLE AND ACCESSIBLE --
AND OVER THE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO AND
LOOK FOR THE BLOCKING OFF HOURS
AND HOURS OF MY TIME -- FOR
ANYONE THAT WANTS TO MEET OR
HAVE THEIR STATUS MEET WITH ME
TO DISCUSS DETAILS OF THE BILL
AND TO HAVE QUESTIONS ANSWERED
THIS IS A STARTING POINT IN
TERMS OF A LONGER PROCESS
AS THE CHAIR ASKED EARLIER
HONEST CONVERSATIONS BUT WAIT
A MINUTE THINKING ABOUT WHAT
WE NEED TO DO IN TERMS OF I
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM IN
A SINGLE PAYER SYSTEM I THINK
ABOUT THOSE THAT ARE SUFFERING
THERE'S PLENTY OF PEOPLE THAT
SUFFER IN OUR CURRENT SYSTEM
THAT WE NEED TO BE THERE FOR
THEM WE NEED TO BE THERE FOR
OF THOSE PLACES THAT DON'T
GET HURT -- FOR THOSE THAT ARE
STUCK IN A JOB OR AN ABUSIVE
RELATIONSHIP AND DON'T LEAVE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE HEALTH CARE
THEY DON'T WANT TO LOSE IT FOR
THOSE LAWS ON HOUSE NEIGHBORS
THAT FELL INTO HOMELESSNESS
BECAUSE OF MEDICAL BILLS --
AND FOR THE YOUNGER GENERATION
AN ADULT THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
WE WANT TEN FIFTEEN TWENTY
YEARS AND ANOTHER GROUP OF
LEGISLATORS ARE GRAPPLING WITH
OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IS EVEN
THAT MUCH MORE OUT OF REACH
AND THAT MUCH MORE PAINFUL
FOR CALIFORNIANS -- I HEAR THE
CRITICISM I HEAR THE CRITICISM
OF THE PERSONAL CRITICISM
OF MYSELF -- BUT I WILL SAY
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
I TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY -- THIS
SOMETHING AB FOUR TWO HUNDRED I
BELIEVE IS A VERY WELL WRITTEN
POLICY BILL AND IT IS TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT MANY DIFFERENT
ELEMENTS OF PAST BILLS AND
FEEDBACK FROM COMMITTEES AND
COMMISSIONS AND STUDIES -- IT'S
BETTER THAN FIVE SIX TWO THE
PRESIDENT OF DIFFERENT COST
CONTAINMENT MEASURES AND OTHER
ELEMENTS THAT ARE IN AND SO I'M
NOT SUGGESTING AND NEVER WOULD
THAT IS PERFECT BECAUSE IT'S
NOT NO BILL IS WHAT I AM SAYING
IS THAT THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO WORK TOGETHER TO TRY
OUR BEST TO BRING A SYSTEM THAT
FOCUSES NOT JUST ON HEALTHCARE
JUSTICE IN THE PRINCIPLE BUT
ACTUALLY BRING HEALTH CARE TO
EVERY SINGLE CALIFORNIA IN OUR
STATE IN A WAY THAT'S DIGNIFIED
AND THE WAY THAT SAVES US MONEY
AND IN A WAY THAT I BELIEVE WE
CAN DO IF WE'RE AS COMMITTED
AS THE CHAIR AND SO MANY OF YOU
ARE WITH THE LAST ONE I BOUGHT
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA BILL IS
-- AS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
TO APPROPRIATIONS MOTION BY
MISTER PRIVATE BY MISS CARILLO
THE SECOND BY MISTER NAZARIAN
-- MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WHAT NIGHT WOULD
I ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS
I AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE
CUNNINGHAM AGAIN NO BURKE
BURKE I CARILLO REAL AYE FLORA
FLORA NOW MAIENSCHEIN MAYES
I'M NOT VOTING MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE NAZARIAN AYE NAZARIAN
AYE THREE OF US THREE OF US I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I WALDRON WALDRON NO
THREE THE BILL WITHOUT
ELEVEN TO THREE OKAY
MEMBERS WE STILL HAVE SOME
WORK TO DO SO PLEASE DON'T
DON'T LEAVE WE'VE GOT -- SOME
OF THOSE WHO NEED TO BE FILLED
-- FILLED GONNA START AT THE
TOP OF THE AGENDA -- STARTED
CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH IS AB
NINETY THREE AND EIGHTY SIX
NINETY FIVE THE SECRETARY
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN HAI MCCARTY
MCCARTY I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
I FIFTEEN ZERO THANK YOU ARE
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO
EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY TWO BY MISS
CLARK SILVA PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ROBERT RIVAS ROBBERY OF THIS
ONE YOU NEED TO CLOSE WITH
THE WITH THE RETURN CALL FOR
QUICK SERVICE SHE'S ON A CALL
CAMPAIGN YEAH SO ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN HAI MCCARTY MCCARTY
I THREE OF US THREE OF US I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI FIFTEEN
ZERO THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
ONE BY MISTER RAMOS PLEASE
OPEN THE ROAD FOR THE LIFT THE
CALL AND HOPE AND AND CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I CARILLO WITH THIS
GROUP CARILLO AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN HAI MCCARTY MCCARTY
I THREE OF US THREE OF US I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HIGH FIFTEEN
ZERO THANK YOU THE FIFTEEN
ZERO -- ITEM NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY
SIX EIGHTY SIX -- BY DOCTOR
REGULAR PLEASE -- LIFT THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I CARILLO
I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN THIS
AREA NAZARIAN AYE THREE OF US
THREE OF US I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
I FIFTEEN ZERO FIFTEEN ZERO
I REMEMBER FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT BY MR WIN --
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE IN CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I ARAMBULA
OOPS GRAMMAR REGULAR
AB SEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT BY MR WHEN
-- I ARAMBULA I CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I IN THIS AREA
NAZARIAN HI THREE OF US
THREE OF US I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
I FIFTEEN ZERO FIFTEEN ZERO
THANK YOU I'VE NEVER SEVEN
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I TO RIO CARILLO
I MAIENSCHEIN MENTIONED HIGH
IN THIS AREA NAZARIAN AYE
THREE OF US THREE OF US I
FIFTEEN ZERO TWO ZERO THANK
YOU -- ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE FOR
MR LEVINE PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I
BURKE BURKE I CARILLO CARILLO
I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN I THREE OF US
THREE OF US I FIFTEEN ZERO
THANK YOU OF FIFTEEN ZERO
ITEM NUMBER NINE EIGHTY
THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR BY MR WIN
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I BURKE BURKE
I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
I FIFTEEN ZERO THANK YOU I
REMEMBER TEN AB FIFTEEN OH
SORRY IT IS HI THERE AND I
-- THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR I
IS THERE A NINE FIFTEEN ZERO
TO FIFTEEN -- ITEM NUMBER
TEN AB FIFTEEN OH TWO BY
MISTER MURATSUCHI PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
NO BURKE BURKE I FLORA
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
I IN THIS AREA THIS AREA
I WALDRON WALDRON NOW
TWELVE TO TWELVE TO TWO
AND THE FINAL ITEM --
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN S.
B.
FIFTY SEVEN BY SENATOR WIENER
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ARAMBULA
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NO
MCCARTY MCCARTY I RODRIGUEZ
NINE FOUR THAT'S NINE TO FOUR
BUT THAT THAT IS THE BUSINESS
-- OKAY YES HI FIFTY WITH
THAT THAT THAT IS THE BUSINESS
OF THE HEALTH COMMITTEE --
TODAY -- MEETING ADJOURNED
NO STRATEGY